this comprehensive course on web
development with HTML and CSS is created
with beginners in mind it's taught by
Akash the CEO and co-founder of Jovian
the course starts with the basics of
HTML and CSS and gradually progresses
into advanced concepts covering git
GitHub and Cloud deployment using
versell as well as mobile first
responsive design the bootstrap CSS
framework and the express web
application framework so let's start
learning hello and welcome to this
course on web development with HTML and
CSS HTML and CSS are the foundation of
modern web design allowing you to create
visually appealing and
functionally uh visually appealing and
functional web pages HTML specifically
stands for the hyper text markup
language and it is a standard language
used to create web pages and this is
what HTML code looks like this is some
of the code that we'll be writing
today it can be used to create create
headings paragraphs images links and
many more things so if I head over for
example to jan.com
this is a web page now on this web page
everything has been crafted using HTML
and then styled using
CSS so HTML is used to structure the
content and add elements and then
cascading style seats uh cascading style
sheets or css is used to describe the
presentation of HTML documents it allows
you to control the layout and the
appearance by defining styles for
elements and you can configure things
like fonts colors margins borders Etc so
today we are going to look at the very
basics of HTML and CSS we are going to
start by creating an HTML file adding
code into it using the Ws code editor
viewing it in a browser we're going to
then use some basic HTML tags to create
a web page then we're also going to use
some more HTML tags to structure content
on a page things like headings lists
paragraphs
Etc then we're going to add styles using
CSS and understand the CSS Box model for
layout that is the core foundational
Concept in CSS and then we're going to
style these uh HTML tags using CSS to
replicate the structure of a desired web
page so we'll look at a problem
statement and we'll try to replicate the
web page that we have in mind using HTML
and CSS and finally if time permits we
are also going to try and deploy that
website to the cloud using an online
hosting service so in just about 2 and 1
half hours from now you will be in a
position where you will have deployed
your first website to the cloud so isn't
that exciting the first very first
lesson you will be deploying your own
website and there are no prerequisites
for this tutorial the best way for you
to learn these skills is to follow along
as you're watching the lesson pause it
at various places follow along type out
all the code yourself don't even copy
paste just type everything out and then
experiment with it using the exercises
that are present in the lesson now you
can find the completed code for this
tutorial here in this GitHub repository
specifically you can open up this folder
my first web page and you will find all
the code that we are covering today in
this
folder so we will explore the basics of
HTML and CSS by attempting to solve this
problem
statement we will create a web page that
show cases job listings for Jovian at
Jovian we have a growing team we have a
growing user base we're adding new
programs so we have certain jobs for
which we want to hire but we don't have
a jobs page yet so we're going to try
and create a jobs page for Jovian and on
this jobs page we're going to show show
a few things we're going to require our
job space to have a few things one is a
nav bar at the top showing the Jovian
logo so something like this this is
called a navigation bar or a nav bar
then we may want a header section
displaying a picture and some relevant
information about Jovan so anybody who
comes to our jobs page should learn a
little bit about the company itself so
we'll have that then maybe a list of job
openings that include the job
designation location and maybe salary
details we'll see what we can put in
there and maybe also a link to apply for
the
job and then a footer at the bottom of
the web page with some important links
so generally at the bottom of any web
page and a website you might include you
might have a bunch of links to other web
pages on the same website or elsewhere
so we are going to try and build all of
this today in the next couple of hours
and we will also attempt to make the
page visually appealing and informative
so let's see how far we can get this is
a fairly ambitious problem statement
while we are also learning the basics of
HTML and CSS now creating your first web
page is actually quite easy all you need
to do is simply create a file put some
text into it and then open that file
within a web browser and while you can
use any any text editor to create the
file and put some text into
it web developers often use editors that
are better suited for programming
because they have certain features that
will help you write code in various
programming languages easily and these
are called code editors or sometimes
also called integrated development
environments okay so in this tutorial
for today we are going to use a code
editor called Visual Studio code now you
can download it for free it is a free
and open- Source tool so you can
download it by going to code dovisual
studio.com all the links are present in
the lesson resources and the lesson
notebook now based on which operating
system you're working on you'll have to
download it for that operating system
you can see that it is available for all
major operating systems and it is
developed by Microsoft so it also has
great Windows support and you should
download it and once it is downloaded
just double click the installer and
follow the instructions to install
install it on your computer and once
it's installed we can then start
creating our very first web page okay so
let's get into
it now the first thing we need to do is
create a project folder typically
whenever you're working on a project
it's a good idea to create a folder
where you're going to put all the files
so that you don't pollute your desktop
or your downloads folder so let me go in
here and let me create a new folder so
I'm going to call this folder let's see
I'm going to call this folder my
first web page okay uh I've just used
hyphens here my first web page um if you
can't see let me just zoom in here a
little
bit yeah so you should be able to see it
now my first web
page all right uh so I've just used
hyphens here my first web page that is
the name of the folder and now we want
to open up this folder in vs code so let
us first open Visual Studio code or VSS
code let me just type Visual Studio code
here and open up visual studio code okay
so now now I've opened up visual studio
code this is what its user interface
looks like you might also see something
like this you might see a sidebar here
as well so that depends you can hide or
show the sidebar you have options to
show this over here now what we want to
do in Visual Studio code is open up this
folder okay so you want to say file open
folder so going to the file menu select
open folder and I'm going to come into
my desktop and select this folder my
first web page don't double click on it
just select it and then click open okay
so now you will immediately see that you
you will see the folder name here in the
sidebar my first web page I hope you can
see it and then you will see this
welcome screen I'm going to close this
welcome screen but now this folder is
open in vs code so VSS code is showing
us this folder and what I can do is I
can now create a file within this folder
directly from vs code so if I just go
here I should see a new button and in
this new button um I can using this new
button I can create a new file and I'm
going to create a file called Web page.
HTML so any web page has the HTML
extension just like images have a JPG
extension or Excel files have XLS
extension so web pages have the HTML
extension okay so now I've created this
file called webpage. HTML and I can
verify that this file is actually
present here web page. HTML you can see
that when I open that window when I open
that folder I you can see that the file
webpage. HTML has been created okay now
let me just get this on to the
right now once I've created this file
webpage. HTML and let me close the
sidebar I'm going to put some text into
it so let me just say hello
HTML all right so I've just written the
words hello HTML into webpage. HTML all
right now here's what I'm going to do I
am going to now open this file webpage.
HTML in the browser so I'm going to say
open with and I'm going to select the
browser that I'm using or sometimes you
can also just double click and it will
automatically open in Google Chrome but
just to be safe I'm opening it with
brave browser that's the browser that
I'm using and you can see as soon as I
opened it the same text that I
entered into the web page. HTML file the
exact same text showed up here you can
see I'm just zooming into about 200% so
that you can see it more clearly okay
let's keep it at 200 all right
so hello HTML is what I typed here and
hello HTML is what showed up when I
opened when I opened web page. HTML in
the web browser so that's it that's how
you create a web page you just create a
text file call it something. HTML and
then open it in a web browser and you
have a web page
however you want to put some kind of a
structure into the web page because we
don't just want to write text we can p
paste a lot of text but it will all just
be text on the screen so that is where
you you use something called Tags so
first let me just put in some code here
so I'm going to create this tag called
HTML and you can see that this tag
starts with a less than symbol or an
arrow bracket and ends with an arrow
bracket and every tag has a tag name in
this case this tag has the name HTML let
me zoom in further so it has the name
HTML and every tag generally has a
closing tag okay so this is the opening
HTML tag and HTML is always the
outermost tag in any web page and then
there is this closing HTML tag and the
difference between the opening and the
closing tag is this slash character
before the tag name okay so any HTML
page or any web page is built up using
tags these tags are used to create
structure within the page okay now
within an HTML tag I'm going to put in a
head tag okay we'll talk about what
these tags do in just a second and again
vs code does this nice thing that as
soon as you create an opening tag it
automatically adds a closing tag for you
and that is why uh develop Vel opers use
these code editors okay and then uh
another tag that I'm going to put in
here is called the body tag okay so now
we have a HTML tag which is the
outermost tag inside it we have the head
tag and the body tag and let me just
save that for a second and reload and
you can see now all the content has gone
away so now nothing is showing up on the
browser because we've not put any
content into the page the first thing
I'm going to do is inside the head tag
I'm going to put in a title tag okay um
so I've just typed title I've created an
opening tag and vs code added a closing
tag for me and let me just say my first
web page here inside the title let me
save that let me come back here into the
browser reload and now you will notice
that nothing has happened here on the
page but if you notice carefully the
browser tab the the browser
heading the tab the browser tab here it
has the title my first web
page okay so it has the title my first
web page and you can zoom in here and I
can zoom in here and I can show you that
has it has a title my first web page all
right now uh let us add something here
in the body so I'm going to just add
something called a div here in the body
so div is again another tag that is used
to put some content into the body and
let me just put here hello HTML and CSS
okay so this is what a typical web page
or typical HTML document looks like it
contains a bunch of tags and then it
contains tags within tags and each tag
has a specific purpose okay so now let
me put that in and let me reload and now
you can see that here we have hello HTML
and CSS and then you can go back and
change this let's say let me make it
hello html/css and let me reload now it
says hello html/css okay so this is how
you construct a web page you put in some
tags and then you open the web page in a
web browser all right so so that's the
basics of how you create an HTML page
you launch vs code open up the project
folder within vs code and then put some
code into it this is HTML code so we put
in an HTML tag head tag title and body
and then save the file once you've added
the code and then open it with a browser
and this is what it looks like okay now
let's understand HTML tags a little
better so tags are the building blocks
of HTML and they are used to describe
the structure and the content of a web
page now normally every tag will have an
opening tag like the HTML tag had an
opening tag like this over here and it
will also have a corresponding closing
tag and sometimes tags can have
attributes and these attributes are used
to provide more information to the
browser or modify the behavior of a
particular tag for example the HTML tag
has this attribute called Lang which is
simply written in within the opening tag
itself and then the attribute Lang is
given a value en n which means English
so here what we doing is we are
indicating to the browser that this
particular HTML page is written in the
English language so now that browser can
use it for let's say uh setting up a
translation automatic translation tool
or something like that right so an
attribute is used to provide some
additional information about that tag or
modify the behavior of that tag and we
look at a lot of attributes with time so
I can say here for example HTML Lang
equal to
en and that doesn't do anything visible
but that does inform the browser that
this is an English web page all right
now uh so that's about tags and a tag
can contain one or more children so like
the head and the body are called the
children of the HTML tag and a tag along
with its children together is called an
element okay so the tag is simply this
piece this is the opening tag and this
is the closing tag everything inside a
tag is called its children which is
again other tags and then a tag together
with the children is called an element
so this this whole thing is an element
and then this is an element and then
this is an element so every tag along
with its children is an element and then
what whatever is inside a tag is called
children okay these are just some
terminology that you'll see when you're
reading about HTML and CSS all right now
tags contain attributes we talked about
that that and there are various
different tags to create headings
paragraphs lists images Etc and we look
at those in just a bit now one thing I
want to mention is that HTML is the
outermost tag however in many web pages
you will find a dock type declaration
just above the HTML tag so you will find
something like this you will find a doc
type let me zoom in here so you will
find Doc type HTML at the top of most
web pages and that is just a good
convention that is followed that at the
top of every HTML web page it's a good
idea to just put this dock type HTML
okay and this this is just something
that you cop copy paste at the top of
every HTML web page and you can
literally just go on Google and search
doc type
declaration okay and you can find this
link HTML doc type declaration and you
can just copy this and put it at the top
of each HTML page and if you want to
understand what this does you can I
encourage you to go through this H W3
schools link uh it's not important it's
just a convention that you want to put
in because there have been multiple
versions of HTML and this is a way for
you to indicate that you want to use the
latest version of HTML to the browser
okay now we have the doc type then we
have a bunch of these tags now the HTML
tag is the outmost tag we already talked
about that and the HTML tag is typically
only contains two other tags the head
tag and the body tag and it has a lang
attribute and it has some other
attributes also that can be set and
you'll see a dock type declaration just
above HTML so that's the HTML tag okay
then we have the head and title tags
which are the tags that we are seeing
here so the head tag is a container tag
in HTML that often doesn't contain any
content that is going to be visible on
the page exactly but it generally
contains some information that is passed
on to the browser and that is useful for
the browser and that is also useful when
you're sharing this link with somebody
else so for example it contains the
title tag we put in the title tag over
here in the head and the title tag is
used to set the title of the browser tab
similarly there are some meta tags so
and then some meta image tags Etc and
these are used to set the preview image
and the description that shows up when
you share this link on a social platform
or when this is seen by a search engine
or something like that okay so the head
tag is very useful it is also used to
sometimes include maybe stylesheets CSS
um files and sometimes used to include
scripts we'll cover all of these don't
worry if these terms don't make sense
just yet for now we just using the title
tag within head so within head we just
have the title tag and then we have the
body tag now within any HTML page you
have a body tag and the body tag defines
the main content of the HTML document it
is usually placed after the head tag and
it contains all the visible elements of
a web page okay and the body tag can
also include other HTML tags like
headings paragraphs links Etc and here
is the key thing here is the key
difference between just putting some
text into a file versus putting it in
the body tag and putting it in in HTML
tags you can add styling you can add
colors fonts you can change the layout
and you can even add interactivity using
JavaScript and CSS right so all of these
things are applied within the elements
in the body tag to change the appearance
and functionality of the web page which
is what we're going to do today so here
is an example of a web page with some
content within the body tag so here
there is an H1 uh which is a heading tag
we'll talk about it there is a paragraph
tag there is an image tag and there is a
a tag so I will not paste these right
now but I'll actually leave these as an
exercise so maybe maybe just try and
paste this into an HTML Page open it in
the web browser and see what you can
come up with okay so that is the body
tag it is what contains all the content
of the web page that we are going to be
building
today then we
have the div tag okay now you notice
that inside the body I did not directly
put in hello HTML CSS I created a div so
I didn't have to do this I could have
just put it into the body itself
but the div tag is typically an HTML
element that is used to group and
organize other HTML elements together
for example you can create one one piece
of content here in this first div div
this is some content and then you can
have a second piece of content under in
this second div and then you can have
maybe a third piece of content which is
itself divided into multiple pieces of
content in this third div okay so div
stands for division and it literally
creates a division on the page
vertically speaking it kind of divides
the page vertically essentially you can
think about it and it is used to divide
or group content into logical sections
and it is a block level element which
means that it takes up the full width
when you add a div tag it takes up the
full width and then the next div tag is
going to appear below it and the next
div tag is going to appear below it and
so
on and it does not have any its own
style or semantic meaning or anything
but it is used with CSS for styling okay
so the div tag is something that we will
attach a lot of CSS properties into to
style the web page so let us create a
let us look at an example of a web page
create containing some div tags okay so
here is the content that we're going to
put in or type in one by one so first
let us create a div tag and let us
[Music]
say this
is
some content okay so now we have put in
some content into div tag and it says
this is some content as we might expect
then let me create another d tag and let
me say this is a second line of
content okay now if I reload the page
you will notice that this content showed
up below this content so that is what
the div tag is creating it is basically
creating a division within the page so
this content is shows up in this area
and then this content shows up below it
in this area now notice that I can go
into the next line I I can type this
is isn't a third line
now I'm not creating a new div tag I'm
still using the second div tag but this
time you can see that even though I've
typed this content on a new line it is
still showing up on the same line as the
second line okay so here is the
important of importance of div if you
want to split content vertically on a on
a web page then you want to create Dives
and each div is going to create a new
vertical section or New Vertical
division within the web page okay and if
if you simply create multiple lines of
content like this all of that is going
to show up in a straight line that is
not necessarily going to show up one
below the other now here is another
example now this time I have a div div
tag but inside the div I'm then creating
more div so
sum
more lines okay so now I have this third
div tag and now in this third div tag I
have again another div tag three more
div tags one around each word so now
even though all these three div tags are
on the same line within the HTML source
code you can see that each div each
inner div tag takes up its own vertical
space okay so that's what I want to
convey here that as you want to keep
building as you want to keep adding
content below the existing content on a
web page you should be creating new div
tags okay so that is the div tag and
those are the most basic basic HTML tags
now we've just looked at what the head
the HTML tag we've looked at the head
and title tags we've looked at the body
tag we have looked at the div tag and
I'll encourage you to experiment with
this what we really want to do though is
maybe first figure out what our web what
we want our web page to look like okay
so when when you're building a web page
it's a good idea to First plan ahead and
create what is called a wireframe and
this is what a wireframe for a web page
look like it just it is just a rough
drawing of what the web page should look
like okay that's what we typically
called a wireframe like you don't put in
colors you don't put in exact fonts and
sizes of fonts Etc you just put a rough
diagram of the structure of the page and
you can use that as a visual guide while
you're writing the HTML and CSS okay now
if you don't already have a design to
work with then sometimes it can be
confusing if you're trying to design
your web page as you're trying to code
it so the having a wireframe is going to
help a lot and you can use you can
create a wireframe using pen and paper
or you can use digital whiteboards like
excal draw.com so excal draw.com is a
digital whiteboard so this is what it
looks like and here on this digital
whiteboard you can create boxes you can
create circles you can create lines you
can add
text and you can do a bunch of things to
create U your wireframe okay so you can
use a digital whiteboard any any one of
your choice but I like using excal
ra.com
um and the idea here is to separate the
design and the implementation process to
help you focus on one aspect of the
development at a time okay now I will
note however that professional web
developers work with the detailed design
mockup of the page and not generally
wireframes because these design mockups
or these design specifications are often
created by uiux designers uh with a
standardized design system so normally
at a company you will receive a
full-fledged design and that design will
have all the colors all the fonts and
everything specified there and you'll be
working from that but for your own
personal project it's okay to maybe just
do a quick wireframe and then figure out
the design over time okay so let's
recall the problem statement and then
create a wireframe for the problem
statement we want to create a web page
that showcases job listings for Jovian
and it includes a nav bar at the top of
the page showing the Jovin logo it
includes a header section displaying a
picture and some relevant information
then it includes a list of job openings
that includes the job designation
location and then it includes a footer
at the bottom of the web page with some
important links okay so keeping these
requirements in mind let us try to First
design very broad very rough in a very
rough fashion let's try to design what
this web page should look like okay so
I'm just going to zoom to an area of
excal draw where I can actually design
now you might see a bunch of these
controls here so when you're actually
dra drawing you might have these
controls and you can always hide them so
there's an option called Zen mode here
uh but here let's say this is what our
web page is going to look like okay now
at the top of this web page we want a
jovian logo so I'm just going to put a
box here indicating the Jovian logo and
I'm just going to put the word Jovian
here all right and so now that's the
Jovian logo that is going to show up at
the top of the page and this is going to
be the navigation bar so maybe let me
just put a
separator between this and the rest of
the page then let us uh we want maybe a
banner image a header section with a
banner image and some information about
Jovin so let's say this is going to be
an image so I'm just going to draw maybe
like some hills here uh we'll figure out
something better than a hills and a sun
but uh here we're going to put here
we're going to put an image and then
below the image maybe we could have a
section called about Jovan because when
somebody visits a job base job page we
also want to tell them a little bit
about Jovian so let me come in here and
let me just put in about Jovian and then
uh maybe on the left here we want a
picture of the team so here we're going
to have a a team
picture maybe a bunch of people
here all right very very rough
drawing and here on on the right here
and on the left maybe we have some
information about Jan okay so some info
about J now I'll show you a quick trick
sometimes you need to generate or you
need to get a bunch of text to fill the
page now that you can do using this tool
called lurm ipsum so loremipsum
doio okay lurm .io and the link is in
the notebook is a quick tool to generate
as much text as you need as many
paragraphs of text as you need so I'm
just going to copy a bunch of this
random text this doesn't mean anything
I'm just going to put that in here and
let me just split it into multiple
lines okay so yeah just about that and
maybe also let me reduce its size a
little bit so now we have this let me
change its
color yeah now we have this about Jan
section this nice about Jan section over
here and let's move all this here as
well so one nice thing about digital
whiteboards say you can move some of
this stuff around and then let us put a
section called job
opportunities okay and in this section
job opportunities I'm going to just make
that black in color once
again in the section called job
opportunities let's make that a little
bigger like that let us put in a few job
roles so we have a job Ro for a front
end
developer
and then we have a job rooll uh and this
is in bangaluru
India and maybe we want like an apply
button
here okay or an apply link or apply
button or something let's put that here
a small apply button let's make this a
little
smaller like
that so that is what
our uh that is what a single job roll
looks like and now once again the good
thing about these digital whiteboards is
I can just take this and I can create a
copy and create a second job rooll and
copy and create a third job rooll all
right so let's call this backend
developer and let's call this data
scientist and maybe let's also put
something like remote here and let me
put Mumbai India here right and uh apart
from the jobs we maybe also want to have
a footer at the bottom of the page so
I'm going to just add a separation here
and maybe I'm just going to add a few
links so one link to
coures one link to programs and one link
to
YouTube okay and just put that in here
coures
programs YouTube Let's Line these up so
these are going to be our footer
links and finally right at the bottom
I'm just going to add a copyright notice
copyright 2023
Jian and let's make that a little
smaller and put that in here as well
okay so yeah just in about four or five
minutes we have just created a wireframe
for what our web page should look like
all right and then you can C you can
take this whole thing and you can copy
it as PNG and save it somewhere maybe
you can send it to uh send it to a
coworker for review you can just like
copy that as a PNG or I think you also
have the option to export it you can go
in here and you can actually export the
image as well um so this is a good thing
to do anytime you're building a web page
first it's a good idea to just go ahead
and create a wireframe using a digital
whiteboard and something that you can
modify easily as well okay so now that
we have this wireframe you can see here
this is what the wireframe looks like we
have the nav bar we have an image we
have an about Jian section we have the
job opportunities we have an apply
button or apply link and then we have a
footer at the bottom okay so I encourage
you to again try and replicate this
wireframe on your own using excal maybe
try adding a additional section here and
there just to see if you can do this on
your own okay so you should be following
along with this lesson pausing the video
following along pausing the video
following along and trying to make
changes here and there just to
experiment with things okay so now that
we have created this wireframe we can
now use this wireframe as a reference to
add content in our HTML page okay so
right now we don't have any useful
content in our HTML page so we can start
adding the content one by one and the
first thing that we're going to add is
headings so let's figure out what
headings we have within our web page so
here we have a couple of headings we
have this heading called about Jovian we
have this heading called job
opportunities and then I could even
consider these as headings of each of
the jobs okay so heading is generally
just some big text on the page it is
maybe the start of a section it is maybe
a start of a subsection or it is maybe
the most important piece of text in a
particular element on the page so I'm
going to consider about Jovian job
opportunities and front end developer
backend developer data scientist as
headings now there are various kinds of
headings in HTML uh in fact specifically
there are six heading tags uh these tags
are H1 to H6 and H1 is the highest or
the biggest heading tag and H6 is the
lowest now heading should always be used
in a logical order and should accurately
describe the content on the page so if
you're using H1 then for subsections you
should be using H2 and then for Sub sub
section you should be using H3 and so on
don't use an H2 as the heading of the
entire page and an H1 in the middle of
the page because that is going to
confuse people even though you can
change their font sizes from the default
but still it's logically it makes sense
for you to use um use the
headings that are uh use headings
appropriately within the page so H1
should be used for the most important
heading H2 for the subheading and so on
okay so let's go ahead and let's add
some headings into our page so the first
thing I'm going to do is clear all of
this let me also
just
let's see let me get rid of this piece
over
here yeah so the first thing I've done
is I've cleared out all the existing
content on the page and let me save that
and that that has all gone away so let's
add the headings one by one the biggest
heading on my page is about Jovian so
let me add that and once I do that you
can see that okay now now I have a nice
big about Jan section the next heading
on the page is job
opportunities great and then we have
three of these jobs so you can see here
we have front- end developer backend
developer data scientist so let's go H3
frontend
developer
H3 backend
developer and
H3 data
scientist okay I can go up to H6 but I'm
just going to use these three headings
here now we have this nice
logical separation between headings so
we have about Jovian then we have job
opportunities and then we have these
three job roles and all these three job
roles should use the same header ideally
because they're indicating the same
level of hierarchy okay so that is how
you create headings really
straightforward just put H1 H2 H3 and
keep going all right so now we've added
headings and this is what that looks
like great and our page is start slowly
starting to take shape not exactly what
we're looking for just yet but it's
getting there next is there are specific
text there there are specific tags for
adding text specifically we have a
couple of tags one is a P tag or a
paragraph tag and the second is a span
tag and both are used to define text in
HTML so this is some text you can see
that we we going to add below about Jin
and this is added using the P tag so the
P tag defines a paragraph of text and it
is typically used for longer sections of
text that form a distinct block so if
you have an entire paragraph that is
what you should put into a P tag and and
then the span tag defines a small
section of text typically if you have
maybe just a few words or maybe a single
line somewhere within a div you can use
it and it is typically used for inline
styling let's say you have a longer
piece of text and within it you want to
make uh some specific piece of text
bigger or of a different color then you
will wrap that around a span and we look
at examples as we go along but p and
span are the two tags that are used to
create text on a web page okay of course
you don't need to use a span or a p you
can directly put a text within the div
tag as you saw already but p and span
give some one they semantically inform
the browser that now inside this tag
there is going to be text and second the
div is going to automatically create a
vertical separation the span doesn't do
that so sometimes if you want text to
maybe join together and show show up in
a single line you can use a span and the
P tag has some spacing before and after
so it automatically adds some separation
between the text and the rest of the
content Okay so so let's use the P tag
to add some description below about
Jovian so here is the description that
we're going to add at Jovian we're on a
mission to build the world's highly most
highly reputed Technical University and
we're building it complete building it
completely online let me change that to
it and we're building it completely
online we offer several beginner
friendly courses that are taken by
300,000 plus registered users okay so
right below the H1 right below the
section here I can put in all of this
content and I can just click save and
then I reload this and you can see that
this P tag has been added and in this P
tag we have this basic text now somebody
had a question why not use a div tag
here well if I just use a div
tag you can see that the amount of well
it it works just just fine but as you
noticed as we put in multiple paragraphs
of text you will notice that the P tag
automatically adds some gap between
paragraphs so that is going to be the
difference between using a P tag versus
using a Dev tag
okay all right so now we've added a P
tag then uh the other place where we can
possibly use a span is within the job
opportunity section notice that under
each job opportunity we have also put in
the location of the job so let's put
that location of a job using the using a
span okay so here's what I'm going to do
I am going to first
wrap I'm going to create a span and I'm
going to take the span and the H3 and
put that in a div tag because each job
is logically separated so each job we
want it to show up in a logically
separated area that is why we're putting
a div around the uh job okay and don't
worry if this doesn't make sense if
you're wondering when should I put a div
around something when should I not put a
div around something well uh you just
experiment with ITT HTML is all about
experimentation all right so here we
have an H3 tag and then I'm going to put
a span and I'm going to put in bangaluru
India then I'm going to put in another
div here and I'm going to move this
backend developer role here and I'm
going to put in a span I'm going to put
in let's put remote
here and I'm going to put in another div
here and I'm going to put
in the third H3
here and I'm going to put in a
span let's put Mumbai India here okay so
now we have added these job
opportunities uh locations and we' put
each of the job opportunities plus
location in a div tag now one quick
thing I want to show you is let's say
you're typing and maybe things go a
little bit Haywire uh and you don't have
this nice indentation or this nice
logical structure visible anymore just
right click and select format document
and that is going to automatically
arrange all the tags in this nice
fashion that tags that are children of
an outer tag are automatically going to
get some indent a or some space before
them and then it's also going to split
up the lines nicely so anytime you want
you can right click and select format
document and there's also a keyboard
shortcut to do it and then you can save
it and let's reload now and all right so
now it's starting to look a little
better now we have the front end
developer role and under it we have
bangaluru India then we have backend
developer under it we have remote and
data scientist under it we have Mumbai
right so our notebook our our web page
is starting to take sh ape pretty nicely
okay so now we have this information now
apart from this there are also several
smaller modifier tags so there's a tag
called B in case you want to make
something bold in with within a
paragraph there's a tag called I in case
you want to make something a talic there
is a tag called u in case you want to
underline something now you can use
these tags in between I'll show you an
example let's say we want to highlight
300,000 plus I'm just going to put it in
a b tag so there's a opening B tag and
and then there is a closing B tag and
you can see that 300,000 is now bold
however these specific tags are slowly
falling out of fashion what is being
done instead is you just put a span
around a specific piece of text and then
use it use CSS to style it and we look
at CSS soon so uh just know that
although you have all these tags the use
of these modified tags is now considered
a bit outdated and it is recommended to
use CSS Styles instead okay so but still
as an exercise I will encourage you to
just play around with these tags and
check them out okay perfect so now we
have looked at text we have looked at
headings we have looked at spans as well
um next let us look at lists in HTML so
almost every web page that you might
have seen contains some form of lists
and there are two types of lists in HTML
specifically there are more but these
are the two that are commonly used one
is an unordered HTML list and an
unordered HT list is simply a bullet
list it does not have any ordering it is
ordered but it doesn't have numbers for
the elements or the items within the
list and then you have an ordered HTML
list and ordered HTML list simply has
numbers associated with each of the
items and special HTML tags are used to
create lists which allow for
presentation of information in an
organized and structured manner so there
are two types of lists as I said
unordered and the unordered lists are
created using the UL tag and then list
items within an unordered list are
created using the LI tag and bullet
points are used to denote the list items
and you can change the appearance of
bullet points using CSS or using some
attributes as
well similarly you have ordered lists
and ordered lists are created using the
o tag so o is ordered list UL is
unordered list and list items are added
using the LI tag and numbers or
characters are used to denote list items
okay and the appearance of the numbers
can be customized using CSS or using
attributes within the HTML element
itself you can also Nest lists within
each other so you can have maybe a list
and then each list item can have a sub
list inside it and so on so you can do a
bunch of interesting things but it's
important to close all your tags
properly to ensure that the page is
rendered properly otherwise the browser
is going to run into issues and things
are going to look a little weird Okay so
remember we had a footer on our page uh
let's try and maybe this looks like a
list of links so let's try and maybe
create
an unordered list for the footer
elements so I'm going to come in here
and again I'm going to just create a
logical Separation by creating a div and
I'm going to create a UL or unordered
list and then in the unordered list I'm
going to have three list item so I have
a list item called
courses and I have a list item called
programs and I have a list item
called
YouTube okay and then below this I also
have this cop copyright thing you can
see we have this thing copyright 2023
Jovian so I need the copyright character
so I'm just going to go on Google and
I'm just going to search
Copyright
symbol okay this is the copyright symbol
and I can just go ahead and copy it from
here and paste it so this is how you get
special characters in your HTML you just
search the special character online and
then you can copy it from there and put
it in so
copyright 2023
Jian okay now let's reload the page and
just like that you can see here at the
bottom of the page we have courses
programs YouTube and we have copyright
2023 Chan great so our page is taking
shape and apart from this let's also add
a an ordered list somewhere so maybe in
the about Jovian section in this region
let's maybe also list the programs that
we offer so let's add another paragraph
here let's see what do we want to do
well we we we add another paragraph and
we're going to say we also offer two
industry focused boot camps so let's
create another paragraph
p and let us put in this text we also
offer to Industry Focus boot camps and
in this paragraph let us create an
ordered list because we are we have two
programs and we can list them one by one
so let's create an Li here one or
actually I don't need to put the number
one the number one is going to come
automatically full stack
developer boot camp and then the second
one
is data science boot
camp okay I think we want Jian first
developer boot camp and Jovian data
science boot camp all right so now you
can see that we have we offer two
industry Focus boot camps the Jovian
fullstack developer boot camp and the
Jan data science boot camp and the
numbers one and two have been added
automatically just as it was done in the
the case of the fter items where here it
just added a bunch of bullet
points great so so far so good we have
added some lists as well and that has
added some more content on the page next
up we can add some links now since we
have added some footer uh we had added
some footer items we also added maybe
couple of programs so we can now link
these to other Pages you know that any
web page on the internet typically
contains links to other pages and that
is how you navigate a website now links
can be to the same website links can be
to other web pages on the internet um it
it is completely up to you but links in
HTML are created using the a tag the a
tag is used to create hyperlinks and the
a tag must have an hre attribute to
specify the URL of the destination page
and the text that is displayed as the
link is placed between the opening and
closing a tags and let's say you want
the link to open in a new tab then you
can use a Target attribute to specify
where the link page should open Okay so
let's see that step by step let's first
do this for the Jovian fullstack
developer boot camp so what we what we
want to do is we don't just want to show
this text Jovian fullstack developer
boot camp we actually want it to point
to the program application page because
let's say somebody's applying for a job
but they also want to see what kind of
programs we offer it would be a good
idea to maybe just link that from here
so let me go to
www.job.com
and I'm going to scroll down here and
I'm going to find the section full stack
developer boot camp I'm I'm going to
grab the link of that and let's come
back here and let's create an a tag
inside the LI item so inside the list
item we creating an a tag so a and then
you provide an href href href is the
attribute and then the attribute value
is always put within double codes so
Within These double quotes I'm going to
paste the link okay and then I'm going
to close the a tag and I'm going to take
the closing tag and put it outside the
text okay so now you have a HF and then
you have the HF of the or the you have
the URL of the Jin fullstack developer
boot camp and then you have closing the
a tag inside the LI tag so remember your
tags have to be matched up properly when
you you cannot put the a tag closing a
tag outside the LI tag because that is
going to cause some problems so just be
careful as you're doing this and now if
I reload the page you can see that
clicking on this is going to take me to
the full stack developer Boot Camp Page
great let me grab the data science boot
camp page as
well so data science boot camp copy that
link and once again let's put that on a
new line let's create an a tag here AHF
equals oops yep data science boot camp
and let's take the closing a tag and
let's put it
here and let's save that and now we have
the Jovin data science boot camp linked
from here here as well and that is how
easy it is to add links within a web
page let's go ahead and maybe let's also
link a bunch of these footer links so
I'm going to come in here and I'm going
to
say let's
see a href
equals let me just point it to jan.com
learn for
now yeah all right and let me also point
the second one to jan.com
learn okay so both the courses and the
programs footer links for now are just
going to go to the same page join.com
learn and then the third footer link let
me point that to our YouTube channel so
a href
equals PPS
youtube.com at Jovian
HQ
okay let me just format that so let's
say format document and that's going to
just indent things a little better all
right so now we have this courses link
that opens the courses and we have the
programs link that opens the programs um
but of course both are going to the same
place uh but what we have here is is
this particular section within the page
it actually has an ID so this section
has an ID called courses so if we
actually type something like this ash
courses at the end of the
URL okay that doesn't seem to
work never mind yep so uh yeah we have
linked the courses we've linked the
programs and we've linked the YouTube
channel now one thing that I want to do
here is I also want to add a new I want
these links to open in a new tab I don't
want want to change the current tab
because if somebody's looking for jobs I
don't want to get distracted and lose
track of the jobs page so I'm just going
to add Target equals underscore blank
okay so anytime what does this mean what
does underscore blank mean why do you
need that underscore don't worry about
all that this is a very standard syntax
anytime you need to open a link in a new
tab just put Target equals uncore blank
as an additional attribute in your a tag
okay that's all it is used for um there
are other targets that are possible as
well but underscore blank is typically
what you should be using in most cases
okay so now if I click on
courses that is going to open it in a
new tab Okay then if I click on programs
that is going to open it in a new tab if
I click on YouTube that's going to open
it in a new tab all right so now we've
added links and our page is shaping up
quite well now we have links on the page
as well what next what else is missing
from our page so we've added headings we
we've added some text we've added some
um jobs as well uh We've added footer
links I think the images are missing so
let's add the images as well how do you
add images in HTML well so the way to
add images in HTML is using the IMG tag
so there's a tag called IMG and you can
use that to add images now the just like
links are added using the a tag a a is
short for anchor so links are added
using the anchor tag or a tag and you
have to specify an href attribute
similarly images are added using the IMG
tag and you can specify the SRC
attribute with the location of the image
the image could be on your computer the
image could be next to the web page
basically or the image could be
somewhere on the internet both of these
work um you can just specify the
location of the image using the SRC
attribute apart from that because images
also typically have you should also
indicate what that image is about this
is for screen readers and for search
engines Etc so you can also add an ALT
attribute or an ALT attribute which is
used to provide an alternative text for
the image which is displayed if the
image is not loaded and it is also read
by screen readers for people who are
unable to see the image and it is also
read automatically by search engines uh
to improve the visibility of your page
on
search now the width and height
attributes of the image can also be set
using the width attribut and the height
attribute and you can specify the width
or height of the image as pixels on the
screen so if you know the resolution of
your screen the resolution of your
screen is typically given in pixels for
example 1 1280 pixels horizontally and
720 pixels vertically something like
that so you can specify the height and
width of the image in pixels as well
okay now the last thing is that the
image tag or the IMG tag is a self
closing tag which means that it does not
require a closing tag you just put the
IMG tag you put its SRC you put its alt
alt attribute you put its width you put
its height and if you want and that's it
you don't have to put a closing tag you
don't have to put anything within the
image tag as children
okay so let's check out some images that
we can possibly use we need a couple of
images One image here as the banner
that's going to show up on the entire
page left to right and one one one image
here which is going to show up here on
the right okay so how can we add how can
you find these images well one good
place to find great photos that you can
use for free is unsplash so unsplash.com
is a great place so I'm going to search
for career here and let me scroll down
to find an image that might be good as a
banner I think this image looks good so
this image is a nice image that I could
use as a banner on the page maybe not
the entire height of the image but maybe
like just this section would be good so
I'm just going to go here and I'm going
to say download free and from here I'm
selecting the medium size okay so that
is going to download a JPG file and I'm
going to come into my desktop go into
the folder where I actually have the
webpage. HTML file and put in the image
file here so let me just call it
banner.jpg
okay so now we've created a banner.jpg
file so that is going to be the banner
that we use on the page let me grab
another image which is going to show up
here maybe here I want to show a team
picture
so let me close this and let me search
for team let's see if we can find a good
team
image or let's search for
maybe people
working okay that looks good not the
Jovian team but uh never mind we can
still put it on the careers page so
let's download this also in medium
quality so let's go and call this
team.jpg
all right so now if I open up the
sidebar once again by the way you can
open the sidebar using this button here
or you can also just use command b or I
believe it's controlb on Windows you can
see that along with webpage. HTML we now
have these files team.jpg and banner.jpg
and now we can add these images into
our HTML page so the first image the
banner. jpg image is going to show up
above the heading about about Jovian so
I'm just going to add IMG SRC equals and
paste okay I'm just going to put in the
file name here banner. jpg remember this
could also be a URL of an image on the
cloud or somewhere on the internet but
for now the image is right here next to
the file that I have so I can just put
that and let me just put the alt text
here and the alt text I'm going to put
here is uh Banner this is just the
banner and I'm going to close this tag
let me now reload the page and you can
see that the image has been added here
but it's too big let me just shorten the
image so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just say height equals and I'm
going to set the height of the image to
let's say 360 pixels so when I say
height equals 360 and reload now you can
see that the height of the image has
been reduced to 360 pixels okay I can
reduce it further maybe just for now and
we can make it bigger later yeah now the
height of the image has been reduced so
now we have this image of course it's
not laid out how we want but it's there
in the right place and then the second
team image is going to show up on the
right side so in some sense right is
next or after so I'm just going to put
that second image after this speed
tag before job opportunities so I'm
going to say IMG SRC equals
team. jpg and ALT equals
team and let me give it a height of uh
200 okay let's reload that okay so now
we have the image here as well great so
again you should what you should be
doing is pausing this video watching
maybe 5 minutes and then following along
typing out everything on your own and
build this step by step the best way to
become a better programmer is to just
code write a lot of code and even if
you're writing the code that you're
seeing on the screen you should be
asking yourself what that code means and
you should be experimenting with it a
little bit and if something breaks you
should be searching online and maybe
asking us a question okay that is how
you're supposed to do this it's not
enough to just watch this but at this
point I feel like we have all the
content that we require on the page it's
just not laid out properly all right so
we have all the content let's see yeah
we have all the content we needed we
have this about Jovian we have this
image okay maybe we don't have this
Navar logo right now how about we fix
that sometime later we we'll figure it
out U but we have job opportunities we
have uh this image here we have this
footer and we have this copyright
section now one thing I want to mention
about HTML tags and CSS HTML and CSS in
general is that there is so much here so
many different tags and everything that
you shouldn't go about trying to learn
every single tag and every single
attribute of every tag before you start
building web pages because then you'll
just be doing that for years it's uh you
should take the opposite approach where
you start trying to build something and
whenever you feel that okay you're not
able to build it with the tags you
already know then go and search online
to see if there is a certain tag or
maybe a certain other CSS property that
is going to help you do it and over time
the things that are going to be used
most frequently are going to become
second nature to you and you won't need
to look them up that is what I do I
still look up some fairly basic stuff on
CSS even after 15 plus years of web
development and I do this every every
week so uh one exercise for you is to
check out this tutorial on HTML
dog.com on the
various beginner and intermediate level
tags so you can check out the HTML
beginner tutorial in the HTML
intermediate tutorial so up once you're
done with this lesson itself check this
out at the very least go through all
these different types of tags and if you
have the time you can also go through
Advan but that is something that we're
going to cover in a future lesson anyway
okay but this is a good place for you to
practice another good place for you to
practice is the w3schools.com website
this contains a great HTML tutorial so
if you want to learn about a specific
type of HTML tag just go find it in the
sidebar here and go ahead and do it we
are not going to look at every single
HTML tag here because that's that is
defeating the point the the reason we
are here is because we want to build
good web pages okay so let's move
forward we are halfway there let's go
ahead and style the web page P now
cascading stylesheets or css is used to
describe the presentation of HTML
documents it allows you to control
layout and it allows you to control the
appearance by defining styles for
elements such as fonts colors margins
borders and more so let's look at some
different ways to apply CSS Styles there
are a few ways to do this by and we'll
do this by attempting to just Center
this about Jovian heading we just want
to bring it into the center of the page
um horizontally speaking we want to
bring it in the horizontal Center like
that and let's see how we can achieve
that using CSS okay so the first way to
do it is using something called inline
Styles now in inline Styles you can
achieve this simply using the style
attribute and you can put that directly
within whatever HTML tag you're trying
to style so let's say we have H1 and we
want to style it so we want to set the
style and then within the style
attribute we want to set this as the
value value so this is what a CSS
declaration looks like so what you do is
you declare certain properties about
that tag using CSS you have a CSS
property so here the property that you
are fixing is called text align and
there are hundreds of such properties
but text align is the property that is
used to decide the alignment of the text
should the text be aligned on the left
Center or right and then you have a
colon the colon separates the property
from the value and then you have a value
okay so all of that goes inside the
double quotes that are used to enclose
the value of the attribute so yeah so
you have the CSS property and then you
have a colon and then you have the value
and then you have a semicolon to end the
Declaration and then you can have
multiple declarations here let's say
apart from Center lining it you also
want to change the color to Indigo that
is something that you can do here as
well okay so that is the simplest way to
apply H uh apply CSS to some HTML tags
you simply go in into the HTML and then
you add a style attribute now within the
style attribute you add a property so
let's say we want to do text
align and for now let me put Center here
and then you put so you have the
property colon you have the value
generally CSS values do not require qu
quotations some of them do most of them
don't and then you put a semicolon and
let me save that and let let's just
reload that here and just like that this
is centered now you can experiment you
can go and change this to right and you
can see that that should bring you to
bring it to the right of the page and
again you can go back and change it to
Center and that should bring it to the
center of the page okay let me also add
a color so color is added using the
color attribute and let me set the color
to Indigo you can create any color you
want using something called an RGB or a
hex formula but there are some named
colors within CSS and you can always
look these up so you can search CSS
named colors so these colors are
recognized by every uh these colors are
already recognized by every browser so
these are all the colors that are
already available in CSS and you can use
all of these color names whenever you
want directly okay for example I could
use dark blue instead of indigo and that
would work as well and let me just
reload the page here and you can see
that now the content is centered on the
page um just the about Jovian heading is
centered on the page and it has the
color dark blue okay if you want want to
create colors that are not named already
in CSS then we'll talk about that in the
next lesson all right
um so that is one way to add Styles this
is called the inline style and you
simply add a bunch of CSS declarations
in the style attribute the other thing
because you might want to add a bunch of
different styles or you might want to
add the same set of styles to multiple
tags is to use a style tag so you can
create a style tag with within the head
or the body and then you can put some
CSS code within the style tag let me put
the uh let me create a style tag within
the head here so I'm just going going to
create
style and now inside the style tag the
first thing you need to put in is a
selector because now you no longer know
where you want to apply the style to
unlike this attribute which was
associated with a tag already so you
need to put in a selector okay so there
are many ways to select a particular or
a bunch of HTML tags on the page the
easiest way to select a bunch of tags is
by the tag name so when you say
H1 and then you open these braces or
curly brackets what you're seeing that
whatever I put Within These curly
brackets or these braces should be
applied to all the H1 tags on the page
now of course here we have just one H1
tag but if you had multiple of those
then it would apply to multiple H1 tags
but let me get rid of the inline style
here so now that the inline style is
gone you can see it's back to this
position and now in the style tag I'm
just going to
write text align
Center and now one of the benefits of
using a style tag is you can use
multiple lines you can make your code
easier to read instead of stuffing a
bunch of styles within the same
attribute and color what was that deep
blue or dark blue
yeah okay so now we have about Jovian
which is at the center of the page
horizontally and it has the dark blue
color okay now notice that this style
did not get applied to any other element
on the page but suppose this second
element on the page job opportunities
was also an H1 tag you will notice now
that job opportunities is also receiving
the same style that the first H1
received okay so that is the benefit of
using the style tag you don't have to
retype the same style over and over for
each
tag but let's revert that back for now
we are going to make this in
H2 okay so that is the second way to do
it which is let's just revert that yeah
this is fine so that is the second way
to do it which is using the style tag so
in the style tag you have a selector and
then you have this bracket and then you
have a property and then you have a
property value okay and then you close
the bracket and of course you can have
multiple properties that you can apply
using a to the tags that have been
selected using this selector and the
simplest selector is just a tag we look
at other selectors as well now yet
another way to create to apply CSS to an
HTML file is to create a separate file
containing CSS this is very popular
because that way you can put all your
Styles in a single file and all your
HTML in a single file and then link the
file link the CSS file within the HTML
page using the link tag okay so you use
a link tag to specify within the HTML
page that the the Styles should be
picked up from this particular CSS file
so let's do this let's create a file
styles.css let's first get rid of this
H1 all of that and let's get rid of the
style
tag okay and you can see that the style
is gone now let us open up the sidebar
once again and let us create a new file
styles. CSS and now in this styles. CSS
file let us add H1
and let us
put text align Center and let us put
color dark blue okay and let's save that
and let's reload the page nothing
happened because we've not connected the
CSS file with the HTML file so let's
come back here and now I don't need the
sidebar anymore let's add a link here so
link is a tag special tag this typically
used for adding stylesheets and it has a
structure like this so you say Rel
equals stylesheet you basic you
basically specify what is the relevance
of this link to this page so Styles
sheet or what is the relation of this
link to this page stylesheet and then
you say hrf equal
to styles.css
okay and that's it and again you don't
need a closing tag this is a self
closing tag so there are a lot of self
closing tags in HTML now this hre can be
a c file that is sitting right next to
your web page or it could be in a sub
folder let's say it was in a folder
called CSS then you could put it under
CSS styles.css or you could also specify
something on the Internet so that is
what is done typically with Frameworks
like bootstrap somebody has put up a
bunch of styles on the internet and we
simply include it link it to our page
using the link tag and notice that the
link tag is different from the a tag
which is the anchor tag which is used to
add links on the web page the link tag
is used to to Simply link stylesheets
it's a bit confusing the terminology
because of how HTML evolved but uh
that's what it is okay so now we have
link Rel equal stylesheet styles.css
let's reload the page and once again
this is now back to the center and it
has the deep blue color okay so those
are the three ways in which you add CSS
you have the style attribute you have
the style tag and then you have CSS
files now one thing I want to mention is
CSS stands for cascading Styles sheets
and inline styles take precedence over
style tags and style tags I believe take
precedence over the um
external external files and there are
also other ways in which precedence is
decided so for example I if I went in
here and I added a style tag I did a
style attribute and I changed the color
to Black again you will notice that even
though the styles. CSS file says color
dark blue because I've specified the
style explicitly on the H1 tag that
takes precedence and and that is going
to apply the black color to it okay so
keep that in mind this can be sometimes
confusing and generally speaking keep
things as simple as possible so that you
don't run into all these issues okay so
now that we have done we've added CSS
let's maybe look at what are some other
ways in which we can select specific
elements and then apply styles to them
so when using the style tag or a
separate CSS file CSS properties can be
applied to multiple desired elements on
the page using three types of selector
one is the tag selector this is
something that we've already seen for
example we've done this text line Center
and color deep blue or dark blue for the
H1 tag the second is the ID attribute so
typically what you can do is you can set
the ID attribute for a particular tag
and then use the hash prefix within CSS
to select it okay so I can do this I can
add an ID for this banner.jpg image so I
can just say ID equals Banner
and generally as a rule there should be
only one element with a specific ID on a
page you can have multiple and the
browser won't complain but just as a
rule semantically speaking you should
have one element with a particular ID on
a page okay so ID should be an unique
identifier so now we have banner and now
we can select the Banner element so now
if I said IMG that would apply to all
the images on the page right if I said
IMG that would apply to all images on
the page but now I only want to apply to
the tag which which has the ID banner
and that is why I have this hash or
pound character and now I can set
something like width
100% okay and now you can see that this
image has a width of 100% 100 width 100%
simply means occupy the entire space
available horizontally okay even if you
resize the page you can see that this
image automatically resizes of course
there is an issue here that it this
image is getting stretched we'll fix the
stretch in just a bit but but at the
very least we are able to apply the
width of 100% to just this specific
image and not to this image so that is
the second way to select an HTML tag and
apply some CSS styles to it then the
third way to select an HTML tag is using
a class now sometimes what you might
have is a several tags which you want to
style at once and all these tags have to
be styled using the same set of styles
so here is an example let's say I add
location let's say I add
here no I have location somewhere here
let's say I look at the location here
yeah so I have locations here I have
location for the front end developer
role I have location for the remote
developer role I have Lo or the backend
developer role and the data scientist
role let's say I want to make the color
of the location gray so I can do this I
can say span and I can say class equals
location okay and let me go in and let
me add that here as as well span class
equals location span class equals
location so there may be many spans on
the page you can see that there is a
span right here at the very bottom as
well but these three particular spans
have the class location and now I can
apply some styles to specifically these
three spans by using dot location so I
can say dot location dot is used to
indicate a class you can either select a
tag where you don't need any prefix or
you can select an ID which is Hash or
you can select using a DOT which is a
class and now I can say color gray okay
and let me reload the page and now you
can see here we have bangaluru India
remote and Mumbai India so this is
applied this color is applied
specifically to these specific sections
okay now you might ask okay how do I
know when I should use color when I
should use text align when I should use
what the simplest way is to just go on
google.com and search okay how to
center
text in CSS and you can say it uses the
text align property but now we also have
tools like chat GPT where you don't
actually have to go and search this on
Google and browse various web pages so
this is something that I've been using a
lot these days you can see that I have a
bunch of conversations here already with
chat GPD regarding HTML but you can just
go into chat GPD or chat. open.com and
you can search how to center text in CSS
okay
and it is going to tell you that it's
going to come up with an answer for that
it's maybe also going to come up with an
example and you can ask it some
follow-up questions as well okay let's
give it a second maybe it will come up
with yeah to Center text in CSS you can
use the text align property and set its
value to
Center okay and it's showing you an
example as
well
right and that's it so you this is great
it works really well it doesn't always
give you the right answer but you could
ask it a couple of things and you can
try it out it's a good starting point
whenever you face an issue to go ahead
and ask in chat GT in fact I'll
encourage you some of the questions
you've been posting on Zoom try posting
them to chat GPT and uh you might be
surprised uh at how well it can answer
these
questions okay so that is about the
different ways in which you can select
things now I encourage you to learn more
and experiment with various types of CSS
selectors what you can also do is you
can combine selectors of various types
to select a specific set of elements
that match all the conditions for
example let's say you have certain divs
with the class location and you have
certain spans with the class location
and you only want to apply these uh
settings to the span with the class
location then you can say span. location
and I believe that is going to or span.
location and I believe that is going to
just select the spans which have the
class. location okay
now the next thing I want to tell you
before we go ahead and actually style
the rest of the pce is the CSS Box model
the CSS Box model describes how HTML
elements are rendered as rectangular
boxes in a web page okay and the box of
for any HTML element is composed of
several layers that determine the layout
and the sizing of the element so let us
create um uh there are a few components
to the Box model there is the content
there is a padding there is the border
and there is margin we're going to
understand all of these terms and we'll
do that by creating another web page
just so that we can experiment with the
Box model so I'm going to open up the
sidebar here and open up another page
called box model.jpg
okay there it is box model. jpg oh
sorry box model. HTML let me rename
that let me create another page called
box model. HTML okay and I can open up
box model. HTML here in my web page in
my web browser like that just double
click on it now that opens up box model.
HTML for
me and now inside this let me start
putting in some content so HTML let me
put in the doc type declaration as well
you can see that vs code Auto completes
a do declaration it's nice so let me add
head let me add a title here so CSS Box
model and let me add the body here and
let me
add a couple of divs so let me add a div
called first let me add another
div called second and let me give both
of these divs a class each so let me
call
this box
one by the way for class names you can
put hyphens in between so in CSS
whenever you're using class names or IDs
you can put hyphens let me call this box
two okay and let's reload that let me
zoom in a little
bit 200 is good enough yeah so you can
see that we have content as we expect
first and second okay let me add a style
tag
here and for box one I'm going to set
some Styles and then for box two I'm
going to set some Styles okay no change
here so far um now the first thing I
want to point out is what does the
content of a div look like well uh let
me a background color so the way you add
background color is you just start
typing and vs code shows you so let me
add a background color let me add the
background color aqua for box one and
let's add a background color let's
see beige for box two let's reload that
and now you can see that each of these
boxes or each of these uh divs and a div
is essentially a box which occupies the
full width of the page mostly each of
these boxes have a background color one
has the back backr col aqua and one has
a background col bee okay just first
notice that the content of the of the
Box occupies the entire width by default
when you create a div okay you can see
that there is some empty white space
around that is because the body the body
tag which is the outermost tag on the
page contains some margin and padding
which I'm going to or some internal
spacing which I'm going to just set to
zero for now um we'll understand these
terms margin and padding in just a
second okay yeah so now you can see we
have first and second we have box one
which is first and box two which is
second so you have the actual content
which is the innermost component of the
box and right now our boxes just have
content they don't have anything else no
no border margin padding nothing now the
content itself can be controlled using
the height and the width properties of
course if you put in a lot of content
the height will automatically expand but
I can also set the height specifically I
can say this should have the height 240
PX and this is how you specify length in
CSS you specify a number and then you
specify PX now you can also specify in
inches you can also specify in
percentages and all but in in the
current case I'm just going to use PX
okay 240 seems too big let me just set
it to 40 PX right now yeah now we've set
the height to maybe 80px okay so now
we've set the height of the first
container or the first box to 80px and
let's set the height of the second box
as well height 60
PX so the height of the second box is
set as well so so far we just our boxes
just have a Content nothing special now
the next thing that we can add is
something called a padding now the
padding is the space around the content
so you have the content and then you
have padding which is the space around
the content okay so let me
add padding
20px and reload the page and now you can
see that we have this box first and the
content itself is of height 80 but then
around it there is this additional space
of 20 PX okay you can you can by the way
you can uh just comment out something or
you can disable some CSS property simply
by putting it under these uh slash star
commands um and you can do this using
the command slash okay command plus
slash is going to comment something out
you can see without the padding it this
is the size and then with the padding
this is the size and clearly it is added
more uh it we we have added some space
before the on the left and also you'll
notice on the right as well if you try
to actually do something with it okay so
let's say we set a width I can also set
a width here width 100
PX again you can see that this is the
structure or this is the content of the
box without padding this is what it
looks like and with
padding it is added around the content
so padding is space around the content
but the key thing about padding is that
the background color or the background
image or whatever also applies to the
padding okay now next thing that you can
do is you can set a border you can you
can set a border and you can set a
border of let's say one
pixel and let's just reload nothing
happens because when you're setting a
border you need to specify not just the
Border width you also need to specify
what kind of Border you need and the
typically the border that you need is
like a line border which is solid and
you also need to specify what is the
color of the Border okay so one PX solid
blue that is what I'm setting as the
border of the of the of the Box okay so
now you can see that outside of the
padding a border has been added which is
blue in color let's make that 10 pixels
so now we have a 10 pixel border and you
can see once again the size of the
entire box has grown so first we have
the content and then around the content
we have the padding which is
indistinguishable because uh it has the
same background but it is space you can
click clearly see and then around the
pading we have the Border by the way you
can also add a border radius radius here
let's say you can add a border radius of
20 pixels and a pixel is simply one
point on the screen okay and you can
just you can just play around with the
pixel values when you're experimenting
and over time you'll get a sense of
which what pixel values make sense for
the web page you're working on okay but
I'll remove the Border radius for now so
now we've added a height we've added a
width we add we've added a border so we
have the content and then we have the
padding and these two are
indistinguishable because the they have
the same background then we have the
border and the Border has its own color
it can match the background it can be
different but it's going to show up
separately then you can add some space
outside the Border as well okay and that
is called the margin so margin and
padding are the two most confusing
things for when people they're getting
started with CSS so I hope this is going
to clarify so let's say margin
20px and when we add a margin of 20 PX
you can see that outside the Border 20
pixel have been added left and right
around the
entire box okay so the CSS Box model
basically tells you that you can get
some content then put some padding
around it and that'll have the same
background then add a border around it
and then add a margin around it which is
going to space it away from the other
elements on the page okay now U with
border and Marg padding and margin you
can actually use a different Border Side
uh you can use a different border width
or padding width on each side so for
example you could say something like
this padding left is 10px padding right
is 100 PX padding top is 20 PX and
padding bottom is
30px okay let's for a second let's just
disable that I'm just commenting it out
or basically this is done using command
plus slash okay and you can see now we
have some some padding here and then we
have some padding here which is which
seems to be higher and then we are going
to have some padding at the bottom as
well you can you'll be able to see it
more accurately if I hide so there's
higher padding at the bottom lowest ping
at the left and then there is some
medium padding here and then there is of
course a lot of padding here without the
right padding it's going to be different
right so that is one thing you can do
you can actually specify padding
properties for each side separately or
you can also just specify for all sides
directly here so you can say 10 PX
left padding 100 PX right padding 20 PX
sorry you have
left no I'm not sure well um I think you
start from the tab you start from the
top so padding
property
order yeah so the first first padding
applies to the top the second to the
right the third to the left and the
third to
the bottom and then uh the last one to
the left okay so instead of padding left
left right bottom top bottom you can
have padding and then you can specify
what padding you want for the top what
padding you want for the right what
padding you want for the bottom and what
padding you want for the left so 20 PX
okay and that is going to set the
padding top right left top right bottom
left okay clockwise order starting from
12:00 so that is padding top right
bottom left and similarly you can
specify margin separately as well so you
can say 20 PX at the top 30 PX on the
right 50 PX at the bottom and 100 PX on
the left and that is our margin applied
properly
okay now one thing you can also do is
let's say your top and bottom margins
are equal or top and bottom paddings are
equal then you can keep them the same so
you can um you can do this you can say
margin or padding 10 PX and 100 PX so
the 10 is going to get applied to top
and bottom and then the 100 PX is going
to get applied to left and right okay
again top bottom left right if you put
just two values it is going to repeat uh
those two values okay top bot top top
right left bottom clockwise orderorder
top right left bottom always get
confused all right so that is margin and
padding now here's one interesting thing
I want to point out though I hope this
is all clear and you can also of course
go say border bottom width is 30 PX and
that is going to just change the B
bottom width now here's one interesting
thing I want to point out let's say we
give this a padding as well padding
20px okay so now it has some padding and
let's say we give it a border border 10
PX solid
red now it has uh now it has the second
box as a border as well now let us give
it some margin specifically let me give
it some margin top okay so notice keep
your eyes here keep your eyes here and
I'm just going to add a margin top of
20px and let me just save that and
reload you can see nothing happened so
what happens is that margins between
consecutive elements can collapse into
each other okay so what happens is this
has a margin bottom of uh this has a
margin bottom of 50 PX you can see here
it's coming from here it's it has a
margin bottom of 50 pixels and this has
a margin top of 10 pixel so when you
have two elements side by side or one
above the other and both of them have
margins then both those margins collapse
into each other and only the bigger of
the margins is maintained okay so even
if I had let's say margin 20px all
around and reload this page you can see
that a margin got added here a margin
got added here a margin got added here
but a margin did not get added here
because this margin is shared with the
margin of the above element okay so
that's something that you should keep in
mind that margins of successive elements
collapse don't worry if you forget this
you're going to figure it out when you
build your web pages anyway here's
another thing that I want to tell you
you can use another margin setting
called Auto so let's say I said margin
top to be 20 pixels margin uh right to
be Auto margin bottom to be 30 pixels
and margin left to be Auto what happens
is and I also set a width for
this let me set the width to
80px you can see what happened that the
width constrained how much space the div
can take up because you've set a width
properly and then the margin on the top
and bottom apply as usual but because
we've set the margin left and right to
Auto both of those are automatically
adjusted to be equal and this is a very
powerful thing this doesn't work with
top and bottom this works with left and
right only if you set the left and right
margin to Auto what that does is that
centers the div horizontally on the page
you can see as I change the size of the
browser the second div stays in the
center so that's a good neat trick to
center a div or horizontally on a page
just set the margin to Auto for left and
right all right so that's about the CSS
Box model and generally speaking if you
want to if you have a doubt about where
a particular space or margin or padding
is coming from here's what you can do
let me just zoom let me just make this
full screen for for once and you can
right click on an element and this works
in Chrome or Brave browser doesn't work
in Safari I believe but right click on
an element and click inspect
and when you click
inspect the browser is going to show you
the actual HTML structure of the page so
you can go into any web page on the
internet you can right click and you can
inspect and you can study the HTML
source code of the page you can see here
it has all the entire style it has the
entire body div all of that and when you
hover over a particular div it shows you
what that div looks like and
specifically the green area the the
green area that you're seeing that is
the content of the div including the
padding and then the Orange area that
you're seeing that is the generally the
margin of the div okay you can see the
orange area is the margin and the green
area is the content you can also come in
here on the right and you can study all
the styles that are applying to this
particular component and you can
actually look at the Box model for that
particular so if you select box one you
can see its box model here you can see
that it has the size 100 by 80 and it is
highlighted and it has a padding of 10
at the top 100 at the right and then 10
at the bottom and 100 on the left and
you can see it has a border of 10 on
each side and finally it has these
margins 20 30 50 and 100 on each side
okay so that is one great way for you to
explore the CSS properties if you scroll
up you can also see what are all the CSS
properties that are applied here you can
actually turn off these CSS Properties
or you can add additional CSS properties
for example you can say text align
Center and that is going to apply that
additional CSS property so this is a
great way to just experiment with your
web page in the browser itself before
you go back and make some change in your
code okay and if you reload the page all
of these changes will go away but uh the
Box model is useful to explore then the
CSS properties are useful to explore and
you can also add additional Properties
or you can change the values of specific
properties let's say instead of Aqua I
want to change this to Gold I can do
that here as well and again all of this
is just changing in the browser it's not
going to go and save anything all right
so that's an interesting way for you to
explore uh web pages by the way if
you're not able to see the Box model let
me just turn this off here yeah so this
is the Box model uh you can see that if
you scroll up you can see here that you
have the Box model you can see the
margin you can see the Border you can
see the padding and you can see the size
of the Box itself okay that is the CSS
Box model okay
so let's go back into the page webpage.
HTML and let's also open up styles.css
so let's go back to styles.css by the
way you can use command P within vs code
to open styles.css vs code is really
nice for coding it makes your job really
really easy you can also close or
collapse some of these HTML tags in case
you don't want to see them and that way
you can reduce the structure of of your
page so I'm just opening everything for
now but you can do that if you
want okay and let's go back here
to my first web
page and let us now try and achieve this
layout step by step okay so the first
thing I'm going to do is go into
styles.css right at the very top I'm
going to go into
body and I'm going to set a few things
right because every browser has its own
setup of the body uh the its own margin
and padding you can see here that there
is some white space around this image
even though I've set it WID to 100% So
within the body I'm just going to set
margin as zero and I'm going to set
padding as zero as well
great so now this is completely out
there touching the edges okay one other
thing that I want to do in the body is I
don't like this font which has these
things sticking out of the J you can see
right at the top it has this old look uh
this is called a serif font this small
piece sticking out of the
J this thing over here is called a serif
and similarly this is called a serif so
this is what is called a serif font um
generally speaking Mo most modern
websites are built using Sans serif
fonts so I'm just going to go in and
change the font now the way you set the
font is by setting the font family and
there are many font families that are
available on the internet uh by default
browsers support several font families
and then your operating system may have
certain font families and then you can
include new font families from the
internet from a resource like Google
fonts and we'll do all of those things
but for now I'm just going to say Sans
siif okay what that does is if I reload
the p page you can see that now it looks
a lot more modern now it looks that now
it doesn't have those things sticking
out of the J and out of the B and all so
that's one other thing that we've done
let me just zoom out a little bit okay
so now we've done that uh let's start
fixing things or let's start
implementing the wireframe by applying
the styles step by step okay so the
first thing that I'm going to do is I'm
going to add a header so I'm going to go
in into webpage. HTML and here right at
the top I'm going to create a div and
I'm going to give it the
ID
navbar okay this is going to be the nav
bar right at the top so over here and
inside this I'm going to need an image
I'm going to put that image in in just a
second but let us give me let us give
some styles to the Navar so let's go in
here let's add I've given it the ID nav
bar so I can select it using hash and
let me then set the
height or let me just give some padding
to the nav bar let me give it a padding
of 8 pixels let's just set it to 8
pixels for
now okay nothing happened oh there it is
yeah there is so that is a nav bar right
there it has eight pixels of padding
that is why it's just showing up like
that let's now put an image under it so
image SRC what is going to be
the uh location of the image well I have
picked out a jovian image logo here so I
have this image hosted online okay so
whenever you're using an image from the
internet make sure that you're actually
getting the link to the image itself and
not the link to a page containing the
image for example this page over here
contains the image but I shouldn't put
this in the SRC because then the browser
is going to try to fetch this entire
page as an image no so you can do two
things right click if you want to
include an image from the internet on
your web page right click and say copy
image address and then just put that
here in SRC or you can right click and
say open image in new tab and then grab
the URL of just that image okay always
open the image in a new tab and then
grab the URL that is the safest way to
do it all right so IMG SRC equals uh
that and I'm just going to give it an
ALT because that's a good practice so
I'm just going to
say Jovian logo and I'm going to give it
um
ID logo all right and now this image
should show up here but it's obviously
too big let's go in here and let us set
the so we have the logo which is an
image let us set its height to 32
PX okay that looks nice maybe even 30
PX and remember this is zoomed in I've
actually zoomed it to about 150% in your
on your side it may actually look a
little smaller all right so that is
starting to look
good is there a margin for the snap bar
let's set the margin to zero let's make
sure that there is no margin
here okay there's no margin and this is
looking good so now we have this nice
it's looking a bit unequal you can see
on the top and at the bottom we have
unequal um space so we can verify why
there is this unequal Space by checking
the nav bar and looks
like
well looks fine to
me okay I have no idea why this is
unequal that is something in CSS
sometimes you have to figure out ways to
fix but in any case I I think one one
way we could do this is maybe just chug
this into a
div no that doesn't do
it oh that's a wrong thing
maybe I can just set the height directly
here so height equals what is the height
we need for the image 30 PX so let me
just set the height to 30 here directly
sometimes that tends to do the
trick and let me remove the height from
here so I've just set the height
directly okay still doesn't do it so
you're going to run into these issues in
CSS where something is slightly off and
I normally just keep these towards the
end so that I don't worry about them
immediately but in any case now we have
the Navar in order and and then let us
fix this image so this image looks fine
but the only trouble here is that the
image is
stretching okay now what I want you to
do what I want this image to do instead
is just to cover the entire area that is
available to this image instead of
stretching and the way you can do that
is
by adding something called an object fit
into the image okay again something that
you can look up so this image has the ID
Banner so I'm going to come in here and
I'm going to add for Banner I'm going to
set
object fit cover okay and now you can
see that whether I zoom it in or Z
whether I increase or decrease the size
of the web page the aspect ratio of the
image isn't changing so this is the way
you you fix your stretchy images you
simply set object fit cover whenever you
see that an image is
stretching
okay so that takes care of our nav bar
that takes care of our Banner fine let's
fix the about Joan I think we don't need
the dark blue color I'm actually okay
with the black color and now here we
have these two things so we have the
left and we have the right so we want to
show two divs side by side each taking
half the screen and again this is
something that I I would search online I
would say how to show two divs side by
side with same
width
and you can see I've searched this
already I think this one was one that I
found useful so yeah you can explore
this a little bit but I'm just going to
go ahead and show you the solution here
um whenever you need to show show two
Dives side by side what you need to do
is first make sure that this content and
this content both are within a div so
let's take uh let's see let's go to
about Jovan and under about Jin first
let's create a div called
description let's give it the ID uh now
let's give it the ID
about okay this div is going to capture
everything under the about section and
then let's create two divs inside it
let's give this the
ID
description and this is going to be the
description and then let's create
another
div let's give this div the
ID
team and this is going to be the team
image okay so we have created two divs
one is called description and one is
called team now by default divs are
going to show up one below the other in
HTML if you want to change that here is
a quick trick you can apply if you want
the divs inside a particular outer div
to flow not horizontally but vertically
then what you can do is go in and this
outer div is called about so I'm going
to just go into about
so I'm selecting the outer div with the
ID about and I'm going to just set
display Flex okay we're going to learn
about Flex the flex display in a lot of
detail later on but the quickest or the
easiest reason to use flex is to change
the orientation of the divs inside and
outer div
from horizontal from vertical to
horizontal okay and I reload that and
you can see now we have description and
team image coming side by side now
here's what I can do I can set the width
for description and team okay so I can
do something like this we have
description and I can set
width 50% what I wanted to do is occupy
50% of the area of the parent div and
similarly we have
this team image uh or this team div and
I want that to occupy 50% as well
okay and now you can see that
description takes up 50% if I added a
background to it you'll be able to see
so let me add a background just to show
you yeah so you can see around
description there is this background so
description takes a 50% and the team
image takes a 50% and of course now I
can go in and I can put these two pieces
of content inside those divs okay so I
have the speed tag with a with this o
and all of that so let me just grab that
P tag and cut that and put this in the
place of description okay and let me
just right click here and indent I think
it should be formatted already and now
you can see that this P tag contains the
data or shows this P tag shows the
information on the left half similarly
we can take the image
now this contains this is the team image
and and we can put that here in the team
section okay now we have the team image
on the right all right so that's one
thing that I want to point out to you
that you should what you should do is
you should first try to create a layout
using a couple of empty divs maybe even
add background colors and borders to
them just so that things are super clear
and once you've created the layout with
those empty divs especially horizontal
layouts then put the content inside
because otherwise you might just lose
track and become confused but now once
you you put the content inside later you
have actually already fixed all of this
so you have fixed what the description
and team should be laid out as and then
the content inside can be laid out
independently okay so build your web
page step by step in these steps okay
let's maybe clean this up a little bit
further let's see so maybe this team
image Um this can have a border radius
so this it's looking too sharp let me
just call give this an ID
team image and let me come in
here team image and let me give it a
border radius let's give it a border
radius of 5
pixels again experiment with it trial
and error but yeah five pixels looks
good I think I would like to have maybe
some space here so maybe I can go in and
I can add some padding into team so let
me come into team and add or let me come
into description and add some
padding let me add a padding of 8
pixels okay so now I've added a padding
and maybe let me add this padding only
on the left and right so let me keep the
padding top and bottom as zero and let
me add that padding but you can see here
that there seems to be some space above
this as well and I believe that is
because of this paragraph tag because
this paragraph tag generally has some
space above and I can verify this by
creating in by clicking inspect and
verifying that in description this
paragraph tag has a margin above so I
can just set for this particular
paragraph tag style equals margin Z or
margin
top so when you're specifying a zero
margin you don't need to say PX you can
just say margin okay right so the page
is starting to look pretty good I would
say um one issue here is that if I
extend the this
forward ah looks like I have a for the
steam image looks like I have a width
set let me get rid of that width
here or a height for the team image
where is the team image over here yeah
this is a team image I think I have a
height set for it let me get rid of the
height that I've
set and now it ends up taking up the
entire space so maybe what I can do is I
can just come back in here under team
and or under team image and I can set
the height to I can simply set the width
to 100% of the parent which is half the
div okay so that's nice now it is taking
up the entire space inside the inner div
and it is
expanding um in size based on that but
as the page gets bigger and bigger this
content becomes too wide so maybe I want
to limit the overall width of this
description right so overall width of
the about section itself right so the
about section I don't want it to become
too too big the about section should
maybe I I just want to restrict it to
this region generally speaking so what I
can do is I can set a Max width I can
set a Max width now the max width is the
maximum width that this particular
section can take so max width let me set
it to 800 PX and let me reload the page
so now you can see that even as as we
make the page smaller both of these are
going to take half the space and as we
make
the page bigger it's going to stop at
800 pixels but of course it would be
nice for this to be centered on the
screen so that's where I can also use
that margin trick I can say margin zero
Auto so zero margin on the top and
bottom and then uh right and left margin
can be Auto and now you can see about
Jin and here we have this and then we
have here we have this image and it's
all nicely centered okay it's all
remains centered remains centered and
then it goes out here and it becomes
small okay and maybe we can also add
some padding here let's see let's add a
padding of maybe 8
pixels just so that it's it doesn't
touch the
edges okay and if we've added padding
here then maybe we don't need this
padding here over here maybe we just
need a padding
right 8
pixels okay so this is what web
developers sit and do all day they
fiddle around with small CSS settings
just to get things to look exactly as
they desire uh but this is looking fine
to me I think the about section looks
good
largely yeah somewhere around that is
looking good yes this is slightly
falling over into the next uh outside
but that's okay okay so now we're done
with the about joing section let's go
ahead and fix the job opportunities
section so I'm going to go in and under
job opportunities okay once again the H2
as well I'm going to add a center so H2
I'm going to say text align
Center okay now this this has centered
then I can go in and I can maybe again
create another outer div called
jobs so I created a div called jobs so
let me give it the
ID
jobs all right and again for jobs I'm
going to set a maximum
width so max width for jobs is 800
PX and I'm going to set margin 0 Auto
and I'm going to set padding 0
8px okay all I'm doing is I'm creating
an outer div into which I can then put
in all my jobs so let me grab all these
jobs and this is all the footer yeah all
this point till this point we have the
jobs and I'm going to put it under the
jobs div and let me reload again and you
can see that it has this nice it remains
centered on the screen that's nice
pretty good remains centered on the
screen and it is also not touching the
edge of the screen so generally you want
to have some space from the edge of the
screen here so that's
it okay then we have this H3 over here
there's a lot of space between front end
developer and then bangaluru India so
how about we come in this is an H3
remember it's an H3 uh let's give it a
class called
uh job roll
so that we don't affect other h3s on the
page if we had any at the moment we
don't
but
yeah okay and let me come in here
H3 and let us just give it margin bottom
zero I believe it's a margin let's see
okay margin bottom zero this is looking
good now it is much closer maybe Zero's
too little maybe let's make it 8
PX Maybe 4 PX should do the job so
normally with margins and paddings you
want to use multiples of four that's a
good idea and you want to go double
double double half half half and that's
a quick way to work around this stuff
okay now what would be nice if we could
also get that nice apply button or apply
link here on the on the job page so I'm
going to again show you a quick trick
we're going to learn a lot more about
things like flexbox Etc but a quick
trick to just get one single element
pulled to the right side is using
something called float so I'm going to
show you right now so let me say a href
equals nothing for now and let me just
put in
apply and let me give this a class as
well and this class is also called
apply and let me put it above every H3
here okay so now we have this apply
apply apply that is going to show up
above every H3 and I think I can go in
and I can fix the margin top as
well for this H3 to
be
zero yeah so now we have apply apply
apply
and what we can do
is take the apply class so do apply that
is the that is the class given to this
apply link and I'm just going to add one
thing
float right okay so that's just going to
pull this apply all the way to the right
that's nice it's going to just pull it
all the way to the right and I think we
need probably under the location we need
some spacing so I'm going to go back and
add some location add some spacing under
location so we have class location and
class location has already had we've
added the color gray let me add margin
bottom 16
PX okay that's a span so that's another
learning margins don't work for spans I
know it's confusing happens all the time
margins don't work for spans so I'm just
going to go in and I'm going to change
these spans to
divs okay margins and paddings don't
apply to spans because they are inline
elements I'm going to change these all
to
divs and now it's to apply okay great so
this is looking nice now we have the
front end developer we have Bangalore
India and we've pulled this or we've
floated this apply link to the right so
that's nice one thing that I would want
to do now is maybe get rid of these
underlines under these links uh these
underlines aren't looking that great so
I'm just going to go in and then for all
the anchor
Tags I'm going to remove the underline
how do you remove the underline all the
anchor or the link tags well remove
underline from a a tags CSS I just
search that and it says that it can be
removed using the text decoration
property so you can say text decoration
none and that should do it so if I go
text decoration none that should
hopefully get rid of all the underlines
right we have gotten rid of all the
underlines as well now we have these
apply links as well last thing is the
footer I think we're almost there we
just need this footer at the end so let
me come in and once again let me create
this div called foter okay it's already
there so I'm just going to give it the
ID
putter okay and then we have this list
let me just call it let me give it the
ID footer
links okay so I'm going to do a couple
of things first I'm going to give the
footer so dot um it's it's an ID so hash
footer I'm going to to give it the
background
color gray or something very light gray
let's see gains borrow okay that looks
like a nice grayish color oh what is the
lightest gray we can find let's search
for a very light gray ghost white okay
that is interesting let me just get
Ghost
white yeah that's a very light grayish
color you may not even be able to see it
on the screen but it's there then for
the footer links I want to get rid of
these bullet points and let me just
bring that up here so for the footer
links I want to get rid of the bullet
points and I just want to keep them all
on the same line so I am going to
say putter links and again this is
something that I would look up normally
but uh I happen to remember it what the
way you can get rid of these bullet
points is to say list
style none I believe that should do
it and now now you can see that the the
bullet points are gone now of course for
the footer itself it might be nice to
maybe add some padding at the top and
bottom and maybe all around so let me
just add a padding of
8px and okay now the footer is looking
nice too and maybe let me also add some
margin top the footer is too close to
the data scientist job role let me add a
margin
top I'm going really fast but I'm
expecting you to follow along here pause
follow along and maybe also look up what
each of these prop properties mean
because that's really how you do web
development 16 PX so let's add a
margin H let's
see did not do anything maybe let's make
that
32px yeah that increased it so remember
our location also has a margin so the
margins collapse into each other um all
of that
happens okay final thing we want to make
these list items come up up in line so
there whenever you have three divs
showing one below the other and you just
want to show them all in line now
another quick way to do it is well we
could just do I think display flex and
that would do
it yeah display flex and that should do
it U for phot links um we can also
add but I want to show another way to do
it and this is something that you can
set on individual list items so you can
say footer
links
lii and that is going to select the LI
items under the ID footer links and I'm
going to say display in
line okay and you can see now they're
showing up inline so the difference
between flex and inline is flex is
something that you apply on the parent
and that applies to all the items within
it and then in line is something that
you apply to the child element let's say
you went into one of these list items
and applied in line only that that would
appear in line instead of block which is
the entire horizontal width um but here
we are applying to all the list items
and I'll tell you why in just a second
but apart from the in line we also want
to add a margin so let's add we don't
need a margin at the top let's add maybe
16 pixels of margin on the left and
right so let's add the margin here let's
reload okay so now we have a margin and
the last thing that I'm going to do is
I'm going to say text align Center and
that is going to Center these links on
the page okay and in fact text align
Center can be done not just for footer
links but for the entire footer itself
we can do it like that and finally let's
fix this as well so let's go in and
let's call this
copyright class
equals copyright and let's come back in
here and well we could also give it an
ID but fine class is
fine copyright and let's let's give it
the
color
gray okay so that is our page I think
that is looking pretty good so we have
the nav bar at the top we have this
banner and this Banner always occupies
the entire length and it doesn't stretch
the image too much um then we have this
about Jovan section that is always at
the center and then we have the job
opportunities that are also in the
center if you want we can experiment
with the colors of these and finally we
have these apply links uh they don't do
anything right now but it wouldn't it be
nice if they could at least maybe
trigger some sort of an email and that's
where I want to introduce you to another
form of Link called mail to Links okay
so just search for mail to
Links what is a mail to Links well you
can do this instead of having a link
point to some website on the internet
you can have a link say mail to colon
and then
some email address and when the user
clicks on that link it is going to open
their email application whether it's
Gmail or whatever email application
they're using it is going to open their
email application and put in this
address in the subject line okay so
that's a very interesting hack so this
is what we can use here for our apply so
I can go in here into apply where is my
apply yeah so I can go in here and in
the HF I can say mail to I can just say
mail to support at Jovian
okay and let me come in here and let me
say mail to support join.com and mailto
support join.com and reload the page now
if I click the apply button you can see
that it opens my mail application which
is Gmail and it is automatically filled
in the address support jan.com okay and
then here you can actually then fill out
the subject and you can send an email so
essentially what we're saying is when
the user clicks on the apply button that
is going to trigger their email client
and they can just send us an email that
they're interested in a particular um
job one thing that we can also do is we
can also put in a subject here so we can
say mail to and you can just say subject
you can say question mark subject after
the email address equals front
end and question mark subject
equals
backend and question mark
subject
equals
data scientist or just say data all
right and I'll also add a Target uncore
blank so that it opens in a new
page underscore blank and let's
add Target equals uncore blank and let's
add Target equals uncore blank okay so
now each of these mail to Links is going
to have a different subject and it's
going to open a new tab you can see here
that it has automatically added the
subject front end and you can construct
more more complex subjects and in fact
you can also set up some kind of a body
directly as well and similarly you can
go in here and uh let's click on backend
developer and it fills up the subject
backend and you can go in uh click on
the data scientist and it fills up the
subject data okay great and then all
these other links are working fine as
well I think I'm very happy with this
I'm very happy with this web page at
this point so I'm just going to save it
and let's see I'm just going to reset
the zoom level okay so this looks good
at the normal zoom level and it contains
everything that I'm looking for I have
the header I have the banner I have this
section I have some text on the left I
have something on the right yep I have a
couple of links here as well I have the
job opportunities and I have locations I
have this apply button and then I have
this footer and then I have this
copyright at the end as well great so
I'm feeling very happy with this web
page now the final step now that we have
completed this web page the final step
is to go ahead and deploy it so this is
what it looks like roughly now we can
deploy this web page to the cloud now
we're going to cover deployment
extensively over the course of this
program or the course of this next few
lessons as well and there are many many
ways to deploy a website to the cloud
there are hundreds of platforms but the
simplest thing is to just upload a zip
file right wouldn't it be nice if we
could just zip up our web page and just
upload it on the cloud well that is what
you can do using this platform called
static. apppp and there are a bunch of
these platforms but static. apppp allows
you to Simply dragdrop an archive with
your page or a website in it and it will
take care of the rest okay you'll
automatically set up a website for you
now here is what we do first we have to
make sure that we have an index.html
page so there is this convention in HTML
that a file called index.html is going
to be the root page of a website okay or
the root page so when you open jan.com
that's actually opening jan.com
index.html so let's go back here here
and let us rename webpage. HTML to
index.html so let's rename this
to
index.html
and then let us go and zip up this
folder so we have this folder over here
which has a index.html file which is the
sort of the root page or the root web
page and it has a bunch of other files
and images as well I'm going to zip it
up so I'm going to say uh compress and
depending on your operating system you
may have a different way to zip things
and then on static. apppp I'm just going
to click upload for
free I am then going to upload this ZIP
file over here and that is going to then
ask me to maybe pick a domain name so
it's going to be a subdomain of static.
apppp so let me just put it as
Jovian j o v i a n can't spell my own
company name okay and let me just put in
an email here Sydney is the account I'm
using Sydney jan.com
and let me put in the name here Sydney
Carton okay let me put in a password
here I'm not going to say that and let
me just accept the terms of privacy and
let me just say continue okay looks like
this email has been taken let me just
provide a slightly different email yeah
so now that is going to ask me to verify
my email I've uploaded the zip file
already so I'm just going to go ahead
and verify the email I am going to let's
see let's open up
gmail.com and here is the account and
here is the verification
link okay now my email is
verified and now you can see that Jovan
careers. static. apppp this website is
getting deployed okay so let's give that
a couple of minutes looks like it is
deployed so let's maybe go and check it
out let me just click joen careers.
static. apppp and yes looks like this
website is already deployed and in fact
you can open it up on your end as well
and because we have set up because we
have set up this
page web page. HTML as index.html that
is why it's opening up directly but I
can also just type index.html and it
will open the exact same page okay not
only that remember we have this other
page called box model. HTML well box
model. HTML should open up just fine as
well there you go box model. HTML and in
fact if we had a link here from
index.html to box model. HTML then that
link would work properly as well and you
can see that both these images got
uploaded as well so that is how you
deploy a site the the simplest way to
deploy your site side is to just zip up
your code and put it up online you don't
need any G AWS deployment commands Etc
it's all really simple to do okay and
that's it so let's take a quick summary
of the whole thing here's what we did we
created an HTML file on we created a
folder on our desktop we put in our HTML
file into it we added some code into it
using vs code and then we try to view it
in a browser then we using some basic
HTML tags like HTML head title body div
Etc we created a web page then we use
some more HTML tags H1 to H6 P list
links Etc to structure content on a web
page so remember this piece before we
added any CSS we just put up a bunch of
content on the web page and here is what
it looked
like then we learned how to apply styles
using CSS so cascading stylesheets the
way we saw we saw that we can apply
Styles in line we can apply styles using
the style tag we can apply styles using
CSS files and the key idea is you have a
selector and then you have a property
and a
value then uh we looked at the different
kind of selectors we have tag selectors
we have ID based selectors and we have
class
selectors then we learned the CSS Box
model which is how you have content and
around the content you can add padding
and the padding is also shares the same
background and then the padding is
inside the border the border is
something that you can set WD for and
then outside you have margin and margins
can overlap for side by- side
elements and then we of course we
implemented a wireframe using excal
draw.com and we then tried to replicate
this wireframe within CSS You by adding
a bunch of CSS properties starting from
the top so we picked section by section
we added a na bar we added a logo in it
we fixed the banner we fixed the section
about Jovian then we went into job
opportunities and then we added a footer
right so that's what we did and finally
we just deployed our website to the
cloud using static. apppp we just went
to static. apppp created a zip file
renamed our main page to
index.html and uploaded that zip file
verified our
account and it is deployed as a um yeah
so it is
deployed where is it yeah it is deployed
as a subdomain of static. apppp but
within static. apppp itself you can also
go into settings and actually configure
a custom domain so you can actually put
this on Jovian careers.com or something
like that you can go and you'll have to
upgrade your plan you'll have to pay you
can set up a custom domain you can just
set up a domain like janc careers.com
and you can set up some DNS settings and
make sure that that is where your web
page shows up so that's not bad for a
first lesson we probably spent about 2
hours 2 hours 15 minutes if I exclude
the breaks and we were able to build a
pretty good functional website and
clicking on this website the actual
functionality is also present because
you can click apply and you can actually
go ahead and send out an email to the
Jan team to apply for a job so that's
how simple HTML and CSS really is once
you can become familiar with just the
most basic parts now of course there's a
lot more to it there are tables there
are forms there are various CSS
properties Flex Box
Etc but what I want you to take away
here is that you should try to First
figure out what you want to build and
try to build it using what you already
know and then just try to learn as you
go along the things that you don't
already know okay and here are some
references that you can check out you
can find the completed code for this
lesson it may be slightly different
because we've done this live you can
find the completed code for this lesson
here you have this index.html over here
so that's great and then you have maybe
some beginner friendly HTML and CSS
tutorials in case you want to look at
other tutorials as well after practicing
this you can go and check that out so
HTML dog.com is something that I found
very simple to follow along with but you
want some if you want some interactive
HTML tutorials you can go to
w3schools.com and if you want more
detailed and comprehensive tutorials
check out mdn or Mozilla developer
Network you can check that out as well
they have fairly detailed tutorials um
and a lot of text lot of explanation as
well so take your pick depending on how
new you are depending on how comfortable
you feel after practicing this lesson
after watching this lesson and prac iing
it writing out all the code by hand you
can pick whichever other tutorial you
want to take and some of the other
things you can look at is the LM .io
this is the text generator that we
normally use so that's something that
you can use to generate text when you
want to fill a page um if you want to
learn about the CSS CSS Box model you
can check out this YouTube tutorial
there is this website called CSS
trick.com this has a lot of great guides
on various Topics in CSS um don't
recommend doing all these guides but
whenever you're working on a particular
topic if you need to maybe get help with
a particular Topic in CSS you can check
it out and normally you can just search
online and you'll find something good
enough and then if you want to create
more advanced mail to Links so you can
use this mail to link. me and you can
craft maybe a a very interesting mail to
link which can have a two line a subject
line a body and a bunch of other things
as well you can add CC BCC all of that
too so the last time we looked at the
very basics of HTML and CSS and we did
that by working on a problem statement
where we built a simple jobs careers
website for Jovian so today we are going
to continue building on that in this
tutorial we will dive deeper into the
world of web development and we will
learn some Advanced Techniques for
Designing and styling websites using
HTML and CSS we will learn how to create
HTML tags of various types we will learn
how to use some Advanced CSS properties
and we'll also learn how to optimize
your code a little bit for performance
and
accessibility so here is what we're
going to cover today we're going to
iteratively improve the existing web
page we are going to create and style
HTML tables we're going to understand
various text related and color related
CSS properties we're also going to
create an HTML form to collect user
inputs and we're then going to send
those user inputs to a server and
finally we're going to use metatags to
improve how a deployed page is previewed
when it is shared as a link so there's a
lot to get through let's get into it and
the best way to follow the best way to
learn these skills is to follow along
step by step you don't have to do that
if you're watching live but as you're
watching the video just pause at various
places and try to write out all the code
yourself that is how you learn this
quickly and of course we are assuming
some basic knowledge of HTML and CSS
here from the previous
lesson so we'll explore these Topics by
attempting to solve this problem
statement we will try and improve the
Jovian careers website that was created
in the previous tutorial so here is what
the Jovan careers website looked like
let me zoom in here so that you can see
it
easily so we have a nav bar here with
the Jovian logo we have a banner image
here it says do something great and we
have an about Jovian section and then we
have some information about Jovian we
also have an image ideally this should
be the Jovian team but this is just to
indicate something about the team
and we have information about job
opportunities and you can click apply
and an email will get triggered you'll
be able to send out an email applying to
these jobs and then there are some links
in the footer as well for courses
programs and YouTube so this is what we
built the last time and we are going to
improve upon this by making the
following changes we are going to show
the list of jobs in tabular format with
separate columns for the job title
location salary and the job posted date
we we also going to show an application
form below the jobs table where a user
can fill out and submit an application
then we are also going to improve the
Esthetics of the page bring it closer to
the Jovian brand using the appropriate
fonts text sizes and colors then we are
going to deploy the page to to the cloud
and ensure that it previews properly
when it is shared as a link so this is
what we're going to work on today now
the code for this tutorial can be found
here so the starter code which is the
finished website from the last tutorial
is available at this link the completed
code for today's tutorial will be
available at this link and finally the
finished site that we're going to create
today will be available at this link so
check these out in case you have in case
you face issues at any point so let's
just take the starter code and we're
going to download and extract the
starter code first and then we're going
to open it up in Visual Studio code so
let's open up this link this contains a
starter code code and I'm just going to
save it on my desktop it's going to be
saved with the name my first webpage.
zip you can see that I have a zip file
here I'm just going to open up this ZIP
file so extract it and now I no longer
need this original zip file so I'm going
to delete it then I am going to rename
this so I'm going to rename this to my
second web page since this is our second
web page so you can see here I've
renamed it to my second web
page now I want to open this up in
Visual Studio code so let me open vs
code or Visual Studio code and I have
Visual Studio code I've installed it
already in case you don't know don't
have it installed just go online search
for visual studio code and install it
and now I'm going to go into the file
menu and I'm going to select open
folder and now I'm going to just select
the folder my second web page that I
have just downloaded and let's open it
up and here you go now we have this HTML
file now we we have a CSS file and we
have a bunch of other files as well from
last time so this is all the starter
code that we have and let me also open
up the web page in the browser so I'm
just going to open it up in the browser
here as well so that we have it open
both for editing and for
previewing so now we have a file
index.html here and that file contains
all the content for this page let's
quickly review what this file contains
so that we when we start modifying it
we'll know exactly what to do now of
course we have this head tag here which
sets the title of the page notice that
we didn't actually set a proper title
right now it just says my first web page
it should say something like Jian
careers so we'll fix that then it
contains a link to a stylesheet or a CSS
files so there are many ways to attach
CSS styles to
HTML web pages and one way to do it is
by using the link tag and putting all
the Styles in a separate CSS file which
we have
here then of course in the body itself
self we have the nav bar over here and
this is all the code for the nav bar so
we have the nav bar which is a div and
then an image inside it which is the
logo over here then of course we have a
banner which is an image tag right here
then we have an header we have a header
H1 which is right over here you can see
that all of these are styled as well so
we have the body the body we've set the
margin and padding to zero and we've set
the font family to Sans serif we've also
set a text decoration for the nav bar
we've set a padding we've also set a in
for the banner we've also set an object
fit over here so that it shows up
properly no matter what the size of the
page is and for the header we've set the
text Line to Center so we've added
various Styles as well then we have this
about section and in this about section
we have a left section and a right
section so the way we did this is we
have this about div and for this about
div we have set the display to flex and
we have set a maximum width for this
about div so you can see here that the
maximum width is ensuring that this
about div doesn't become too big apart
from that we've also set a margin uh
that ensures that it is always at the
center okay so I'm going through this
quickly but review the previous lesson
if not if some of this doesn't make
sense we've also added a padding so
remember the CSS Box model the padding
is inside the border the margin is
outside the Border um it's a good thing
to practice and review from time to time
then of course we have we have the
description which takes up 50% of the
width then we have have the uh Team
image which again takes up 50% of the
width and the team image also has a
border radius over here and then we have
these job opportunities so we've uh used
an H2 here so you can see we have the
description we have uh information about
the two boot camps which we have used a
list for a list tag and then we have job
opportunities we've used an H2 here then
we have a div called jobs and in this
div we have
the three jobs front end developer
backend developer and data
scientist and finally we have courses
programs and the YouTube link in the
footer okay uh of course there are some
Styles related to the jobs div as well
there are some Styles related to each of
the jobs we have those are H3 and there
are some Styles related to the footer as
well okay so very basic HTML and CSS
that we applied and we of course
deployed it to the cloud using a simple
hosting platform where we could upload a
zip file
all right so that's what we have from
the last time so we've opened up the web
page we've opened up the project in vs
code and we have renamed it to my second
web page now the first thing we'll do is
try to improve the wireframe in the
previous tutorial we first created a
wireframe this is what it looked like so
it contained this navbar banner and it
contained the same sections that we have
on the actual page and we use this as a
visual reference while creating the page
so now we are going to improve that
wireframe we're going to make sure that
we are covering all of these things a
list of jobs in tabula format the
application form below the jobs and also
maybe the other things will follow not
necessarily in the wireframe but when we
Implement them and this is something
that you'll see as a very common
practice in the world of web development
this process of improving the design of
a web page and then going ahead and
implementing it on an already live web
page is called iterative development and
a website goes through multiple
iterations or even web applications so
when you look at Jovian we add new
features more or less every week and
that is how we approach building things
so the one approach that you could
follow is something called the waterfall
approach where you identify all the
requirements then you come up with a
final design then you do the development
for the entire set of requirements at
once then you test it and then you
maintain it that takes a lot of work and
you often end up building a lot of
features that nobody might use and
missing out on some very important
features so another way to think think
about web development is to take an
iterative approach you should at the
very least push something out deploy
something that people can use every week
or or if possible every single day so
whenever you're building a website or a
web application you should think okay
what can I build in a day that people
can start using however limited it is
which is what we did the last time and
then once people start using it
depending on their feedback depending on
what else you have in mind and how much
time you have try to come up with the
second version with a new set of
features and repeat that process so
iterative development is a very common
practice in
modern web applications so this is
something that you should get used to so
there are a couple of changes that we
are making today the first thing is to
replace the list of job openings with a
table and some benefits of the table are
they it leads to an improved readability
because tables make it easier for people
to scan things visually tables also
offer better organiz oranization so
because organizing them in a table you
can also group them by Department
location or other relevant criteria
later on when we Implement more
interesting tables and then tables can
also have things like sorting searching
filtering Etc which we look at once we
look at web application development
later in the program apart from the
table we'll also add an application form
below the table so the form will ask for
the users's first name last name or
maybe the name as a whole let's just
change that to name
so the form will ask for whoever is
applying the form will ask for the
applicant's name email the job that
they're applying for their phone number
their resume and a cover letter and
here's what you can do you can actually
start revising the wireframe here itself
so you can take this and then create a
copy of it and then paste it and then
start moving things around for example
you could get rid of you could get rid
of these and then you could insert a
table here so I I could for example go
like this and create a table and then I
could make some more changes let me
change that
to
Black yeah so I for I could for example
create a table here and then into that
table I could add various columns like
this so here's one column here's a
second column here's a third column and
then I could start adding rows within
the
table and then I could maybe start
adding information like job title so
these would be the column headers and
after adding the column headers I can
also add some data within those columns
so this is how you enhance your
wireframe you are visually trying to put
together what you want your next version
of the wireframe to look like and then
you could also go ahead and maybe extend
this a little bit so move all this
forward let's
see let's move all this down and you
could then add a application section so
you you could add a section
called
submit your
application and then you could go ahead
and maybe add uh various input fields
for example you could get an input field
called name
here and put an input box below
it and then just create multiple copies
of that to create the other input fields
and so on and you could add maybe a
submit button somewhere at the end right
so this is how you enhance a wireframe
just create a copy of your existing
wireframe and keep adding new things new
sections before you go out and start
coding now I have already done this so
I'm not going to show this entire
process to you but I encourage you to
just do it all yourself get into the
habit of creating quick wireframes
before you uh start writing HTML code
that will save you a lot of time while
coding so here we have added a job
opportunities table and you can see that
we have a job title location salary and
posted on so we have the job titles we
have a bunch of locations we have
salaries both in Indian rupees and in
dollars and then we have a poster on
date and below that we have a submit
your application form and in this form
we ask for the name email phone number
and there's a drop down here asking for
the position the user has applied to and
then there is a cover letter uh there's
a box here for submitting a cover letter
okay and there's also this check box
here that we're asking the user to agree
to the terms and conditions which is to
be contacted by us or for their resume
to be shared within our company and so
on and there's a submit button so now we
have a clear idea of what we want to
build today specifically these are the
two sections that we want to work on
today and of course we want to make them
aesthetically pleasing and then we also
want to make some other changes to the
site in general so this is the revised
wireframe we still have the Navar Banner
about section but now we have a job
opportunities table and we have a submit
your application form and of course we
have the footer as well again for
personal projects a wireframe is usually
enough to plan a website's design and
layout but in a professional settings UI
developers will often create detailed
mockups providing more information on
colors fonts and visual elements that
you can work uh that you can use while
actually coding the web page so as an
exercise I encourage you to replicate
this wireframe and maybe also add some
new sections see if you can add a new
section and Implement that while you're
working through this lesson but let's
come to tables and HTML now tables are a
fundamental component of HTML used to
display data in a structured Manner and
tables are created using a combination
of the table TR TD and th tags so there
are a bunch of tags that have to come
together for you to create a table and
tables can be styled using CSS just like
all other HTML tags to add borders
backgrounds and other visual elements
tables can also be manipulated to merge
cells so if you see here it's not just a
simple table with rows and columns you
can see that these two are merged and
then these two are this is vertically
merged as well so you can do lots of
interesting layouts with it using
tables but I do want to mention that TBL
should be used appropriately don't put
everything within a table you might get
this temptation to just use a table for
the entire web page to lay things out
but that's not a great idea you should
be using CSS for layout and tables
should be used only when you want to
show a grid of data which fits in neatly
into a table so A good rule of thumb is
if something can be represented using a
sprad sheeet then a table is a good way
to represent it in HTML okay so a table
is created using the table TR and TD
tags the table tag is used to create a
table in HTML and all other table
related tags are nested inside this tag
then the TR tag is used to create a
table row and each row contains one or
more table cells and the table cells are
created using the th tag and the TD tag
okay so let's see these an action and
it'll start to to make a lot more sense
so the first thing I'm going to do here
is go down and find the section job
opportunities and I'm going to remove
this div containing job
opportunities and if I just reload here
you can see that now we no longer have
job opportunities on this page let me
just zoom in a little
further okay now let's start adding a
table here so let me add a
table okay and let me save that and you
can see nothing really happened some
additional space got added but the first
thing I'll do is I'll add a row within
the table so a row is added using the TR
tag and let me save that and still
nothing happens now let me actually put
some headings so let me create a heading
called heading one so I'm going to
create two column headings one called
heading one and one called heading two
and these are created using
the pH tag okay so now you you can see
over here in the corner we have heading
one and heading two and normally you
might want a table with a border so one
quick way to add a border for a table is
just by specifying the Border attribute
okay now once I've added a border you
can see that there is a border around
the entire table and then there is a
border around heading one and there is a
border around heading two as well okay
let's add more rows within the table so
let's add a TR now let me add
another
element so now I'm no longer adding
headings now I'm actually now I'm adding
actual data elements okay so I'm just
going to call it data one for now and TD
data
2 okay and let me just replicate that
for one more row TD data
3 and TD data
4 all right so now we've created a table
successfully I hope you can see it you
it's right here in the bottom left
corner of the web page and now now that
you've understood how tables work we
have this table tag and in this table
tag we have a row this is the header row
and that contains these th tags so th is
header then we have these uh more rows
and in these rows we have the TD
and TD creates normal data you can see
the difference between the heading and
the normal data is that the heading is
bold and if the table was bigger you
would also notice that the headings are
centered but the normal data is left
aligned so that is a difference but it's
also semantically informing the browser
what is the heading and what is just
data within the table it is also used by
screen readers and search engines to
identify the structure of the table okay
now encourage you to experiment with the
table what happens if for example I put
an additional column here let me just
save that and you can see that a new
column got added here
but they you don't have that same column
here available and that is why you have
empty space here or what happens if
let's say you have like a stray TD
somewhere so let's say you have this
data five somewhere what what does that
do so that creates a new row even though
you do not have a proper TR so even if
you do not have a perfect structure of
table and then TR and then TH or TD most
browsers will still render your tables
but it's a good idea to M maintain the
proper structure while building a table
okay so that's how you build a table in
HTM fairly straightforward okay so let's
maybe go ahead at this point and let us
add this data into a table so we want to
get the job title we want to get the
location we want to get the salary and
we want to get when the job was posted
now here's a quick tip for you whenever
you're building HTML tables it's always
a good idea to First maybe create a
spreadsheet like I have done here I've
created the spreadsheet let me Zoom that
in a bit and I am simply going to now
use this spreadsheet as a reference for
creating the table and I can also just
copy paste the data very easily from the
spreadsheet onto the table so let me
just go in here and copy the table
headers and now I am going to paste in
these
headers so my first row is going to be a
row of headers and that is going to
contain these th
tags so now we have a th for
for job title we have a th for location
and we have a TH or table header for
salary and finally we have a TH or table
header for when the job was posted great
now let's start adding the jobs one by
one so once again I'm going to go in and
copy this front end developer bangaluru
I'm going to copy the salary and the
posted on date as well and let me get
rid of these and paste that in here
let's bring that into new
lines over
here okay and let's put in a TD
here so again wrap the data inside a TD
and you don't just have to put simple
text you can put entire lists you can
put paragraphs you can put whatever you
want you can put images into a table but
for now we'll keep things simple we are
just going to put some normal text into
each table cell so each box that you see
within the table is called a table cell
so that is something that you will
notice in the terminology especially if
you're searching for questions online
okay so that is the second job role let
me just grab this and create a few
copies of this and in fact what I'm
going to do is also give it a couple of
classes so I'm going to give it the
class I'm going to give the entire table
an
ID jobs
stable and I'm going to give this a
class jobs table
header and or jobs header row let's just
call it jobs header
row and let's give this a
class jobs data
row okay and let's create copies of this
so we are adding the classes because
we're going to use them later for
styling now we have the jobs header row
and then we have jobs data row let's add
the second role full stack
developer I believe the second role is
in New Delhi
India
and the salary here is
[Music]
15 let's see and the Feb 1 2023 is when
it was
posted let's create a couple more copies
for the next couple of
rows okay we have a data
scientist this is is in San
Francisco
USA and this is I believe
175,000 yep and this was posted in
December 22 December 22nd
2022 and finally let's get get that last
role in here as well ml
engineer and this one is a remote
job and this one is is
$80,000 and I believe this was posted on
September
19th okay so that's our table we have a
table inside the main div and then the
table has a border and the table has the
ID jobs table then we have these rows
and the first row is the jobs header row
because it is for the header we style
headers separately and then the rest of
the rows are data rows and we are using
TDS inside instead of pH which is what
is used for the header and let's save
that and let's reload the page and you
can see here now we have the job title
location salary posted on and we have
all the information here that we had in
our spreadsheet so this is roughly what
our table looks like we do have borders
but the borders are not very pretty so
as an exercise I would encourage you to
try adding more columns to the jobs
table for example requirements and
responsibilities try including
paragraphs or lists within table cells
and as you do so you might need to VAR
vary the widths of different columns you
might need to say that the requirements
column should be at least 30% of the
table's width and so on and that is
something that you can add by following
this tutorial so sometimes depending on
the kind of data you have you may need
to vary the widths and that is all
something you can control using CSS or
just using normal table
attributes but let's talk about styling
HTML tables styling HTML tables with CSS
can greatly improve the visual appeal
and the readability of a website so here
for example is the careers website at
stripe which is a payment processor
company and you can see that they're
also using a table but their table
clearly looks a lot better than our
table so let's try and make our table
look a little better not exactly like
this but we'll try and come close so
here's what we're going to do we can use
Simple CSS properties that we already
know to make some changes to our table
one we'll add borders around the table T
and table cells using CSS not using the
Border property or the Border attribute
because CSS allows us to control other
things like color then we will also make
the table full width on the page and
then we'll align the headers we'll left
align the headers headers are Central by
default we left align them and we'll
also show a different background color
for headers and we'll add alternate
colors to the rows so here for example
you can see that rows have alternate
colors so we'll add this kind of an
alternate color pattern to our table as
well okay so let's try doing this step
by step so the first thing I'm going to
do is grab the ID jobs table and I'm
going to style it by putting some
content into the styles.css file and
remember that the styles.css file is
linked here using a link tag from the
head tag of the page that is how you
connect a CSS file to apply the Styles
into an HTML file okay so let me open up
styles.css and I am going to come down
down here to let's see this region over
here so I think we don't need this dot
location this was there in the previous
page but we don't have
location with this class anymore so we
don't need that let's put in the table
let's select the jobs table so I'm
selecting it by ID so I'm using the hash
or pound character to select the jobs
table by its ID jobs hyphen table and
let me set its width first to
100% so what I wanted to do is take up
the entire width of the parent div okay
not the entire width of the screen but
the entire width of the parent div you
can see that we have this jobs we have
this jobs div over here and this jobs
div is set to have a Max width of 800
pixels and it has a margin of zero Auto
that is what centers it on the page so
there's this outer jobs div and inside
it we have this jobs table which is now
taking up the entire width of the parent
okay so that is one way to specify
widths apart from pixels you can specify
it in
percentages okay that's great what next
well let us now add a border so let us
remove the border from here
first and let us first look at that how
it looks okay this is what it looks like
let's add a border here so border one
pixel solid border there are various
border Styles solid means you do not
want any dashes or anything in the
Border it's a complete continuous
straight line and let's make it gray
let's not make it black so that's the
Border let's see okay so now we have a
border for the table but apart from the
table we also need to add a border for
each cell so I'm just going to say jobs
table or actually I'm just going to
select the cells let's see so we have we
have jobs header row so let's get the
header row using jobs header row and and
this time I'm using the dot selector
from CSS not the hash selector because
the hash selector is used to select by
ID but the dot selector is used to
select by class and this T this TR or
this row here has the class jobs header
row that is why we using the dot
selector okay and I am going to give it
a border as well border 1 PX solid
three
and
oops this is not doing it so if you
notice here the TR over here contains
the class jobs header row but what we
want is a border around each cell not
around the entire row so that is where
we have to select that th cell inside
the TR of the class jobs header row and
you can do it very simply by simply
writing the tag that you want to select
so now what we've done is we are saying
select using the class jobs header row
so that is going to select the row that
is going to select this row and then we
seeing inside the jobs header row class
inside an element with the class jobs
header row look for a th look for a
table header cell and apply this border
to it and now if I reload you can see
that now our table headers have these
borders okay I hope you can see this our
table headers now have these borders
let's also add borders to the table
cells so I'm just going to to grab the
data row class so jobs data row is the
class for the row containing the jobs
data and now we have the TD or the table
cells over here which contain the actual
data and I'm going to set border 1px
solid
gray okay and let's set that as well so
now once again we have borders now but
now these borders have been added using
CSS which is some what nicer we have
more control now the next thing I want
to show you is how to get rid of these
double borders you can see that we have
these double borders over here
so we have the salary posted on and then
we have this border around it and then
another outer border around the table
the way we can do this and this is
something that you just have to look up
is using the Border collapse
property okay so border collapse
collapse you will almost always have to
put this on on a table if you're just
styling from uh styling on your own so
I'm just going to put border collapse
collapse and this is something that you
could looked up you could have looked up
how do I get rid of the double Border in
a table and this is what you'll see okay
so this is nice now I have the border
collaps now the border is looking nice
next let us maybe space things out a
little bit the data is very close to the
edges it would be nice if there was some
space around it so here's what we can do
we can go in in and we can put in put in
a padding here so let me put in a
padding of 8 pixels so remember the CSS
Box model the padding is inside the
Border okay let me add a padding of 8
pixels in the data as well so both of
these will add space inside the border
so you can see here inside the border of
a cell we have added additional space if
we had margin on the other hand that
space would get added outside the Border
okay so keep the CSS Box model in mind
you can always just search search online
CSS Box model whenever you are unsure
how this works okay so we have the
content then we have the padding uh then
we have the border and then we have the
margin outside it all right so this is
looking pretty good let us now maybe add
a background color to yeah let's add a
background color to the header so
background color let's see I am thinking
of the
color let's maybe just add the color
Alice blue for now one of the named
colors okay nice we have a nice
background color for the header I hope
you can see it it's very light um we are
not going to use very strong color see
what happens is if you use a proper
strong color like this your text becomes
unreadable that is why you always want
to use very muted very light colors and
we'll talk a lot about color guidelines
later down the line okay this is looking
good let's also add a back background
color now for each of these alternate
rows so we don't want to add a
background color for every single row we
want to add it for alternate rows and
this can be done using again using a
special property now this is the thing
about CSS that you have to look these
look up these special properties from
time to time there's no way to remember
them I just looked it up a few hours ago
that's why I can partially remember so
you can say TD and in the TD um I'm
actually just going to look it up over
here in the TD
or actually not in the TD I want to add
this for the header row so I want to get
the
rows from the
table which are the nth child where n is
odd okay and I'll just show you what
this does first and then you will
see yeah and then you will see exactly
uh then we'll discuss how it works
okay let me make that job
stable yeah so here's what we've done we
have said job table so select the job
stable by
ID inside the jobs table select a TR a
row okay so we have the jobs table here
with the ID jobs table inside it we want
to select a row so each TR represents a
row but we only want to select the rows
which are the nth child okay where n is
odd so all the odd rows which selects a
full stack developer row and which
selects the ml engineer row so all the
odd rows get selected by putting this
colon nth child odd and then we are
giving them the background color of
ghost white okay again if you see
carefully here we have of course a color
background color for the header that we
have specified IED then we have this
background white color for this first
row which is row number two technically
and then we have for the third row New
Delhi India we have another background
color okay uh it is very light but I
hope you can see it and we've selected
alternate rows using the nth child and
how do you know this well you just have
to look it up I just look it up every
time so I don't worry about it too much
okay great one last thing we want to do
is maybe this is looking a bit odd that
the headers are centered so let's Maybe
put the headers on the left so I'm just
going to say text align
left okay now the data is now the
headers are also left align all right so
I think we've with that we've
implemented everything that we set out
to implement we added borders around the
table we made the table full width we
left align the headers we are showing a
different background color for the
headers we are using Alice blue and we
are using alternate colors for the the
rows using the nth child e using the nth
child odd property okay so that is the
CSS that we need to style our table not
a lot it's about 10 12 lines but it look
it makes a table look rather nice I
would think okay great so that is how
you style tables with CSS and you can
also verify if
I resize this that the table remains in
the centered and it occupies the full
width of the parent component okay so
that's
tables now I would encourage you to
maybe also learn a little more about
styling of the rows and columns so there
is this tutorial on HTML table styling
you can have these zebra stripes which
is what we've implemented or you can
also stripe you can also have colors for
the different columns if you want again
using nth child and you can also combine
vertical and horizontal stripes so you
have a lot of different ways in which
you can combine of course you can do
tables you can have tables Without
Borders so one change for example we
might make is we may not want the
borders between the inner rows so we can
come in here and we can say that for the
TD for these data cells we don't want a
border bottom we just want a border
right okay and what that's going to do
is that's going to remove this border
bottom because we already have
alternating colors and that's just going
to keep this border on the right all
right um yeah so that is how you style
tables in in
CSS so moving right along we'll also
talk a little bit about merging rows and
Columns of data in tables now you can
use you can create all sorts of
interesting tables in HTML what you can
do is you can merge a bunch of data
cells to look like a single cell either
vertically or horizontally so what would
be nice for us is to maybe try that with
one of the columns here so let's do this
let's get the location column and let's
have the location column split into two
columns City and Country okay so here's
how I'm going to do it I'm going to have
sub columns under location called City
and Country so let's come back here into
the table definition and we have this
first
row we have this first row and this
first row now contains a location so
that's great let me add a second header
row so let's add TR and here again I'm
going to add let me keep that class here
as well
okay now here I'm going to add a couple
of headers one is called City and the
second is called
country all right and what does that do
well as you might expect that add the
second row of headers but now in this
case the second row of headers
says City and Country below job title
and location that's not what we want
what we want is to show to make this
show up under location itself so here
I'm going to use two special attributes
the first is called call span or row
span okay so we want the job title to
actually span two rows so row span
equals
two and now what this does is the job
title the job title
header is now taking up two rows of data
okay we we've simply added the property
row span equal to two the attribute and
that ensures that job title take takes
up two rows of data whereas location
salary posted on are still taking up
only one row of
data now we want the location to take up
two columns so that City and Country
show up under location so we can add a
call span and we can say call span equal
to
2 for
location and let's reload that and now
you see that the location cell takes up
two columns so that's why the city and
Country headers show up under location
because each of them take up only one
column each and now let's go ahead and
finish this Heading by actually giving
row span of two to salary and posted on
as well so let's set row span equal to
two for
salary and let us set row span equal to
two for posted on okay so now we have
the job title which spans two columns
then we have the location which spans
two rows uh sorry now we have the job
title which spans two rows then we have
the location which spans two columns but
only one row then we have the salary
which spans two rows and then we have
posted on which spans two rows however
we have now also added the second row in
which we have the city and Country both
of which only span one row and one
column and because we have these other
values spanning two rows they
automatically get adjusted under
location okay so this can be complicated
at first you're not going to get it just
by watching so practice it try watching
the video re-watching the video and
typing it out step by step and it'll
start to make a lot of sense okay now
finally let's also split up the data
right now you can see that the data is a
bit messed up so let us split up the
country and city for the data so I'm
going to come into the first row here
First Data row and add
another
column so now we have bangaluru India as
the country and city and Country let's
do that for New Delhi India as well so
let's let's come in and
add
India okay that's good let's do this for
San Francisco USA as well again let's
extract out USA and put it in a separate
table
cell all right so now we have bangaluru
India New Delhi India San Francisco USA
now remote creates a problem for us
because it's neither a city nor a
country so how about we expand remote to
take up two cells so let us simply come
in here and let us sell call span equal
to two for remote and let's reload that
and now suddenly you can see that we
have the job title and then we have the
location and under location we have City
and Country and then we have the salary
and posted on and of course City and
country are split properly except in the
case where it is remote where it is just
a single cell okay so this is how you
create a more complex table by merging
rows and columns using the row span and
call span attributes now that we have
this slightly more complex table I think
it might be better to maybe bring these
headings back into the center so I'm
just going to go in here and I'm going
to remove this text align left or I'm
just going to put in text align center
for the headings so under the jobs
header Row for the th which is the
header cells I'm going to Center the
headings so I've centered the headings
right here perfect and I think I'm also
going to bring back the separators
because here this line ends abrupt ly so
I'm just going to come in here and
change the border right for the TD or
the data cell to border so that the
Border shows up on all sides not just on
the right okay so now this is our job
opportunities table now it contains the
job title it contains the location split
by City And Country it contains the
salary and it contains the posted on
information as well okay so now our
table is looking very nice we have
simply added some row span and call span
properties and we've added some updated
some CSS to make it look something like
this exactly what we are looking for now
you can again check out this resource to
experiment with the rose span and call
span property to become familiar with
CSS and HTML you have to practice you
have to experiment you have to break
things and only then you understand how
things work okay so here's one exercise
for you create a layout on paper which
contains different merged cells and
columns and then put in some sample data
into that layout and try to replicate it
using HTML and CSS tables the next thing
that we're going to talk about is text
Styles in CSS now that we've set up our
table uh one thing that we also want to
do is we want to improve the Aesthetics
of this page and there are two parts to
Aesthetics there is the text and then
there is the colors as well right so
let's talk about text Styles in CSS now
CSS provides a wide range of text
styling properties and they allow you to
change the appearance of text in your
web pages and these properties can be
used to modify the font the size the
color spacing and other visual aspects
of your text specifically you can use
external fonts within your HTML
Pages using C CSS okay now why do you
want why might you want to use external
fonts there are some inbuilt fonts that
most browsers come with but that differs
from browser to browser and the
selection is very small when you're
working for a company the company may
have its own design principles may have
its own design guidelines may have its
own fonts that it is using and you may
want to incorporate those fonts into the
website and that is what you use
external fonts for
so external fonts make your website
stand out and look more unique compared
to other websites on the internet and
you can add external fonts to your
website using the Google fonts web uh
using the Google fonts tool okay so
let's visit Google fonts and let's check
out some fonts okay so looks like we
have a bunch of fairly interesting fonts
here and of course there are fonts in
all kinds of languages now uh you can
click on any one font for example I'm
clicking on
Roboto and then once you've clicked on a
font let me just reset the state over
here once you've clicked on a font you
can then select some styles of a font so
each font can have many styles so you
can see here we have the thin font we
have the thin italic font we have a
bunch of different styles from thin to
thick let me just switch to light mode
yeah so we have a bunch of styles here
and you can then select a bunch of
styles so you can select which Styles
you want to use in your website for
example let us use the regular style let
us use the regular italic style let us
use the Bold style let us use the black
style and let us use the medium style
okay so I've selected a bunch of styles
for the Roboto font this font is
something that I want to use on my page
and then there's a button here called
view selected families on the top right
and now you can simply copy this code
over here so there's a bunch of code
here that you can copy and paste into
the head of your HTML page to use these
fonts within your site okay so that's
what we'll do in just a second but the
basic idea is if you want to use
external fonts first you choose a font
from Google fonts then you add the font
to your CSS using the link
tag and we're going to look at that in
just a second then you use the font
within your CSS so let's say you've
Incorporated the Roboto font now to
actually use it on the page for a
particular tag you can select that tag
and within your CSS file you can simply
specify the font family Roboto or
whatever font you have downloaded or
included on your site and that is how
you can set fonts for various elements
on the page okay so that is how you use
external fonts you find something from
Google fonts add it to your page and
then just add some CSS
properties now it is common practice to
use one font family for all the head
headings and use a different font family
for all the body text and at Jovian we
use the inter font so this is the inter
font right here uh which looks pretty
similar to Roboto but has some small
differences so we use the inter font for
headings and we use the Roboto font
which we already looked at that for
text within our web page so let's grab a
bunch of styles from the inter font and
the Roboto font and then include them on
our web page okay so here is the inter
font and on the inter font I'm going to
select let's see I'm going to select the
regular I'm going to select the medium
I'm going to select semi bold bold all
of these so those are all the styles
that I selected from the inter font and
from the Roboto font I have regular
medium bold all right so now we have
styles from Roboto and we have styles
from inter and now I can go in here and
copy all this so if You observe this
link tag over here it contains
information about which fonts we want to
include in our page and then I can come
back into my HTML page
index.html come up into the head and
before my CSS file I'm going to paste
all these link tags okay so just to show
you what that looks like it it looks
like we have added a link tag called
preconnect and two of these preconnect
tags one goes to Google apis one goes to
gstatic not something we need to worry
about we just have to paste it in but
here is the interesting thing we have
this link tag which contains the link to
Google fonts and it contains these font
families inter and Roboto so we have
these font families and these font
families are included as a stylesheet
okay and in in each of these font
familyes various weights are also
included so you can actually go in and
edit this URL slightly in case you want
to include different weights but I'm
just going to save this now and at this
point the fonts have been included on
our page okay so if I reload the page
you can see that nothing has happened
yet because I've simply included the
font right now the next thing I need to
do is actually use this font on the page
and that is something that we're going
to do in the CSS file okay how do we do
it well
we need to add the font family for the
body and then we also need to add the
font family for the headers let's do
that first I'm going to add the font
family for the body so let me change
this to font
family
Roboto okay so what we often do is we
specify a font family for the body but
in case this font was not loaded
properly in case the request failed or
something we also specify a backup as
one of the default font families from
that are already present in CSS so in
this case the backup is Sans serif okay
then I am going to just reload the page
after saving this and you can see that
there was a small change in the font so
if I disable this and reload you can see
that the font looks different and if I
enable this and reload you can see that
the font looks different and if I remove
Roboto you can see that font looks
slightly different it's a very slight
different
all of these fonts are very similar
often but Roboto is what our design team
has told us to use so that's what we
going to use for our body okay great
next let us set a different font inter
for the headers so let's select H1 H2 H3
so you can also select multiple tags
like this using commas so H1 to H6 we're
going to apply this style to all of them
and let us set font
family
enter and let us set the backup as
sanserif
okay and let's reload and now you can
see that again there was a slight
change if
I show you so this is without the inter
font
family and this is with the inter font
family okay slight changes but it looks
on brand it looks closer to what we have
Elsewhere on Jan all right so that is
how you use external fonts now there are
thousands of fonts available on the
internet and you should try to pick
simple leg fonts for a good user
experience otherwise you might run into
issues where people are not able to
actually read what's on your site even
though it looks pretty so check out this
link to explore some other font pairings
so a header and a body font pairing is
often called uh is
often so there are many header and body
font pairings that people have created
by looking at Google fonts for example
Calbert and acumine so this is a good
combination
yeah
calart calart and Acumen is a good font
combination monster art and corer is a
good font combination but obviously it
looks very different from what we have
then we have a bunch of these These are
serif fonts these are not Sans serif uh
and we have these more interesting fonts
we have some fairly nice cursive looking
fonts so depending on what you want you
can use various fonts on your web page
and I encourage you to experiment but
also be conservative stick to some of
the more standard types so that people
can actually understand what's on your
page now apart from the font of course
there are many other text styles that
CSS also offers and we're just going to
run through them very quickly we're not
going to cover everything necessarily
but uh I encourage you to explore these
and experiment with these as you are
working through the lesson so the first
is font family this is something that
we've already looked at it select it
sets the font family of the selected
text we set a font family for the body
and then we overr that font family so we
set a font family for the headers as
well and the specific setting for
headers will override the setting from
the body which is applied by
default then we have a font size so we
can actually go in into the body and we
can change the default font size so
let's say I set the font size to 24
pixels and reload the page you can see
that all the fonts have become slightly
bigger um I'm going to keep it to what
it was earlier the
default now there are many ways to spe
specify sizes and we'll look at those as
well then we have the font weight so we
have a bunch of properties that we can
use to set the weight or the thickness
of the font so I can show you here in
terms of the body so if I set font
weight to
400 that's basically the regular font
weight but I can set it to 600 and then
it'll be slightly thicker and I think we
included a bunch of other font weights
as well let's see we also included 500
700 and 900 so let me select
700 okay that's about the same then
let's select 900 that's really thick uh
we also have 500 which is like a medium
weight so that's a less less thick so
depending on what you want to convey how
prominent you want the text to be you
can set a font weight and 400 is the
default but you can set set a bunch of
other font weights as well okay and we
look at a few examples of font
weight then then we have the text align
property so the text align of course is
used to do a center alignment left
alignment right alignment so you could
say for example text align we've already
done this here we've done H1 text align
Center we could have changed this to
text align right and then the text would
be right aligned we could set it to
Center again and that would be centered
again so alignment is just left right
center there's also an alignment called
justify which is often used in text so
we you say text align justify what that
does is you see this empty space at the
end of the line it makes sure that all
line there are no empty spaces at the
end of a line and all the SPAC is
distributed between the
words so you can see now I set text line
justify for the body and all the space
is now added between the words this is
not very readable so it's generally
avoided unless you have to ensure that
there is no space at the end of the text
so I wouldn't do it but it's it's an
option for you so you have left Aline
Center align right align Justified all
of
that okay then you have the font style
so the font style is used to maybe make
things italic so I can say
font style
italic and you can now see that
everything is a little italic everything
on the page you can of course also apply
it to just a specific section so I could
just go into the description here and I
could just apply the font style italic
so that everything else on the page is
Norm but this is italic which is just
slanted to the side and there are a
bunch of other font Styles as well that
you can apply okay so I'll encourage you
to check it out there are a bunch of
different font Styles you can use what
else well we have uh text transform so
text transform can be used to
automatically make the make all the text
uppercase for example let's say we
wanted all our headings to be all caps
so we could of course type it in caps in
HTML or we could could just set text
transform uppercase and now all our
headings would automatically be
uppercase of course this is just for H1
but I could go in here and apply it to
all the
headings and now everything is uper case
all right so that is text transform and
finally we have this text decoration so
text decoration is used to add a line
whether you can have a underline
overline or strike through so I could go
into the headings and let's say I want
my headings to be
underlined so now the headings are
underlined or maybe I want to line over
my headings not sure why I might want
that but it's possible sometimes for
certain designs that might be useful and
you could also have a line through it
this can be useful if you have specific
things within the text that you want to
strike out so you could put a span
around some text and then just put text
decoration line through let me show you
a quick example let's come in here into
the description deson and let's say
we want to change this to we want to
strike out most highly so I could just
put a span here and I could say style
equals text decoration line through and
I could close the
span all right so now we've put this
span and now you can see that the word
highly is struck out
as we might expect so that's how you can
use this text decoration line through
okay so that's just one of or these are
just some of the properties there are
many many more one other that you might
use from time to time is the line height
so you can see this text over here um if
we want to make sure that maybe there is
more space between the lines we could
set a line height so we could come in
here and we could set a line height and
the line height is normally expressed as
a single number which is a fraction of
the point size so let's say we want the
fraction of the font size so let's say
we want the line height to be 1.5 times
the normal font size so if I just do
that you can see that now everything is
a little more spaced out if I set it to
two so then there's going to be almost a
double distance between each line or I
can just set it to one and then
everything is going to be very close
together that's probably not what we
want something around 1.2 is the actual
line height that is set by default so
that's what you might want to stick with
okay again all of these things are
properties that will be defined in the
design system or in the design mockup
that that will be shared with you by a
designer at your company but it's good
to know what each of these do and you
can experiment just to visually see what
what looks good U you might have the
question given so many properties so
many values how do I decide what to pick
well keep it simple just use as few
properties as possible and then
introduce properties one by one if if
they make things better you don't have
to add all these properties
necessarily and of course most of the
time you're going to be using some kind
of a framework which will have all of
these properties configured by
default okay so as an exercise create a
new web page with some text on it then
look up available values for each of the
above properties and then apply them to
the text on your web page and understand
the effect okay so the more you practice
the more comfortable you'll get you
don't have to remember this stuff but
you have to know how it works so that
when you need to you can look it up and
there's also this reference that you can
check out on styling text it contains
everything that you'll need to know
about text styling now one last thing I
want to cover before we head into a
Break um I mentioned to you that one way
you can add sizes or lengths in CSS is
by using pixels or another way you can
do it is by using percentages so for
example in index in our styles. CSS we
have set the max width of the about
section to8 800
pixels and that set sets the max width
of this section but along with that we
can also SE select a width in percentage
so here we have 50% which is the
width and that ensures that it takes up
50% of its parents width okay so the
there are two kinds of length one is the
absolute length which is expressed in
pixels and then we have the relative
length which is expressed in percentages
but there are also many other absolute
measures that you can use so you can
also use inches which corresponds to
visual inches on the screen you can also
use centimeters millimeters points or
pasas all of these are not very common
so most of the time you'll only see
people using pixels but just know that
these are all also present in case you
want to specify so let's say we want to
set the font size of the
body
2.5 in we could do
that and of course that's very big we
may not actually want that but that
scales the size of the body okay um the
other thing is in relative font sizing
as well most of the time you will use
percentages but when it comes to text
specifically people often use these font
sizes called em and r m and REM what do
M and REM mean well M and REM are both
units of measurement that are used to
size elements based on the font size of
either the parent div or the font size
of the root element which is the body
body tag okay so first I'll tell you
about REM so here's what happens let's
say I sent a set a font size for the
body font
size of 16 PX okay so now I've set the
font size of 16 pixels for the body and
now let's say I set for H1
I set the font
size as 3
RM okay when I set the font size of
three remm for H1 what I'm saying is
relative to the root tag which is the
body tag I want the font size of the
header H1 to be 3x and that is what is
specified by three RM and you can
actually verify this you can go you can
right click you can say inspect and that
is going to open up
this
yeah so that is going to open up this
box model for you and you can inspect
this H1 and you can go into computed
here and you can verify that its font
size is 48 pixels so 16 3s is 48 right
so just by specifying three Ram we have
specified that the font size of the
heading is supposed to be three times
the font size of the body why would why
would we want that well why not directly
just set it to 48
PX well let's say we had a design
overhaul and we wanted to change the
body font size from 16 pixels to 20
pixels we want to make our text bigger
so that people can read it more easily
so if you changed it to 20 pixels and
reload the page you can see that the
text became bigger but the heading did
not become bigger so now we've lost that
balance which we had earlier established
on the other hand if we had three Ram
here every time we change the
basic or yeah every time we change the
basic uh body size that is going
to yeah that is going to automatically
scale the font size of the H1 as well
okay so if I remove this you will notice
that the H1 well it should have become
bigger okay there might be something
else that is affecting the H1 so I'm
just going to put in important
here that doesn't do it
either
maybe we have to set it at the root
level yeah so I believe the root the
root font size has to be set using star
or just using maybe HTML or something so
you set the or you set the base font
size over here using star and then
everything else is expressed as REM of
that so the body font size is going to
be one RM and then the H1 font size is
going to be 3 R so if I reload that you
can see that the body is 20 pixels and
the H1 is 60 pixels but if I change the
body font size to 16
PX now you can see that this is set this
is now scrolled down to about 48 pix
pixels okay so that is how you use RS uh
to specify the font size in relation to
the root tag of the entire page but of
course you can also set it to 3M in
which case if the H1 is outside another
div and that div has a particular font
size then we are simply going to use the
font size which is three times that let
me show you an example here so let's say
I have this H1 inside a
div and in the div we have set the font
size to five
pixels so now this H1 has the size 3 * 5
15 pixels because it is set to 3 m e m
okay so m is relative to the pair font
size REM is relative to the default font
size of the entire page okay so that's
that let us revert that
change so now you might wonder that
since we have all these different kinds
of font sizes how exactly do we decide
what font sizes you should be using how
do you decide the font sizes for the
different headers how do you decide the
font sizes for paragraphs so I just want
to share a few guidelines for you
and this is from this Library called
bootstrap which we look at in the future
so while designing your website it's
important to consider appropriate text
sizes for optimal readability and
usability and here are a couple of
guidelines for the body text 16 pixels
is a commonly used font size and this is
the default in most browsers so you can
just use that so in the body you can
just come in and you if you just
say font size 16
PX that is going to be the default font
size you see nothing changes then for
the headings you can use these font
sizes so for the H1 you can use 2.5 Ram
which is 2.5 times the font size of the
body or 40 pixels for H2 you can use two
RAM for H3 1.75 H4 1.5 H5 1.25 and H6
one RM okay and of course all these will
also be bold so you'll have different
font weights and then if you have maybe
slightly smaller text on the page
somewhere which is smaller than the body
text then you can use point 875 RM or 14
pixels and any larger text you can make
it 25% bigger so you can set that to
about 1.25 RM right so this is a good
rule of thumb that you can have nobody
tells you this when you're learning HTML
but it's very difficult to determine
what font sizes you should have so just
use this keep the screenshot with you
and most of the time you'll be using a
library so this won't be a
problem but if you're working at a
company you'll probably have a design
guide which will specify something
similar for for you as well okay so
let's apply these font sizes so for the
body we have the font size of 16 pixels
for H1 to HED 6 I'm going to use the
inter font and I'm going to use the font
weight of 500 as well so font weight 500
so I just want to make it a little
thinner I don't want it to be so thick
or maybe 600 let's see yeah I think I
like 600 so I'll keep 600 and then I
also want to set the font sizes for for
H1 to H6 so let us set the font sizes
for H1 to
H6 again I am just selecting the H1 tag
opening this bracket putting in the
putting in the property font size and
then using REM so that if we change the
base font size of the page all of this
scales automatically so 2.5 to 1 RAM for
H1 to
H6 and that's good and one other thing I
want to do is this particular section
over here I want to make it a little
bigger so that it's bigger than the rest
of the text on the page so I'm going to
come in here into the description
section and I'm going to say font size
1.25
G and now this is a little bigger a
little nicer all right compared to this
table for instance or compared to the
footer and of course I could go in here
and I could make this smaller so I could
come in here into the copyright and I
could say font size
0.875 RM okay now it is slightly smaller
than the rest of the textt all right so
our page is already starting to look
aesthetically a little nicer we have
these font sizes the next thing we
should probably fix is the colors we
have too many colors on the page
but that is how you set sizes for text
that is how you style text in various
using various properties and as an
exercise you can try changing the base
text
size I believe you can just go in here
and you can select the HTML tag and say
font size 20
PX and I think this should make
everything bigger you can just
put body as one REM as well so yeah and
if you come back make this smaller
everything becomes smaller so that's how
you can scale for font sizes up and down
for the entire Page by just setting it
up on the HTML tag and then using Rems
everywhere or even m in some
cases now let's talk about colors in CSS
because this is where a lot of people
face a a difficulty what color should I
put why is my web page not looking good
the single reason the number one reason
why web pages often look ugly is because
of poor choices of colors and contrast
that's why we have a dedicated section
and again this is not something that we
that people go into in an introductory
HTML and CSS lesson but we want to make
sure that you build good visually
appealing web pages that's why we are
talking about color and colors colors
play a crucial role in web design and
colors also convey brand colors also
convey balance colors also
convey emotion in a lot of cases and
there are many ways to incorporate
colors into your web pages using CSS and
the simplest is of course using the
inbuilt color names so CSS provides 140
predefined color names that you can use
directly for example you can set the
color of a paragraph of text to Red so I
could come in here and I could say color
red and that would make all the text on
the page red which is obviously not very
nice but when you're starting out out
you tend to pick some of these basic
colors don't use them they look your
they make your page look bad instead if
you have to use named colors if you're
not sure what colors to use pick some
slightly muted colors slightly pastel or
softer colors so you could use black or
you could use gray most of the text on
your page should be some version of
black or maybe some shade of gray
sometimes you may have a slight tinge of
blue or a slight Ting of some other
color but definitely not a very strong
color of any kind for example this one
caded blue is an interesting color so I
could probably use this this could be a
nice color to use okay still two
different probably not that great so I
should probably just use one of these
grayish colors like dim gray so let me
just come in and use dim
gray and dim gr definitely looks
somewhat nicer but it's still not better
than the default anytime your color
choice is not better than default it's
probably a poor
choice but you do have 140 plus choices
of colors that you can pick and these
are all named colors within CSS
okay next you have colors that you can
Define using the RGB system so RGB
stands for the red green blue which are
the primary colors of light so all the
colors that you see around you all the
colors that you see on the screen
specifically are built using
combinations of red green and blue so
what you can do is there is this
RGB Color Picker
here I'm just going to search RGB Color
Picker it's a build inbuilt Color Picker
in Google and into this Color Picker you
can a Color Picker you can select a
value for red green and blue let me put
0 0 0 and press enter so when you have
all of them set to zero red green and
blue all set to zero then you get the
color black which means you have no red
no green no blue everything is black on
the other hand let's say I start
increasing red I increase red to 10 it
starts to get slightly redder I increase
red to maybe 40 it's getting more red I
increase red to 50 okay more red I
increase red to 100 now it's like a dark
red I increase red to 200 now it's a
very bright red 150 red of 150 would be
something in between now it's a medium
red and maybe somewhere right at
255 is the brightest red now you cannot
have value is higher than 255 so because
of how colors are represented internally
in the computer memory you have to
choose values from 0 to 255 Z is the
darkest and 255 is the highest or
brightest and of course that is the
color for red you could do a similar
thing with green so let me set red to
zero let me set green to 50 and now
you're getting a dark green let me set
green to 100 and now you're getting a
darker green slightly brighter green let
me set green to 150 it's starting to
look like light let me set green to 255
and now this is the brightest possible
green that your computer screen can
display similarly we have blue so this
is the 50 blue this is the 100 blue this
is the 1 150 blue and this is the 255
Blue okay 255 is the brightest zero is
the darkest now of course you can
combine so you know that red and green
when combined become yellow so you can
say 100 and 100 and that gives you a
yellow ish color but it's still not
completely yellow you have to go all the
way to 255 and 255 to get a proper
yellow color right and if you combine
all three colors in equal quantity you
get Shades of Gray so 255 255 255 is
white and 0 0 0 is black but of course
somewhere in between let's say 100 100
100 is going to be gray and you can make
this gray lighter by going 150 150 150
and you can get all different shades of
colors by combining various amounts of
red various amounts of red green and
blue for example I believe green and
blue together give you the seon color
and then red and blue together give you
I don't know what it
is let's see red and blue together give
you the magenta color right so you have
all these other colors that come
together as well um of course you don't
have to type out all these colors
directly sometimes you have you can work
the other way you can go and select a
color here that seems nice okay maybe
this color seems nice I'm going to use
it I want to use it for some of the text
not a great color for text but let me
just try using it anyway then I can just
select that using a Color Picker and you
can just search Color Picker on Google
and get this widget and now I can copy
these red green and blue values now I
can come back into my web page and let
me just change the font font color for
now so
color RGB so we use the RGB function and
then p paste the red green and blue
value and that will just apply the color
to that particular element whatever is
selected right now I've selected the
entire page that's why it's applying to
the entire page and now I can modify
this uh vs code actually gives you a
Color Picker directly over here you can
actually go in and select a value
directly from here and that's going to
modify it and you can then use that
color on your
page oh sorry you'll have to yeah you'll
have to copy it and I believe then you
can use that color on the page so there
are ways to do this within us vs code
itself but whatever red green blue color
combination you have you can use that
and for now let's just set the default
size to some or the default color to a
gray not exactly black let's set it to
maybe
210 and 210 maybe a slight tange of blue
maybe set that to
230 okay that's actually very light so
maybe let let's make it very light so
maybe 30
30 and maybe 40 over
here yeah and that is looking actually
not bad right so zero is dark 255 is
bright and combined red green and blue
okay so that is the RGB system you can
use the RGB function you can use it for
background colors let's say I want to
use it not for the color of the page but
for the background
color background color of 30 40 40
that's very dark maybe let's add it to
230 230
240 yeah that's a pair background but
generally speaking even backgrounds it's
okay to just keep them completely white
or a very very light gay or very very
light gray okay um so that is the color
then there is another way to represent
colors which is using the heximal color
codes okay so the hexadecimal is a
textual representation of RGB but
instead of numbers you use numbers and
characters now this is represented using
the hexadecimal number system I will not
get into it here but the idea here is an
hexadecimal color is represented using
three uh represented using six
characters and each character could have
a to F or 0 to9 so 0 to 9 or a to F and
the first two characters represent red
this is in fact the
hexadecimal notation for the red value
and then the next two characters
represent green and the next two
characters represent blue okay so often
what you can do is you can if you have a
RGB color in mind let's say the color I
want to use in RGB is 230 230
240 I can put that into a Color Picker
and I can get that hexad deiml code from
the Color Picker and I can just copy
that and instead of typing out the
entire
RGB I can just say
color is Hash Hash includes ex decimal
and then type out the color here okay
and that will just change the color on
the page it's a very bad color but you
get the idea okay so RGB and hex are
equivalent it's just that hexad decimal
is more commonly used because it's
easier to copy paste and use across
different platforms so often you will
find colors in HEX so when somebody says
get the hex code or get the color code
this is what they're referring to and
you can always get hex codes online in
fact a lot of color Pickers also give
you hex codes instead of RGB let's say I
go in here and I go select a very dark
color and I click
this yeah I just click that and that is
going to get the RGB color for me oh
sorry that's going to get get the hex
code of the page for me okay so now I
have applied the hex color to it as such
now of course as you might expect 0 0
0000 0 is white oh sorry is black all
zeros is zero uh very dark red very dark
blue very dark green is black and
because each value goes from 0 to 9 and
then a to F so f f f
f FF that is white okay now everything
has gone white and of course if you if I
put 0 0 0 0 here that would be red and
so on so first two characters are red
from 0 0 to FF and next two characters
are green next two characters are blue
okay let's get rid of that so that is
the hexad diml color code and you can
use that to set background colors you
can use that to select text color all of
that and you can use the Google Color
Picker to convert RGB colors into hexad
decimal or vice versa you can for
example copy this hexadecimal color code
and come into the Google Color Picker
and paste it here and that will give you
the RGB code in case you need
it all right so that's the hex another
color scheme is something called the
rgba color scheme which is similar to
RGB you have red green blue but then you
also have transparency so you can for
example make the background of a div or
you can make the text um on on a
particular page slightly transparent so
that the color behind it shows through
okay let me show you an example let us
set the background color of the page to
let's say red going to look very ugly
but let's set it here no problem then
let us set the color of
the text to 0 0 0 or maybe just 20 20 20
which is a very dark
gray okay it looks very similar it's
still looking very black almost close to
black but now let us come in and change
this to RGB a and let us set the opacity
or transparency to 0.5 so one is I
Believe full opacity and zero is
completely transparent in fact let's put
0. five first and you can see that you
can see some of the red behind you can
see some of the red behind the text If
This Were
green you would be able to see some of
the green behind the text so if I set
the transparency to zero or the opacity
to zero now you can't see the text at
all if I set the opacity to one you
can't see any of the background color at
all through the text but somewhere
around. 4 for instance you will see that
we are able to see some of the
background coming through okay so you
can also use this rgba and similar to
rgba there is also the hex code where
you have red green blue and then two
more characters to represent the opacity
level as well okay not very commonly
used but this is also something that you
can do so that is about colors in HTML
and as you might have seen all the color
choices that we making by default look
pretty ugly
so we'll talk about how to come up with
good colors but now that you know how to
create a color these are all the
different ways in which you can use
colors so you can use color to set the
color of the text which is what we've
been doing right now you can use
background color to set the background
color of an element we've done that as
well you can set the Border color and
then you can use box Shadow and text
Shadow so box Shadow is used to create a
shadow around a box or a div and text
Shadow is used to add Shadow for text
okay so you can look up the properties
specifically and see how these are set
but I'll just show you an example of
Border color let's say we can come here
and we can set for the team image we can
set the Border
width or we can just set the border to
five pixels
solid and let's pick a color deep blue
or something like that dark
blue yeah now you can see that there is
this dark blue border and I can in fact
just change the Border color separately
so I can say border
color RGB and let's say 20 20
and that gives it a blackish or a dark
gray border and I can also set these
border properties separately so I can
set border width to 1 PX and get rid of
this and I can say
border
style as solid this is a solid
border let's make that 5px this is a
solid border I can also have a dashed
border you can see that we can have a
dashed border like this not very common
but you can do it if you if you want and
you can also set maybe the width of
different borders so you can say border
left width is 5 pixels that you have
this border only on the left and
everywhere else you just have a one
pixel border okay you have all these
ways in which you can specify borders
and you can specify the styles of
borders and colors of borders as
well so again experiment with colors a
little bit and generally speaking
picking good colors is really hard and
if you're picking at random just looking
at some colors and try to use it that is
you're going to have a tough time so
here are some guidelines for picking
good colors the first is to use a color
palette so use color palettes to ensure
consistency throughout your design and a
color palette is a set of colors that go
well together so color palette will
typically have a primary color and some
shades of the primary color which are
often used either for text or for maybe
buttons or for um backgrounds then you
will have a secondary color which is
also used sometimes for buttons
you may not have a secondary color at
all and then finally you should have a
maybe a few Shades of Gray that you're
going to use as backgrounds or as text
colors then one other thing to keep in
mind is contrast you want to make sure
that the text is legible which means
that the text should have should have a
high contrast compared to the background
okay if generally speaking you're not
able to read the text then that's a bad
color choice so light text on dark
background or dark text on light
background works well then the other
thing is simplicity avoid using Too Many
Colors just because there are all these
colors doesn't mean you have to use them
just use as I said a color palette with
a primary color a few Shades and a
secondary color a few Shades even there
stick to one or two shades all the text
on your page should more or less have
the same color and ideally should just
be Shades of Gray maybe with a slight
tting of blue or slight tting of green
depending on the theme of your
website and finally um know that
sometimes there are issues like some
people have color blindness some people
do not have have a perfect vision so
there might be color vision deficiencies
that your users might have and there you
can use tools like color contrast
Checker so you can just search online
for color contrast Checker and you can
paste some HTML code here or you can
like set the foreground color background
color and you can check what the
contrast ratio is and it'll tell you
whether this is going to be readable for
for somebody who has color vision issues
or general reading issues all right so
just keep those things in mind now
generally most companies have a design
system with predefined sets of colors
for various parts of the
application and for now you can just use
this one color palette so what I would
suggest is use this color palette
tailent color.com it's linked in the
notebook page and from this color
palette for whatever website you're
working on pick a primary color in my
case I tend to almost always go with the
blue and pick a secondary color the
primary color is what is going to be
used in most places and then the
secondary color is going to be used in
some other places where you need a
second color and then maybe just use the
different grays for showing text okay so
that is what I would suggest pick a
primary color pick a secondary color and
pick a bunch of Grays don't use the
predefined CSS colors they don't go well
together don't use random choices of
colors uh that you find come up with or
try or you're trying to figure out using
the RGB Color Picker that generally
doesn't work use a color scheme
okay so based on the color based on
these I would also encourage you to go
through some example sites here these
are some examples of bad color choices I
mean this one's not too bad but it's
still too bright I would say uh these
are all all completely fairly bad color
choices this is you used to see a lot of
that a lot of this earlier in the
internet era and these are some choices
of good color so one thing you can do
for your website is just pick color
combination so you can see that there's
a prime primary color which seems to be
orange and orange and yellow so some
shades of orange and yellow and the
secondary color here seems to be this
blue and here again there is this
primary color of yellow for Lego and
there there's no second there's a bluish
secondary color that is used in some
places here the blue is the primary
color and here there's the seems there's
this I don't know what this color is
called but this like light pink color
probably again there's this primary
color secondary and then maybe like a
black secondary color uh sometimes you
can use images and matching colors with
images so you have the green color
shades of green and then you have a
secondary color which is the red that's
great a primary color this color and
then the secondary is just black here
again here we have this gradient which
is basically just shades of the primary
color and then the secondary color also
just seems to be a shade or maybe these
are the two colors primary and
secondary and again here we have gray
and we have red so yeah look at examples
look at at your favorite sites and just
copy what they do and use a color
palette of Tailwind color.com while
you're designing your website okay
specifically for text I want to share a
few guidelines normally text should be
almost always some shade of gray some
shade of black uh you can have a slight
tinge of blue or a slight tinge of green
or red depending on your themes uh but
here's a good guideline your headings
can be 90% black or just 22 2222 would
be the color hex color
your body text can be 75% black or 4444
and any secondary text that is not
important can be 60% black which is 6666
and disabled text should be 40% black so
it's a bit confusing because black is
zero so 90% black is going to be very
close to zero and 40% black or 60% white
is going to be very close to FFF right
but I hope you get the idea hex colors
can be a bit confusing to wrap your head
around but as you practice more you'll
get used to it okay closer to zero is
dark uh away from zero is is light so
90% black is very close to zero let's do
that let's come in and let's set these
colors let us first come in into our
body and let us
set these let's set the font size and
the color so the color we're going to
set to 4444 or 75% black so let's come
in here to the body we've already set
the font size to one ram I think that
should work
we have just added the 4444 color and
our body text is slightly gray but it
still looks fine but I think the
headings can be made slightly darker so
let's come into the headings and for
each of the headings let us set the font
weight to 500 and font color to 222 so I
think I'm going with 600 here I like 600
it's looking good for me so I'm just
going to set the color to 22 and now our
headings are slightly darker so that's
fine then what else well
we have this jobs table on this jobs
table I want to make these titles
slightly darker because they are more
important more prominent so I'm just
going to come in into the jobs table and
into the row header I'm going to add the
color
of 22 22 22 which is the same color I'm
using for the headers some now these are
a little darker so that's great then
okay now these backgrounds right so
remember I said we don't want to use the
named colors we want to pick from a
theme so generally for uh for
backgrounds of tables you can use maybe
the primary color and a very light
version of the primary color so let's
see I'm going to go in here into
Tailwind color palette and I'm going to
pick the lightest version of
indigo for my Row background so it is
simply Indigo 50 or let me let me pick
blue 50 just to be very safe and when I
click on it it copies the hex code so I
can come in here into the nth child and
I can paste this color and now I have
this very light blue that is behind
the uh behind some of the rows as a
background color and for this let me
pick maybe blue 100 or I could also pick
the secondary color but for now let me
just stick with Brew 100 and I'm going
to set this on the header row I'm going
to select the background color not as
Alice blue but as this darker slightly
darker blue so you can see now that it
looks slightly nicer because these two
are shades of the same color essentially
so this is a slightly darker blue this
is a slightly lighter blue I could also
maybe experiment with blue 200 if
I'm not happy with the contrast but
that's the most I would go I would just
go up and down within the same um within
the same shade and maybe let me come in
here and let us also set the background
for this so you have this footer here
generally for backgrounds or for body
backgrounds you just want to use gray
and you just want to use the lightest of
Grays so I have a blue gray here which
is slightly bluish gray so let me just
copy the blue gray and let me come into
footer and set the background instead of
ghost white let me set it to blue gray
and now that looks slightly nicer or I
could even just have used a simple gray
as it
is okay fa fa fa and that looks fine
finally for the link on this page I
might want to use the blue color so I
can just go in and I can pick a um the
500 blue for links on the page so let me
pick the a tag and let me
say color 500 U
sorry that color so links on the page
will show up like this but now you can
see that as I hover over a particular
link the color doesn't change so this is
where you can actually use a something
called a pseudo class or a hover state
if you want to change how a link looks
on hovering you can say colon hover and
now you can put in a different color let
me make it 700 so let us check set the
color to 700 over here for the h state
so now when I hover over a link I get a
different color okay and there are
various hover States we'll talk about
them in a future lesson or various
pseudo classes that you can apply but
basically whenever you're styling links
you should specify a normal color and
you should specify a hover color and
sometimes this hover color um hover is
used when you use the mouse but when you
tap using the keyboard um you can use I
think you can use Focus or active or
something like that so when you are
using the keyboard then the focus color
gets applied so both hover and focus
should generally be set together okay so
that is about setting colors so now our
page is looking rather nice because I'm
using a consistent color scheme that's
good what else well we have a gray here
so the gray for the copyright I'm again
going to just grab one of the Grays from
yeah maybe gray 400 or yeah gray 400
should be good enough and let me just
paste
that or maybe gray 500 should be good so
let me just paste gray
500 I think I was
yeah that's gr 500 I think I'm happy
with that okay so our page is looking
nice we have picked a nice set of colors
so let's continue now and let us talk
about forms in
HTML now HTML forms are an essential
part of creating Dynamic web pages
because they allow users to input and
submit data to a web server which can
then be processed and stored in fact
most web applications that you see on
the internet are built using forms and
forms are going to become increasingly
important as we go further into the
course and in the program now the form
is created a form in HTML is uh cre and
no doubt you've used several forms so
you know what forms are this is what
they look like you can put in some
information forms are created using the
form tag so you start a form tag and
then you put a form tag at the end and
you put the entire inputs Etc inside it
you can then use three types of tags you
can use the input tag to create these
text boxes or other various types of
inputs you can use the select tag to
create dropdowns you can use the text
area tag to create big text boxes where
people can enter full paragraphs of text
and there are various types of input
Fields like text you can have password
input fields which is what you do when
you log to a website you can have email
input fields that automatically validate
that what you're entering is an email
you can have radio buttons you can have
check boxes and then of course drop
downs Etc as
well with each input box often you also
have a label so you have these labels
that are associated with these form
input tags and these these labels are
important because they allow not just
the person who is using it normally but
people who are let's say who have a poor
vision and are using a screen reader
labels are used by the screen readers to
tell people what to enter into specific
form Fields labels are also used by
search engines to determine what the
structure of your form is so there are
many ways in which labels are important
so don't ignore labels when you're
building a form and finally most forms
have a button at the end sometimes
multiple buttons to reset or clear the
data uh but you almost certainly have a
submit button or a save button or a send
button that is going to actually trigger
a form submission which is to grab all
the data from the form and send it to
some server some web server and we send
the data using the action and the method
attributes of a form so typically for a
form tag you have an action and then you
have a method now of course in today's
lesson we don't actually have a web
server we are just just building static
HTML Pages a server is something that
can take some request do some processing
on it and return a response we don't
have that today so we're going to be
using a third party service to collect
these form responses but over time we're
going to learn how to use um our own
inbuilt servers okay but this is what a
form looks like you have a form here and
then inside the form you can have labels
and inputs I've put these labels and
inputs inside divs because otherwise you
will find that everything just lines up
on a single line which may not look nice
so let's create a form step by step and
in fact we're going to create a form uh
so one thing you can do is you can just
copy this code and you can just paste it
into the web page and see what that
looks like so let me just show you first
and then we are going to create the form
step by step again let me create a div
here first let me call
that
application okay and let me then put
in an hed2 here and call it submit your
application okay so now we have the
submit your application section let me
then put in this form here so I'll just
paste this form and by the way if you
just want to include a comment something
that is not actually displayed on the
page you can do that using
this comment operator so started with
the open tag and then start Ed with an
exclamation followed by a hyphen hyphen
and you can just put put some text here
so some sample
form remove
later so this is a way for you to just
add some note for yourself this is not
going to be read by the browser this is
not going to be displayed on the page
but this is just a note that you can
leave for yourself you can just say too
sample form remove later okay but now
I've put in this form so this form has
an action this form has a pro a method
these are not things that we're going to
use right now then it has a div and in
this div we have a label so we have the
label name and then we have an input
okay and this is what it looks like so
we have name and we have this empty
input then we have email and then we
again have an input then we have message
then we have an input so we' basically
created a very simple form which
contains a label and contains these
input fields and a couple of things I
want to point out with regards to the
structure of the form
let's make that a little
bigger is that normally for every input
you have to specify a type okay so here
we have specified the type text so here
you can enter any form of text instead
if you had specified the type number for
instance then you would not be able to
enter normal text here you would have to
enter numbers okay so that's one thing
I'll just zoom in a little bit here so
that you can see that I can't enter text
I have to enter number numbers and you
have very various other kind kinds of
inputs as well you have the date input
now in this case it's going to open up a
date picker so that's nice but I'm just
going to revert this to text for now
because it is for name then another
thing that you often have to do is to
specify an ID for each input so what is
a common practice is to specify an ID
for an input and then specify the in the
label which input it is an it is a label
for okay because the label may not of
may not necessarily always be next to
the input itself sometimes the label
might be in a different div the input
might be in a different div because of
the structure of the page so you specify
an ID and then you specify that the
label is for this ID using the for
attribute your form is going to work
perfectly fine without
this you can see that the form still
works but it's a good practice to
specify an ID for the input and specify
a for for attribute for the label okay
so keep that in mind ID for the input
and the ID of course should be unique
and the for attribute um on the label
which which points to the ID of the
input for which this is a label finally
I know I know it can get a bit confusing
right now finally when you also need to
have a name attribute for every input
okay now this input itself is also
called name that's a different thing but
here is another input called email and
it has the name email or I could just
uh yeah or here there is a or I could
just yeah I could just call this
something else mail ID for
example now what what is the value of
the name attribute so the name attribute
decides that when you hit the submit
button and some data is getting picked
up from the form what is going to be the
name of each field okay so if let's say
we wanted to send the data to the server
in this format so let's say we want to
send the data to the server with a full
name
property and an email address property
so when we click submit the server is
going to receive some form data and in
that form data it's going to have a
property called full name whose value is
going to be whatever you have entered
here similarly uh the server is going to
receive some form data and in that form
data there's going to be a property
called email address and that email
address is going to contain whatever
email address has been put in here okay
so the name property is useful on the
server once the form is submitted we'll
see that in action when we actually make
a form submission and finally if a form
is if a form field is required which
means it has to be filled out without it
submission cannot be made then you can
put in the
required attribute here and it doesn't
have any value you just set required and
if it is required then as long as you
fill it you you'll see that you'll not
be able to submit so it's it just says
please fill in this field when you try
to submit the form okay so that is where
you have the required property so those
are some of the properties that you can
specify for a form okay so now we're
going to build a form step by step for
our application remember we had this
application form here which has name
email phone number position resume and
cover letter so we're going to build
that step by step and there are various
form input types so I've just listed a
few here that you can browse you have
the text input obviously we can create
checkboxes so if you just change the
type here to checkbox that is going to
become a checkbox then we have radio
buttons so checkboxes are often used
when you have like you want to show
multiple checkboxes and multiple of
those can be selected so that's when you
show a checkbox and the radio input is
often used when you want to only allow
selecting a single option from a list of
options so again you should experiment
with this a little bit it's all about
getting some practice then to create a
do drop down we use the select tag we're
going to look at an example if you you
want to allow the user to enter a larger
amount of text then you have to use a
text area okay now one key thing I want
to specify about text area in particular
is that all inputs are generally
self-closing tags so the input that you
see here this does not require a closing
tag it is self- closing but a text area
is not self-closing so whenever you have
a text area you have to add the closing
text area tag as well it's just how HTML
has been defined so make sure that
whenever you have an input it you you
don't necessar need a closing tag you
can put one if you want but you don't
need one and for text area normally you
do need a closing tag so that's
something to keep in mind then you can
use a date input again just change the
type here to date and that's going to
become a date you can use a password
input in case you want to build a login
form where you don't want to show what
is being typed um I'll just quickly show
you what that looks
like let me reload this page you can see
now that whatever I'm typing is not
visible here so that's the password
input and then of course you can have
email input so this is going to validate
that the data is being entered is an
email before submission and then you can
have a number input and that is going to
make a
numeric input field and you can also
specify attributes like minimum and
maximum and also the step like let's say
you want it to be multiples of two or
something you can specify that as well
that is again achieved using the input
type now there are several other input
tags that you can use so you can check
out various other input types here there
are lots of these you can have an image
input you can have a color input you can
have a range input so you can have a
slider um you can have a search input
you can have a sub uh submit is of
course the input that is used to create
a submit button uh but yeah there are a
bunch of different input types and now
let us actually build out this
application form okay so I'm going to
take this all away for
now and let's start building the
application form so I'm going to just
first create a form nothing and I'm
going to give it an ID let's call it
application
form and now let us start by creating a
div first again we're putting things in
a div so that they just show up nicely
and let us now create a single input of
type text and let's give it the
ID name and let us give it the
name full
name and let us make it
required okay and let's reload the page
now we have this input box that's fine
let us put a label for this
input
and in the label let us put
the value full
name okay so now we have full name and
then we have this box let us maybe also
add this a small empty line so I'm using
the BR tag here it is a self closing tag
that is used to add a new line um it's
not used a lot anymore but in forms if
you just want to add a new line after a
label you can quickly add a br tag or
you can wrap the label in a div so now
this now you can see that the input box
comes below the label that's one thing
and let us also set the for property
that this is for the input with the ID
name okay so that's looking good the
form is looking good let us also style
it a little bit so that it looks
slightly nice sir so I'm just going to
come in here
and I am going to first select this
application so right now this
application div is always at the very
left so I just want to make maybe Center
it a little bit so I'm just going
to come in here and Center it so let's
see yeah let me just add it here so we
have this application div
with the ID application let me give it
the same Max width of 800 PX and let me
give it a margin of 0 Auto so remember
Auto margin on left and right
automatically centers the div and let me
give it a padding of 0 and 8 pixels so
that it's not sticking to the end so now
you can see here that there's a nice
padding and as I expand it you can see
that it remains centered so that's good
okay so far so good then maybe let's
also improve the
input a little bit so for the input uh
actually for the label so first let me
go in into application
form application form and let me select
the label and for the label let me use
Font
weight 600 so just make the label
slightly bigger or slightly um slightly
bigger in size and then let me come in
here let me say application form
input and let me add a padding here as I
type here you can see that it's very
small I don't have a lot of space around
let me add a padding of
8px so now there is it's it's slightly
bigger let me make that 4 PX I think 4
PX should be fine yeah so it's slightly
bigger let me also increase the font
size so that the text that I'm entering
is of a bigger size 1.25 RM remember the
base font size is 16 so 1.25 of that is
20 okay so now this is looking a little
better and let me also add a margin top
here so that it's not sticking to the
label so margin top of 4
PX yeah so this is looking definitely
looking a little nicer and then I can
put in the words Akash and is here and
it's starting to look nice okay so that
was the input for the full name let's
then add email and we'll add a couple
more and then we'll start
Maybe copy pasting some in the interest
of time so again label for I'm going to
call the email email and I'm going to
call this email as well the text that
I'm going to put inside the label input
type equals
email and ID is email as well and name
equals let's see email
address and this is also
required okay so now we have email to
and once again let's add this BR so that
this comes on the next line and I can
see that this email is very close to the
previous form so I'm just going to come
in here and I'm going to
say label
margin
8px or
actually let me just set the margin
top to
8px that isn't doing much
well let's just set the margin on the
div okay so what's happening is that the
label is an inline element just like
span so you cannot set a margin for it
let's set the margin for the div itself
so application form
div let us set a margin of
8px okay so now our application form we
could even make this 16 if you want to
make it just slightly more spread out
now our application form is spread out a
little better
I think one other thing that I can do
here is in the input I can just add a
border radius of
5px so it's just slightly more rounded
and Border color of
gray or I could use or I could just set
border 1 PX solid
gray and now it's looking slightly nicer
okay so we're just slightly making these
a little nicer um let's add maybe what
next so we wanted to have the phone
number so let's grab the phone number
here this is the class for phone
number
and yeah I think we can add this form
group class to select the divs more
easily I'm just adding the class form
group for the div so that I don't need
to select it like this I can simply
say dot form group
yeah okay so now we have the phone
number and you can see here in phone
number we've actually added a
placeholder so we've added this thing
called a placeholder what it does is it
fills out an empty value that goes away
when you try to fill something inside it
okay so I am going to come in here and
add a placeholder for the name as well
so placeholder equals let's say John do
and I'm going to come in here and add a
placeholder
attribute for the email as well let's
say
John or J do atex example.com
okay so these are all various attributes
that you have to specify and now we can
see that we have this placeholder so
this is looking nice
and let's see maybe make
this padding a little bigger maybe eight
pixels look even nicer yep okay what
next next we have the date of birth
which is a date let me add that in here
as well so now we are adding the date of
birth okay now date of birth
automatically gives us this nice date
selector that's nice we can also specify
Max and Min property for date of births
in case you need that what next so next
we have this position applied for which
is a dropdown so here's how we create a
dropdown so we go in
here
and let's see yeah we go in here and let
us create an input let us create a
label and let's say position applied
for and let us give it for equal to
position and let's add a br
here okay so now we've just added the
label
and let us also give it the
class form
group and maybe I don't need a margin
all around maybe I can have a zero
margin at the I can have margin just on
the top and bottom and the left and
right margin can just be zero okay so we
have the label position form group then
we create the select okay so we put
select and inside select we put
options or option so what are the
options we have we have a
front-end
developer we have a full stack
developer we
have let's
see uh data
scientist and we
have what else we have a ml engineer
right so these are the
options now we have this nice select
which has these options of course we may
need to style it as well so again one
trick I want to show you here is I want
to apply these not just for input but I
also want to apply these for select so
I'm just going to add comma select and
that automatically gives me this okay
now I want to I want to tell you a few
things you need to have in select you
need to of course have the ID so that
the position this is not compulsory but
it's good to have so that the label is
specified properly then of course you
need to give it a name so then in the
name I'm just going to say position
applied that is what is going to be sent
to the
server then what else is it required
yeah I want it to be
required what else do we have here yeah
so for each option you need to specify a
value so what ends up happening is what
you show on the screen and what is sent
to the server may be two different
things so for each option you have to
specify a value so I'm just going to
specify the value front
end Dev of front end here and I'm going
to specify the value
backend or full
stack and I'm going to specify the
value data
scientist and I'm going to specify the
value ml
engineer okay so this is just to tell
you that what you show to the user and
what you actually send to the server can
be two different different things okay
when the form is submitted the server is
going to receive this value but the user
is going to see this value in the drop
down one last thing that is often done
is you have an option with an empty
value and that just contains an
instruction which is
Select position right something like
that so the idea here is that by default
you don't want to select any position
otherwise that default position can get
picked automatically you want the user
to pick a position specifically and that
is why you have the select position uh
this is like the placeholder option in
some sense and that is often given the
empty value okay so that's the value
then we have file inputs so file input
simply has input type equals file and we
are using file input for resume and you
can also specify what kinds of files it
can accept like PDF Doc and docx so let
me just come in here let me put in the
file input here as
well so we have this file input so
that's great and then we have this form
group for the cover letter so for the
cover letter we are using this text area
component so in instead of input we are
using text area and again you specify
the ID you specify a name you can
specify the number of rows that you want
in the text area by default that can be
increased by the user you can specify
whether it's required and you can
specify a placeholder as well but just
know that you have to have a closing tag
for the text area Okay so let's add the
text area here as well let us come in
here add the text area for the cover
letter and now here we are asking the
user to enter a cover letter as well
again I'm going to come in here and I'm
going to apply these Styles not just to
input but also to text
area and that way my text area is going
to have a better colelection I might
want to make the text area full BD so I
can say form group text
area width
100%
and this way my text area is going to
take up the whole width or at least let
me set it to like about 80% let's say
Okay so the text area is slightly bigger
and you may also have to specify your
fonts or font family for the text area
in this case clearly it is picking up
some random font family so you also
specify font family let me specify
Roboto because it is just some normal
body text and Sans serif okay and now we
have specified our text area as well
okay last couple of things one is a
checkbox so we're going to add a
checkbox called I agree to the terms and
conditions and all we need to do here is
just specified type checkbox for the
input and it's going to show a checkbox
okay so now often for a checkbox the
checkbox is created slightly differently
because a checkbox you may require to
actually show the input uh you may
require to show the label next to the
checkbox so often in the checkbox what
you do is you put the input inside the
label okay and what that does is if you
click on the text as well that also
takes the checkbox so that's good now
one thing we might want to do is for the
input checkbox I might want to make it a
little bigger so I can do that again I'm
going to show you another CSS trick here
not something you need to know right now
but I can say form
group
input and I can say only for the type
checkbox so now I'm selecting in the
class form group I'm selecting an input
tag
and I can say only those input text
which have the type attribute set to
checkbox and for them I want to use the
width to be 16 pixels and the height
also to be 16 pixels and that is just
going to make the checkbox slightly
bigger as you can see here okay that
makes the checkbox bigger and finally we
have the submit button so we just have a
div form group input type submit value
equals submit the value is going to be
whatever you want to show on the
actual button so you could say submit
application okay like that and that is
how you create a form so I'm just going
to zoom out a little bit I'm going to go
full um I'm just going to go to the
normal size so now you have a banner now
you have this description now you have
job opportunities and then you have
submit your application full name email
phone date of birth Etc and you can fill
out all the and then click submit
application of course these are all
required Fields so they will have to be
filled in and if you want we can make
the cover letter optional so let's do
that so that we can submit without the
cover letter for the purpose of testing
let's bring this back
here okay and let
us remove required from here so that
this is no longer required okay and now
we should be able to submit an
application but uh let's also add some
styles for the submit button I think a
nice blue color would be good to have so
again I'm going to come in into Styles I
am going to select form
group input type equals
submit and I am going to set background
color to Blue and I'm going to pick a
blue from my color scheme so maybe I'm
going to pick blue
500 and I'm going to set that as a
background color
so that looks nice I may have to make
the text color
white so color
white I can make the font
weight five let's say
600 so the font weight is bigger so
maybe 500 might do the
job and I can maybe increase the
padding 8
PX maybe 16 PX make it a little
bigger
yeah yep okay so you can specify some
things I think the padding is not
getting specified here but you can uh
specify it it's U just a matter of
specificity I guess um but now my submit
application button is actually looking
nice and if I also want here's another
property that you'll often use cursor
pointer and what can what this does is
this converts your cursor into a hand
symbol when you have the submit uh when
you hover over the button and you can
also change the hover style you can
change the color of the button when you
hover over it so you can do all sorts of
things and this is something that you
should look up and then you should
attempt to do but yeah at this page at
this point you click submit application
and that is going to uh submit the
application so let's try that so we say
Akash a b.com
some number I'm going to pick a date of
birth I'm going to select a position I'm
going to select a file so I have a
resume I'm going to add a cover letter
I'm going to submit okay it doesn't do
anything because we've not configured
the form to do anything yet okay so what
we need to do is we need to send this
data somewhere normally this data is
sent to a server but we don't have a
server right now to process this data
that is where we are going to use an
online
platform called form bold okay this is
not something that you would do in the
real world you can actually if you're
building a personal website you can use
form um what this does is this allows
you
to just provide an action for your forms
that you are putting into your simple
website static pages and it is then
going to capture those responses and
also send it to you over email so how
about I just log in here into form bold
and create a new form let's call it
Jovian application form okay and any new
responses that are filled into the form
is going are going to be sent to this
email and I'm going to create this form
so you may have to verify your email to
actually create the form but I'll let
you figure that out okay and now let's
open this form so let's go to the form
settings and in the form settings you
will see this integration option so
let's click on integration and here it's
going to give this Endo so just copy
this Endo okay this is where we want to
send our form data so copy that and come
back here into the
form and what we can do is we can say
action
equals this
link I'm just going to put it all here
so that you can see
clearly action equals this link okay and
we also have to specify a method and you
can see how you can see an example of
how how this form should be used so is
this link and method is post so method
equals
post and let's just save that and since
we want an HTML form with a file upload
so I'm just going to select this option
with a file upload so I think we also
need to put in this ink type multiart
form data okay now don't worry too much
about what these mean whenever you're
using a form you'll have to set these
sometimes these will be set by your own
server so we are going to look revisit
forms in a lot of detail later but for
now we just using a third party service
that can capture these form responses
for us when we hit the submit button
okay let me save that and now I can come
back here and I can reload the page and
I can start filling something so Akash a
b.com and put in a number put in a date
here put in a full stack developer
choose a
file and put in some cover letter here
agree to the terms and conditions and
click submit now when we click submit it
is going to send all the data and each
data is going to be assoc each each
piece of data picked up is going to be
associated with the name property that
we have specified the name attribute and
it is going to be sent into the form
okay so I click submit application and
you can see that it has sent the data to
this form and this form bold the service
that we're using is asking us to maybe
just verify traffic lights to prevent
spam and once it checks that the form is
submitted okay now I can come back here
on the form bold page and I can go into
the
submissions you can see that one
submission was obtained and these were
the values that were filled in full name
Akash cover letter empty and the file is
not showing up because there's a way to
view files maybe in some other way but
they've accepted the terms so if a
checkbox is ticked it is marked as on
and then the form and then the date of
birth all of it is present and the date
at which this form response was created
was also captured by Form T form bold
but that is something that you can pick
uh on your own server okay um so the
idea is not to tell you that you have to
use form bold for all your forms the
idea is to tell you that every
form requires an action to be specified
and a method so method and action is
something we'll talk about in a lot of
detail later so don't get confused right
now but the form data when is collected
and sent to the server which processes
it in whatever way it wants it can
process it and send an email it can
process it and maybe make a database
entry or it can process it in just show
you on the screen like that however it
is okay but this is how you create HTML
forms by creating these um by picking
these tags and by using the input and
the label tags and then styling them as
required so to deploy this web page once
again we can go to static. apppp and it
is a simple application that a simple
web application that can be used to
Simply upload a zip file I'm going to
come back here I am going to Simply zip
up this folder my second web page let me
just zip it
compress this was a copy let me let me
create a zip file
compress okay a zip file has been
created now I'm going to upload it I'm
going to select this ZIP file and I am
going to just pick whatever domain name
it's giving me I'm going to put in my
email so I'm just creating a new account
here so that's where I'm putting in this
plus 10 to create a new account
um
Sydney
Jovian let me create a
password let me accept the terms and
let's continue and it should ask it
should upload the Cs the file so of
course this contains our index.html it
also contains the team and the banner
files and it contains maybe a couple of
other the styles. CSS file and I need to
verify my email so I'm just going to go
in into email and verify my
email let's verify my email
address and now what we have done is we
have taken the code that we have written
which contained the HTML file the CSS
file and a couple of images we've put
that in a CSS put that in a zip file and
we've uploaded that zip file to static.
apppp and that zip file should now get
deployed as a website at careful b.
static. apppp we have the website
deployed we have this header over here
do something great we have some
information about Jovian now it is using
the colors and the fonts that we want on
Jovian we have these nice links that are
colored using our theme our primary
color we have these job opportunities
over here and then we have a place to
create and submit an application and I
can go in here and I can say Akash NS I
can say Akash NS chan.com I can put in
my phone
number
and I can select my date of
birth go back select a date of birth
from long ago and if I try to submit
without filling everything I'll have to
fill it I can select a position let's
say first track developer I can upload a
resume I can pick a cover letter so this
is a cover letter I agree to the terms
and conditions and I click submit
application okay and that pushes the
data form T form bold that is the third
party online service we are using so our
website is on static. apppp and it is
sending data to form bold because
static. apppp cannot run a server it can
simply show your pages as they are okay
and once that is submitted I should be
able to check in on my formboard
dashboard that there is a second
application by me this is the cover
letter this is the phone datee of birth
terms accepted Etc okay so you can also
see it in more detail over here and now
we can go back and we can fill out the
form again okay so yep you can try this
out and there is one last topic which we
have not gotten to today which is adding
meta tags so there are a bunch of these
tags that go in the head tag and what
they do is they determine what shows up
when you share that page online or let's
say when you share that page on Facebook
what is this preview image that should
show up what is the page title that
should show up what is the page uh
description that should show up that is
something that you can actually
configure within HTML similarly when
Google finds your page what is the
information it sees and it displays on
in a search result that is also
something that you can configure using
HTML meta tag but I think this is a good
point to stop so quick
recap we started by looking at this
problem statement to improve the
previous Jovan careers website where we
had this list of jobs and this
application we wanted to create a table
of jobs jobs and we wanted to also
create an application form then we used
the starter code which is my first web
page which basically contained the code
for this and we also want to make
aesthetic Improvement so first we
changed the wireframe so we came up with
this we had this initial wireframe here
which looked a bit
like let's see yeah we had this initial
wireframe which looked like that we
wanted to improve this wireframe and so
we made it look like this so we have
this table and we have this submit your
application form so that gave us a
visual reference for what we wanted to
create and of course this is the
iterative method of software development
you build something deploy it let people
use it then you come back and improve it
and then we came in and we created a
table so we created tables using the T
table TR and TD tags and also the th
tags so you first create a table tag you
then create rows using using the TR tag
then you create heading cells using th
and data cells using TD and we just did
that we looked at some data that we had
put onto a spreadsheet and we just uh
transferred that into HTML code and that
allowed us to create a table that looked
like this of course we this is not a
very pretty looking table so the next
step was to style the HL table to make
it look a little nicer and the basic
styling that we did with CSS was adding
borders around the table and the table
cells you can see here we've added
borders for the jobs table um also we've
said border collapse equal to collapse
otherwise we get these double borders
that we were looking at earlier so to
avoid the double borders like this you
have to set the Border collapse property
just something to keep in mind you can
always look it up then we also wanted to
make the table full width so that it
occupies the entire width of the parent
element which itself is limited to about
800 pixels at the center of the screen
um if the browser is large enough so
then we also left aligned the headers
initially and then we centered align
them again over time then we also try to
show different background color for the
header rows and different background
colors for the alternate rows of the
table and that is all achieved using CSS
and this is what our output looked like
then we went ahead and we looked at some
Advanced table row and column merging
using the row span and call span
specifically the job title salary and
posted on were configured to span two
rows and location was configured to span
two columns and then we added two sub
column City and Country under location
and then we also split the the data
itself into City and Country except for
remote where we just set it to span two
columns and we also modified the CSS
Styles a little bit to better represent
the data in this new structure so this
is what our table looked like after
styling then we learned a little bit of
about text Styles in CSS we learned
about how to use external fonts from
Google fonts so you choose a font on
Google fonts you add those fonts so you
select a bunch of fonts and you add them
to your CSS and then you use that font
in your CSS using font
family and we use the heading and body
fonts specifically we use the inter font
for our headings that is what we use at
Jovian and the Roboto font for body you
can use any other pair there are a bunch
of pairs you can find online and to add
them to our web page we simply need need
these link tags and additionally we also
need these CSS Styles um to use these
fonts So within the body we've added
some fonts and then for um I added the
Roboto font family and within
the H1 to H6 this so within the headers
we've used the inter font family okay
then we saw some common text Styles some
common text CSS properties of course
there's font family then there is font
size and there are various ways to
express size and CSS there is font
weight which is how thick each character
is so you can use 400 which is normal or
500 600 700 800 there is line height
which is how much space there should be
between lines about 1.2 is common but
you can go 1.5 you can go smaller as
well there is font style which you can
use to italicize the text and you can
check out other properties as well there
is text transform you can make
everything upper case you can use
sentence case which is to capitalize the
first letter of every word or you can
use
lowercase and there is text decoration
which can be used to underline overline
or strike through text okay again you
have to experiment with these and only
then you become familiar and you don't
have to remember them you can always
look them up I don't remember them after
15 years of web
development then we looked at how to
express sizes in CSS so we have these
absolute sizes or pixels and we have a
bunch of other absolute sizes which are
not commonly used in relative sizes
percentages are more common when we are
specifying widths or Heights for divs
but for fonts we often use M and R M
expresses the current elements font size
as a fraction or a proportion of the
parent elements font size and REM
expresses the current elements font size
as a proportion of the default font size
for the entire page which is set on the
HTML tag I believe okay there's also
these viewport Dimensions that is left
as an exercise for you in terms of
sizing uh we had some guidelines that
for body text 16 pixels is the common
size and smaller text can be 875 RM or
14 pixels and larger text can be 1.25 r
or 20 pixels and then for headers you
can use different sizes from 2.5 RM to 1
RM from H1 to H6 and we prefer using
Rams for sizing because you can simply
go and change the HTML tag text or the
root text of the body of the page and
everything will get updated
automatically okay
and then you can of course specify these
Styles in CSS so again type out all the
code yourself that is how you understand
this you should spend four five 6 hours
this week just typing out all this code
on your own then we looked at some
guidelines around colors uh the first
thing we looked at was how to use colors
in CSS of course we have a bunch of
inbuilt color names but often you will
find that they do not look very good
when you actually use some of these
inbuilt color names but you have a bunch
of these you can use from and if you
want use an inent color um start with a
color that is very muted very light so
maybe just a light the last set of
colors here and of course you can use
RGB red green blue and you can specify
value of 0 to 255 for red green and blue
respectively and that is going to create
a color for you zero is dark uh 255 is
light so you can go from black to white
if you vary all of them equally with
Grays in between or if you pick
different values for red green and blue
you can create millions of color
combinations now another way to
represent he uh red green blue colors is
using hexad decimal codes and this is
the hex or the base 16 representation of
red green and blue combined together
into a single string and this is what
you often find on the internet because
these are easy to copy and paste around
instead of
RGB and then we have rgba colors with
transparency so you can use rgba where
you can specify red green blue values
you can specify the opacity value one is
completely opaque and 0 is completely
transparent and 0.5 is somewhere in
between so that the background color is
going to show through or the background
image is going to show through then we
have CSS color properties so you can use
color background color border color box
Shadow text Shadow all these properties
that have color and there are some other
properties as well that can use color
Okay in terms of picking good colors
ideally you should be using color
palettes you shouldn't be picking random
colors from the internet here and there
a good color palette tool is Tailwind
colors.com where you can just use maybe
one of these as the primary color and
then use a bunch of grays for text and
maybe a secondary color if you need to
use a second color okay and just use
shades of the same color also have
enough contrast keep it simple don't use
too many colors and don't use colors
just because you can sometimes black
over white is as good as it needs to get
now also make sure that the colors are
accessible to people with color vision
deficiencies okay there are some
examples of good and bad color schemes
that you can check out in general it's a
good idea to maybe explore the color
schemes of specific websites and for
text specifically for headings you can
use 90% black with a tinge of blue or
green as per the website that you're on
uh that you're designing for body text
you can use 75% black or 4444 for
secondary text you can use 60% black and
for for disabled text you can use 40%
black so these are good rules of thumb
to make your pages look good and we've
just applied this to the various headers
and the various headers Footers Etc in
our code okay then we looked at forms in
HTML so you can create forms using the
form tag and in the form tag you can
then specify labels and inputs and
inputs can have various types and
normally we put these within div so that
each shows up on a separate line and of
course you can Al add a br tag after
each label to show the input on the next
line after the label and there are
various types of form inputs text
checkbox radio dropdown so most of them
use the input tag some of them use a
different tag for example there's a
select tag that is used for creating
drop downs along with the option tag and
then there is the text area tag which is
not a self-closing tag that's one thing
to remember and we have date input
password input email input these are
again all inputs okay and we have number
inputs as well so then we created the
this actual application form here which
was which had a bunch of fields and we
also styled it using CSS so we looked at
some various interesting ways to select
things so for example we selected the
label change its font weight we selected
the input select text area all together
we selected input of type checkbox using
this special kind of selector and input
of type submit which is a submit button
using the special kind of selector so
you have all these interesting ways to
select and style forms and over time
we'll start using Frameworks so you
won't have to do much of this styling on
your own anyway and finally once we did
all that we also
then deployed this website to uh we also
then used an online platform called form
bold so we signed up on form.com and we
created a new form inside form.com
copied the action that we need to set up
into our form and we have some example
text here so we need to put the action
method and apparently this ink type into
our form and what that does is when the
user H submit this data is going to be
sent to this site called form bold okay
and that's it so we just need to add
these few lines and we can send our form
data wherever we want it can be a
completely separate site but over time
we'll of course build our own server
which is going to accept this form data
and that's what we looked at you can
check out the section on HTML metatags
if you need and finally deployment was
really straightforward all we did was
create a zip file and that Z file
contained our index.html styles.css team
and banner JPG files and we took that
zip file and uploaded it on static.
apppp and when we uploaded it on static.
apppp it created this free site for us
and in this free site we simply deployed
it and we tested it out hello and
welcome to this live workshop on turning
a figma mockup into a web page and this
is completely unscripted I'm I'm going
to pick up a design and I'm going to
implement from scratch something that
I've not practiced before so you will
see me making a lot of mistakes you will
see me uh you will see things go wrong
but I hope to show to you what happens
when you are going through the process
of turning a design into a proper web
page what are the challenges you
encounter and how can you answer or
overcome some of those challenges so
with that let's get started today we are
going to pick up a mockup from figma by
the way figma is a design tool so at
most companies you will find designers
specifically UI or user interface
designers use a tool like figma to
create mockups of web pages and then as
a web developer you will have to turn
those mockups into proper HTML CSS or
sometimes you might use a framework like
react
Etc and if not figma sometimes people
use a tool called sketch sometimes they
use some other tools but every design
tool more or less looks similar and let
us open up this mockup so typically as a
developer you will receive a read only
copy of the mockup and you are going to
be able to then inspect specific areas
within that mockup so looks like this is
the web page that uh we've picked out by
the way I've picked this out from the
figma community which is where a lot of
free such free web pages can also be
found in case you want to practice and
this is what we'll try and create today
so we have this web page where uh this
is created by feri feri sahen and looks
like have their phone number email and
we have a picture not sure if it's a
stock picture or it's a picture of the
person who created the design uh then
there is this this is often called the
hero section this is often called the
section where um you have some big text
and maybe a a call to action or a button
in this case that button seems to be
contact me then there is a section
called what I do talking about his uh
developer and designer experience so
this looks to be a personal website and
there is some information about front
end development backend development
interface development that he's talking
about here then there is information
about some of his projects now of course
most designers will just put in some
random text or lurm ipsum text as this
is called most designers will put in a
lorm Ipson more a placeholder text but
of course in the real world when this
when this website goes live some actual
text can come in here okay so this will
be information about the projects
created by feri and then there is also
this uh uh footer at the bottom all
right um there's actually a more uh let
me just sign up here so that we can
actually see this and I'll be able to
inspect specific parts of this web page
I'll be able to look at the fonts colors
and things like that and in fact I am
going to pick a slightly harder version
of this so this is what is given as an
assignment in one of the courses that we
are running this is in fact the first
assignment on HTML and CSS but I'm going
to pick a slightly harder version of
this so let me just find that so I'm
going to use this extended design mockup
uh something that is is actually a
little bit harder so here now we have
not just the same hero section but we
also have this in this uh skills and
project section as before but we also
have the section called pricing which
seems to have like a
pricing a bunch of pricing elements
sharing information about various
services and we also have this section
about frequently asked questions so what
we'll do is we'll try and cover some of
these more advanced uh Design Elements
as well and maybe we'll also try and add
some of these background element so
there seems to be this background
element over here there seems to be this
background element here and there seems
to be this line over here that shows up
just below WordPress developer so we'll
see how much of this we can cover I have
no clue if we'll be able to touch on all
of this within the hour or so that we
have but uh whenever you're given us a
design mockup this is where you should
start you should start by just studying
the page and understanding what's on it
identifying the various sections within
the page and I've actually laid out a
step by-step process that we will try
and follow today very very roughly uh
but the prerequisites that I'm assuming
here are HTML so I'm assuming here that
you have some knowledge of HTML I am
assuming here you have some knowledge of
CSS and I'm assuming here you know how
to use a code editor like Visual Studio
code if you don't then you should check
out some beginner friendly tutorial or
come join our uh full stack developer
boot camp where we cover all of these in
a lot of detail okay so the first thing
is to inspect the design mockup now of
course we've opened up the link and we
have created cre an account on figma so
we can actually inspect the mockup and
once you've created an account you can
go into this inspect tab on the right so
if I just let me just zoom in here a
little bit so that you can see things a
little
better so on figma you have this inspect
Tab and this is this inspect tab gives
you a lot of very powerful details that
you can directly translate into things
like CSS properties colors fonts Etc so
let's let's say I want to check what
exactly is the background color here or
maybe the background color for the
entire uh for the entire design you can
see here that the background color for
this entire design seems to
be over here F ff8 F0 all right so that
is how I can pick out the background
color and seems like this particular
design was created with a width of 1440
pixels and a height of 3596 pixels so
1440 piece is a common width setting
that people use so we're going to use
that same width setting and I can go
into individual sections so I can go
into this particular section here and
here I can see okay this is the width
height Etc this is the actual text in
case I want to copy it the content um
this is the typography so it seems like
the font used is leagues pattern and
then there is a certain font weight
there is a certain font size so all of
this information is going to be useful
when we all when you start putting in
some of the CSS for our page and there's
a bunch of information about the Cs CSS
as well that we'll try and use later
okay so first thing you should do is
just inspect a few things and figure
things out understand the dimensions and
styles of various components and
identify the fonts used on the page so
that we can find them on Google fonts so
for example the F font used here on this
page is called League Spartan you can
see here so I can just come in into
Google fonts and I can search League
Spartan and here is that font right so
most fonts that designers use will be
picked from goog will be available on
Google fonts so you will have to then
include those fonts within your uh web
page to actually start using them okay
you might also want to export the images
as PNG or JPEG files so here for example
in this mockup we have this image and
this image need may need to be exported
so you can just go to the export Tab and
you can just press plus and you can
export this image so let me just export
this image as let's see uh let me just
call call it hero image so this is since
this is part of the hero section the top
section is often called the hero section
I'm just going to put it on my desktop
and call it hero image right and
similarly if there were other images on
the page you could also export those
images we don't have to do it
immediately we can do it slightly later
as well all right so that would be step
one inspecting things but let's now
start coding so step two is to set up
the basic page structure and styles and
then step three is to actually go ahead
and implement the web page section by
section so first I'm just going to
create a folder on my desktop and open
it up in Visual Studio code I'm not
going to use git or anything here I'm
just simply going to let me see let me
create a new folder and let me say let
me call it uh let me give it a
name figma to web page and in this
folder I'm also going to move in my hero
image that I just downloaded and I just
want to open up this folder in Visual
Studio code so let me just open up
visual studio code this is the code
editor that is often used by web
developers and on Visual Studio code I'm
just going to go to file open folder and
I'm going to navigate to the folder on
my desktop figma to web page so here I'm
selecting the folder figma to web page
and I'm going to click open all right so
now we have this folder figma to web
page over here and in this this folder
has been opened up in Visual Studio code
and now I can start developing so I can
create a new file and I can call this
file
index.html and this is going to be my
HTML file which is going to contain all
of the HTML code and I'll add a CSS file
later on as well and you can see that
the same file got added here too and let
us put some very basic content into this
file H index.html let us just put the
HTML tag again I'm assuming here you
have some knowledge of HTML but in case
you don't um take a a very basic
tutorial should be sufficient to follow
along with what we're doing here now
within the HTML tag we generally have a
head tag and a body tag the head tag is
where we are going to put all the links
like CSS JavaScript fonts Etc and we
also put a title here so let's give this
a title what is this is the personal
website for feri sahin so f e r d i s a
h i n so let's just put f e r d i s a i
n for the sahin and let us uh in the
body let just let us just create a div
and let us just put hello world here in
the div Okay so I've done nothing here
nothing so far I've just created a
folder in that folder I've created an
index.html file and that index.html file
now has some HTML content very basic
stuff and now I can open up this
index.html file in a browser so I can
just double click and here you can see
that the file has been opened up in a
browser over here if I zoom in a little
bit and now we are ready to get started
so let me just put this on the side and
I'm going to close this sidebar for now
as well so so now we have done the first
thing we've created a folder on our
desktop opened it up in vs code we ready
to go then we are going to create an
index.html file and we are also going to
create a styles. CSS file that is
something that we will also need to add
where we are going to add all our CSS
and we have copied over the image that
we were using here there's just one
image so let me create another file
called styles.css
all right perfect I've created a file
styles.css this is where my tech my CSS
is going to go and now I need to
incorporate the styles.css file I need
to link this file from index.html into
my uh so that I can use the styles from
this page all right and I'm just going
to search so how to link CSS file in
HTML page I should be knowing this but I
keep forgetting this so I just look it
up so HTML Styles CSS how to add CSS all
right and there are three ways to add
CSS we want to add the external CSS file
so the external CSS file is simply we
simply do this link Rel equal to
stylesheet and href equals my style.css
so I'm just going to add that link Rel
equal to stylesheet of course in this
case it's not my style.css it is
styles.css that is the CSS file that we
using and this seems to be this doc type
HTML that is there here so let me just
put in this HTML here as well okay all
right so now we have set up the ind. uh
the HTML file we have set up the styles.
CSS file and we can verify that things
have been set up by let's say going into
an going into the CSS file and adding
some Styles let's say let's add a
background color antique white and let's
save it let's reload the page and you
can see that the color of the page the
background color has changed all right
so I'll just reset that for now and get
back to where we were perfect so now the
next thing for us to do is to add the
head title which we've done already the
link tag for the style and the body and
maybe add section wise divs so we have a
bunch of sections here let me come back
here into the design so I'll call this
the hero section uh and you can see here
even the designer has called it the hero
section so this is the hero section then
under the hero section we have
this what I do section and under the
what I do section we have this project
section and under under the project
section we have this pricing section and
the question section all right so let's
just create a bunch of divs so we have a
top level div called hero then let's
create another div called what I do and
then let us create another div
called
projects then let us create another div
called pricing let us create another div
called questions and let us create
another div called putter there's also
that black footer at the end so I am
going to have another thing for that as
well so 1 2 3 4 5 and six so we have six
sections and let's reload that and this
is we are this is what we're hoping is
going to eventually turn into the actual
web design the page that we are looking
at okay perfect so now we've created
these sections what next set up the
basic Styles header body font family
text size Etc so let's start setting up
some of the basic Styles here okay first
thing first is the background of the
entire page so I'm just going to go and
select the entire uh this is called a
frame in figma so I can just click on
the frame name and get the frame and
looks like this is the color that is
being used here so I'm going to go in
here and I am going to come into
styles.css and for the body I am going
to set background color to this color uh
okay I think I didn't need to type yeah
so background is this color and now
we've added the background so we start
starting to make progress we've added
the background Step One is done what
next well I might need to just study the
fonts that are used on the page and
include those fonts from Google fonts
into my project so here is one font
there is this font called leag Spartan
that seems to be used here so leag
sparton okay I want to use the leagues
sparton font and I found it on Google
fonts so let me just seems like I have
some selections here already let me get
rid of all these selections so that I
can go ahead and do this from scratch so
leagues SPN is the font I want to use
and let's see let's get all the weights
and we will get rid of some of the
additional weights so Google fonts is a
place where you can find all kinds of
fonts and to incorporate a font into
your website you can just add a bunch of
styles of the font so you can see that
there are various font weights there's a
thin font there's a thick font regular
font and all so I'm just grabbing all of
these so that I might need to use any of
them I'm not sure I'm grabbing all but
later on I can go in and edit the uh the
link tag or whatever I incorporate so
that I don't uh um I don't have to worry
about including additional fonts that
I'm not using but just to give you an
idea what you're going to get here is
let's say I close this so once you add a
bunch of fonts you can see this view
selected families button on the top
right and from there you can check you
can review that okay for leaks pattern
you have selected a bunch of these fonts
and then to use that font on your
website you can then use a link tag so
to use the link tag you simply copy all
of these and then you go and add that
within the head tag of your HTML page
but of course leaks PN is not the only
font there are other fonts here as well
so let me go and check what other fonts
are being used so that I can just
incorporate all of them into my website
at once okay now this font over here
seems to be popins so Poppins seems to
be a font that is used here and there is
this font inter that seems to be used
here as well this seems to be popins
this seems to be leaks pattern this
seems to be popins this seems to be
enter and popins okay so from what I'm
gathering here there there seem to be
three fonts here one is the font that is
used for very big large headings then
second is the font that is being used
for these uh smaller headings or section
headings or big text and then third is
the body text the actual body text and
that seems to be enter
so let me grab popins and let me grab
enter and then we'll then we'll add all
these fonts into our web page so let me
search for the font popins so let's go
back to Google fonts let's
go
popins okay that is the popins font I am
just going to select all the variations
right now probably not the best idea I
should probably check with the designer
which all we need to use but it's okay
we'll go and fix this
later
okay I am I have selected a bunch of
these
fonts all right looks like there's a lot
of these so I've added the popins font
let me go back in let me search for the
inter font and I'm going to get a bunch
of variations of the inter font as well
again I'll just select all of them just
so that we don't have to worry about
missing any important
fonts looks like we got the inter font
as well okay great so now you can see
that our link tag has been populated
over here so we have this link Rel
preconnect etc etc and over here this is
the specific area where we have names of
fonts I can zoom in a little bit you can
see that we have names of fonts and then
weights of those fonts as well so let's
just copy that entire link tag and let's
go in and put that link tag into our
head so I'm just pasting the link tag
here and I'll just right click select
format document so that it it just shows
up a little nicely and now we have
Incorporated all the fonts into our page
two of course we've not started using
them we've just Incorporated them so no
change happens on the page itself but
let's come back here into the page and
let's see so we have it looks like inter
is the main body font so I'm just going
to come in here into styles.css and into
the body I'm going to add font family
enter um actually I can just copy this
from yeah I can just copy this from fig
by itself I can just click the copy
button and that's going to copy all of
these things so font family enter the
base font size I'm going to just set it
on HTML just so that we can use Ems for
relative font sizes font weight of font
weight of 400 on enter okay then the
font line height seems to be 24 pixels
letter spacing we probably don't need
that it's by default it's I believe it's
just zero and then text align left we
don't need that okay so just as I do
that I've changed the body fonts and you
can already start to see that now we are
getting something that is closer to what
we expect okay what about the color of
the body text so the body text seems to
have
this slightly uh slightly different
color and this is the color that they're
using here so the color of the body text
is 5520 6D so I'm going to come in here
and set the body color body text
color let's come back here let's
see body text color yeah it's it's all
added here so over here we have this
color
55206 so this is a nice thing about
figma it gives you the CSS properties
that you can use directly of course
sometimes the CSS properties may not
have an exact mapping you may still have
to modify things a little bit depending
on how the designer has set things up
but in most cases you should probably
just be able to copy things over and now
you can see that the color of the text
is also changed great that's fine
what next what next well uh let us set
up maybe so this is like a heading this
is an H1 and there's an H1 tag so for
all the headings H1 to H6 I feel like or
maybe at least this is an H1 and then
this is an H2 and looks like H1 and H2
are the only headings used and then this
is an H3 which also seems to have the
font popins so for H1 and H2 seems like
we using leagues part
so I'm going to come in and I'm going to
say
H1 comma H2 I want to use the font
family leaks Parton
so let's see font family leaks PN so I
can just copy that over here or I can
just copy all the typography at once so
let me copy the typography here for for
the entire
thing and let me come in here and let me
paste it of course sometimes we may have
to edit what we paste so H1 H2 let me
just put font weight 700 I'll verify if
this is correct actually let's just do
H1 for now we'll do H2
later okay and let's format this
document and all right so now for H1
which is the heading of the page we have
set up the font family we don't need the
letter spacing in text line I think that
should be fine we've set up the font
weight we've set up the line height so I
can come back in here and then maybe I
can actually just put in this text
directly so again I can click on this
text I can scroll down and or scroll up
and copy that actual content so just
click go go into the content Tab and
click copy come back here and maybe in
the hero section let us just put in an
H1 here so let's
do hero section and let us just put in
H1 and let's paste
this okay all right and I was just using
a a very big font earlier that's why a
zoomed in version that's why it was so
big but now uh that we have this H1 in a
big size I'm zooming zooming back to
100% uh visibility okay all right so now
we have the H1 but the color seems to be
off like you see here the color for this
H1 seems to be different so let's grab
the color the color is shown here so
let's just grab this color 1 190
d37 and let us grab this color and let
us just go in here and let us set color
to 1 190 d37 and now we have the right
color for the H1 as well okay great
let's also fix the H2 let's fix this
style as well so I'm just adding in the
basic Styles the we added the body text
background we ordered the body font size
we added the body font family let's add
the font family for H2 so with H2 seems
like we are still using League Spartan
and how did I decide this is an hed2 I'm
just going by my my gut feeling here the
biggest uh heading on the page should be
in H1 the second level heading should be
H2S and then maybe these can be h3s so
we'll see but for H2 here I'm just going
to grab the typography settings and I'm
going to create another H2 style and I'm
going to again give it the right Styles
let's get rid of letter spacing text
align we don't need that and let's just
verify that an H2 is loading fine as
well so with 10 years of experience Etc
let me come in here and let me come in
and let me just verify what I do section
I'm just going to add an
H2 okay and let's reload okay again the
color seems to be off let's verify that
we're getting the right color so in this
case the color just seems to be black or
0 0 0 yeah so I'm just going to grab the
color 00 0 ideally although this could
have been a mistake on the part of the
designer we do not mix too many colors
on a web page so my guess is that the
designer may have intended to use the
same color 1 190 d37 or for this H2 as
well but they probably just forgot to
set it on figma because these both look
very dark um but in this case I'm just
going to go with the design whatever is
on the design let's just replicate that
and but that that is a that is a
question that I might ask the designer
and by the way you can leave comments on
figma to ask questions but or you can
just check in with the designer directly
okay so now we have the H2 that is
looking fine too what else well uh we
have this body text over here that is
already enter we have verified that so
let's maybe add this body text in as
well so but the color and the color also
has been set for the body text
no um but this is not body text exactly
uh this is the body text and this we
have made enter this is like headline
text of some kind so this is big text so
what I'm going to do is I am going to
set up a class for this and I'm going to
take a I'm going to apply those those
color and font settings to a class over
here okay so let me just grab this and
let me grab this color and let me just
call this class headline so whenever I
need to
use or let me just call it Big text
maybe even headline may not be the right
thing so for big text the background or
the color that we want to
use is this this and what is the font
size let's study the font size here so
the font is Poppins the weight is 400
the size is 18 and then the line height
is 32 pixels so let me grab that and let
me put that in here as
well yeah and now we have the font size
for big text and if I want to verify if
this big text Big text is going to show
up properly I can just copy this content
over here and I I can come in into
index.html under the H1 let me add a div
and let me just give it the
class big text and let me just paste the
content here okay and I can verify that
okay this looks more or less like what
we have here lmm doors yeah it it looks
to be it's definitely bigger than the
normal body text okay I think we have
set up most of the basic styles at this
point there are maybe there is this one
style and there is this one style here
that we may need to deal with let's deal
with them when we get to them but at
this point I I feel I'm feeling pretty
good in terms of the background of the
page we've made a lot of progress we've
brought in all the fonts we brought in
the inter font of course which and we
may want to give it like
a um like a backup font in case the font
is not picked up
properly then similarly we may want to
give a backup font to leaks SP as as
well I'm just going to put Sans serif
here so whenever you're putting in font
families it's always a good idea to also
provide backup fonts and let me also
provide a backup font
here and let me provide a backup font
here for popins as
well okay great
so that is going to make sure that our
fonts load up properly and we've
provided the right backups fine next up
let us actually start building the web
page section by section because we've
set up the basic Styles header body font
family text size background Etc so let
us add the content for each section one
by one first using HTML and then let us
check the CSS properties for that
content and then finally let us add
styles for each completed section one by
one using CSS so we are going to go
Section by section so I'm going to start
with the hero section or the top section
and I'm going to start by adding the
content so what do we have here well
there is this the way you should
approach these is you should go in you
should go outside in so this entire hero
section here seems to be a box right and
then in this box let me actually just
copy this over to a whiteboard so that I
can actually show you how I I would
think about something like
this okay so here is the design we
have so here's the design we have and
now we're going to start annotating or
dra uh start drawing boxes around this
design now in this design we have first
of all of course this entire thing is in
a box right so this is our entire outer
div so to
speak now up in this div there are two
parts there is a left half and there is
a right half so this is the left half
clearly this is where a lot of the
content lives and then there is this is
the right
half this is where where we just have an
image okay so now you're already getting
a sense that you need an outer div and
inside that you need two divs you need
the left div and you need the right div
now in the left div we can start again
breaking things up so what you want to
do is you always want to see okay is are
things arranged horizontally or are
things arranged vertically so clearly
first in the outer box things were
arranged horizontally so that will
inform our CSS settings then but in this
left half things are definitely arranged
vertically so there seems to be this one
box that I can draw around this contact
information then there is this one box
that I can draw around this High section
and then there is this one box that I
can draw around
this section which is just uh the
headline um or the sort of the big text
and then there is this um one box that I
can draw around this big text which is
the body text which is big in size and
finally there's one box I can draw
around the Conta me button okay so at
this point we actually have a very clear
structure of the page and we can now
start turning that into HTML content all
right and I'm going to start giving some
of these boxes IDs just for easy
identification but another thing that
you can also do is you can just use HTML
comments so let's do both maybe okay so
first let's just create let's just add
an HTML comment here and let's say this
is the hero
section all right now in the hero
section we have I'm going to get rid of
all of this for a second I'm going to
add it back later with time in the hero
section we have two boxes so you always
want to do the design outside in so in
the hero section we have one box and
this box is going to be
the by um hero
text
parts and then this box is going to
be hero image okay
all right and now inside the hero text
let's go back here so inside the hero
text we have a bunch of vertical div so
1 2 3 4 5 so let me just add those in as
well just so that we have set up the
structure before we are actually adding
a lot of the content so this is going to
be let's
see so this is going to be email and
phone and let's just put that in here as
we'll write that in here as well then
after email and phone we
have high we have
the name
basically after the name we have
this let me just call this
like
H1 so the H1 is going to be here I'm
going to create a div right now but but
maybe later I might just replace that
with an with a direct H1
tag and then we have this explanation or
this let's let's call
this um subtitle or let me call it title
and subtitle and then a button right so
let's call this
title and let's call
this
subtitle okay and then finally let's add
a
button so there's a there's going to be
a button
here all right so now we've set up the
basic layout we've set up a couple of
we've set up an outer div called hero in
which we have the hero text div we have
the hero image div and then in the hero
text div we have a bunch of divs 1 2 3 4
five divs for each of the sections
within that uh section okay so let's see
um the first thing we need to do is if I
just reload the page
let me save this and reload the page so
right now we have nothing here right
right now we have nothing in the hero
hero section so the first thing we need
to do is maybe start putting in some
content so that we can start getting a
sense of where things are right so this
is
the um maybe the first thing I'll do is
I will put in the email and phone so let
me get the email let me get the phone
information I'm going to just go in here
I'm going to copy the phone information
and let me put in the email and phone
here so let me just put put that in
right now okay so now we have the phone
then below the phone we have this text
hi I am F the sahen so let me just copy
in the text for the sahin I'll put the
email shortly as well or let me just
I'll put in the email right now too let
me just go in here we'll figure out how
to add the icon first so the idea with
any kind of web design is do the easy
Parts first and figure out the hard
Parts later so okay now we've added the
phone we've added the email I hope you
can see here uh I'll just zoom in for a
second again and then I've added that hi
I'm FY sah I've added that part as well
then let's add in this content as well
which is the freelance frontend web
developer and word WordPress developer
so this is an H1 so I'm just going to
add this in as an H1
directly okay all right so now we got
the H1 here in in here as well and then
let us get this sub this subtitle so
which is is going to be I believe it is
of the class big text so let me just
give it the class big
text and paste the
content okay and now we have the class
big text so now now we have the content
starting to shape up so we have the
email and phone and we have hi I'm F
sahen which is just body text normal
body text we have freelance frontend
developer we have this and we have this
button here so let's let's add in this
this button here as well and so we have
this button and this button button is
called contact me let's put that in a
div okay so there's a contact me button
Perfect all
right now there is this image this hero
image over here let's come and get this
let's grab this hero image as well so we
have already downloaded this image if I
show you here we have this hero image
that has been downloaded already so I
can go in and I can just import or use
this image using the IMG tag so IMG SRC
equals um hero image.png and let me just
for now let me just give it a height so
that it's not too big but we'll adjust
the size later so let me give it a
height of 240 and we'll adjust specific
exil Styles later so heroen
image.png yeah there it is so now we
have the image here as well okay perfect
so now we are getting to a point where
for the first section we have all the
content now the next step is to maybe
start aligning things a little bit right
and of course you can go back and forth
with this you can add a little bit of
content do a little bit of alignment
then add a little bit of content do a
little bit of alignment uh but just to
keep things simple for now I'm adding
the entire section content and then I'm
I'm going to style it um okay so we
first of the first thing we want to do
is we want to show these two diffs
horizontally and we want to maybe make
them both take up 50% of the screen area
right so to make things horizontal and
you can always look this up you can
always say how to show two divs
horizontally but let me just give this a
class or let me give this div an ID
called hero
section and into the hero section I'm
going I'm going to go into styles.css
so for the hero
section I am going to say display Flex
so this is a quick trick that I want to
tell you anytime you want to show the
the children of a div horizontally just
set display Flex okay and just as I do
that nothing seems to happen because
inside it we have these two divs and we
want both of those inner divs to be
taking up 50% of the space right so let
me just give them some IDs as well so uh
let me say Let me give this an ID hero
text and let me give this in
ID hero image wrapper because it's this
is not exactly the image tag itself this
is a wrapper around the image so hero
text let's give that a width of 50% so
it takes up 50% of the parents width and
then we have the hero image
wrapper let's give that a width of 50%
as well okay and let's see what
happens okay okay nothing seems to have
happened which is strange so these are
the issues you run into when you are
doing things
live at this point I the way I'll debug
this is I will just right click here I
will check inspect and let's Zoom this
out a little
bit and I am going to
then yeah I'm going to then maybe just
check whether the div actually was added
properly or not so we have the hero
section div and we the Styles don't seem
to have been
applied why was the style not
applied hero section oh yeah so the
styles were not applied because I'm I
have to select by ID so let me just make
that hash instead of dot okay and let's
reload the
page and now you can see on already
that both of these seem to be taking up
so this is the hero text section and
this is the hero image section both of
these seem to be taking up about 50% of
the space now of course this image
itself is not taking up the entire space
so I might want to come into the image
here
and maybe let's just put the image let's
get rid of this div and let's just put
the let's just give the image an
ID and let's just call it hero image
and this is one question that you'll ask
yourself a lot when should I be using a
div when should I not be using a div the
answer is whatever does the job but you
can start start with something and then
modify it as you need so let's just give
the hero image a width of
50% okay so now the hero image has a
width of 50% that's fine but that is not
fully doing the job for us so I think
I'll just revert to the old style and
then I'll just apply some styles to the
outer hero image image so let me go in
here let me remove the oh that's because
I had the height so let me add the ID
hero image
here so I keep my hero image wrapper at
at width
50% and now I'll go into my hero image
and I will give it width 100% so it's
going to take up 100% of the parents
width okay so now the her hero image
should be taking up about 100% of the
parents width which it seems to be
doing however you can see that this
parent itself this entire thing is kind
of spreading across the page which we
may not want we may want to just put a
maximum width to this entire uh to this
entire section and I think the maximum
width that we are putting here is about
1440 pixels so let me just set the
entire maximum width for the hero
section to 1440 PX and let me set
the margin to zero Auto so that things
always remain centered on the page okay
all right so now it's looking a little
better so now we
have now we have this page and on this
page we have the on the right we have
this hero image on the left we have this
content and we can verify that both of
them are taking up 50% of the space so
here we have the hero section the hero
section within the hero section the hero
text seems to be taking about about 50%
then Z image wrapper seems to be about
50% of the
width yep great so now we are getting
very close to completing our hero
section Styles I can see that there's a
small padding or the small spacing here
at the top somewhere so I can probably
that's probably spacing on the body so I
may need to reset the margin to zero and
the padding to zero on the body to get
rid of that top spacing okay that top
spacing is now gone perfect great now
let's fix this side
uh let's fix the left side of things the
right side seems to be fine so let me
just bring this back here into half
size and let's start actually adding
content into this particular section
over here so I can see here that
we seem to this seems to be about 33
pixels below the top so there seems to
be like a padding of 32 pixels I'm just
going to guess about 32 pixels so I'm
going to come into the hero text
uh I'm going to come into hero text I'm
going to add a padding of 32 pixels on
the top 0 pixels for on the right 32
pixels on the bottom and 0 pixels on the
left okay and let's do that so now we've
added some padding so things are looking
a little bit better so that's
great yeah so now we've added a pad now
we've added padding that's good what
next well let's start fixing things one
by one maybe we need some left and right
padding as well let's see what left and
right padding we can add so here seems
to be there seems to be about a 20 pixel
space between uh the text here and the
image here I would probably take a
similar 20 pixel padding on the left as
well so I'm just going to make this 20
PX so these are places where often you
may not be able to get exact details
from figma and you may either have to
guess or you may simply have to uh ask
the
designer okay great so so now we have
about now we have padding so now things
are looking a little nicer then uh let's
start fixing one by one things starting
from the top now let's separate out so
here we have the phone number on the
left and the email on the right so let's
separate those out one very simple way
to do this when you have one thing on
the left and one thing on the right is
to just use a float so you could say
div style
equals float right
and again this doesn't always work
depending on the complexity of the
situation but if you want to do a very
simple thing where you want one thing on
the left one thing on the right that's
what you can do just use float so that's
fine now we have added that information
as well and let's check the font size
here so the font size seems to be small
and the font seems to be Roboto again a
fourth
font this seems like too many fonts on
the page so I'm just going to use the
font enter for
now instead of Roboto because I don't
want to import another font and I may
need to check with the designer why they
have so many fonts U because three two
to three fonts on a page is generally
sufficient but let us come in here let
us give this and let us give this a
class or let's give this an ID because
there's only going to be one of
these or let us just give it a class
called small text and we'll use it
elsewhere as
well small text okay and now we will
just pick dot small text and let us set
the font family to enter I'm not going
to use Roboto here and Sans serif font
okay line height Etc all that is fine
and I may need to check the color as
well maybe there might be some change
required in the color but now it is
smaller so it's definitely what we are
going for slightly smaller then what we
have okay the color seems to be just
black so 0 0 0 so I'm just going to set
the color
to it copies as background but it should
actually be color
okay so yeah so now the color is fixed
and this is all good then we have this
next section and there seems to be about
a 52 pixels of Gap normally these gaps
should be multiples of four and like
four
16 um 32 48 but 52 seems to be what
they're using here so I'll just use 52
as per the design so let me go in here
and this is
like let me give this the or let me give
this a small um Let me give this an ID
and let's give it the
ID name or like high and name so always
coming up with good names always hard
but always try to give a descriptive
name so that when you're just browsing
through the CSS file you know exactly
what you are referring to so highend
name right highend name has a margin
top of 52 PX so let me add that so now
you should see here that there's a
margin top of 52 PX all right so this is
good um then let's also maybe check over
here what's going on so there seems to
be too much Gap here the Gap here is
only 10 pixels we may need somehow this
Gap seems to be higher than 10 pixels so
I'm just going to check here okay looks
like this is the
default this is the default padding or
the default margin for for H1 and right
now the margin the default margin for H1
seems to be set to about 32 but the
default margin that we want is 10 pixels
so I'm just going to set this to margin
top
10px and let me reload that by the way
I'm using the inspect element browser
tools this is something that you'll
often have to do okay no sorry that's
not for H1 that's for and that's not for
HTML that's for H1 margin top 10 PX
perfect great this is looking find to
high am fahin freelance front end
developer and WordPress
developer what next LM IIM okay this
again the Gap here seems to be 30 it's
currently 32 let's change the margin
bottom as
well to 30
PX to match the design exactly okay
looks fine I think we have probably
fixed the margin
here and we can always verify by going
into inspect element so we go into
inspect element check the computed
settings you can check that okay margin
bottom seems to be 32 still oh I've not
saved it yeah so now it's a little
closer it's a little better so this is
what you do you look at the design then
you come into your HTML file and add
some CSS properties then you go and
inspect to make sure that things are
exactly as you want them to be all right
so that's fine what next well we have
this contact Buton Buton let's try and
fix the color and the font etc for this
button okay so the background color
seems to be 2f 2 f2f so that's what I'm
going to use for the background and then
the width and height also seem to be
provided here so width is 44 let's just
copy them all and let me come back here
and let's go into the
button here and let's give this a let's
give this button a
ID let's call it contact button button
let's come in here back
into and let's paste in all the
properties so we are adding a height we
are adding a width we adding a left I
don't think we need this left and top
generally speaking because we are
already arranging things in the right
order so we won't need that so that's
why be wary of copying things directly
from figma sometimes you might got get
weird results um but width and height is
something that I can use and I can add a
background so let me grab the background
uh color as well so let's see background
color 2f 2f 2f seems to be the color
that we
using and looks like the text color also
needs to be changed so the text color in
this case or the text size is 16 pixels
the line height is 19 let me just grab
that and put that in
here font family enter font size is font
weight is 500 line height is 19 font
size is 16 pixels
okay and there's a text color as well
the text color just seems to be white FF
FF FF so color is just going to
be
can all right and there is some space
above this so this about there's about
20 pixels of space above it so I'm just
going to say margin
top 20 pixel
all
right okay so our hero section is
looking good now I'm not going to get
into responsive design in this
particular tutorial because now you may
ask okay what how does it look like on
mobile Etc but at the very least if I
compare it to what I have here I think
this is looking fairly similar hi I'm
fery saheen freelance frontend web
developer WordPress web developer um a a
subtitle and then a contact me button
and clicking on the button may probably
open an email or something like that so
let's actually just make the button
functional instead of the button I'm
just going to use an a tag and I'm going
to put in a mail to link so that
clicking on it will open up a mail and
mail to fahin mail.com so let me just
grab
that and let me put that in here and
let's just
say Target equals uncore
blank okay so that's going to open up
email thing and I think we don't need
this div at this point so whenever you
feel that a div is not necessary you can
always just go ahead and delete that
div let's come back and let us change
that to slash a and let us just format
the document and save
it okay that's not doing it well I think
a tags you might also need to
set display block for a tags in case you
want want to add margin and
padding okay that's still not doing it
I'm just going to I'm just going to keep
it to a button for now let's forget that
right so you have to sometimes make
these decisions what should be which
kind of a tag in in most likelihood you
you will probably be just using a
framework that will take care of these
things for you but for now I think let's
just keep this button which is not
exactly
functional so with that we are more or
less done with the hero section uh you
you might notice that in the hero
section
our content here our image actually goes
all the way to the right but the text
does not go all the way to the left so
we may need to fix that so that is what
I mean by saying do the easy Parts first
what you might want to do is implement
the entire page and then figure out
exactly how you're are going to
implement this Behavior because you also
have to think about what happens when
you resize the page and all uh in in
this case for now I'm just going to keep
things equal width for now and I'm going
to come back come back and maybe fix it
later when I have the time okay or I'm
going to go back to the designer and say
hey this design looks a little odd
because over here it kind of goes all
the way till the end over here it
doesn't how about we keep it centered on
the page right how about we make sure
that all the content is centered on the
page so that we don't run into these
issues okay so that is the hero section
there's also this thing here the in the
background I'm yeah I'm not sure how
exactly we can Implement something like
this let's let see in the background we
have this ellipse of some
kind
um okay we'll have to figure out how to
add this glow and it may not even be
that easily possible and we'll have to
figure out how to add this image and
again that is something that we can
possibly look at towards the end or
something okay cool well I I think we'll
do one more section because we can of
course as we keep doing this it's going
to take a lot lot of time so how about
we do one more section let's do the
pricing section and I'll leave the other
sections to you as an exercise so let me
come back here and let me get rid of let
me get rid of these other sections so I
have this what I do section that is left
as an exercise I'm getting rid of that
by the way you can comment out an entire
section like
this so just start with exclamation mark
hyen hyphen and close with hyphen hyen
exclamation mark and then that you can
comment out an entire section so let me
do that and let me do that with projects
as well let me just comment that out for
now I'm going to implement the pricing
section let me comment out the questions
and the footer as
well okay and let's go ahead and now
let's start implementing the pricing
section so this is the pricing section
and in this pricing section we have like
the small thing here this blue thing
called pricing and we have a like a
subtitle or a or a heading H2 then we
have this
subtitle and then we have a bunch of
these
boxes so let's see let's again go step
by step let us first take this and
create a box around
it okay and let's come back here into
our oops a drawing
tool and let's draw some boxes so in
this case there is obviously this big
box right
here that's where that's what everything
is under in this big box I can see that
the direction of elements is downwards
coming down so there's definitely this
one div here at the top which is the
pricing and then there is this other
thing here and then there is this other
thing here
so there are three things pricing you
can take a look at the pricing table
based on the work I do and then you that
subtitle and then there is this box that
I can draw so always try to draw full
boxes in that direction all right so in
the downward Direction in the outer div
we have one 2 3 four boxes so let's try
and achieve this for now and then we'll
go inside this inner box later okay so I
am going to come back
now and let's start adding some of this
content so in the pricing section I just
think I I need this the direction is
vertical so I don't need to do display
Flex or anything like that let me just
add a div here and let's just type it
type out the word pricing let's add
another div here actually this seems to
be an H2 so we can just use an H2 here
probably so
H2 H2 and let's grab this content which
is you can take a look at what I do Etc
so let us just just copy and let us
paste this
content okay it things are starting to
take shape we will come back and fix
things a little further then we have
this Laur mipim dollar cell okay this
seems to
be
the description like a subtitle I think
this seems to be the big text it's about
let's see it's 18 pixels so this seems
to be the big text the same kind of big
text that we have here so I'm going to
create a div I'm going to give it a
class of big text and I am going to
paste in this content
here okay all right so now we have
pricing we have this big we have this
header we have this big text and finally
we have this actual pricing boxes so for
now I'm just going to create a div and
I'm going to say pricing
boxes all
right so that's everything that we need
to going to put in into the pricing
section for now now let's start fixing
the style one by one the first thing is
that you can see that the pricing
section is also centered it's a it's
centered on the page
and yeah so I'm just going to give it a
maximum width as well so I'm just going
to go into the pricing section I'm going
to
say ID
equals pricing section
and what is the idea of the pricing uh
what happens in the pricing section so
it seems like it is 190 pixels out from
this
side and it is about 190 pixels out from
this side as well so 190 190 the total
width is 1440 so out of 1440 pixels it
is you we are subtracting 190 1440 minus
190 - 190 that is 1060 pixels so the
width of this or the max width of the
pricing section is
1060 Max width is 1060 PX and I'm also
going to set margin to zero and auto
margin Z Auto basically says top and
bottom margin is zero and left and right
margin is auto which means that you want
to compress things into the
center and let's come in here and let's
just reload the page and you can now see
that it is centered on the page so it's
slightly better than what we had earlier
okay
then uh we have this thing here called
pricing over here it's a very small
thing it's in blue
color and then we have the same thing
later called questions so let me just
call this over title because it's
showing up over the title so let's just
call this over title and let us grab its
Styles so I'm going to create a class
called over
title and let me paste the Styles here
so left and top are not required we
don't need a water radius so height is
49 pixels width is uh no we don't need a
height and width either I think we just
need the text Styles so let's get the
text the typography Styles so we are
using popins and 12 pixels and line
height of 18 pixels and we don't need
these lettest Styles so you have to be
careful about which CSS Styles you're
bring in from figma you use it as a
reference but don't use it as the ground
truth
essentially okay and then let's add that
over title to this pricing section so
div class equals over
title okay and it seems like it's all
uppercase so let me just make it pricing
actually we can do it
in I think it's called text decoration
so let me see CSS
uppercase you can use a text transform
property so I'm going to use the text
transform
uppercase okay and I'm going to put in
the right color as well which seems to
be 2858 FF so color is 2858 FF okay so
now we have the right price now we have
the right color I think we need to add
a text align Center as well so that this
is centered on the page okay great so
now this is centered on the page
two perfect and finally
I think this is it but finally one other
thing we we have to note here is that
there seems to be a significant amount
of gap between sections so I'll have to
estimate this I I don't see any direct
way of yeah there it is well 98 pixels
is seems to be the gap between the
pricing section and
the yeah 98 pixels seems to be the
vertical Gap so maybe what we can do is
within the pricing section itself we can
add
that let's say each section can have a
40 pixels and a 40 pixels up up and down
uh Gap and we we can fix the exact
things later so in the pricing section I
am just going to
say well it's 98 right so let me let me
make it 48 pixels so let's see pricing
section I'm going to say margin top and
bottom to be 48
pixels right and I'm also going to add a
margin bottom for the hero
section um zero Auto 48 pixels Auto so
that between two sections we have this
98 pixels of Gap all right so this is
looking fine now we need to fix this H2
so we have this H2 seems like there is a
maximum width so it's we are setting a
Max width of 700 pixels for this so
let's set a Max width for 700 pixels for
this hed2 let us also set maybe um text
line Center so in this in this specific
case I am going to
say I'm going to give it a hiding I'm
going to give it give it a
ID or give it a class called section
heading and I'm going to come in because
there may be other H2S which may not be
section
headings and or do section
heading and I'm going to say text align
Center I'm going to say Max
width let's see 700 pixels so max
width 700 PX I'm going to say margin
zero Auto so that
margin so that it becomes centered on
the page so whenever you want to Center
something within its parent horizontally
speaking just give it margin zero Auto
and sometimes the zero may be different
because you may want a upper and lower
margin to be different and I think the
margin is not exactly zero but it's 8
pixels so for the over title let me add
a margin
bottom of 8
pixels okay so let's do that and now now
you can see suddenly that we now have
this pricing section you can say you can
take a look at the pricing table based
on the work I do so this is good now we
have the uh section as well let's let's
finally fix this too so this seems to be
the pricing or the section subtitle
essentially so let's add a class called
section
subtitle section
subtitle and let us again give it text
align Center let us give it margin Z
Auto let us give it uh what is the max
width here Max width seems to be 686
about 700 let's give it Max width of 700
PX and finally and there seems to be
definitely a 8 pixel Gap so it's not
exactly zero Auto it's 8 pixels above
and for now let me give Zer pixels let's
check the bottom distance as well so
let's see 48 pixels below right so 8
pixels above 48 pixels
below and then Auto all right so with
that and textaline Center as well oh we
need to add the section
subtitle so we can add a second class
here
section subtitle so this is how you add
multiple classes you can add not just
one class but you can add multiple
classes to a div so we have big text and
we have section subtitle so big text is
going to ensure that it gets this font
size and it gets this color and section
subtitle is going to ensure that it is
centered on the page as we might expect
right so now now you can see now we have
this pricing section and in this pricing
section we have the title in this
pricing section we have this and we have
this content as well okay great so
things are looking good let's finally go
ahead and maybe try to also add the
pricing boxes I think if we can add one
box we should be able to add all the
boxes so let's come back here and let's
We There are three pricing boxes so
let's create three divs so let's call it
pricing box one
and div Box 2 and div box 3 okay and now
into this div I let me give this a ID
pricing
boxes okay I have given it I've given it
ID pricing boxes so I'm going to come
back into my Styles file and for the
pricing boxes div I'm going to
say display flx
okay we want to flex uh we want the the
children of this div to be horizontal so
display flex and let me give all of
these a class pricing box so that I can
set each of their widths to
33% let's
see class equals pricing
box and let's add that to all of them
you can also use Advanced flexbox
properties to do this but for now I'm
just going to use something very
simple and I'm going to set for width of
33% for a pricing
box okay
and
yeah so now you can see that we have at
the very bottom we have box one box two
and box three okay I forgot to add the
class here it added it in the wrong
place yeah so now we have box one box
two box three at the bottom of the page
I'm just going to add a small div with a
large height uh at the end just so that
we can bring up some of these pricing
boxes so I'm just going to give
it style
equals height 600 PX this is just to add
a another div at the bottom so that I
can scroll this up a little bit while
developing okay so now we want to create
these boxes so what we want to do in
these
boxes let's see one by one what we are
going to do in these boxes by the way
you can see here pricing boxes we may
also need to add a little bit of a
padding so so that it's not sticking to
the corner but we'll figure it out okay
so coming back here to the design what
we've already done is we figured out
that we need a vertical or we need a
horizontal layout here that's why we use
display flex and then we have these
three boxes each box seems to
have
equal yeah each box seems to have equal
width we've done that with 33% WID now
in a particular box the layout seems to
be vertical okay so we have a bunch of
these and in a vertical layout if I
start drawing boxes we have 1 2 3
four and five boxes okay so one is this
PSD to HTML which is the service one is
the price then one is the description
one is the um uh these are let's say
benefits
and a contact button right so let's do
that and let's add let's start adding
all of these so in the pricing box one
I'm just going to do one box and let's
see if we can maybe just copy paste and
use similar Styles wherever possible so
I'm going to create a div and I'm going
to give it the
class
service and what is the service here so
the service here is PSD to HTML so let's
just say
PSD or PST to HTML so that is the
service that is offered in the first
pricing box then I'm going to have
another div here I'm going to give it
the
class
price so the price for the first service
is
$999.99 per page we'll fix the styling
later then let's add the description so
let's say class service description so
it's good to be a little specific with
class names because description is a
very generic um very generic class name
that may apply to a lot of things so
let's copy that content let's put that
in content in here service
description then let's go in and let
let's call these uh service benefits so
this is a list so I'm just going to
create a single div for
this let's give the class service
benefits okay and let's just put service
benefits
here and finally there is this service
contact button right so let's put in a
button
here and let's just say service
contact all right so now we have some
content here and of course this is not
looking exactly how we want but now for
the first box we have some content in
place now let's start actually laying
out the box so this box by itself seems
to be seems to have a white background
so let's do that
let's um let's and the different boxes
have different backgrounds so maybe
background is not something that we want
to
set or let's set it let's okay let's set
on pricing box itself let's set the
background and if required later we can
change it so pricing box should have the
[Music]
background or background color
white I've added the background color of
white for pricing box so so now you can
see that each pricing box has the
background color
white oh the third one is not given the
right
yeah so these pricing boxes have the
background white but they seem to be
touching we don't want them to touch we
actually want a 20 pixel gap between
them or maybe a 10 pixel Gap around the
box so here's a quick trick that I'm
going to use I'm going to create a new
div called pricing card
so div class equals pricing
card and I'm going to put everything
inside this card okay so I'm going to
keep the outer div just to determine the
widths of each widths of each of the
boxes and I'm going to actually use a
pricing card which is going to have the
margin which is going to have the Shadow
and all of that okay so instead of
adding the background color on pricing
box let me add it on pricing
card and background color is okay FF and
let me add a margin
of 0 pixels at top and bottom we don't
need that but left and right let's get a
10 PX margin okay so now the benefit
that you get is that inside the pricing
box which determines simply the width
30% 30% 33% or let's actually just do
that
33.33% just to be very accurate and then
we have this card this card is going to
be inside the box it is going to have
some margin around it it is also going
to be have its rounded borders all so
the radius okay the Border radius seems
to be about 10 pixels so let's add a
border radius border radius 10
PX okay now a border radius has been
added then uh it seems to also have a
shadow so there seems to be this drop
shadow I think we can just copy this
drop shadow setting and paste it in here
oh so it seems to have a box Shadow so
now you can see here that it has gotten
its shadow as well so that's good now we
have a shadow then inside it seems to
have about 20 pixels of padding inside
it you can see that all the content is
padded by about 20 pixels so let's add a
padding all
around of 20
pixels yep so now we have a nice padding
as well and what you can do just for now
is uh I can just copy over the same
content into the other boxes as well and
we'll edit the content later but the
benefit of that will be we'll be to see
that how we as we modify one particular
class that's going to apply to all of
the different boxes at
once
okay yeah so now we have okay now we
have these pricing boxes and these
pricing boxes seem to be looking at
least on the outside as we expect them
and now we can start modifying the
service the service the class for the
service is let's see so this is of
probably the same class no it's a
slightly different class but seems like
it has a let's see it has this font
Poppins so price service is the class so
for the class service I'm going to add
the font color or the font
settings font family popins okay font
size 14 line height is 21 get rid of
these two let's add maybe the color as
well let's add the text transform
uppercase and let's add the color I
think it's the same color as the pricing
uh section over title which is
this so let's add the color
here okay so now the services are
looking good PSD to HTML sketch to HTML
figma to HTML okay well I'm just going
to edit those as well so I'm just going
to
say for box two I'm going to say sketch
HTML and here I'm going to say figma to
HTML yeah so PSD to HTML sketch to HTML
figma to HTML 99 per page let's get the
styles of 99 so the style here is
Poppins and line height is 54 size is 36
weight 700 so this is the price so let's
add the styles for Price do
price okay all of this looks good font
size line height all of this looks
fine and the color seems to be just
black so I'm going to say
color 00 0 okay the color is fine too
then okay this slash per page so this
information I think this is something
that we can put under a span probably so
I'm just going to put a span around
this span and I'm just going to give the
span
uh a class of price
per okay so let me just copy that and
paste it in the other ones as
well price oops let's copy this whole
span or price per page let's give it a
class of price per page and let's copy
the entire span and let us put that Span
in each
one
okay price per page in fact we should
probably
also we should probably also have uh
yeah the pricing seems to be same okay
so price for page and then we have the
span so into this span price per page
let's give the right
colors price per
page and let's give it the color popins
font weight 14 okay all of this this
looks
fine and let's just add
that let's reload the page
okay price per page is the span oh it's
price per page I think I made a mistake
here in in
typing yep and we need to change its
color as well the color seems to be 8 a
8 a 8 a so let me just change the color
here as
well okay great so now now we have uh
the price figured out so price per page
is done as well then we have this
subtitle or this description essentially
so for this description again the font
style seems to be popins 14 pixels and
23 pixels the same I think it's exactly
the same thing that we have here so
service description is exactly the same
as the price per page so
service
description
yep 8 a is the color no the color seems
to be slightly different 8 B 8B normally
again you don't use so many different
colors you have a fixed set of colors
but this particular design seems to have
it so let's just keep it that way let's
make sure that there is enough Gap so
there's a gap of8 pixels above in this
case there may not that Gap may not have
existed so let's add margin top
8px and we've added a little bit of a
gap as well as expected and there seems
to be a gap between these two two so let
us add that Gap to uh what is that Gap
let's see 8 pixels between these two so
between the price and so let's add a
margin top for price of 8
pixels yeah so that looks a little nicer
that's again a little more spaced out
and then we have these benefits all
right now let me fix the benefits as a
service benefit so this is going to be a
list so I'm just going to create a list
here in the first
box Li and in this Li I'm oh sorry I'm
going to use UL to create an unordered
list and let's see how many benefits
there are and let's add those lapsim 1 2
3 4 5 6 so the benefit in each case the
value seems to be the same and so let's
just create six copies of
this all
right y now of course I I don't think we
need this div specifically I think we
can just do this on the UL itself so
let's get rid of this outer div let's
shift this
back and first of all I think we don't
need
this margin here so it's automatically
getting indented I think we don't need
this indentation so let's see how we can
get rid of this indentation where is it
so it is so there seems to be this
padding which we can get get rid of so
service
benefits
benefits so I'm just simply inspecting
it I am then going into this I'm
selecting that particular div and I'm
just inspecting its Styles and it has a
certain padding so let's set the padding
to
zero okay so now it is moved left
definitely but let's also set the list
style to
unstyled or
unset
or
okay UL how to remove bullet
points list style type none okay so list
style type
none okay then we have this check mark
here that we need to somehow figure out
how to
add I am going to deal with this later
for now I'm just going to maybe use an
emoji so let's just search check mark
Emoji yeah and I'm just going to copy
this Emoji of over here the check mark
button and I'm going to deal with this
icons and stuff these are things that
can always be added later so I'm just
going to go in for now as a quick trick
and I'm just going to add this Emoji
over
here excuse
me okay so it's looking close let's add
the color let's add the actual
settings which
is yeah in the the color seems to be
let's see let me select some text so the
width it seems to be again popins but a
bigger size and a slightly different
color so I'm just going to copy that and
I'm going to put that under the font
settings so now font size is 16 font
weight is 400 line height is 24 pixels
and I'm going to copy the color which is
6666 so I'm going to say
color
6666 okay yeah and what is I think this
is looking exactly no this is not
looking exactly the same seems like
there is also an 8 pixel difference
between each one so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to say service
benefits
Li
margin
bottom
8px yeah and now it is a slightly more
spread
out
and yeah looks fine to me I think maybe
all these all these settings can
actually just be moved into the LI
itself
right okay so it's looking pretty close
weight font weight 400 line height 24
pixels and margin bottom of
8 and then finally there is
this contact me button so let's add that
contact me button so this is service
contact
button let's give it a
class
service service contact button all right
and it simply says contact me right I
think it just says contact me so let's
go in here let's say let's call this
contact
me and let's come back and let's start
styling this contact button okay let's
close this for
now so for the service contact button
first thing seems to be that there is a
the width is just full width so I'm just
going to set WI width
100% so that it takes up the entire
width then there seems to be a height or
actually we can just figure out maybe
what is the spacing that is there within
so there seems to be a 12 pixels padding
at the top and bottom so let me just put
padding 12px all around just to yeah
that looks roughly
similar does it
yeah
or we can just set a height that that
could be the other thing we can just set
the height for the entire thing let's
see the height is 44 pixels so let's set
a height so often you'll have multiple
ways of implementing this I'm just going
to set the height to 44 pixels yeah I
think it is about the same then there is
the Border radius so border radius is 4
PX okay great border radius has been set
I guess the Border width can be set
to
zero or maybe one one
pixel yeah let's see what is the Border
width here 2 pixels and 2 f 2 F 2f so
border
is
2px solid # 2f2 f2f that is a color then
there's a background color the
background color in this case simply
seems to be white so we can just say
background color FFF
FFF which is just white okay now we need
to actually add some text colors so the
text color seems to be 2f 2f 2f so let's
add that text
color okay then let us add the text size
or the text seems to be enter weight 500
16 line height 19. 36 let's add all of
that in
here so even though there are two two
different elements on figma on our when
we creating the button it's just this
one thing all right and that's it now of
course we may want some sort of a hover
State here so you may want to say
something like this where when we hover
over the service button some of the
things
reverse so when we hover over the
service button maybe the background
color could become 2f 2f
2f and the text
color could become
could
become white so that is f f f f
FF or text color is just color right and
maybe you also want to turn let's see I
think this should do it yeah maybe we
also want to turn this cursor into a
hand button so you can say cursor
pointer this is again a common thing
that you will often end up using it
turns into a hand button over here right
so now you see if I zoom in a little
bit so you see now we have this contact
me button and now we have these
preferences and now of course we can
copy that over to the other ones as well
so let me just copy the service benefits
and let me copy the contact me
button let's copy it over to the second
one let's copy it over to the third
one okay so now we have a pricing
section that is more or less what we
expect so this is what the pricing
section looks like here and this is what
the pricing section looks like here now
of course the second pricing section the
sketch pricing section seems to have a
yellow background and a few other things
so that is something again we may have
to figure out how to do and I'll show
you the quick way to do this what you do
is go into that second box in yeah so
this is the yeah let's just add it let's
add box two here box two pricing box box
two and and into box two you can
actually go in and add specific changes
so you can say do pricing
Box dobox 2 so when it has both of these
both of these classes in that case we
want the background to be yellow which
is just
this this color over here so I can
change the background
color to
that
okay that's probably not added to the
right thing I think it's pricing card
that we need to add to and let's let me
just call it card to instead of box two
so let's get rid of that and I should be
adding it on the second one so this is
the second pricing box and in the second
pricing box let me add card hyphen
2 and now you can see that it has
changed to yellow color let's quickly
modify these Styles as well so here it
is just sketch to HTML is just black so
I'm going to say say that
within I don't need this so I'm going to
say that within card 2 if I have a
service then the color should
be black let's reload that so the color
has become black then everything else
looks fine to me maybe this may need
some change the color here is also black
or but 75% black so we can kind of copy
that
So within card 2 if I am looking at a
list item or specifically if I have
service
benefits uh oh let's just do that within
card 2 if I have a list item then I want
it color to be that and I can just
change the color for that list item and
similarly I can change colors if
required so it's 50% here 50% black here
so I can just copy this color and I can
apply that to what is this
well I believe this is service
description and price per page so within
card
2 if I have a service
description then the color
is
that so you just add this additional
selector and within card
2 if I have this price per page its
color should also be
that right and now we have I believe we
have the expected colors you can see
here that I can check that card 2
service description is the selector for
it what else well we have this contact
me is black and white so it's the other
way around so within card
2 we have the only change is
that background color and normal color
are from the hover State and within card
and of course this is for the contact
button so service contact button and
let's flip the styles for the hover
state so when we hover over it we want
it to be the other way around so the
color is going to be
FFF and the other color here is going to
be 2f2
f2f okay service contact
button well that doesn't seem to have
applied we can just give it we can just
give that button a specific card or a
specific yeah we can just give that
button a specific uh class here so
service contact button for card 2 let's
see
card to button card to button so let's
just do that so we don't need this
multiple selectors we can just do card
to selector so depending on what you
want to achieve sometimes you may have
to come up with uh like specific classes
but generally speaking it's with a bit
of experiment experimentation you should
be able to figure it out oh oh wait I
think I understand what the mistake I
made I did not put the word hover
here yeah that should do
it card
2 yep that that does it so now we don't
need this card to button class so yeah
you'll often make these kind of silly
mistakes when you are working on CSS but
this is looking good so now we have this
fer saheen freelance web developer
pricing and all of this is fine let's
maybe add the footer as well um which
should be very quick to add so the
footer is just this black band which
contains which is of height 58 pixels or
which basically has some text and it has
like a 20 pixel padding internally so
let me just add the footer and I think
that'll just complete the page for now
so let's go here let's go here and let's
give this the ID
footer
and this fotter has some text the text
is simply for sahin copyright so let's
go in let's put in the text
here and let us just give it some
Styles
so let me come back into
index.html oh sorry into styles.css and
let me go into footer so the first thing
with the footer is that it occupies the
entire width of the page so so I'm just
going to give it width
100% then I am also going to text line
Center so I'm going to say text align
Center I'm going to add a padding of 20
pixels 20
PX so yeah now we have that we of course
have to add a black background to it so
00 0000 0 uh so let me add
a background
color 0
0 okay let us change the text color over
here um I think I'm going to get rid of
that additional div I had or maybe
reduced its height to just 100 pixels so
that it's a little closer and you can
see things more
easily now we can just get rid of it
completely yeah um let's add
maybe a margin top to it so that it's
not too close to the content so I think
the margin top of 48 pixels
should be
fine and let's change its color so the
color seems to be white so let's add a
color FF FF
FF the color of the page is footer is
white let's grab the properties the text
properties so the text properties just
seem to be the typography is just popins
so Poppins 12 PX 18 PX so let me just
put that in here as
well yep and that's it so now the footer
has been added and the pricing has been
added and we
have I believe we've achieved what we
wanted to set what we set out to achieve
at least in terms of the adding the two
sections the only thing that I'm a
little worried about is
that this Edge seems to be lining up
with this Edge over here right uh which
is not happening in our design our
design is a little more spread out and
so maybe what we might want to do is we
might want to restrict the width of this
section also to match with this section
let's see so this is
about uh what is the width of the
pricing section so we have
this pricing section and the pricing
section I believe has a maximum width
somewhere set
the pricing section has a maximum width
of 700 pixels no no it has a width of
1060 pixels so maybe let's set the same
maximum width for the hero section as
well let's set the maximum width to 1060
pixels so now everything is centered on
the page you have this pricing section
which is centered and then above it you
have this section which is also
centered like that now this is something
that you may want to discuss with with
the designer in the
design you see the image actually sticks
out a little bit but there are two
issues with this if the image sticks out
like this what happens is that one the
content is no longer centered on the
page properly and
second what happens when you have a
wider screen is the screen is the image
still supposed to stick to the side
probably not right because if you have a
really wide screen it's not that you're
going to like let's say the screen was
this white from this end to this end you
wouldn't want the image to just be so
big that it sticks out or be somewhere
in the corner um so what we have now
feels like a
reasonable feels like a reasonable
Middle Ground to me uh but of course
it's only the designer who can give the
final answer here in terms of how they
want the image to look right so this is
something that you may want to go back
and discuss with the designer one thing
that I will do for this image is I'll
probably give it a radius like this on
this side as well just to make it look a
little nicer so it has a radius of what
it has a radius of about 200 so let me
just go in here and let me add that
same radius for the image in my code as
well so I'm going to go to the hero
image and I'm going to
say border
bottom right or border bottom
radius
okay like that so that's what I'm going
with and or the other option is that I
when I export the image I don't export
it with the radius at all I just keep it
blank um but I think this looks largely
looks fine of course the content is
sticking out a little bit a little more
than I would have hoped so I may even
reduce the width of the image slightly
so instead of going 50/50 I may go let's
say 60/40 with content and
image okay so this is where you may like
when you come to the implementation
often things don't work out exactly as a
designer expects so some things may be
need may need to be changed might be
that we maybe we can reduce like a
little bit of the description so that we
have one less line in the
description let's
see
so this is the subtitle and in the
subtitle let me get rid of this entire
section like that let me reduce a little
bit of the top margin over here so
before the high I'm for sahin let me
yeah let me just change that to about 16
pixels let's
say or 20
pixels okay and that looks good I think
this is this page is looking fairly good
we have this phone we have this email
here both of this both of these pieces
of information we have this High
freelance front end developer and
WordPress developer a subtitle and a
contact me button then we have this a
little bit of a gap we have pricing you
can take a look at what the pricing
table at the pricing table based on the
work I do then we have again some
description then we have these three
pricing sections then we have these
contact buttons and then finally at the
bottom we have this for the saying
copyright 2022 All Rights Reserved so
that's fine too and maybe the only last
thing that we may need to do is add
these
icons over here this icon over here and
maybe also add these icons these check
mark icons that we have over here so
let's do that and I think then with that
we'll close for the day of course let's
see if we can also incorporate this but
I'm just going to add this icon for now
so I am going to export this so I can go
into export
and let me export this as a PNG file or
I can also export it as an SVG file SVG
is good when you have to resize things
so let me export export this as an SVG
and let me export this as phone. SVG or
phone then let me export this and again
I'm going to export this as an SVG and
Export
as email.svg
and finally I'm also going to export
this check mark over
here so I'm just going to go and Export
that again as
SVG
as check.svg
okay now we just need to incorporate or
bring in these svgs so let's see HTML
include an SVG
image how to use SVG images in CSS
well
looks like we can just do this we can
say IMG SRC and we should be fine and we
can give it a height and width so what
is the height here 16 by 16 right so I'm
just going to do that for I'm going to
come in into my text here and I'm going
to come in before telephone number so
I'm just going to first create a span so
that I have a span around the telephone
number and then I am going to create
this IMG SRC equals
phone.
SVG and let me just set width and height
directly here width equals 16 height
equals
16 and let's say alt equals phone we
should always put an ALT tag for an
image there you go it's almost there
more or less I think it we probably
don't need such a big thing maybe 10 by
10 might actually do it
yeah maybe 12 x 12 so that takes care of
that for
us yeah I think that's what it looked
like here as well roughly right let's
get let's add the email so let's again
get this IMG here and we'll just change
it
to mail.
SVG or email.svg
yeah that's roughly what it looks like
as
well you could say that okay maybe it
has like shifted down a little bit so we
could do something like this we could
just give it like a small margin to
adjust to adjust things a little bit so
what we could do here's a quick trick
anytime you want to Center an image next
to a page you can there are more complex
ways to do it but a very quick way to do
it I need to move the image down just a
little bit so you want to keep you want
to maintain the rest of the things as
they are but you just want to make move
the image down a little bit you can say
margin
bottom minus 4 PX okay what that does is
that does not actually add any
additional space it simply shifts the
image up or down okay so negative margin
is a very interesting thing that it does
not add additional space it simply
shifts the image left or right or up or
down as you say and similarly I'm also
going to add a margin bottom minus 4 PX
over
here so play with negative margins but
now you can see that things are all
nicely lined up and let's go in and add
all of this here as well so I'm just
going to copy this IMG and I'm going to
put it in the place of this tick mark
over here so I'm simply going to replace
well let's do this let's do a find
replace so I want to replace the tick
mark with this I
IMG tag over
here let's first replace one then we'll
see if that is what we want to do for
the rest as well right so let's put that
in here let's get rid of this margin
bottom I think we may not need it and
let us just put check.
SVG and let's reload the page okay I
think we may need a slight bottom margin
to adjust it so whenever you have icons
next to
text margin bottom is your friend so
margin bottom a negative margin bottom
in most cases minus
2px let's check that yeah that looks
fine so now let's grab that and let's
say that wherever we have this sck
symbol or the sck Emoji I'm just going
to replace them all with that okay and
I've replaced everything and now you can
see that my tick symbol is showing up as
expected
yep I could even just uh if I wanted to
make sure that these width height and
Etc and style margin if I don't want to
repeat this everywhere uh maybe another
thing that I can do is instead of just
repeating it like that I can just create
a class called do check
mark and for DOT check mark I can say
that I want margin
I want width to be 16
PX is that 16 yeah 16 I want height to
be 16
PX and I want the margin
bottom to be
minus
2px and now I don't actually need to do
this I can oh the alt tag is also wrong
I don't probably don't need alt tag here
I can just give it a
class class equals check
mark okay and I can replace this so I
can now go back into the find and
replace and what I want to replace is
this and what I want to replace it with
is this IMG SRC and class equals check
mark and let's replace them
all and we get exactly the same result
right with of course this time we using
class we not repeating a bunch of styles
so in case we need to change the height
of the check mark or something let's say
we want to change this to
20 we can do that very easily not that
we have to I think it looks
fine okay so I think this is a good
place for us to stop we have replicated
the hero section closely enough I
personally did not agree with the design
decision to extend the image outside of
the center because that creates problems
in centering in uh the content visually
and that also creates problems with
larger screens so instead what I went
with is I simply centered the
image I simply centered the image or the
entire content of the page here and I
have gone ahead and I have added this
heading and of course reduce the sizes a
little bit so that things probably fit
in vertically then we added the pricing
section you can take a look at the
pricing table and in the pricing table
we added all the specific sections so
I'm sure when you when you looked at it
the design may have seemed fairly
complex but as we just start approaching
it step by step as we break things down
identify okay what are the boxes looking
like and are the boxes arranged in a
vertical direction or a horizontal
Direction Things become a lot easier and
then you just have to go element by
element make sure it has the right
Styles and you can achieve any any
design um no matter how difficult it
looks and of course there are are cases
where you need like custom Shadows you
may need to overlap things on one
another like let's say we wanted to do
this how exactly would we do that well
let's grab it let's maybe export it
let's see what we can do with it let me
again export this as an SVG file and in
an SVG file let me just export it
to um line below or let me just call it
yellow
line right and let's see how exactly we
can fit this so
we want this to show up right below the
H2 right so let me just show that right
below the H1 so I'm going to I'm just
going to come in here and I am going to
say below the H1 I'm going to add this
image IMG
SRC
equals yellow line.svg
and I I am just going to give it the
ID yellow line okay so here's what that
looks like right now and again I can use
my margin trick so um hash yellow
line I can say margin top this time and
I can add a negative top margin minus 30
PX let's see what that does yep that's
getting us close minus 40
PX nope doesn't do it minus 50
PX okay maybe I can put this yellow line
inside the H1 tag because the H1 tag has
its own margin which I cannot get rid of
so let's come back here let's take that
yellow line and let me put that
inside yeah that is better that is
better but it's still not doing it I
think maybe minus
80px still doesn't seem to be doing it
well what if we put this in a
div so this is where you'll have to
experiment this is where it becomes like
a fairly tricky CSS kind of thing to do
and let's see if we can
get IMG SRC ID yellow line margin top is
minus 80 what if we said margin top to
minus 200 pixels still doesn't seem to
be doing
it okay well I
I think I'll I'll I'll just give up at
this point um but maybe what we might
need to do then is we might need to
adjust some of these gaps because now we
no longer need this margin below the H1
so I can go back into
H1 and I am going to remove the bottom
margin which is 30
pixels yep let's see now do we still
have a bottom margin here no oh we
[Music]
do and I'm just going to set margin
bottom to
zero yeah so that is close enough there
are other styling properties that can be
used to achieve exactly what we are
looking for you can use something called
position absolute I believe um yeah
position relative and absolute and then
you can set exact where it is from the
top um that might be able to do it let
me give it a quick
attempt position absolute uh or position
relative
here and here I'm going to give it
position
absolute okay that is doing it probably
I probably don't need this this and yeah
now I can say margin
top minus 10 PX probably like that and
if I want to if I want it to appear be
behind the text I need to uh put the
text as the next thing here and not the
first
thing well or we could use something
called Zed index so so again Z index
is minus 10 let's say something like
that so it shows up behind the text okay
this is good now we can probably add
back that H1 padding that we
had so let's see we had a margin
bottom
30px yeah so now this is almost exactly
okay it's a little higher the yellow
line instead of it
being Min - 10 PX maybe we can go minus
PX yeah and now it's almost exactly what
we're looking for we have WordPress
developer and we have uh WordPress
developer so what you can do is you can
have a position relative on the parent
position absolute on the child and then
you can move it around anywhere within
the parent okay so that's just something
that you can do in case you need to
achieve layouts like these but otherwise
this is looking good I think I'm going
to stop here there is a title section
there is an email section and we can of
course hyperlink this we can hyperlink
this all of those things are possible uh
this is looking good freelance front end
web developer and WordPress developer
and this is looking fine contact
me looks good uh
pricing the boxes with pricing and then
the layout the last thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to quickly show you how
to deploy this in case
you are going to share this with
somebody so here's what you can do just
zip it up go to compress figma to web
page just zip that up and we're not
going to use git or anything here I'm
just going to use this free platform
called static. apppp let me just sign
out here so that I can show
you yeah and here static. apppp allows
you to just take a zip file and you can
upload that and deploy it inexpensive
rabbit okay let me just add Sydney
plus 99 at jan.com
okay and let's yeah so this is a site
where you can upload a zip file and then
you can just you you'll have to verify
your email let me go ahead and do that
right
here doing it on another screen here
okay I'm going to activate my email done
and once my email is activated it has
taken the zip file and it has simply
uploaded it on the cloud and it has
given us this
URL it is it takes a minute or two to
set up but at this
point yeah it is still un packing the
archive looks
like yeah so at this point our website
is deployed and you can also then
connect static. apppp to your own
personal domain so I'm just going to
share this link with you so that you can
actually verify that this is this
website is actually deployed but this is
all there is you have a layout like this
which is given to you in figma the first
thing that you do is inspect the design
mockup you identify y okay what are the
different dimensions what are different
components and there's a guide here that
you can check out which uh an overview
of figma for developers and how
developers can use figma but the idea is
you just inspect the design you identify
what are the various sections you
identify the fonts used on the page you
identify you find them on Google fonts
you export any images or JPEG files that
are being used within your web page then
the next step step two is to set up the
basic page structure and styles so you
create a folder on your desktop and then
you open it up in vs code or if you're
using git or something fancy like that
then you can do that too create an
index.html file create a styles.css file
that's what we have here we have a
index.html we have a styles.css and copy
over all the images that you need so the
hero image was the only image and then
we had a bunch of these then you add the
basic style so you add basic HTML tags
head title link body uh we added all of
those uh first in our file then you add
the various sectionwise div so you
create a div for each section because
each section ultimately is going to be a
box on the page and you set up some
basic styles for the body you set up
basic styles for the header you set up
backgrounds font families text sizes
colors Etc then you go ahead and you
implement the web page section by
section and the key there is to First
identify in the Box whether the box is
in a hor whether things are arranged in
a horizontal direction or a vertical
Direction so you always want boxes and
the box has to be has to have something
in a vertical direction or something in
a horizontal Direction and then you then
create boxes within boxes right so
you're always looking to create a layout
like
this where you
have or a layout like
this where you have a box and then
within this box one possibility is that
you have boxes that are laid out
horizontally like that or the other
possibility is that you have a box and
within this box things are laid out
vertically and so on and of course again
within that horizontal box you can have
like a bunch of vertical boxes like
that right and then within each of those
vertical boxes you can again have a
bunch of horizontal boxes so if you
start thinking of your web design as
something like this as a bunch of boxes
inside boxes inside boxes with each box
having its children laid out in
horizontal or vertical order
then your web design becomes really
simple and you'll never run into a lot
of the CSS issues that often plague web
developers so in this case for the
pricing table we had a vertical layout
first so the box box box and then a big
box and then inside the big box at the
bottom we had a horizontal layout box
one box two box three equal width that's
where for horizontal layouts you use
display flex and then for each of these
inner pricing cards we also used a trick
where we added another inner div which
will have its own on radius and border
and all so that the outer Dives were
just for creating the wids and the inner
Dives were creating the cards and then
in the pricing card we have a horizontal
of a vertical layout okay so that's all
you need to know that's all you really
need to know in terms of taking a web
design and then converting it or taking
a web design mockup and converting it
into a web page of course there are
these special cases like this where you
have to figure out how you're going to
add that but the way you do it is by
using some negative margins here and
there maybe using a position relative
for the parent absolute for the child
and you can always just search position
relative
absolute
examples and there are a bunch of
tutorials on this like nobody knows
exactly how to do these things you have
to Lear you have to search for them and
position is generally one thing when you
have like one thing behind another that
you can deal with so similarly you can
maybe get this one one element this this
nice glow that you have here you can get
this element somehow you can try to get
this element this glowing thing uh and
you can export that ellipse as a PNG
file or an SVG file and let's see yeah
and then you can just incorporate that
within your code as well okay all of
that is doable so yeah so you add
content for each section one by one
using HTML by using that box structure
then you use figma's inspect tab so
remember here you select anything and
you can see exactly what what properties
it is using it's not that you'll be able
to copy these over directly you may have
to make some changes to it but you use
figma inspect tab to check values of CSS
properties add styles for each completed
section one by one using CSS and then
try to replicate the mockup as closely
and as precisely as possible and that's
where we get into these Minor Details
like over here we have this at character
which is vertically centered so maybe we
can achieve the same thing over here
like that and often there may be some
tradeoffs we will have have to make when
you actually go ahead and implement the
design for example we reduced some
spacing here we decided that we are
going to Center the image on the page
and add a border to it because uh
otherwise it just looks a little odd
that the image is not only sticking out
but it's also then there is some space
on the ride which is empty okay so that
is everything that we're going to cover
today so thank you for joining and there
are a bunch of first of all I would love
to know how did you find the session you
can drop a line in the chat and we'll
see but there are a bunch of comments or
questions as well let's
see how do we get the figma file we will
share we will add a link in the
description but let me also share that
link with you right now so this is the
figma file that you can
use then you should use the button tag
inside an a tag for mailia okay so that
was a nice tip that I can actually put
the button tag inside an a tag so that's
great I will definitely do that or we
can actually just fix that right now I
believe it's okay it's okay we are out
of time hover state is not added yeah so
we've added the hover State not for this
button yes we should add it for this
button also but we've added the hover
state for these
buttons would you recommend to use live
server so that you don't have to reload
the website yeah so you can use a vs
code extension like live server so there
is this vs code extension called live
server you can use it if you're using vs
code on the cloud like GitHub code
spaces or you can also use it locally
and the benefit is that anytime you make
a change to the file it automatically
reloads the page so you can use that too
I just wanted to keep things simple for
today and yellow line rotated 45° well
it's not rotated
here but
yeah okay perfect well I think we will
close at this point so thanks a lot for
joining I hope you enjoyed this tutorial
and if you want more tutorials like this
come join our WhatsApp Community we'll
uh drop a link in the
chat it's just jan.com
WhatsApp so you can join our WhatsApp
community and um you'll get to know
about more future events we have events
happening every week more or less you
can also just go on join.com events and
learn more about these events so yep I
hope that is helpful now and I'll see
you next time thank you and have a good
day or good night bye-bye so let's get
started understanding Version Control
git and GitHub is crucial for any
developer or any team working on a
software project so far we have been
building our websites just by setting up
folders on our computer opening them up
in vs code but to professionally build
websites you will need to track the code
in a version control system so these
tools allow you to track changes they
allow you to collaborate with others
because you're typically not going to be
the only one working on a web
application or website and they also
allow you to deploy your applications
easily and efficiently to the
cloud and by mastering these skills you
can streamline your development workflow
so today we are going to learn what
professional web developers use when
they're working on these
projects so in particular we are looking
at these topics we will talk about using
GitHub repositories to store and share
your project source code we will talk
about using GitHub code spaces which is
an online code execution and online
development platform in conjunction with
a browser based vs code for web
development we will talk talk about
developing and previewing changes to a
website using GitHub Cod spaces we will
talk about creating git commits and
pushing changes back to a GitHub
repository then we talk about deploying
a website to the cloud directly from
GitHub using the worell cloud platform
and we'll try to understand the GitHub
collaboration workflow which involves
branches and pull
requests and finally if we have the time
we will also touch on installing and
using git locally on your computer and
connecting it with GitHub now the best
way to learn these skills is to follow
along step by step and type out all the
code yourself git can often be confusing
at first so I want to start with that
disclaimer because there are so many
different terms that you will hear get
pull merge commit Etc but it starts to
feel natural with a lot of practice and
you will see us repeating the same flows
over and over for the rest of this
course and the rest of the program so by
the end you will become proficient in
git whether you like it or not now of
course this tutorial assumes some prior
knowledge of HTML and CSS so if you
haven't completed the previous
lessons so if you haven't completed the
previous lessons please go ahead and
complete them first so we will explore
these Topics by attempting to work on a
specific problem statement we want to
improve the development workflow for the
Jovian careers website so in our
previous tutorials we've built this
careers website which has a navigation
bar which has this Banner which has some
information about Jovian an image which
has a table showing the job
opportunities at Jovian and it has a
form where anybody who is interested in
applying for a job at Jovian can submit
their application and finally it has a
footer at the bottom as well and we
built this by setting up a folder on our
computer locally and then uploading a
zip file to static. apppp and that is
how we have this deployed version so
what we want to do is set up a GitHub
repository to host the source code and
facilitate collaborative development we
also want to deploy the website directly
from GitHub to the cloud using the worel
cloud platform and we also want to add
some appropriate meta tags which we'll
talk about today to sure that when you
share this website with somebody let's
say on a social platform or as a link on
a messaging platform then the page
previews properly so all of that is
something that we'll try and cover today
so here is where you can find the code
for this tutorial we are going to start
with the starter code which contains all
the code for this website that you're
already looking at which we have
developed so far till in the previous
tutorials so let me open up the starter
code this is going to be a zip file I'm
just going to save it here on my
desktop and once it's downloaded I can
then you can see here it's downloaded on
my computer I can then just decompress
it so now I have this folder so in this
folder I have the index.html file I have
a couple of other styles file I have a
couple of images and this index.html
file contains the actual application
page the Jian careers page okay but of
course we are not going to do this
development locally we are going to do
this development now using GitHub now
I'm sure if you have if you are pursuing
web development if you have done any
programming you must have heard for
heard about GitHub and you must have
also heard the terms git and Version
Control so first I just want to
demystify these terms before we start
using
them now git is a popular version
control system which enables developers
to track changes to their code base and
collaborate with others
and GitHub is a web- based platform that
provides hosting for git repositories
and tools for collaboration okay so
let's break down each of these terms one
by one what do we mean by Version
Control Version Control is any system
that tracks changes made to a file or a
set of files or a project so it enables
developers to keep track of different
versions instead of you having to create
multiple copies saying V1 V2 Etc you can
just put put everything into a Version
Control System systematically it also
enables developers to collaborate with
others so that you can have one common
version and two people can build off it
then you can bring those changes back
and sometimes when required it also
allows developers to revert to previous
versions of their code if needed and it
enables developers to work on different
versions of their code simultaneously so
as a developer sometimes you work on
multiple features at a time and again
you need a version control system for
doing that
so there are many Version Control
Systems there's one called SN that was
very popular early early on in the '90s
there is of course git which we'll talk
about today and there is something
called Mercurial so version control
system is any system that allows
developers to track various versions
track changes of files or projects now
you can learn about the various Version
Control Systems and the differences
between them I linked to a site but we
are going to focus on a specific kind of
Version Control system called git now
the key Concepts behind git are that you
have typically a remote server so
typically this remote server could be
something that you have set up your
company has set up or it could be an
online platform like GitHub so you have
a remote server where the ground where
the master version or where the main
version of your code is
stored and this code is called a
repository so your code is stored in
something called a repository along with
all its previous versions
and then whenever you as a developer
want to work on this code you first have
to pull it onto some computer so it
could be a local computer it could be
another Cloud computer and then you make
some changes on your computer and then
you send the changes back to this remote
server and you're not just the only
developer on this there can be other
developers who can be doing the same
thing okay so git is this particular
kind of Version Control System where you
have often this Central server which
stores the repository of code and then
you take a copy of the code make some
changes and push your changes back to
the central server and that is how
people collaborate okay so that is how
git works and here are few Concepts in
git that we will try and cover today so
the first thing in git is that it it
uses something called a branching system
that allows developers to work on
different versions of their code
simultaneously without affecting the
main code base okay
the second thing is that developers can
make changes to their local copy and
then they can push those changes to a
central
repository next suppose two developers
are making changes to the same file or
the same set of files then git also
allows developers to merge their changes
the changes made by different team
members and resolve any conflicts in
case both team members are making
changes to the same file finally git
also has the ability to track changes
made to individual lines of code so when
you're trying to merge some of your
changes back to the cloud repository you
can check what individual lines of code
have changed and you can also roll back
to previous previous versions of the
code okay so it is one of the more
sophisticated and one of the most widely
used Version Control Systems and don't
worry if these Concepts don't make sense
right now we are going to cover all of
this in much more detail over the course
of today's
tutorial okay next what is GitHub so we
talked about Version Control any system
that can be used for tracking changes
across files and folders git is a
particular kind of Version Control
System where there's a central
repository and then you can take copies
make changes and push them back using
branches then we have something called
GitHub now remember in git there is this
Central repository that can be a
repository that you have set up your
company has set up or you can use one of
existing Central repositories and GitHub
is the world's largest Cent repository
for git based projects okay so GitHub is
a web based platform that provides
hosting for git repositories and it
provides a range of collaboration tools
on top of that hosting for developers
other similar platforms are gitlab and
bitbucket so you can use any of these
all of them have free plans but GitHub
is the most popular one it had it has
tens of millions of people using it so
you should probably start with
GitHub now on top of git GitHub offers
several additional features
the first thing it gives you is a web
based interface for managing get
repositories making it easy to view and
manage code it also offers a wide range
of collaboration tools on top of git uh
things like pull requests code reviews
and Team Management features again we'll
touch on these and finally GitHub also
provides hosting for open- Source
projects so most software that you use
on the Internet is built using open-
Source projects and these open source
projects are typically hosted on GitHub
so GitHub is a great place for you to
discover open source projects and even
contribute to open source projects and
it has a vast community of developers
where you can interact with others and
you can interact with developers of Open
Source projects and make your own
contributions finally GitHub also
provides Integrations with other tools
specifically around deployment project
management Etc to make it a complete
software development workflow okay so
GitHub is a hosting is a hosting
platform for git and it offers a lot of
additional features on top of git okay
so I hope that clarifies the difference
between Git Version Control and GitHub
they are like layers Version Control is
a basic kind of a system git is a
specific kind of version control system
and GitHub is a hosting platform for git
repositories with some additional
features so let's start by first
creating a repository for our project so
projects on GitHub are known as
repositories so we'll go ahead and
create a repository so the first thing
you might need to do is go to github.com
and sign up if you're not signed up
already in my case I have already signed
up so I'm simply going to sign in so I'm
just going to click sign in and that is
going to sign me in to
GitHub all right so once you sign in
this is what your dashboard looks like
and on your dashboard the first thing
you want to do at least when you've
created your account for the first time
is to click the new button to create a
new repository or a new project so let's
create a new repository uh we are going
to call it Jovian careers site live
because I'm doing this live and let's
add a description for this repository so
a
website to show job applications at
Jovian or job openings at
Jovian and accept
applications next you can choose whether
to make this Repository public which is
open source for the rest of the world to
see and build upon or you can make it
private now you can make it public and
people can see the code but they cannot
make changes to your repository you
still control who can make changes but
if you make it private only you will be
able to see it and if you add
collaborators only they will be able to
see it and you can also choose which of
those collaborators can actually make
changes to the repository so for now I'm
just going to make it public so that you
can actually see The Code by the end of
this lesson yourself
next you have a few initialization steps
so if you are creating a repository on
GitHub and you plan to develop from this
repository then you should initialize it
with the readme file and some of these
other things on the other hand if you
already have a repository on your
computer you just want to upload it to
GitHub then you can skip these
initialization steps okay in my case I'm
just going to select this initialization
step add a readme file what that's going
to do is just create a file called
readme.md wherein I can put in some
documentation about my uh project so I'm
going to keep that and then there is
something called a git ignore file that
gets added so often when you are
creating a git repository there are
certain temporary files that can get
created as you're executing your code
and you may not want to put those
temporary files or compiled files into
your git repository so that's where a
git ignore file comes in don't worry
about this we'll touch on this later
but for now because we are going to
create a JavaScript and HTML and CSS
project so the top the G ignore template
that you can select is node so node
simply stands for nodejs which is a tool
used to run JavaScript and HTML and CSS
based projects locally on people's
computers so you can just select the git
ignore template node and if it doesn't
make sense don't worry it's not
important right now and finally you can
also select a license so when you put up
any code on the internet specifically on
GitHub you can inform people what you
what they are allowed to do with the
code are they allowed to build on top of
the code are they allowed to use the
code for academic purposes are they
allowed to use the code for commercial
purposes you can specify all of that and
one of the most common licenses is the
MIT license which basically allows the
user of your code to do anything they
want to do with the code whatsoever
without any warranty
okay so that is just a common template
so what you'll often do when you create
a new GitHub project is you will add a
readme file you will select a get ignore
template for JavaScript or HTML CSS
projects the this is typically node but
let's say if you were doing a python or
a data science project you could select
Python and so on and you will also
select a license in many cases MIT
license should suffice and you can learn
more about all of these the readme file
the G ignore and the license by checking
out these links okay now finally as I
said git has a concept of branches so
the first thing you have to do is when a
g GitHub repository gets created it has
a default
branch and the default branch is often
called the main branch okay the main
branch is where the main version of your
code lives but you can then create
multiple branches as you're working on
specific features and then you can um
bring those code from those branches
back into the main branch now for now uh
we will go ahead with main as the
default Branch but know that sometimes
in some older repositories the the
default Branch name was called Master
M but the new convention is to call the
uh default Branch main so that's what
we'll go ahead with
Okay so let's hit create repository and
now our GitHub repository is
created perfect so you can see now you
have this fairly complicated looking
interface you have a nav bar here then
you have a bunch of buttons then you
have a bunch of tabs then you have again
some options Etc so I know it looks
complicated but we will touch on almost
all of these tabs over the course of the
next several lessons and over the course
of the program but for now what I want
you to pay attention to is this area so
here is your username you will see your
username here and next to your username
you will see the name of the
project so the name of the project is
Jovian career site life typically these
are are all lowercase and typically
these are all separated by
hyphens and then in the code tab you're
going to see that in the main branch
which is the only Branch we have right
now we have three files so our
repository has been initialized you can
see that there's an initial commit we'll
talk about comets as well one minute ago
with three files one is a readme file
one is a license file one is a get
ignore file and you can open up this
license file and you can see what it
contains similarly you can open up this
G ignore file and you can see see what
it contains and you can open up this
readme.md file and you can see what it
contains so again this is all created
using markdown which is a fancy way of
writing
text so there are three files in our
repository and at the moment our GitHub
project or repository has been created
so we can already go ahead and share
this with other people let's say we want
to share our code with other people we
can take this link and share it with
them but of course we don't have any
code here right now so the next thing
we're going to do is actually import our
code into this
repository now there are two things we
can do we can actually start writing a
writing some code or we can start
importing some existing code that we
already have in both cases we need to
open up this git repository in a code
editor now you can download this git
repository to your computer and then
open it up in VSS code or any other code
editor or you can also use some online
platforms for developing on this GitHub
repository specifically GitHub provides
something called GitHub Cod spaces which
you can think of as your own personal
computer attached to this GitHub project
or repository but living on the cloud
all right so GitHub Cod spaces is a
cloud-based development environment that
allows you to write test and debug your
code directly in the browser so it
allows you to quickly set up a
development environment without needing
to install any software locally
it provides a consistent development
environment across different machines
because you're writing all your code in
the browser and the browser is connected
to some machine on the cloud where all
of the dependencies are already
installed it also makes it very easy to
collaborate on code with other
developers because you can have real
time shared code spaces so if you're
writing code within a code space you can
create a sharable link invite somebody
else to come and collaborate with you
live and it lets you work from anywhere
so you don't have to work from a
particular computer you can just open up
your GitHub repository and launch a
GitHub code space online and start
typing code into it okay so you can
think of it as a personal computer on
the cloud that you can access from
anywhere and you can check out github's
documentation for setting up Cod spaces
but starting a Cod Space is really
simple what you do is you go to your
repository folder and or you go to your
repository on GitHub and you click this
code button here and you have two
options you have local and you have code
spaces and here you can click create Cod
space on Main so what this is going to
do is this is going to set up a a
computer for you on the cloud and it is
going to associate that computer with
this GitHub repository so you can see
here if I zoom in a little bit it has
set up this cloud-based computer for me
and it has opened up visual studio code
on that computer and it has given me a
browser user based interface to connect
with Visual Studio code on that computer
so there's a lot going on here so
instead of opening Visual Studio code on
our own computer we have opened up
visual studio code on a GitHub codes
space which is a computer running
somewhere on the cloud all right so this
is what it looks like remember we on our
GitHub repository we had these three
files G ignore license and readme.md so
if you come here now you can see that we
have the same GitHub repository now open
for editing in this code space
accessible via these via this browser
based Visual Studio code interface okay
so within the browser we have Visual
Studio code and I can open get ignore
and I can make some changes here I can
open this license file and I can make
some changes here and similarly I can
open this readme file and I can make
some changes here okay but what we want
is to actually put in the code that we
already have from our previous tutorial
which is the index.html styles.css and a
couple of other files so here's what
we'll
do as you work on more complex projects
it is going to it's it'll be a good idea
for you to separate some of these
configuration related files like G
ignore license Etc with your actual
source code so what I'm going to do is
create a folder here so I'm going to
right click and select new folder and
I'm going to create a new folder called
SRC so now I have created a new folder
called SRC and into this folder now I
can add an index.html file so I can say
index do HTML and now I can maybe put in
some HTML code
here and maybe I can start writing
things and so on but I already have a
bunch of these files so I can just
upload these files so let me delete this
file once let me just delete this file
index.html and let me upload these files
from my computer onto this remote
machine so I'm going to say upload I
right clicked on SRC and I'm clicking
upload and now I'm going to open up the
folder my second web page and now I'm
going to select the files that I want to
upload so I want index.html I want
styles.css I want team.jpg and
banner.jpg and I'm going to click
open all right so now all the files from
my computer have been taken and uploaded
into this Cloud code space this Cloud
machine which I'm accessing using vs
code from the browser okay now I can now
we can actually go ahead and delete this
folder entirely I don't need it but all
of this code is still going to be here
for me okay so remember we had this
Jovian career side that we built the
last time and this was built using this
index.html file so let
us yeah so let us look at this
index.html file it obviously it has a
head section where it has a title and it
has a bunch of fonts that are included
then it has a body section which
contains a nav bar it which contains a
banner and it contains this heading so
we have a nav bar Banner heading then we
have this about description section
where we have some information about
Jovian and we have uh links to the two
programs and then we have this team
image over here and then we have a list
of job opportunities which is a table so
that is the job opportunities table that
you can see here and finally below this
we have a form so form contains a bunch
of form inputs and then there is a
footer below the form which is what you
see here as well so there is a form and
then there is a footer below the form
right at the bottom now of course these
HTML elements are styled using CSS so
we've set a base font size on the HTML
and then we've set some body fonts and
we've set some header fonts as well
we've also set specific sizes for the
headers we have set specific colors for
headers and for body we've also set a
bunch of other colors and then we've set
a bunch of other CSS styles to make our
page look as we want it to look and we
have set some styles for the table we
have set some styles for the form and we
have set some styles for the footer and
for the button okay so that is what our
code looks like right now so for now I'm
going to close this deployed website and
now let's try and figure out how can we
actually preview this okay so now we
have some code already on this code
space but this code is no longer on our
computer this is on the remote machine
so there's no place where I can double
click and open it in a browser and
preview it so there is an extension or a
plug-in that we can install into vs code
for previewing these files all right so
this is one of the nice things about vs
code that depending on which language or
which kind of project You're Building
you can install some plugins to ease
your development so I'm going to go
click on extensions and then here I am
going to search for
live server okay so just search for live
server l i s v r it is created by this
person called rck day and you'll know
because it has 32 million downloads so
that is how many people actually use vs
code and also use this extension and I'm
going to click install in codespace and
that is going to install this plug-in
into my codespace now once this plug-in
is installed into the codespace I can
close this extension Tab and by the way
the extension menu is here on the left
so in the sidebar it is this uh fourth
or fifth option yeah it's the fifth
option in the sidebar so that's how you
come to extensions and now now that I've
installed this extension I can come back
here onto my file explorer and now I can
see here that on my index.html file if
you see at the bottom here I have this
go live button right at the bottom here
so this is a new button that has been
added by the live server or I can also
just right click on index. HTML and I
can say open with live server both of
these are going to do the same thing so
I'm just going to click the go live
button what that does now is it is going
to Now set
up our code space to expose this file to
the browser at a separate URL like this
okay so now I can let me put this on the
left and let me put this yeah on the
left and right and let's close these let
us also close the sidebar now you can
see that here I have my codespace
running on the cloud so my vs code
running in the browser and I have a live
preview of my code running here here
open while using the live server in on
the right okay now here is one nice
thing about the live server let's say I
want to go back and I want to change
here I want to change about Jovan to
welcome to Jovan and I just hit save
that goes ahead and that automatically
refreshes the page so the live server
makes it slightly nicer to develop and I
can also go and do this with the
styles.css file I can say let's say
change the default font size from 16
pixels to 18 pixels and I can save it
and you can see that now the Styles file
has been updated and now we have let's
make it 20 pixels maybe and now you can
see that the things are a lot bigger
okay so this is one of the nice things
about the live
server all right so oops I think I
pasted something yeah so this is one of
the nice things about the live server
you can go in you can make some changes
here so you can say maybe I want to get
rid of the word highly and I just save
and that change changes this
automatically okay so that is how you
view the code that you are building that
you're writing on especially when you're
building a simple HTML and CSS page
later on when we look at web Frameworks
and uh things like react Etc then we'll
touch on other ways to look at previews
but on GitHub code spaces this is how
you look at a preview of your code okay
so just to quickly recap to start a code
space you go to the GitHub repository
you click on the code button and you
select open with code spaces you can
create a Cod space on your main branch
if required and if you ever need to you
get two free Cod spaces so if you ever
need to delete previous Cod spaces just
go to github.com
SLC codespaces
and over here you can go into your
specific code spaces repository wise and
you can go ahead and delete them in case
you have a new repository that you want
to develop using a codespace okay and
then you can select a codespace
configuration typically the basic
configuration should be good enough then
the Cod space gets created it takes 10
15 seconds and then you can just open up
visual studio code in the browser or you
can actually also connect your local
Visual Studio code to the Cod space
we're not going to go into that today
but uh browser based development is good
enough for most
projects and then you can continue
working on your code Spaces Project all
right now in terms of how you do actual
development well what you do is you can
uh one thing that we recommend is that
now anytime you're putting your actual
web code uh you should create an SRC
folder so to separate it out from the
readme get ignore Etc just to keep
things clean and now you can add files
like index.html styles.css within the
SRC folder and you can add code within
them and you can also upload existing
files or images by simply right clicking
so you can open up the sidebar right
click anywhere click upload file and
upload a bunch of
files and if you want to pre view HTML
files within code spaces you just use
the live server extension and this
extension allows you to see your web
pages as you develop them and for that
you just go into the extension section
here in the sidebar and you search for
live server install it and then you go
back and just click go live and you can
also shut it down there's a button right
at the bottom to shut things down as
well and once you do that you'll be able
to see a live preview and you can make
changes for example if I change welcome
to Jovian back to about Jovian that is
going to quickly change over here as
well now this is all well and good I'm
making all these changes but if I go
back to this
repository you will see here that it
still does not contain the code that I
have actually added so I've added a
bunch of files but they don't seem to be
here in the GitHub repository well
remember this remember this setup so we
created our repository on GitHub and
then we pushed that code or we pulled
that code into a code space which is
essentially a remote computer on the
cloud and now we made some changes into
our codp space machine using vs code now
we need to push these changes back to
GitHub to actually save them back to the
remote repository so that's what we're
going to look at next okay so how do we
do that well it's a three-step process
and we're going to first stage our
changes next we are going to commit our
changes and finally we are going to push
our changes and this is where some of
the GitHub terminology will start
kicking in you might wonder why do we
have three-step process why can't I just
hit save well this is just how git was
designed to handle a bunch of different
use cases and that is uh what we are
struck with unfortunately but uh once
you do it enough you start to get used
to it and I'll show you some easy ways
of doing this without having to type or
remember a lot of things okay so here is
how works the first thing we need to do
is we need to open up a terminal so git
added score is a command line tool so
you need to actually type out some
commands on a terminal or a command line
so we need to open up a terminal to run
some of these commands of course we have
our code space somewhere on the cloud
here so we will need we can't open up a
terminal on our computer we need to open
up a terminal on this remote machine
which is in the Cod space fortunately vs
code provides an INB built terminal so
you can just click on these options here
and you can say View and you can select
terminal so view terminal and now that
is going to open up this terminal window
okay and what is a terminal a terminal
is simply a place where you can issue
commands you can write commands and
those commands will get EX executed on
the computer so before we had graphical
user interfaces uh operating systems
were just terminal based text based
platforms where you could issue commands
and even today most Developers used
these command line or these terminal
commands to run a lot of their code and
to interact with Git for example okay
all right so now we've opened up this
terminal so it has
this you can see that this terminal it
has a bunch of information already it
tells you who is the current user so the
current user is Sydney Jovian that is
the name of our GitHub user it has the
current directory or the current folder
on the codes space where we are
currently at and it also tells us the
branch that we are currently at so so
it's an informative prompt and now here
we can start typing our terminal
commands so the First Command that we
need to do or we need to type is called
git ad okay so the first thing we need
to do is or actually even before we do
git ad we can just type git status to
see what status our repository in is in
are there any new changes that we have
made since we have checked out the
repository from GitHub so if I type git
status you can see here that it says
that you are on the Bron Main and then
there are a few untracked files and
there are a few untracked files and they
are the files in this folder called SRC
so the entire untracked the entire SRC
folder is untracked by untracked we we
mean that git has no idea about these
files it has never seen these files
before so the first thing we need to do
is we need to Stage these files so we
take the files from our working
directory and we stage them which means
we tell get that okay these are some
files that I'm interested in potentially
putting to putting back on GitHub so I'm
going to Stage them by saying first of
all I'll just reset it U so anytime you
want to reset the terminal just type
reset and I'm going to just stage this
by typing git add
SRC and SRC SL what are all the files
that I want to Stage I want to Stage
index.html banner.jpg
styles. uh CSS and team.jpg well I'm
just going to type get add SRC and that
is going to add all the files present
within the Sr C folder into the staging
area okay so now if I type get status
again this time you're going to say that
it's not saying that there are any
untracked files so there are no more
untracked files there are some files
which are ready to be committed okay so
now in my staging area which is nothing
is yet put into the git repository yet
we now have a four new files okay great
so now that we have staged these files
so from working directory we've staged
these files the next step is to actually
record a new version of this entire
repository by performing a commit so
here is what we do after adding a g dot
a git add so I've reset things again now
I type git
commit and then I say minus M and then I
provide a message
so adding the
HTML and CSS files now I have to provide
this message within quotations so you
can see here get commit if I have if I
need to zoom in a little bit likely this
is fine get commit minus M and then I
provide a message and the message is
within code so now I'm creating I'm
recording a new version of my code by
creating a commit and I'm giving it the
message adding HTML and CSS files and I
press enter okay and now it says that
okay now it has actually inserted four
files into my repository so now you can
see that now we have the create mode uh
now we have created a file called Sr c
banner.jpg Index Styles and team.jpg
where are these files created they were
already present on our codespace well
they have been now created and saved
within our repository formally saved
okay and now if I reset once again and I
say git log now git log is used to view
a history of all the commits and now you
can see that there are two commits or
two times that I've recorded a version a
commit is simply a version of the code
so there was this initial Comm that was
done at such and such time by such and
such author the initial commit was done
and then I have done a second commit and
in the second comment I have added this
HTML and CSS files so that is also
something you can see okay you can in
fact do get log minus minus stat and
that is going to tell you what is the
change in each comit so here you can see
that in the initial commit we added a GE
ignore license and readme.md file so I'm
just using the arrow key to go up and
down and in the new commit adding the
HTML and CSS files I have SRC Banner
index Styles and these are the number of
lines in each of these okay now often
when you run some git commands you will
have to do this scrolling using your
cursor up and down cursor so here's a
quick trick to exit this just type Q to
exit this okay anytime you're stuck in
some git command output just press q and
you should be able to
exit all right so let me reset that
again and let us check G
status so now it says we are okay we are
on the branch Main and there is nothing
to commit our working tree is clean
which means we have no untracked files
we have no tracked files with with
changes to be committed so that's fine
so we have taken our working directory
changes we have first staged them and
then after staging we have committed
these
files let's see if these have shown up
on GitHub
yet no these do not seem to have shown
up on on GitHub yet we still have a g
ignore we still have a license and a
readme.md so once again coming back to
this what we are doing here is so far
we're still just recording new versions
of our code on this code space machine
we need to push these changes back to
GitHub that is where the git push
command comes into picture and you can
see here there is actually a hint here
saying that your branch so our main
branch the main branch on our code space
is one commit ahead of origin main
origin typically refers to the remote
server the whatever repository remote
server from where you've actually pulled
this code so we are ahead of our origin
or we are ahead of the remote server by
one commit so we need to push our
commits so here's how we push it let me
reset that again let's just type git
push and then we provide origin so we
want to push to origin which is sort of
the remote server and we want to push
the main branch so get push origin Main
and I press enter and now you can see
that we are packaging up all of these
new com new changes that have been
recorded in the new commit and we are
pushing this to the Cloud Server okay so
now what happens is we have made some
commits here we've pushed them back to
GitHub and now the next time we run a c
Cod space or somebody else runs a Cod
space on the same repository a
collaborator maybe they are going to
pull the latest changes all right so
that is how you actually push your
changes back to GitHub so once again I
reload the page and now you can see now
finally we have this SRC folder over
here and in this SRC folder we have this
index.html file so that's great that's
exactly what we expect and we have the
styles. CSS file and so on okay so that
is one way in which you push your
changes back to
GitHub sorry about that so that is one
way in which you push your changes back
to GitHub so just to recap you open up
the inbuilt command line terminal using
the browser based vs code window then
you review the changes that you've made
using git status and git diff commands
I'll talk about git diff in a second
then you can stage the changes that you
have made by typing git ad a specific
file name or you can just type git add
Dot and that is going to add all the
files that have been modified or added
then you can commit your changes the the
changes that you staged by typing get
commit minus M followed by a commit
message inside quotations commit
messages are very important because they
give you a short description of the
change you're making and finally you can
verify that the change was made using
git log and you can push your changes to
GitHub by simply typing git push origin
main or in the case of the main branch
you can just type get push so this is
typically the workflow you have you add
some files you commit them and then you
push them and if there are new changes
that are made on GitHub you pull them
back onto your computer okay so if I run
git pull origin Master for example you
will see that or sorry git pull origin
main so if I run git pull origin main
for example you will see that I'm
already all up to date now what is
origin origin simply refers to that
remote server from where you have pulled
the repository originally so it is the
origin of your code it is the original
place from where you've pulled your code
okay and again this is a where G gets
confusing of origin remote this and that
but um that's what origin
means okay now one other thing I want to
tell you is let's say we make a change
here so we say about instead of about
Jovian let me change this back to
welcome to
Jovian so the live server should also
reload to show Welcome to Jovian and now
just to quickly recap the flow I can
check G status and you can see here that
now we have modified the for now we have
modified the file SRC index.html okay
now it is telling me that something has
been modified now whenever a file is
modified you can actually see what
changes have been made by typing G div
when you type G div GitHub is going to
show you in red it is going to show you
which files have been removed which
lines have been removed and in green it
is show going to show you which lines
have been added and everything else in
black is simply the U code around that
line so it is telling us that in
index.html we have removed one line and
we have added one line okay and that is
how GitHub tracks or git tracks changes
it tracks deletions from a file and it
tracks additions from a file okay and
once again we can now do get add dot we
can then commit we can then push but
there's another way to do it directly
within vs code so you can click on this
third button here called Source control
in the sidebar and what this tells you
is this shows you under this changes
section it shows you all the untracked
or modified files so it seems like there
is this index.html file that seems to
have been modified and there's also this
settings. Json file well maybe I don't
need this file so I'll just delete this
file for now let me just come back here
and let me just delete this entire
folder maybe it got added somehow I
don't need it right now but anyway
coming back here so now I have this
index.html file and in this index to
HTML file if I click on it from
the git sidebar I will be able to see
the changes that have been made so you
can see that in
index.html it is showing me a comparison
between the original version which
contains about Jovian to the new version
which contains welcome to Jovian so we
have removed about and we have added the
welcome to or you could also think of it
as we've removed this entire line and
added this entire line okay if we made
some more changes for example in
index.html let's say let's also remove
let's also add the word most highly
reputed and let us come back here and
let us check you can now see that apart
from this one change we also have the
second change over here so you don't
actually need to run the git div command
you can simply come in into the into the
git sidebar and you can check the
changes let's maybe go back and also
make a change into styles. CSS let me
change the body font color instead of
444 let me change it to
444 a slight change
and once again I can go here
into the G git sidebar and I can see
that there is a change made in styles.
CSS and there is a change made in
index.html now I can go ahead and Stage
these changes one by one so I can review
the changes in each of the files by
looking at the diff or the differences
and then I can stage these I can click
plus here and I can click plus here so
remember the flow we first have to add
the files to Stage them so I can click
plus and Styles has been staged or I can
unstage it like that but let me just
stage this and let me stage this or I
can also stage them both together by
using this single plus button now you
can see that we have a couple of stage
changes and no other changes no unstaged
changes so internally vs code is simply
running these git commands for us so
that we don't have to run them but you
should be still familiar with Git
commands in case you don't have the
sidebar or you're able you're not using
vs code okay so now that the changes are
stayed we can type a message here so
let's say
updated index and
styles and now we can click commit okay
now the changes have been committed so
we've added the files and now we've
committed the files but now we still
have to send these back to GitHub so now
we can click sync changes and now it
says this will pull and push commits
from into origin Main and I'm just going
to say okay and now my changes are going
to be sent up completely okay so that is
the other way to send updates to GitHub
make some changes come here then stage
those changes and then commit those
changes with a message and finally press
the sync button and that is going to
push the changes up to GitHub all right
so two ways to do it I generally prefer
doing it from the terminal just so that
I can keep getting some practice so I
prefer doing it from here from the
terminal but feel free to use the user
interface as well both are equally good
enough both do exactly the same thing
okay so as an exercise I encourage you
to look up the documentation or look up
some tutorials to understand these git
commands git status which tells you what
untracked files you have or what are the
files with some changes git diff which
shows you what are the exact changes in
each of the files git ad which can be
used to Stage your files so go on go
from the working directory to the
staging area and you can add individual
files or you can add all files or you
can add a folder at once then git commit
which is used to actually record a new
version then git log which is to see the
history of comits that you have and
finally get push to push these changes
to the remote server or origin server
and you also have get pull in which
which is used to pull the changes from
the origin server in case somebody else
has pushed some new changes okay now all
of these commands also support some
options so you can check out some what
their options online and you can also
use GI help but the thing with G is you
have to practice you have to try these
out a few times you have to get stuck a
few times and only then you start to
feel comfortable but we've already
covered six G terms and there are a lot
more that are going to come but at this
point I want to switch gear and talk a
little bit about Cloud deployment so now
we have our Jovian career site live you
can see here that we can see um we can
see it's history that three commits have
been made so far on GitHub we can see
that there's an SRC folder and that was
recently updated with the index and
styles that we committed directly from
vs code and there are some other files
from the initial commit how do we take
this and how do we easily deploy it to
the cloud we're going to do that using
this platform called worel verel is a
cloud platform that makes it really easy
to deploy websites and applications and
it offers a seamless integration with
GitHub and other Version Control Systems
allowing developers to deploy their
projects almost seem almost instantly
without any additional coding or any
additional work so here is what we are
going to do we are going to sign up on
wor.com so let me just sign up in case
you're not signed up already you'll need
to sign up I am already signed up and
signed in so I'm good to go then uh you
will be taken to the verel dashboard as
soon as you sign up let me zoom in here
and you can add a new project so I'm
going to select new project and when I
select new project it is going to ask me
access for my
GitHub repositories so once one when
you're signing up try to sign up with
GitHub so that you can give permission
to sign up using GitHub directly but
second when you actually try to create a
project versal is going to need access
to your GitHub repository so that it can
it can pull out the code and it can then
deploy them to the cloud not just public
repositories but also private
repositories so you can either give
access to all repositories or you can
give access only to select repositories
and you can select which repositories
you want to give access to in my case
I'm going to give access to all
repositories and it is going to have
access to read and write because it is
also going to write some things into
your pull request which we'll talk about
later but in general yeah you need to
give versel full access to your code so
that it can pick it up even private code
and deploy to the
cloud okay now let's click install so
that is going to install the worel
GitHub application essentially and now
at this point you will see this new
project box and in this new project box
you can select which GitHub account to
use in case you've connected multiple
GitHub accounts and from that GitHub
account you can select which site you
want to actually deploy so I am so my
repository is called Jovian career site
live so I'm just going to click import
Jovian career site live and now I have
to configure the project because versel
has configurations for all kinds of
various different projects so you can
see here that it has a bunch of
different um pre-configured Frameworks
and first you can set a project name I'm
just going to keep the project name on
worell the same as the project name on
GitHub no change here so join career
site live the framework preset I'm going
to select other because I'm not actually
using a framework I'm just using simple
HTML and CSS
files then I need to select the root
directory which needs to be deployed so
remember we created this SRC directory
we don't want to deploy our GE ignore
file and license and readme.md that's
not something we want want to put on the
website itself that's something that we
want to just put on GitHub um so let's
select the SRC folder or the SRC
directory as a root directory so I'm
going to click edit here and I'm going
to just select the SRC directory as the
root directory and click continue so we
are telling verel that we have a simple
website no framework and we are simply
going to pick the code from the SRC
directory and just directly deploy it to
the cloud and there are other settings
which we don't need right now so I'm
just going to click
deploy now as soon as we click deploy
versel has pulled out all the code from
our GitHub repository it has set up a
machine on the cloud conceptually
speaking and it has deployed the code
and you can see here that this is what
the deployed site looks like okay you
can actually click continue to dashboard
and here you can see that we have a
preview of what the deployed site looks
like and we also have links to a couple
of deployments so by default your
project name doval doapp is the location
of the deployed website and let me just
zoom in
here so you can see now we have deployed
our website so now we are developing on
GitHub codes spaces and we are pushing
our changes back to GitHub and then we
are we have connected our GitHub
repository to verel and verel is picking
up the GitHub repository the main branch
and it is deploying it automatically
right you can see here that it is
deployed
automatically so that is how easy it is
to deploy and the next thing you can do
is anytime you make a change let me come
back here in index.html and let me just
change this to about
chovan and I'm just going to make a
quick commit here so I'm going to Stage
the change I am going to
commit and sometimes when I uh when I
try to commit without a message It'll
ask me to put in a commit message
so let me just say change to about
Jovian and let me close that so now it
is committed now I'm going to push again
and okay let's push it now the changes
are going to get
pushed now the changes are pushed here
to Jovian career site life you can see
that we just changed to avoid Jovian and
once you push what happens is you can
see that a new deployment is going to be
made by versal automatically
so you can actually see a history of
deployments you can see just 3 seconds
ago a new deployment was made and this
new deployment was made on the commit
change to about about Jovan so on verel
welcome to Jan changes to about J so
anytime you make any changes to your
GitHub repository and push the main
branch or you make changes on code
spaces push the main branch to GitHub
versal automatically picks up the new
change from the main branch and
automatically redeploys it isn't that
nice that all you have to do is just go
on coding here and keep checking your
live preview whenever you're ready you
can just go in and you can just add all
your changes commit them and push them
and once they are pushed versel will
pick them up and deploy them and that is
a deployment workflow that you are going
to work with more or less right so you
go to wor.com sign up for an account
once you sign up you create a new
project and you choose the repository
that you want to deploy it supports
GitHub gitlab and bit bucket and you you
will have to connect and give access to
verel then you choose the project root
folder in this case it is the SRC folder
and then you click deploy and then it
creates a deployment so it builds your
project deploys to the cloud and
whenever you push new changes to your
repository especially the main branch
versal will automatically build and
deploy your project so that creates a
very nice
workflow now one of the goals in the
problem statement was to add some meta
tags and improve the previews of this
web page so now we have this Jovian
careers site live dovala but one thing
you'll see here is if I zoom in a little
bit here you you see you see it says my
first web page at the top here and it
also doesn't have a icon so it'll be
nice to maybe get a jovian icon in here
as well another thing that you can check
is if you try to share this on LinkedIn
or Twitter or
elsewhere it's not going to show a nice
preview okay normally when normally we
expect to see a nice preview of our
yeah normally we expect to see a nice
preview of any website that we share on
the internet so but that is not showing
up so normally what happens is when when
a website is found by Google or when a
website is shared on let's say LinkedIn
or Twitter or
Facebook they automatically pick up this
preview image there's something that can
be configured and they automatically
pick up maybe a title and a description
all of this so where does this come from
well all of this is done using some
special tags special HTML tags called
meta tags HTML metatags provide
information about a web page to search
engines and browsers and they are placed
in the head section of a HTML document
and they're not displayed on the page
itself so you can actually use a
platform like hea.com you have these
tools like hea.com to actually check
what the preview for a particular web
page is going to look like so let's say
if I just copy this my first web page
link and put it
here and I check what the preview is
going to look like so you can see here
that there is no preview image and the
title of the web page is simply my first
web page which is not very informative
and there is no description as well so
there's no description there is no image
none of that on the other hand most
modern websites so let's say www.
jan.com if you share this link with
somebody on social platforms or maybe
just check on hea.com you'll see this
preview image build a successful career
in TG this is not there anywhere on the
actual page but this is just for the
purpose of preview and you will see that
it has a nice title and it has a nice
description as well um so all of that is
something that is going to show up
automatically so all of this is achieved
using meta tags so there are several
types of metatags each with its own
purpose so here are some of the more
common metatags that will be used in
most web pages there's something called
a meta car set this is used to inform
the browser what is the character set
there are several character sets there's
something called asy something called
UTF Etc what is the character encoding
that this page is using so this is often
something that is set to
utf8 then there is something called the
viewport meta tag this is used to inform
the browser how to scale up or down how
to zoom in on or out the website on a
mobile screen again there is a standard
value that is preferred for more modern
websites then there is this meta name
description and this description is
actually picked up by
platforms when you share this link when
you share the website as a link so the
description is not actually shown on the
page but it is just picked up as a
preview by Google and whenever you share
the platform elsewhere you can also set
a meta author not particularly useful
these days and you can also set meta
keywords and meta robots uh meta robots
provide some instructions whether search
engin should Index this page or not and
meta keywords is used to specify some
keywords that are that were used in the
past for
search engine indexing but are not now
very less important okay there are also
platform specific meta tags so you can
take your url your website URL and make
it show a different way on Facebook and
a different way on uh Twitter for
example so there is this property called
OG title so this is the title that is
going to be picked up by Facebook
LinkedIn and several other sites OG
stands for open graph and there is this
property called OG description which is
uh picked up for description on Facebook
you can also specify this image using OG
image this is the image that shows up
here and finally you can specify similar
title description and a card setting for
Twitter as well okay so those are all
the meta tags that you can have on your
we website on your web page and apart
from this you can also have a title meta
tag and a Fab icon link tag
so the title this title is not a metatag
exactly it is simply used to set the
title of the page so this is also
important because this is what shows up
on the browser Tab and you have a link I
a link tag which contains something uh a
link to an image called a fave icon and
that image is the image that shows up
over here so right now you're just
seeing a small web image here but
instead let's say here you have the
GitHub logo and elsewhere you'll see the
the Jovian logo on Jovian let's say I
open www. jan.com you see the Jovian
logo so putting a logo here in the
browser tab is done using the fave
icon okay so what we'll do is we'll go
ahead and add a bunch of these metat
tags to our web page so we can take all
of these meta tags we have caret utf8
name viewport description keywords
author robots Etc and we are going to
add them all to our project and
specifically a couple of images also
need to be added see we have this one
meta tag called OG image and that we
going to set as Jovian met. PNG and the
file Jovan meta PNG is here so you can
download it in case you want to add
it yeah this is the this is the image
that we're going to use as Jovan met.
PNG so I can just save this image to my
desktop and then upload it to Cod
spaces and we also have a
meta image for our fa icon so this is
the fave icon that we going to use this
is the icon that is going to show up on
the browser over here okay so again
these are not things that you learn in a
introductory HTML course but to build
good practical modern websites you need
to have good metatags otherwise your
websites are just going to look random
on the browser or when people share them
okay there's more information you can
learn about metatags here but uh these
are the tags that we're going to add
into our web page all right well so now
we want to add meta tags so we basically
want to add all this code into the head
tag of our index. HTML file and we know
how to do this we just copy the code put
it into index.html then stage the
index.html file then commit it then push
it but uh before we do that we're going
to take this opportunity to maybe also
learn the GitHub collaboration workflow
because what is going to happen in the
real world is that you you're not going
to directly make changes to the main
branch as you can imagine let's say
Jovian the website is running and before
we actually make push any new changes we
may want to get them reviewed we may
also have a situation where multiple
people are working on multiple changes
and if they're all cons constantly
pushing to the main branch then they may
all be just overwriting each other's
code so that is why GitHub has this
collaboration workflow powered by
branches so what you do is you have your
main branch or your master Branch from
your master Branch you create create a
feature branch and we'll talk about
branches in just a second and then in
that feature Branch you add a bunch of
commits so one by one you keep adding
comments into your feature Branch then
what you do is
you create a pull request so you using
all the changes that you have put into
your branch so far you create a pull
request on GitHub and in the pull
request you can basically list out the
changes you've made the poll request
will also have all the code changes
between your branch and the main branch
and and the team can then review your
PLL request so somebody from the team
can look at the changes you have made
and they can make comments on your poll
request so they may make some comments
and then you can then make more changes
make new comments based on those
comments you can fix the things that are
not working as
expected and once all the comments are
resolved somebody from your team can
possibly approve
your approve your changes and once your
changes are approved you can then merge
those changes into the main branch
okay so you can take the new changes and
you can merge them into the main branch
and then of course we have versal set up
already so as soon as the main branch
gets changed after all this discussion
and review then it is going to get
deployed automatically so this is how we
safely develop software we take out a
branch which is basically we extract out
a copy conceptually speaking we make
changes to that copy we keep adding
commits we then set up a pull request
people comment on it we make changes to
it we do whatever testing we need need
we'll also see how to generate a copied
version of our site which is which can
be used for testing and then once we are
ready we approve the pull request merge
it back to master and that is going to
trigger a deployment so that is how the
GitHub collaboration workflow works and
it's not just uh that you will be using
a single Branch at a time but here's
what might happen that you may have your
main branch somewhere and then somebody
you may start a new Branch you may start
making some changes and then some
changes may get added to the main Branch
from other people and then somebody else
may start another branch and then your
branch may get merged and then their
Branch may have to get merged so this is
how the GitHub development workflow
works you anytime you want to build a
new feature you create a new branch make
changes on the branch get that reviewed
get that get that approved merge it back
into the main branch and the main branch
is the source of Truth for what is going
to go live on verel or whichever
deployment platform you're using okay so
this is the this is the workflow that
we're going to follow and the first step
in this workflow is to create a branch
so what is a branch well a branch
branching is a very fundamental feature
of git and GitHub that allows developers
to work on multiple versions of the same
codebase simultaneously so you can use
it to work on five tasks at a time or
five features at a time or five
different people can use it to work on
different features without disturbing
each other's code okay and a branch is
essentially a separate copy of the code
base conceptually speaking that you can
make Chang just to without affecting the
main branch which is usually called main
or master so here is how you create
branches within git or using git or
within GitHub code spaces first we open
the terminal so once again I go in here
I say view
terminal now I have the terminal open
here and let me close the sidebar so the
first thing you do is you type git
branch and then you type type the name
of a branch okay so you say git branch
and I just want to add my meta tags here
so I'm just going to call this Branch
add hyphen meta hyen tags so you always
use lowercase letters like add hyphen
meta hyen tags all lower case and you
always generally separate by hyphens you
can also separate by underscores if you
want one other convention is to also
maybe put your username before the
branch so you could I could also create
the branch as such Akash in is/ add meta
tags but this is a good convention so
that multiple people don't end up
creating branches with the same name
accidentally uh in my case I'm just I'm
going to just use the shorthand AA for
myself so aa/ add metatags that's what I
use at Jovian okay so we creating a
branch called aa/ add metatags okay the
slash does not have any special meaning
it is simply a separator that I'm using
I could also have said AA hyphen ad meta
tags and it would be the same thing but
it's just a little nicer to look at okay
AA hyphen ad metat tag so now I'm
creating a branch so a branch has been
created but we are still on the main
branch here you can see here here I'm
still on the main branch so now we need
to switch to this new branch that has
been created now the way to switch to a
new branch is using the git checkout so
you say git checkout and then you type
the branch name so aa/ add meta
tags now we have switched to the branch
AA hyphen add aa/ add meta tags great
and that is something that is displayed
here as well now that we have switched
to the branch we can now start making
commits into this Branch so here is how
I might go about making some comment so
I might first let's see here I might
first maybe just replace
the title and the fave icon so let me
just grab the title and the fave icon
here and I'm just going to replace that
over
here okay and I will just test that so
now when I reload the page you can see
that now we have Jovian careers and okay
this still doesn't have the fave icon
maybe the fave icon will come in when we
actually deploy but looks like at least
the title has changed okay so I've made
one significant change so I'm just going
to Stage this change I'm going to say
added title and fave
icon and I'm going to
commit okay I'm not going to push my
Branch yet I want to make a few more
comments before I push my Branch okay
then maybe I might figure out okay I
might talk to the marketing team I want
I might want I might figure out what
they want as the OG and the Twitter meta
properties so I will add those and then
I might talk to maybe the engineering
team and figure out that okay what are
the other meta properties are required
let me grab all of the remaining meta
tags and let me come in and let me just
paste them here okay so I'm just
simulating an example where you will be
making small changes step by step and
making multiple commits so I've gone
ahead and made these and of course now
for this OG image and for this Twitter
image I need to actually upload this
image file and I also need to upload
this fave icon file okay that's why the
fave icon is not showing so I'm going to
let me first add the metat tex I'll
create another comment where I upload
the files so again I can go in here I
can say add the changes I can commit so
let's say added meta
tags I can commit great perfect and now
I can go ahead and I can actually upload
the files so I can come back here I can
say right click upload let me grab
Jovian met. PNG Jovan fav icon.png
upload them they are added as well
and once again I can go in or I can also
do this from the command line so I say
view terminal and I say
reset and let me just do git
status okay looks like there are a
couple of new files so let me do get add
Dot and let me do get commit minus
M add fave
icon and meta image okay
all right so I've not pushed my changes
yet so I have a bunch of comments here
on this particular Branch if I just
check get
log or I can actually just if I just
want to see the list of changes I can
say get log minus- one
line okay so I so my Branch AA hyen ad
meta tags is at the commit add fav icon
and meta image before that I have
another comment before that I have
another comment so I've made a bunch of
comments now
once I have made a bunch of
commits once I have made a bunch of
commits I can then open a pull request
so to open a pull request here's what I
need to do first I need to push my
Branch or my changes to the remote
repository and the way I can push them
is by saying get push origin followed by
Branch name AA hyphen add meta tags okay
of course I can also achieve the same
thing by just clicking publish Branch
here but I'm just going to do it from
here and once that is done you can now
see that a new Branch will have been
pushed to the GitHub repository how do
we verify that well if I open the GitHub
repository and I just reload the
page you can see this there's this
message here that this uh tag this had
recent pushes of course there's this
trigger but you can also see here that
we have two branches now so earlier this
was just saying one branch so I can
actually go and select the other Branch
so the commits that I've made together I
can package them as a branch and I've
pushed it to GitHub and now I have this
on the main branch you can see here that
SRC
index.html doesn't have any of the meta
tags my main branch is unaffected but if
I change to the branch add meta tags on
this Branch you can see that all the
tags are present okay so this is how you
push branches now what you can do is you
can make more commits you can push the
branch again so you decide what you want
to do typically any small change I make
I make a commit and then once I have a
bunch of small changes that are
significant enough I push the branch
okay but coming right back so now we
have pushed let me come back to the main
branch here now that we have pushed the
branch then now that we have pushed the
branch the next step is to create a pull
request so how do we create a pull
request and what are pull requests so
pull requ requests are a way to propose
changes to the code base and get them
reviewed by other developers and then
get them merged back into the main
branch all right so let's create a pull
request so first we are going to come
back here we are going to go into the
pull requests Tab and into the pull
request tab again you can see that there
is notification here GitHub tries to be
helpful where it tells you that if you
recently pushed a branch it'll tell
It'll ask you if you want to create a
poll request but in case this
notification is not showing up you can
click new pull
request okay and now you can select the
base branch which is where you want your
changes to eventually go and the branch
where you are making your changes which
is ADD meta tags okay so now I've
selected that these are the two branches
and I can actually verify what are the
changes so it seems like from the main
branch I want to remove this existing
title and I want to add a bunch of these
meta tags and seems like I also want to
add a couple of images files okay so I
can review the commits that have been
made on this Branch I can review the
changes between the main branch and this
new branch that I'm I'm proposing and
then I can click create pull request and
here I can give the pull request a name
and typically you want to give this a
description of the change so added meta
tags
title and fave
icon and it's Al also a good idea to
maybe provide more detailed description
of the changes so you can say
changes one is added or updated the
title
tag then you can also mention okay added
images for fave icon and meta poster or
meta
Banner then you can say added meta
tags including OG and Twitter
tags and finally you can also mention
added the fave
icon link tag okay now let's say you've
tested these changes you might also want
to say what you've tested so test cases
checked so you can say something like
verified the title showing
up and maybe you might want to verify
later and add later that you have
verified the fav icon showing up and you
verified the metatag showing up okay and
then you click create pull
request so that's great now now the pull
request is created and now somebody else
on your team who is a collaborator on
this repository can go ahead and review
this PLL request so let me first go
ahead and add a collaborator here so I'm
going to go into settings I'm going to
go into collaborators and I'm going to
add a collaborator here let me just add
Akash and S and I'm going to invite this
collaborator let me go back to the poll
request okay so this this pull request
now has a description and there is this
files changed which contains information
about the files that have been changed
so people can review that as well it
also contains information about the
commits that have been made so now let
me go in and log in from a different
account so I have a different account
logged in here and I'm just going to
accept the invite
first so I've been invited as a
collaborator here so I'm going to accept
the invite so anytime somebody you
invite somebody as a collab cator they
get sent an email and they can accept
the invite okay now that I've accepted
the invite I can go here into the pull
requests Tab and I can go check the poll
request you can I can see that okay
Sydney Jovian has invited me or has
created the SP request I can check okay
these are the changes that have been
made I can maybe go in and then I can go
in and maybe leave a comment so let me
say for example I don't like this title
I want it to be a little longer so I can
say make the title longer
please
maybe at least 24 characters okay and
then I can just uh start a review and I
can add a bunch of these comments so I
can add a comment maybe about the meta
tag meta title here as well somewhere
let's
see this can be improved a
bit and so
on and once I'm done with reviewing I
can just say um I can request some
changes or I can approve and I can click
submit
review and once I've clicked submit
review then these changes have been
pushed back and now Sydney Jovian can
once again go through the changes go
through the comments that have made and
make those changes okay so so again we
are just trying to implement this
workflow here where you create a pull
request and then somebody posts a a
bunch of comments and then you create
new comments to fix those comments and
you keep repeating this process till
they're happy with it okay one other
thing I want to show in this process is
that if you see there is a versel bot
that has added a comment here what worel
has done is whenever versel notices a
pull request in your GitHub repository
it takes the code within that pull
request and it automatically creates a
preview deployment so I can click this
visit preview and I can actually preview
the changes okay okay I can see here
that now it says Jovian careers instead
of my first web page and there seems to
be a bunch of uh um this image seems to
be showing here as well and there are no
changes in the actual page but if I were
to maybe take this and maybe go
into metat
tags.io a platform for checking
metatags I can actually check that okay
it is showing Jovian careers and it is
showing a description here image is not
showing up I can investigate why the
image is not showing up but it looks
like the meta tags are now showing up
okay so this is one of the nice things
about using verel what it takes it takes
your branch your pull request Branch it
deploys that and it adds a link to that
without disturbing your original page so
you can see Jovian career site this is
like that Branch preview but your
original site which is over here Jovian
career
site still says my first web page it is
not updated so your main branch is safe
but for your pull request you have a
preview deployment that you can study
okay all right so let's go in and fix
these quickly so I'm just going to go in
and fix these comments so there is a
comment here that says make the title
longer please maybe at least 24
characters so I'm just going to add
maybe here build
a
successful career in Tech and I'm going
to add the
same title
here back in the OG
title like that okay I've made I fixed
the title learn more about job openings
and submit your application now well I
don't think I'm going to update that I
think I'm happy with the way things are
here so I'm just going to click commit
and let me see I'm just going to Stage
my changes and let me say updated
title and I'm going to click commit and
I'm going to publish the branch so now
once the pull request has been created
created anytime you publish the branch
again the pull request will
automatically be
updated okay so let's come back here and
let's reload this page and you can see
that this new commit has been added and
veral is automatically going to take
this new commit and it's going to deploy
it so it's nice like that so if I go
back and check the deployment this time
it has not just Jovian careers but it
has Jovian careers build a successful
career in Tech it has the full thing
that I've mentioned now I can go in and
I can say Okay resolve this conversation
so this is fine and then um here I can
say I think this is
fine as it
is and I can resolve this comment and
resolve this conversation as well okay
so this is what you want to do you want
to resolve all the comments and then uh
the reviewer may go back and make some
more comments and then you resolve those
comments and so on and the reviewer and
you both can use the prev deploy
employment to test out your changes
preview the changes live as well okay
now the reviewer can eventually be uh
can eventually come back later in the
day or maybe the next day and see that
okay all their changes have been
resolved so then they can go ahead and
they can approve the pull request so
they can go back into this files tab and
they can go in and they they can approve
the pull request like
that and once the pull request is
approved then the changes can be merged
back into the main branch Okay so so
far yeah so so far we are still at this
stage where we have deployed we have
done a done a preview deployment and the
P request has been approved but to merge
it back we can come back into the pull
review page the pull request page and at
the bottom we can see that once all the
approvals have
been uh have been received and you can
set conditions this at the repository
level then you can click merge pull
request and you can give it a a commit
message and a commit details and then
you can click merge and that is going to
now merge this to our main branch okay
so now this has merged and now if I come
back into the code Tab and I see the
main branch you can see here now it has
this new commit called updated title so
this is the work so this is the workflow
that we have we created a feature Branch
added some commits to it pushed the
branch created a pull request then we
invited a reviewer to comment the
reviewer commented we made the changes
we also looked at the preview deployment
which verel automatically gave us a very
kindly and we made sure that everything
was working fine and finally the changes
were then merged to the main branch and
of course verel picks this up again and
does another deployment so now if I go
back and just reload the main versel
page you can see that now the fav icon
is updated the title is here is updated
and I can also check so there's a place
here that you can check meta tags I
believe it's
called hea.com yeah so I can also check
all the meta tags now on Jan careers
website live.
w.app so now our careers Jin careers
website has this nice title that is
going to get picked up by Google
Facebook Twitter Etc it has this nice
image that will show up as a link
preview when you share this link on
LinkedIn or elsewhere and it has this
nice description over here as well learn
about job openings at Jin and sub submit
your application now so great so we
learned the we learned about metat tags
but alongside we also learned about a
GitHub collaboration workflow which is
Branch full request get it reviewed
iterate on it and then merge it once you
have received the reviews okay so that's
about branching with Git and that is
about creating pull
requests and I would encourage you to
exercise this a little bit so create
multiple pull requests with minor
changes and then verify that each pull
request gets its own preview deployment
so if you have five pull requests there
are going to be five preview deployments
so verel gives you unlimited preview
deoy deployments for free and then
verify that the main site is not
affected till a particular pull request
is merged okay also one thing that you
can try to do is try to see what happens
if you have two pull requests and then
you merge one and then you try to merge
the next one so these are some exercises
for you to try out git is a very applied
skill so you have to try out all these
things whatever questions you have just
try it within 5 to 10 minutes you'll
actually have your answer now let us
talk about keeping your branch up to
date so here is a scenario that might
happen we already have two users now we
have two collaborators one is Sydney
Jovian and the other collaborator
is and the other collaborator is Akash
Andes so that's why I have these two
windows in black and white so here I am
signed in as aashis and here I am signed
in as Sydney Jovian of course the
repository still belongs to Sydney
Jovian we are both collaborators on it
now let us try to make changes in such a
way that two people are working in
parallel and once changes get merged
into main while the second is still
working okay so let's do this let us
first go into this code so this is
on the user aashan is and I am going to
create a code space to start
editing and it's going to take a second
or two to set up the code space but once
it's done I should be able to start
editing some things
here okay so inside SRC I have
index.html and let me just just go in
here and let me just change this
to let me edit the title again let me
change this to welcome to
Jovian and let me change something in
the description let me remove highly
reputed let me just make it most reputed
Technical University so I've made a
couple of small changes here and let me
also remove the word Jovian from the
names of the programs let us just call
it full stack developer boot camp and
data science boot camp and let me just
commit it so let me go into Source
control let me add the changes and let
me say made some changes
to
index.html and let me commit it and let
me sync the changes okay I have synced
it it looks like I made those changes on
Main right so let me now create some
more changes es and let me make those on
a branch because normally this is not
something we should be doing we should
be creating a branch so let me add back
let's say let me add back the word
Jovian here let me add back the word
Jovian here and let me add the word open
job opportunities here and this time I'm
going to first create a branch so let's
see let me create a new
Branch let me call this
branch open job opportunity
ities and now the branch has been
created and now I'm on the branch now I
can add my changes to the to my branch
and let me commit them so added
open job
opportunities okay and now let me
publish the
branch so what I've done now is I have
made some changes on Main and that will
just go out to everyone for sure but
then I've also created a branch out of
main which I'm going to then create a
pull request on so I can then come back
here and looks like okay this new branch
has been pushed let me click compare and
pull request and let me just say added
job open job opportunities in
index.html and that's the same
description for now let me create a pull
request and the changes that have
happened here are simply well
the from the main branch I have simply
remove added the word Jovian back and I
have added open job opportunities here
okay so just to show you what happened
what we did
was we had the main
branch and then from the main branch we
made another commit so we made some
changes onto the main branch this was
done by Akash so this was the main
branch then we branched out of the main
branch and made one commit and of course
we could have made multiple commits on
that Branch so this branch is the
open job opportunities Branch right and
this branch has been made by Akash Andes
and we've set up a PLL request for this
Branch as well right so let us call this
pull request one now we've set up a pull
request pull request one called added
job opportunities in index. HTML now let
us come back to Sydney Jovian
okay and let us go back here to the main
branch first so there is a selector here
that I can use to go to the main branch
so let's say here I've just checked out
the main branch now the main branch on
Sydney Jovan is a little bit behind my
Old Branch the branch that has been
created by Akash and S so let's say
Sydney forgot to pull the latest changes
before before working on a new change
right let's say Sydney is uh working on
some changes about related to to the
dates of the front end developer backend
developer Etc so what Sydney doeses is
creates a new Branch to make his changes
so I'm going to
say
Branch create a new branch and let me
just say job date
changes and create this Branch so a
branch has been created by Sydney for
his
work and now Sydney is going to make the
changes to the jobs let's say this is
March instead of March 3rd this is March
13th instead of Fab 1 this is Fab 11
instead of December 22nd this is
December 20 and here we change
the salary to 85,000
okay and now let me commit these
changes into the branch I have staged
them so job changes and commit and let
me publish this
branch and now let me again come back
here and let me create a pull request
okay so once again these are job changes
so job date
changes and this is again something that
I would want to
merge okay and the only changes here are
the changes within the dates so let's
once again recap what's happening here
so here aashis has first made a change
to the main branch itself and pushed it
and then created a new branch and
created a pull request on top of it then
Sydney forgot or did not have a chance
to pull the latest changes on Main so
Sydney created a few changes from the
last version of Main and then made a
couple of commits let's say and then set
up a pull request let's call it PR2 okay
so already things are a little out of
hand Sydney is is Sydney's main branch
on his own computer is a little bit
behind and Akash is main branch is a
little bit ahead and of course this is
also the main branch on GitHub itself so
that's why you have a origin has its own
main branch but Sydney has its own main
branch which is a little behind and now
there is this pull request and now one
of these pull requests is going to get
merged let us say the pull request
number one gets approved so let's say
somebody on the team goes ahead reviews
the pull requests
that are all present so let's say they
go into the pull request created by
Akash and S and they go ahead and
approve the pull
request okay so they just approve it and
they just merg that pull request so now
what has happened is that Akash is
changes have gone into master so now we
are at the situation where this pull
request has been merged back into
master and however this pull request is
still tracking the old main branch so
now what we need to do is we need to
update this second pull request to show
changes based on the new new main branch
okay so here's what we need to
do we need to take the changes in the
main branch and then incorporate them
into the currently open pull request how
do we do that well here is a
step-by-step
process first we check out the main
branch then we pull changes from the
main branch then we check out the
feature branch and then we merge the
main branch and then we push the changes
okay so we'll do it step by step and it
will make more
sense okay so now I am here on Sydney's
branch and on Sydney's I'm on Sydney's
poll request Branch so I'm on the branch
which Sydney has created for poll
request number two and this is based off
of a main branch which itself is very
old okay so I'm going to show this on on
the terminal but you can you can do the
exact same thing from your uh from the
user interface as well so first I am
going to so I'm currently on the branch
job date changes I'm going to switch to
the main branch so get checkout
main okay by typing get checkout main I
have now switched on Sydney's codespace
I've switched into the main branch on
Sydney's codespace now of course
Sydney's Cod space main branch is behind
the main branch on the server we already
know that because one direct commit was
made and then one pull request was
merged so I can do um the first thing I
can do is I can do get fetch minus-
all what that does is that fetches the
changes that are there on the remote but
it does not apply them yet so it does
not pull the changes it simply fetches
information about the changes again more
terminology I know know but we right now
what we know is we we have now fetched
information about what are all the
branches that are present on the remote
server and where are the where are they
compared to the branches that are
present on This Server okay let me now
reset and let me type get status again
and now I can see here that your branch
is behind origin main by eight commits
so looks like I'm fairly behind because
a bunch of other pull requests were
merged but here's what I can do I can
say get
full origin main so now what I'm saying
is that I have my local main branch
which is a little bit behind and then
there is this origin main branch which
is ahead if I type get full origin main
then all my changes are going to get my
my main branch is going to get up toate
with the origin okay so what has
happened now is that Sydney's local copy
of the main branch has become up to date
by with the main branch on GitHub
okay that's fine now let us come back to
our job openings Branch so I can just
type get Branch to see the names of the
different branches that are available
and I can switch to the branch so I can
say get
checkout job date
changes okay now I've checked out job
date changes the trouble is my local
Main is now up to date my local main
branch is now up to date with what what
is there on GitHub but my job main
branch but my jobs feature branch is
still pointing to that old main branch
or that old main commit okay so what I
need to do is I need to pull in these
new changes into my job Branch okay so
now we
do get pull or not pull well actually we
need to merge in these new local main
branch changes this into the job Branch
so we say get
merge main so what we
telling get now is that I'm on this job
date changes Branch take the latest
changes from the main branch on my
computer which is already tracking the
latest changes from on from GitHub and
bring all those latest changes back into
my feature Branch okay so I type get
merge
Main and this will ask me to then typee
a message so I'm just going to say merge
main into job date changes and once you
type the message you can just
close and now
magically what it has done is is it has
taken all the changes that have been
made in the main branch on GitHub and we
first pulled that into the main branch
on our computer now all those new
changes have been put into
our feature branch which is job date
changes okay and you can verify that
here is how you can verify that you can
see that we have Jovian data science
boot camp mentioned here so that is
there you can see that we
have uh most reputed Technical
University so all the changes that were
made by Akash have now been Incorporated
so what we have done essentially is we
have taken the changes that have come
newly and we have Incorporated them into
the second poll request Branch okay one
last thing to do here is that these
changes are still local on our code
space so I need to push these so I need
to say get push it to the pull request
so get push origin job hyphen date
hyphen
change changes and this should get
pushed okay finally now we can come back
here and we can see that job date
changes has now been
updated job date changes has now been
updated with the merged changes into the
main branch
okay and now it is tracking against the
latest main branch that is present and
now somebody can come in and somebody
can approve it and then this can be
merged in now we can go in and now we
can merge this change and put that
back okay so I know that there was a lot
going on there but I'll just first
revise this so what we do is whenever
new changes have come onto the main
branch on GitHub and we want to
incorporate them into our feature
branches here's what we need to do first
within our code space or wherever we are
we are doing our development first go to
the main branch our local main branch
using git checkout main then we get the
latest changes from the remote by by
running git pull or git pull origin main
so that our local main is tracking at
the same place where our latest changes
are on GitHub then we check out our
feature Branch we say get checkout
feature Branch name then we merge in the
changes from the main branch that we
have locally now into our feature
branch and finally we push these changes
to the remote repository so we take our
feature branch and push it to remote so
that the pull request gets updated okay
so this is the workflow that you will do
over and over as a developer you'll
check out the main branch get pull check
out the feature Branch merge the changes
from the main branch and then push your
feature Branch back to GitHub and these
steps will ensure that your feature
branch is updated with the latest
changes from the main branch okay so as
you have created a feature branch and
you made some comits on it and made a
pull request if new changes have come on
to the main branch you can simply pull
those changes in by following this
workflow and then you can push your uh
main branch back uh push your feature
Branch back and your pull request will
get updated and then the merging will
happen seamlessly okay
so that's how mer that's how merging
works this is called uh yeah you're
basically merging changes from the main
branch into the feature branch and git
is smart enough that if the changes were
made within the same file but to
different parts of the same file then
things will work out just fine uh git
will be able to combine all those
changes from multiple users multiple
commits together okay and again I
encourage you to practice this create a
branch make some changes create a pull
request create another Branch uh and
make some changes create a second pull
request now approve approve and merge
the first pull request and then update
the second pull request to incorporate
the new changes from the first pull
request and repeat that process a few
times using the command line and using
vs code's user interface to see if you
understand how this whole thing works
okay now there are certain cases where
two people in two separate PRS have
updated this exact same line of code in
which case there is going to be
something called a merge conflict so let
us try and simulate a merge conflict
situation now by both users updating
just the title of the page okay so let's
do this let us first go back here into
the code space that
is being used by the user Akash NS and
let me open up a terminal I'm just going
to do everything on the terminal so that
things are super clear so we are
currently on the branch open job
opportunities I'm going to first check
out the branch
get checkout
main okay now I'm on the main branch on
my Akash NS Cod space then I'm going to
run G pull origin main so that I have
the latest
changes
perfect I am going to get the latest
changes on the Sydney account as well
shortly but now I'm going to create a
new
Branch I'm going to create a branch get
branch a ayen title change
one okay I've created a new Branch title
change one I'm going to check out that
new Branch get checkout AA title change
one so now I've checked out a new Branch
so I have the latest Main Branch from
the latest main branch I've checked out
a new Branch now I'm going to come in
here and I'm going to change the title
of the page which
is I'm just going to change it back to
Jovian careers okay so I am changing the
title of the page to Jovian careers that
is one change I making and I will also
change here welcome to Jovian to about
Jovian so two changes I'm making I've
changed the title to Jovian careers and
I have changed well about Jovian to uh
welcome to Jovian to about Jovian so
those two changes and you can verify
these changes by using G diff I can see
that those are the only two changes I
have
made now I'm going to commit these
changes so I'm going to say get add dot
I'm going to get commit minus
M change title and about
Jovian okay now I have committed my
changes onto my local branch and now I'm
going to push my local branch to the to
GitHub so I'm going to say git push
origin a a hyen title change one so now
my
branch which is based on the latest Main
and has a couple of changes one to the
title and one to about Jovian has been
pushed and now I can create a pull
request using this Branch okay now I can
go in here and I can say create a pull
request I'm going to just call it change
title so I've
changed title to Jovian
careers and and then
change description heading to about Jian
okay and I'm going to create a poll
request perfect so we understand this
flow so far we created a branch we made
some changes we committed and we pushed
it created a pull request and we can
verify that it contains only these two
changes it contains a change Jovian
careers and it contains a change about
Jovian
perfect now let's say before this pull
request was merged
Sydney was also working on some changes
where he's going to change the title so
I'm going to say
file view terminal or sorry view
terminal I'm opening up the terminal
again let me reset
it let me also go back here to the
master so let me say get checkout M or
let me say get checkout main so now I'm
on the main branch back let me also do
GP origin
main so I have the latest version of the
origin main okay so in the latest main
our title still has Jovian cers build a
successful career in
Tech
and the title here for the description
is still welcome to Jan because the
changes were made in a pull request that
is not yet merged to main okay so I hope
this is clear to you that our main
branch is still still has the old title
and the old heading okay now I'm going
to create a new feature Branch so I'm
going to say
get
Branch Sy or for
Sydney title change
to okay fine and now I am going
to come in here and I'm going to remove
this part okay so I'm just going to
remove the part build a successful
career in Tech I'm going to keep the
part build a successful career in Tech
so maybe two people got different
instructions Akash and has made the
change to about Jovian he was asked to
shorten the title and Sydney also got
the instruction to shorten the title and
he changed it to build a successful
career in Tech and maybe I also go in
here and change something about the job
opportunities so I don't don't want it
to say open job opportunities I wanted
to say job
openings okay and I have I will also
check out this Branch get checkout sy/
tile change to and once I've checked out
the branch I'm going to to add the
changes so get add dot then I'm going to
say get commit minus
M change title and job
opportunities okay now I've committed
now I'm going to push this Branch so I'm
going to
say get push origin sy/ title
change
to now my branch has been pushed to the
origin which is GitHub now I can come
back here and create a pull
request and here I'm changing the title
so change title and job opportunity so
here I'm changing the title
to build a successful career in
Tech all
right yeah so the title is changed to
build a successful career in Tech and
then the change the job section
header to job
openings okay let me create a pull
request
here
and let's see now so here now there are
two changes on the title and on job
openings here also there are two changes
on the title but a different change to
the title and on the job openings and
both changes are made against the the
latest version of
Master now let us merge one of the pull
requests so now let us go in
here and let us merge this first pull
request so what will happen is that when
by merging this pull request which
changes the title to Jovian careers in
our main branch we are going to get back
Jovian careers as the title okay so I'm
going to go in here and I'm going to
check mer click merge P request confirm
merge and the pull request has been
merged and I can verify if I go into
code and check the main branch and check
index.html it is going to have the
change title Jovian careers okay
so now the first PLL request has been
merged the title of the page has changed
to Jovian carers and the header of the
first section has changed to about
Jovian
however obviously for Sydney the title
of the change title of the page is
whatever they have set in their feature
branch and the heading of the first
section is welcome to Jovian and not
about Jovian and of course they've also
made an additional change called job
openings so now Sydney's feature branch
is behind the main branch on GitHub so
Sydney needs to update their feature
Branch so let's update the feature
Branch step byep step so I'm going to
open the terminal again I'm going to
reset things and remember the
step-by-step process for updating the
feature Branch first you go to get
checkout main first you get to the main
branch because our local main branch and
code spaces is behind the main branch on
Origin then we can check using get fetch
minus minus all or just get
fetch how far behind we are okay so we
can say get status to check that we are
behind origin main so we are behind the
changes by two
commits so let us run
get pull origin main so now we are
pulling the changes from the origin main
branch on GitHub to our Cod space on the
Sydney Cod
space great so now our main branch is up
to date but our feature branch is still
tracking the old version of the main
branch now we go back to our feature
Branch so let's Che check the name of
the branch okay the feature branch is Sy
title change 2 so get checkout
Sy title change
to and by the way you can verify here
that so far we are on the main branch
and on the main branch it says Jovian
careers which is the change that had
been made by Akash Andes and the title
of the first section is about Jovian
which is also a change that was made by
Akash as soon as we go into the feature
Branch now we we have the title that was
set
by Sydney here and now of course we have
welcome to Jovian because this is
tracking the old main
branch and we have this job openings
here okay so now we need to merge in the
latest the new main branch that we have
just pulled in so we say get
merge main let me just reset that and
type that again get merge
Main and here is what happens okay
finally we've done all this setup to get
to a point where when I try to update my
feature Branch using the new changes
that have come into the main branch I
run into an issue because both of us are
trying to
update the same line aashis has updated
so there are two things you have a
current change which is the change in my
feature Branch so in my feature Branch I
have updated the title to build a
successful career in t
however when I try to merge in the main
branch the main branch that has come
from GitHub the latest main branch
because of some other poll request has
the title Jovian careers so both the
main branch and my feature branch have
been independently updated on this one
particular line and you can see only
this one particular line is an issue
this this becomes about Joan as expected
no issues here and this becomes job
openings as expected no no issues here
right so this came in from the main
branch no problem no because we didn't
change it in the feature Branch this
change came in from the feature branch
no problem because it was not previously
change in the main branch but this
change was made in the main branch as
well which is called Jovian careers and
this change was made uh made in the
feature Branch as well which is called
build a successful career in Tech so
this is what git does it inserts this
like random characters here which
basically tell you that what do you have
on your current branch and what do you
have on the main branch and you can
either edit it manually you can kind of
erase all these characters or you can
just use one of these buttons whether
you want to accept the incoming change
which means the incoming change is what
is coming in from the branch you're
trying to merge in which is what is
coming in from main or you can accept
the current change which is what you
have in your feature Branch or you can
keep both changes so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to click
accept current change so I want my
feature brand change to override what
has come in from the updates in the main
branch so I'm going to click accept
current
change and now in my feature Branch I
have overridden I have resolved the
merge conflict and I've have overridden
the change that was made in the main
branch and now I need to create another
commit okay so now I can
say get add dot get commit minus M
resolved merge conflict
okay now I've made this change I need to
push my feature Branch to update my PLL
request so now we can say get push
origin syy title change
two okay and now I can go back here and
reload my pull
request so if I did not make this fix
this merge conflict and I tried to merge
this pull request it would say that the
PO request cannot be merged because it
is conflicting with the latest version
of main but now that I've fixed this
merge
conflict you can see that I have said
that from the main branch I want to
change Jovian careers which was the
latest version of the title on the main
branch to build a successful career in
Tech and I want to change open job
opportunities to job openings okay and
then we can go ahead and merge this PLL
request right and that's it so now we
should on the main branch we should
should have Incorporated changes from
both the places right so if we look back
at the pull requests we have closed a
couple of pull requests one of them
changed the title to Jovian careers and
about Jovian which merged first the
second one changed the title to build a
successful career and change the job
section header to job openings which
merged second and while merging the
second one we chose to override the
changes from the first one we could also
have chosen to keep it at the point of
the merge conflict we can decide what to
keep so the end outcome of all of this
is going to be that if we just check the
title here so the title becomes build a
successful career in Tech we have about
Jovian this came from pr1 from the pr by
aashis we have job openings this came
from PR2 the pr created by Sydney Jovin
and this is how you reconcile changes
okay so just to recap how you resolve
merge conflicts occur when git is unable
to auto automatically merge changes from
two branches and this can happen when
two or more people have made changes to
the same file or the same line in of
code in in a file and the changes made
in one branch conflict with the changes
made in another Branch okay so these are
the steps to build a fil uh fix a merge
conflict so when there is a merge
conflict vs code will display a
notification in the bottom right corner
and will also show a way to merge
changes there you can see the
conflicting files so you can see it like
this and you can have multiple files you
can have multiple conflicts within a
single file and then for each file you
can choose which changes to keep and how
to select and select the right version
and once you have resolved all the merge
conflicts you need to make a new commit
and then those changes can be pushed
safely to the remote repository okay and
just to make it super clear I'm also
going to draw this out here for
you so here we have the origin main
branch so this is the I'm calling it The
Origin main okay and based on the origin
main branch in each of our code spaces
so let's say this is the code space for
Akash and S and this is the code space
for
Sydney based on the origin main branch
each of them has their own main
branch what Akash has did was first make
a change to the main branch directly and
then push that back to origin so that's
how origin got updated then Akash has
created a feature branch and then
created a pull requ reest from the
feature branch called
pr1 then Sydney based on the old version
of the new of the main branch not using
the new version of the main branch made
some changes and created a pull request
called
PR2 then we merged the changes from pr1
into the main branch so this pr1 is
tracking a side branch and we merged
those changes back into the main branch
so now the main branch is in conflict
so these two cannot be merged there's a
conflict because both of them have
edited the
title so then we trite to here's what we
Tred to do into our main branch we try
to pull in these changes so into our
main branch here we try to pull in our
changes and we try to get a new version
of the main branch then we try to merge
those new version of the main branch
back into our feature branch and that is
when we resolve the merge conflict and
then we pushed our feature Branch back
and now the feature Branch was
compatible with the main branch and so
these could be merged together okay I
know it's confusing you have to work it
out on paper by yourself you have to try
to create a couple of pull requests you
can also go through uh this explanation
again um but only when you do it you
realize it but all said and done what
we've been able to achieve is we've been
able to resolve a merge conflict all
right so that is the final topic that
we're looking at today resolving merge
conflicts there is another optional
topic on using git locally I will not
get into it today because we've covered
a lot of material already we have looked
at a bunch of different things but there
is a way for you to use git locally what
you can do is you can
um download git on Mac OS or on Windows
or on Linux so you'll get this git
command line tool on your computer it
will look something like this G minus
minus version it will show you g
okay then you can actually you'll need
to configure git so you'll need to
configure a username and you'll need to
configure an email before you can start
creating repositories making commits now
what you can do is you can either create
a repository and push it to GitHub or
you can get an existing GitHub
repository down onto your computer if
you want to First create a repository on
your computer that is done using the git
init command and that will create a new
directory called dogit in your present
working directory and then you can make
commits locally on your computer and
then you can add a remote repository on
GitHub and you can then push your
changes to the remote repository so
there are some instructions here and you
can also if if other changes are made on
the repository online you can pull those
changes back okay so that's one flow
where you create a repository on your
computer add some commits to it and push
it to GitHub the other flow is that
there is an existing repository on
GitHub in that case to get the first
version of that repository you do
something called a get clone okay so
more terminology uh you clone that
repository which means you get your
first version of that repository then
you can make commments into that
repository and then you can push that
repository back onto the cloud okay so
I've linked to a tutorial here that you
can go through in case you want to use
um in case you want to use GitHub on
your computer so follow this YouTube
tutorial it's about 40 50 minutes long
and it'll get you through all of these
as well but here is where we are going
to wrap up today so here's what what we
looked at we looked at using GitHub
repositories to share your project
source code and the simplest usage is
very simple you go on github.com you
click create repository put in some
information add a readme file add a add
a get ignore file add
a a license file and you create a
repository very straightforward right so
the simplest way to create a repository
is just to go on github.com and create a
repository then opening up a GitHub
repository on COD spaces is also very
straightforward you just go onto the
repository P page you click the code
button and you say edit in code spaces
so till now there's no git commands even
that you need to run you just have to
open up um a Cod space and you can use
vs code for
development then while you're developing
the website U using Cod spaces you just
make changes you can upload files or you
can create new files and you can add
code within those files and you can then
preview them using the live server
extension on git so the live server
extension within vs code can let you
preview changes while you are developing
that is again fairly
straightforward the next step now all of
this is still happening on the main
branch the single branch that you get is
to create G commits so what you do is
you take some changes you've made you
first stage them and then you st then
you take those stage changes and then
you commit them so you record a version
a new version locally and then you push
those committed changes back to GitHub
and that way the GitHub repository gets
updated so always remember
this always remember this picture what
you do is you do some local development
and then you push the changes back into
the remote
server you push the changes back into
the remote server which is GitHub okay
then we learned how to deploy a website
to the cloud directory from directly
from from GitHub using verel and again
it's really simple you just go to
ver.com sign in connect it to your
GitHub repository and then just click
deploy and every time the main branch is
updated which means every time you push
some changes into the main branch then
your repository uh is going to get
updated and your website is also going
to get automatically deployed very easy
and you can also connect a custom domain
if you
want so all of this is largely enough
for working on personal projects
but we also have the GitHub
collaboration workflow so what happens
in the GitHub collaboration workflow is
that on your code space you take a
branch out you make some changes within
the branch you make some commits within
the branch you push that Branch to
GitHub then you set up a pull request
and once you set up that pull request
then somebody else can review that pull
request and versel also creates a sample
of preview deployment without effect in
your main branch and once that pull
request is approved you can merge that
pull request back and the main branch
gets updated and so a new version of
your project gets deployed automatically
by versel so that is a safe way for you
to work on multiple features at a time
without affecting the main branch
without affecting the main deployment
and whenever you're ready to bring
things back you can merge you can
approve that pull request or somebody
else from your team can approve the pull
request and bring the changes back back
into the main branch okay so that is the
GitHub collaboration workflow which is
also fairly straightforward create a
branch make some commits create a pull
request get it reviewed um keep
iterating on that branch and finally you
merge those changes after the pull
request is approved back into the main
branch okay now where it starts to get
complicated is when you have these merge
conflicts when you have to keep your
branches up to date and you have to and
there are conflicts where multiple
people can have updated the the same
file now although we've covered it today
don't worry if that does not make sense
right now because that's not something
you're going to run into immediately and
that is something that we are going to
cover at a later stage multiple times so
you will become familiar with the flow
over time okay so but how it works is uh
you have to first get the latest changes
from the main branch onto your code
space then go into your uh feature
branch and pull in those latest changes
from Main from or merg in those latest
changes from the main branch into your
feature branch and then resolve any
merge conflicts if they show up and push
your feature Branch back to update your
pull request and that is how you keep
your pull requests up to date okay it's
complex no doubt but only when you do it
a few times you get used to it so all
the code for the tutorial is found here
you can find the finally from this point
on we'll just be using GitHub
repositories and you should also just be
using GitHub repositories for all your
work going forward so you should do that
and you can check out the finished site
here as well which contains all the meta
tags Etc in place as well so we also
looked at meta tags and how they can be
used to set up a preview image some
description and a preview title when a
link is shared online now G can be
confusing because of all the various
terms and commands but it does become
second nature with practice I still look
up commands on git because even after
using it for 15 years there are so many
terms that I often find myself at a loss
in terms of what I what I need to do but
in particular just try to remember these
common workflows when the simplest
workflow is you make some changes you
check those changes using git D or using
the visual code Visual Studio code API
you add those changes or stage those
changes using git ad dot then you commit
those changes using git commit minus M
and then finally you push those changes
to update your repository okay this is
what you should be doing right now you
don't need to do anything more than this
the next level two is understanding the
GitHub collab collaboration workflow
where you create a branch and you make
commits on the branch you push the
branch you create a pull request uh for
the branch to be merged into the main
branch that is reviewed by other people
you iterate you make changes based on
the comments and then you merge that
back into the main
branch the third and the most complex
workflow which will take some time to
get used to is the branch update
workflow where you have to first
whenever your branch has fallen out of
date uh because the main branch has been
updated a few times first you go back to
the main branch on your codespace get
the latest change from GitHub check out
your feature Branch merge the main
branch and fix any merge conflicts and
then push the feature Branch to update
your poll request and you're good to go
okay try to practice it try to set up a
couple of accounts or maybe even um with
the same account you can create two pull
requests with some merge conflicts and
practice it and here are some resources
you can check out to learn more so there
is the get documentation of course which
is the official documentation and
reference that you can check out there
is the GitHub learning lab so
specifically dealing with merge
conflicts Etc you can check out GitHub
learning lab so all of this you can see
that there is this section on reviewing
pull requests there is this section on
reviewing merge conflict so this will
set things up for you in such a way that
it'll give you a starting point and then
you'll have to do some reviews you'll
have to resolve some merge
conflicts there are some tutorials on
atlassian some tutorials on get Kraken
you can check out these as well um again
get us that kind of thing that you can
keep exploring more and more you don't
have to become an expert on get right
away if you can just do the first
version you are good to go if you can do
the second that's great over time as you
start working in a team you'll be able
to start working on the third version or
the third workflow as well okay there's
a g cheat sheet by gitlab you can go
check out this cheat sheet it contains
some of these common workflows so that
you don't have to think about all all
the different git commands together and
you should also check out the
documentation for vs code so if you just
search vs
code Version
Control you will find that there is this
detailed set of videos and tutorials on
how you can perform every git related
action directly within vs code without
ever having to type a single command so
most of the time you'll just be using
this at work so check this out as well
as well there is this nice YouTube
tutorial that you can check out for a
for local git development we did not
cover local git development because we
are going to use we are going to be
using Code spaces for the rest of this
course and for the rest of this program
as well but if you want to do some local
development on git then we have some
instructions on installing git on your
computer and then you can check out this
tutorial for things like G config git
init git clone Etc of course you should
check out the documentation for verel if
you have more questions about how verel
works but the flow we've shown here
which is connected to your GitHub
account pull in a GitHub repository code
select the root folder and just hit
deploy and then automatically anytime
the main branch is updated it's going to
create a new deployment and anytime you
create a pull request it's going to
create preview deployments that can be
used for testing without affecting the
main deployment and then anytime the
pull request gets merged the main
deployment gets updated automatically so
it makes things really seamless and it
is used in production that is what we're
going to be using extensively in this
program and you can learn more about
their versal and GitHub inte ation here
as well responsive design is a crucial
aspect of modern web development and it
ensures that websites adapt gracefully
to various screen sizes and
devices and by utilizing responsive
design principles you can effectively
build user interfaces and accessible
websites that can cater to a diverse set
of audiences from any set of devices and
in fact this is important because over
70% of web web traffic today comes from
mobile and maybe another 10% from
smaller tablets and there's only about
10% of traffic that comes from the large
desktop screens that we typically
develop our websites on so there is a
bit of a disconnect in terms of what
developers look at when they're
developing websites and what people look
at when they're actually browsing these
sites so we'll talk about using CSS
media queries and breakpoints to
implement a mobile first in responsive
web design we will also talk about
leveraging the various properties off
offered by the CSS flexbox layout model
to build fluid and dynamic layouts we
will then learn how to create separate
wireframes to determine the layout of a
web page at various breakpoints and this
is how designers will often share
designs with you and finally we will
talk about implementing testing and
deploying a a responsive website using
CSS media queries and flexbox and of
course the best way to learn these
skills is to follow along step by step
and type out all the code yourself if
you are not been doing that if you have
not been typing out all the code
yourself you're making a big big mistake
it is going to severely slow down how
much you're going to learn so type out
all the code yourself question
everything that you do and if you get
stuck at some point please ask us uh we
have also just added a lot more
one-on-one support call slots and we're
also decreasing the amount of time that
we take to respond to your queries so
please feel free to get all the help
that you
need all right so here is a problem
statement that we look at today now in
the previous lesson we built a jovian
careers website so this is what the
website looks like we have a Navar here
with the Jovian logo we have this Banner
image that says do something great we
have an about Jovian section that talks
about our mission and talks about two
programs we offer along with a picture
we have an employment opportunities
table we found that a table was a nice
way to Showcase some employment
opportunities so that's great and and
then we have the submit your application
form where people can fill out their
name email phone number date of birth
select a position upload a resume add a
cover letter agree to terms and
conditions and submit the application
and finally at the bottom we have a
footer so this is the website that we
have been developing step by step over
the past few
lessons however this same website if
you've tried to open it on mobile you
will see that it doesn't really show up
properly what happens on mobile is this
image takes up a lot of space there's a
lot of blank space above and below it
above and below this do something great
part so we might want to reduce the uh
the height of the image on mobile you
may also notice that on mobile it
doesn't really make sense to show these
side by side the text and the image
maybe it'll be better to show the image
below instead of on the side then you
will also notice that the table does not
show up completely on mobile the table
actually goes out of you and that
requires horizontal scrolling which is
not a great experience on
mobile and finally the applic ation form
as well it feels a little cramped on
mobile and it would be nicer if there
was more space on mobile for each of the
input Fields so we will try and improve
this website to make it more mobile
friendly or what's called responsive and
here's what we're going to do we are
going to use different layouts for
different screen sizes to ensure that
the page shows up properly on any device
so it's going to look different on
mobile it's going to look different on
tablets and different on desktops we're
going to use CSS flexbox to make the
layout more fluid and ensure that it
adapts properly to any screen width and
we will also set up a GitHub repository
a new one so that the old one is not
affected now normally you will continue
working on the same repository however
just so that you have access to the old
code as well we will set up a copy of
the previous GitHub repository and we
will also deploy this new GitHub
repository to the cloud using verel okay
and of course we are assuming here that
you are familiar with the the previous
lessons which is HTML and CSS Basics
Advanced HTML and CSS and Version
Control with GitHub and Cloud deployment
with
worel the code for this tutorial can be
found here so this is the starter code
so I'm just going to open this up
here this is the this is a GitHub
repository which contains the starter
code you can see here that there is an
SRC folder here and inside the SRC
folder there is
uh there is an index.html file and there
is a styles. CSS file these contain the
HTML and the CSS for this Jovian career
site okay you can also check out the
starter site which is what we looked at
just
now so this is the starter site that
we're going to work on today and I
encourage you to take this URL and open
it up on your mobile phone to ensure to
confirm that it actually does not look
very good so that you can compare it
with the changes that we're making today
and you can find and the completed code
and the finished site here now to work
on this tutorial we will create a new
repository containing a copy of our
original repository let us open it up
here in a new
window so this is the repository that we
want to create a copy of okay now
normally if you want to create a copy of
a repository that is owned by somebody
else you can just click this button
called fork and what Fork will do is
take the GitHub repository that is part
of somebody else's profile and copy that
completely to your own profile as a
separate copy so that you can do your
own development there um but sometimes
you have to Fork your own repository and
GitHub does not allow forking your own
repository so I'm going to show you a
quick way in which you can create a
complete working copy of your GitHub
repository as another new repository so
here is how we do that go to github.com
and on github.com click the new button
here so I'm clicking the new button and
when you click the new button you will
get the option to create a new
repository so let me call this
repository Jovian
careers responsive live because I'm
going to create a responsive or a mobile
friendly version of this site and I'm
doing this live so I'm just going
calling it Jan careers responsive live a
responsive
version of the Jovan career site
okay I am going to leave this public and
I'm not going to add a readme get ignore
or license so this time I'm creating a
completely empty GitHub repository so
once I click create repository now a
completely empty repository gets created
okay now what I want to do is I want to
take this GitHub repository and import
all the code from this GitHub repository
into my new repository okay this is the
repository for the previous lesson I
don't want to disturb it now normally in
a job you will probably be continuing to
work on the same repository but just for
demonstration I'm showing you how to
create a copy so that the previous
lesson doesn't get affected okay so
there are many ways to add code into a
empty repository you can check out some
of these but here is one called import
code so what you can do here is click on
the import code button and then grab the
URL of the old repository so here is the
old repository I'm grabbing the URL Joan
career site and I am going to copy the
code from or import the code from the
old repository into this new repository
Jovian careers responsive life and I'm
going to click begin
import okay now this is going to take a
couple of minutes to maybe import the
entire code depending on how much code
you have in your repository all right
and once we have this we will be able to
now see our new repository and make
changes there without affecting the old
one okay so our import is now complete
so let's open it up and I can close the
old repository so now I have a new
repository with my starter code all in
place without affecting the old one okay
all right so that's what we just did we
created a duplicate of a GitHub
repository by creating an empty
repository not including a readme g
ignorer license pressing the import code
button and providing the URL of the
starter code okay now of course as I
mentioned if you are on somebody else's
repository you can do all of this very
quickly using the for button so you can
see that there is a fork button here
which is disabled for me because this is
my own repository but will be available
for you when you need to okay the next
thing we'll do is we will also deploy
our new repository to verel so I'm just
going to open up wor.com and worel as we
know is a deployment platform that has
good integration with GitHub and once
you're logged in on worel I'm going to
add a new project so I'm going to say
add new project project and if versel is
not already connected to my GitHub then
it will ask me permission to access my
public and private GitHub repositories
which I have already granted so here I
can see on worel that I can I have the
option to import the git repository
Jovan careers responsive life so let me
just go ahead and import that and that
is going to create a project and I'm
going to use a framework preset other
because I'm not using any framework it
is just a static site with some HTML and
CSS and then I'm just going to click
edit and I'm going to go into SRC
because I don't want the entire folder
to be deployed I don't want the entire
repository to be deployed you can see
here I simply want the SRC folder to be
deployed because that is where my
index.html file or my default web page
is present okay so I'm just going to
select the SRC folder and click continue
and then I'm going to click deploy and
just like that in just a few seconds the
reposit will get deployed and I will
have my new website Jovian careers
live Jovian careers responsive
live let me see I can just continue to
dashboard and now I have my new project
Jovian careers responsive live dovel DOA
okay so now the repository is completely
deployed to worel and any changes that
we make will now be affecting this new
site okay perfect so that's our basic
setup in place so that's good to go now
let us come back here and also open up
this code using GitHub code spaces so
that we can actually start writing some
code and start editing things so I'm
going to click on code and here now I
can create a new code space on Main and
remember a codespace is a local machine
for us on the cloud given by GitHub
associated with this repository and
we'll be able to write our code in that
code space machine so let's click create
codespace on Main and by the way if this
button is disabled you may have to go
ahead and delete some older Cod spaces
so you can go to github.com /c
codespaces and I think GitHub provides
two code spaces for free so you may have
to go in and maybe delete an older code
space so you can just go to an older Cod
space and click delete and that's going
to delete your old code space so that
you can
now reload this page and actually access
this button okay so you can have at Le
only two free Cod spaces otherwise you
can pay and you can get unlimited number
of them but free should be fine you can
just delete code spaces when you need
Okay so let's click code and then let us
click create codespace on mean and let
me bring this over here now what this is
going to do is open up a machine on the
cloud get the code from the repository
and give me a browser based interface of
Visual Studio code to edit and test and
develop the code from this repository
okay so GitHub is for storing the code
Visual Studio code code spaces is for
actually developing the code and then I
can take my changes and push them back
either onto the main branch or I can use
the GitHub collaboration workflow where
I can create a full request and get that
reviewed and so on okay all right so
looks like our code
spaces system is now open and ready for
development so I'm just zooming it in a
little bit so you can see that this is a
visual studio code interface and let me
just close
that now here we already have the
repository the root file of the
repository open you can see that we have
an SRC folder we have get ignore license
readme all of these were imported in
from the original repository I can open
up the SRC folder and open
index.html and here in the index.html
file I can see the entire code for my
website Jovian cers so you can see that
we have a head we have an HTML tag
inside which we have a head tag in the
head tag we have a bunch of meta tags to
set how this page previews when we share
it online we also set for example the
title and the fave icon of the page then
we have the body tag and in the body we
have the nav bar and this is the nav bar
we have a banner image this is the
banner image we have a header we have an
about section with an image and some
description then we have a table here
the table contains the employment
opportunities then we have some a form
here an HTML form and that form makes a
submission to form bold which is an
external service that we using for form
submissions and finally we have a footer
here which is the footer right over here
okay and of course we have all of the
Styles here captured in styles.css so
each section has it has its own various
set of styles which is what we have
captured in styles.css so there are some
basic styles for HTML body H1 H2 Etc and
then there are sectionwise styles for
each section and then the subsections
inside those section and so on okay and
we have certain images as well which we
are incorporating within the page and of
course we have uh we are connecting the
styles with the main page using the link
here the link r equal to stylesheet plus
we're also using some external fonts
from Google apis from Google fonts okay
so this is the basic setup that we've
explored so far all right so now we've
looked at how to deploy to the cloud
using verel we've looked at how to start
development with GitHub Cod spaces now
let's talk a little bit about responsive
web design responsive design is an
approach that ensures that websites
adapt gracefully to any screen size any
device and any orientation and that is
the purpose here is basically to
optimize the user experience by making
the content visually appealing and
easily readable and accessible okay now
responsive design starts from the user
interface design so even before you have
started coding the page user interface
designers will often create design
mockups in three to four sizes depending
on the available screen width so they
will create a mobile design so let's say
they're designing a website they will
first create a mobile design and in the
mobile design everything just goes top
to bottom you generally don't don't have
a lot of things side by side because the
limit on the because the screen width is
very limited and in fact just as a
common practice something around 576
pixels and below is considered a Mobile
screen just for reference so typically
you will get a mobile design which is
about which is something under 576
pixels in
width then they will often give you a
tablet design now the tablet design will
have maybe two columns in certain places
in certain places it will still have one
column so certain things you have
slightly more space horizontally on a
tablet and that's why there might be a
slight change you can see that these two
sections were brought in here on the
side on a tablet screen and typically
tablet screens are about 550 to 750
pixels and then you have desktop screens
desktop screens are screens that are
bigger than 768 pixels so this is where
you have a lot more space this is where
maybe you can use three columns this is
where maybe you can have more space on
the left and right and finally
optionally sometimes you will find a a
layout for large desktops so often now
as we are getting to bigger and bigger
screens like 4K screens and 8K screens
and so on we have the opportunity to use
a lot of leave a lot of blank space on
the left and right so sometimes
especially if your website is going to
be viewed by people primarily on the
desktop you may get a fourth mockup or a
fourth design for very large desktops
okay and typically this refers to
desktops with a screen width of greater
than 992 pixels if you don't get a
design like this this then you should
just take the hint that you should take
the desktop layout and just limit its
withd so that the content remains
centered on the page instead of
completely spreading left to right
making it hard to read okay so your
designer will often give you three
separate layouts at least and sometimes
even four or sometimes you may just get
two layouts one for mobile and one for
desktop and you may have to guess what
the tablet layout looks like okay now
the specific wids at which these design
changes are made where the design
changes significantly are called Break
points because the previous design
breaks at the at that point and a new
design takes over from there okay so the
break point for mobile screens is 576
pixels beyond that it's the tablet
screen and then the breako for desktop
screens is at 768 pixels beyond that it
is
a beyond that it is a a large yeah
beyond that it is a desktop screen so
the break point or the highest break
point for tablet screens is 768 pixels
and beyond that it is a desktop screen
screen and then sometimes Beyond 900
pixels or so it is a large desktop
screens now these numbers are not set in
stone these are just some common values
but different sites different Frameworks
that we use for CSS have different
values but these are just some of the
more standard ones
okay now your role as a web developer is
to implement layout changes at specific
breakpoints while ensuring that the page
adapts gracefully at all intermediate
screen wids okay and that is what we're
going to learn today now one important
thing to keep in mind whenever you're
trying to make a website responsive is
that to make a to implement a responsive
web design you must include this
following meta tag within the head tag
of your web page so this there's this
meta tag with the name viewport and it
has the content width device width and
initial scale equal to one or sometimes
this is written as 1.0 and you have to
take this and you have to put this
inside the HTML head tag of your HTML
page okay now in this case I already
have it meta viewport let me zoom in
here
slightly yeah you can see here I have
the tag meta viewport with Device width
initial scale
1.0 why is this important well back when
mobile Mobile smartphones just came out
there were no designs that were
optimized for mobile screens so there
were certain tricks that were employed
by mobile devices to zoom in and somehow
scale and make the text more visible
nowadays those tricks are no longer
required because developers Implement
responsive designs so that's why to
indicate to your browser to indicate to
the device that please don't apply any
tricks to make the content look good on
mobile I will handle it myself you
include this meta tag okay so all you
need to know is whenever you're making
your design responsive make sure that
you have this meta tag included in your
design
okay so one good way to build your
responsive design skill skills is just
by checking out some examples of
responsive design so here's one you can
check out a bunch of examples here so
here is one
dropbox the homepage for Dropbox is a
good example where this is the mobile
view this is the tablet View and this is
the desktop view which also contains a
form here's here's another one this is
dribble it shows images so here you can
see that on mobile it shows two images
side by side on desktop it shows four
five images side by side and then a
tablet it's somewhere in between GitHub
is another example that there is often
you will find this pattern that in the
desktop layout there is space on the
left and right there is possibly a form
in somewhere on the right and then in
tablet the form comes in the center and
on mobile the form can go away Al
together okay and there are a bunch of
other examples that you can check out as
well similarly there are again some more
examples here for you to check out so
whenever you're trying to make your
website responsive it's useful to look
at how other websites are doing it you
can see here examples of uh design Modo
so they have this layout for mobile
tablet and desktop you can see this
architecture site they have a different
layout for T desktop tablet and mobile
and here's another one this seems to be
like a personal website so to become a
good web developer you have to go and
explore what other people are doing
there are no ground rules there are no
set rules for responsive design in in
fact these Trends are constantly
emerging so just explore and pick
whatever you feel is working
well now how do you develop a responsive
websites so you can inspect how a
website looks on mobile by simulating
other devices within your browsers
developer tools so that you don't
actually have to go and open that
website on your mobile each time you
want to test it that's a good idea you
should always do a final device test but
you can just do that within your browser
itself let me let me show you an example
let us open up
this let us open up this Jo Jovian
career site and let me just zoom back to
100% so this is what the career site
looks like on desktop if I right click
and I select
inspect now that open opens up these
developer tools and I can just put these
developer tools on the right so there's
this button here on the corner this
three dots button and I just click this
three dots button and dock the developer
tools to the right okay so now my
developer tools are on the right side
it's exactly the same but I'll show you
in a second why putting it on the right
head and now there is this button over
here and I'll just zoom in and show you
so this button is called toggle device
toolbar so if you just press this button
now suddenly
your browser turns into a mobile device
and you can go in and select a specific
device as well let's say let me select
iPhone
10r so this is iPhone 10r and this is
what my mobile and this is what my and
this is what my website is going to look
like on iPhone 10r okay I can even check
that the screen width here is 414
pixels let me just zoom in there a
little bit so the screen width here is
414 pixels so that tells me that this is
an iPhone 10r or I can even just select
the option responsive and I can just
vary the width of the screen and see how
my website changes normally you will not
be viewing a website on under 360 pixels
so normally you might want to start
around 360 pixels and just vary the
width of your screen slightly and see
how the website looks as you increase
the width okay so this is a great idea
this is a good way for you to inspect
how things are going you can see that
definitely there's a big problem here
the table doesn't look good at all
on mobile and it starts to look a little
better when we go into tablet or maybe
even desktop screen okay and one good
idea for you would be to open up
developer tools on your browser turn on
device mode and see how various pages
and websites look with different device
vids you can check out Jovian so let's
check out jan.com our
homepage let's start with mobile this is
what it looks like on mobile so on
mobile we just have this text we have
this explanation here we have these two
things and you can see that the text is
centered on mobile and we have this logo
cloud and then we have a form below it
and then we have all of these benefits
that are shown one below the other as we
go on a tablet screen you can see now
that the text is still centered and but
now we've put a maximum width for the
logo Cloud we've put a maximum width
we've added space around the form and
now we showing two of the benefits on
the same row as we go further let's go
onto a desktop screen so now we've gone
beyond the 900 pixels or so which is a a
desktop screen or a large screen and now
you can see here that we have a bunch of
options here in the nav bar then we have
left text and we have a form here and
then we have now all four benefits
listed on the same page on the same row
and of course there are similar changes
that are there on each section as well
you can see here intensive programs here
goes one in each row instead of two of
two per row okay you can see that okay
maybe this is something we need to fix
so looks like like in the pricing div we
haven't taken care of spacing and this
is what happens when you are building
responsive websites there will be slight
cases here and there a certain place
where you've not thought about how
things should look and you'll have to go
and fix it and that is why it's
important to check across the entire
range of fits okay let's check another
one NY times.com so this is what the New
York Times looks like on mobile you have
a very little space on mobile that's why
there's just this title and then there
is this nav bar and we'll touch on how
to show these NAB bars at a later point
and then there is just this date and
there's the sale offer going on then
there is just one story and then another
story below it and so on but as you
start to increase the width you can see
that now we go from one story to
multiple stories and we also get this
second bar here which opens up a bunch
of categories and we also get something
here on top we also get maybe a login
button and all so things change
significantly based on the screen that
we on right and you can see now we go
into three column layout when three
columns are available so a lot of time
is spent by designers deciding where
exactly to change the layout what the
break point should be and what the
structure should be for the site and
really this is where a lot of the time
is spent just fine-tuning small things
and testing things carefully okay so I
encourage you to maybe explore a few
more sites and see how they work now
certain websites redirect to a
completely different page when you try
to access them on mobile for example if
you were to open Gmail on mobile it will
redirect to a slightly different page or
show a completely different
design that was a common practice
earlier but now that there are many
tools to or many techniques to build
completely responsive layouts it's not
recommended any longer so try to find
some websites which follow this outdated
pattern and avoid it when you are
building websites instead what you
should do is build something called a
take something called a mobile first
approach which is what we look at today
let's talk about CSS media
queries CSS media queries are a powerful
tool that allow you to apply different
styles to your web page based on device
characteristics such as screen size
resolution and
orientation and here is the basic
structure of a media query you say at
media and then you specify a media type
and then you specify a condition and you
can have one or more conditions and then
you open up these brackets and inside
these brackets the CSS rules that you
write will only apply when you are
looking at this particular media type
and you're looking at this particular
condition okay now when you're working
with responsive web design the media
type is almost always going to be screen
so there are three types of media there
is the screen and then there is print
and there is all now print is used the
print media type is used when you try to
print a page or export it as PDF which
is not something we're going to look at
today so in our case the media type is
almost always going to be screen or it
can even be all and the condition is
something that you can set based on the
width of the screen or the orientation
of the screen or there are a bunch of
other properties that you can use so
here is an
example let's say we want to change the
background of the body when the screen
width is at least 768 pixels let's say
on mobile screens we want to have a
separate background and then on on large
screens or desktop screens we want to
have a separate background so here is
how we might do it we can say at media
and then we can say screen because we
only want to affect the screen layout
not the print layout and then we can say
and and now we can specify a condition
Min width is 768 pixels so when the
minimum width of the browser is 768
pixels then we can specify that the body
should have a background color of light
blue okay so let me just copy that and
and let me put that into my CSS file so
here I am in my CSS file and right maybe
right below here the main body
declaration I'm going to add this at
media screen and minan
width 768 pixels that means at a minimum
width of 768 pixels when the condition
holds true for the body I want the
background color to will be light blue
okay all right now I need a way to
actually preview the changes that I just
made what I'm looking at here on the
left is the deployed website but I'm
making changes in my GitHub code space
so what I need to do is I need to launch
this GitHub
codespace this index.html file in a
preview and remember for preview we
actually use an extension called live
preview because our codespace is a
system somewhere on the cloud
and we need to now view the HTML code in
our browser as a web page and for that
we can use this live server extension
okay so let us open up the live server
extension so search for live server by
ritwick day and click install and code
spaces and again all of this is covered
in the previous tutorial so you should
review that in case this doesn't make
sense and now let's come back into
index.html and let us right click on
index.html and click click open with
live
server okay so now what this is doing is
this is going to set up a simple server
which is going to serve the file for us
so that we can now view it in our
browser and let me just bring that and
put that here on the left let's bring
this back here on the
right okay so now I have this styles.
CSS and I've mentioned here that
whenever the screen width is more than
768 pixels my body should get a light
blue background clearly it has gotten a
light blue background which is not
looking good but it demonstrates what
we're looking for but let me go in here
and let me also click inspect and let me
just reduce the width of the screen let
me reduce it down to maybe an iPhone 10r
you can see that when I'm viewing the
same page on a mobile
device on the mobile device it is still
has a white background but on this
device over here it has a blue
background and you can see the exact
change happens at 768 pixels so as I
increase you can see that just before
768 pixels it is still white but at 768
pixels it turns blue okay so you can do
all sorts of things like that let me
change another thing Let Me Maybe set
the body font size to 10 pixels or 2 20
pixels let's just make it 24 pixels so
that the font size also changes
drastically so here you can see that I
have below 768 pixels and then as soon
as I cross 768 pixels the body font size
should
change
well okay it didn't I just need to
reload the page
maybe yeah maybe if I just remove this
it might
change well it doesn't seem to be
changing right now but but it will uh
depending maybe I just have to like set
the uh properties properly but you can
set any property here and the font size
can change significantly for that
particular tag and or for that
particular selector based on what
property you set here okay so for now
I'm just going to revert it and Below
768 pixels the background is white above
768 pixels the background is blue okay
so that is how you use media queries and
let me just get rid of this for
now but one other thing you can do is
also combine a bunch of conditions so
you can say something like this that you
want a particular CSS rule to apply only
between Min width of 600 pixels and Max
width of 1024 pixels so at 600 pixels
you want it to start and that same set
of rules you want them to end at 10 to 4
pixels you can imagine how using this
you can set up maybe one layout for
under 400 pixels one for 400 to 600 one
for 600 to 800 and so on all right let's
look at an example of this let me just
take this and let me put it in here now
I'm going to put a couple of layouts I'm
going to say that at let me just make it
400 and 8 600 pixels just so that we can
actually view the changes very
easily now what I'm seeing is that under
400 pixels I have a white background and
then as soon as I touch 400 pixels the
background turns blue but as soon as I
cross 600 pixels the background turns
white again okay so do you see what's
happening you can combine multiple
conditions like this and you can also do
something like this let's say I want to
only have a condition for Max width so
then I want to say that only under 600
pixels the color is blue and over 600
pixels the color is going to be white so
as long as this condition or all
conditions are satisfied these CSS rules
apply and I don't just have to put body
here I can maybe put change the H1 color
change the H1 size here I can put maybe
change some other size here as well so I
have all those controls that I can
modify
okay now of course you don't only have
to look at the screen size you can also
use the orientation so let's say you
want to use a certain font size only in
a certain orientation you can do that
too let us maybe try that so only in the
landscape orientation we want the light
blue color so
orientation landscape
and the orientation is also orientation
is also piece of information that is
sent by the browser itself so let us go
to iPhone 10r and let us change the
orientation here so there's a button
here you can see that there's a button
right here to change the orientation you
can see that now this is in landscape
orientation and in the landscape
orientation it has a blue background and
I can change it back to the portrait
orientation or the vertical orientation
and in this case it does not have the
blue background right so
let's bring that back and let us get rid
of this so that is how media queries
allow you to change the layout of a page
at various breakpoints and that is what
we're going to use today okay you can
combine multiple conditions and you can
check out some information about media
queries here but we've covered the most
common use case you'll be using the
screen media type and you will be using
maybe the max width or Min width to set
break points specifically as we said
earlier break points are the points at
which Your Design changes to adapt
different screen sizes based on the
designs that your UI designer have has
given you you may have to set some break
points and these are generally set on
some common device screen widths so
media queries can be used to set
breakpoints and apply CSS rules for each
layout for example if you want to write
completely separate CSS for mobile
tablet laptop desktop and large desktop
screens you may do something like this
you may have one section in your CSS
file which only deals with Mobile screen
so you may say media screen and Max
width 576 so under 576 screen width all
these rules are going to get applied
okay then you may have maybe another
media query here called media screen and
M width has 576 pixels and Max width has
768 pixels so between 576 pixels and at
maximum width of 768 pixels so between
these two wids
all the all these CSS rules will get
applied and then you may have maybe
another one between 768 and 992 and you
may have another one between 992 and
1200 and maybe you may have one for 1200
and higher right so depending on how
many break points you've decided on for
your website you can set up these Min
and Max conditions and then you can
write completely separate rules for each
of these okay so this is one way you can
go about doing things but a slightly
better way is what is called mobile
first design so the way you should be
building most web pages today is by
starting out with a mobile design so
first you should just design your web
page or build your web page for mobile
and then slowly enhance that same web
page to make it look good on uh on a
tablet and on a desktop screen and maybe
on a large desktop screen as well right
so in a mobile first design the base CSS
styles are for mobile devices so you do
not have a media query for the mobile
devices you just write all the base CSS
Styles and apply that to mobile devices
and then media queries are used to
progressively enhance the design for
larger screens right so what you're
basically trying to do is you're going
to implement this design first and then
slowly you are going to add a break
point and then at a certain break point
you're going to maybe make you're going
to maybe change this layout and maybe
shift to a two column layout then slowly
you're going to add another break point
and at that particular breakpoint you're
going to add a bunch of these categories
and you're going to shift to a three
column layout and so on all right so
that is what we're going to do we're
going to start with the base Styles and
then you can have whatever new Styles
you want to introduce for tablets you
can simply say media screen and Min
width 576 so you're telling the browser
only for screens with more than 576
pixels apply these new CSS rules and
some of these CSS rules will override
the old CSS rules that have been set in
the base Styles so that that's how media
queries are more selective so they can
overwrite the existing
Styles and then we have similarly these
a next set of uh a next set of rules Min
with 768 and these rules are going to
override the rules that have been
created in these and these so they also
follow the order and they follow the
specificity that is how CSS works so all
these rules are going to override the
previous rules that you have set and
then you can similarly have maybe
another where you can say media screen
and M with 99 2 so only when the screen
width crosses 992 these new rules will
get applied only a selective set of
rules and they will override any rules
that have been previously applied okay
this way you don't have to repeat a lot
of CSS for every screen rather you can
sty you can start with the mobile design
and you can just add a few properties
here and there to make the website look
nicer on tablet and this is a great
approach because if you start out with
the desktop layout and you try to
compress it down to mobile you're going
to face a lot of difficulty rather if
you start out with the mobile layout
often the tablet and desktop layout will
simply either have more information or
rearrange some of the things in a into
multiple columns and that is easier to
achieve rather than taking more
information and compressing it down into
one column okay so even as a designer
you should always start from the mobile
layout and then slowly build out the
desktop
layout so by removing the max with
condition for the first breakpoint and
using only minwidth queries for the rest
we ensure that the base Styles apply to
mobile devices only
and then they apply to all devices
further as well but progressively we
also enhance the design as the screen
size increases okay so try experimenting
with this try setting up some of these
break points in the CSS file and
experimenting with this to make changes
to the careers Jan careers website make
it more responsive and observe how the
mobile first approach is different from
the previous approach where you have
different set of styles between each set
of break points okay
all right so one other thing we need to
cover before we go ahead and actually
implement the mobile design is something
called the CSS flexbox layout because
it's not just that you're going to
change the layout at certain break
points between those break points as
well sometimes you will have to make the
layout a little more fluid so that
things go from maybe two columns to
three columns or maybe the sizes of
things increase and decrease and maybe
you add space on the left and right so
to handle these kind of fluid layouts
CSS has something called flexbox and
this is something that was added to CSS
about 15 years ago U about 14 about 12
years ago to be exact so this this is
something that was added to CSS about 12
or 13 years ago when mobile layouts
became more common when mobiles mobile
phones became more common to allow for
creating fluid layouts that can be
flexible and that can grow and that can
automatically shift into multiple
columns Etc and as required okay so
we're going to look at the CSS flexbox
setup we're going to learn a little bit
about flexbox it's not a detailed
flexbox tutorial we're going to learn
the most common flexbox properties and
it is a versatile method for arranging
elements within a container in a
flexible and adaptive Manner and it
simplifies complex layouts making it
making it easy to achieve responsive
designs and accommodate of varying
accommodate wearing content sizes now
the flexbox layout can be applied to an
HTML element by modifying the CSS
display property and it was added to CSS
in 2010 and it was implemented by most
browsers in the early
2010s and the CSS display property this
is something that we've already seen
here it determines how an element is
displayed on a web page so just to give
you an example I'm going to first just
create a new file
called display.
HTML and in this file display. HTML I'm
going to create a bunch
of HS so let me just put in
body and in the body let me put in a
bunch of
divs let's create a div called item
one item two item three and item four
okay and let us open up this page using
the live server so let us right click
and say open with live server
and we'll open it up
here right any the way to open up any
page in live server is by simply write
clicking and selecting open with live
server okay and you can see that we have
a bunch of these divs here and I'm just
going to set the display property for
each of these divs so first I am going
to set the display property for item one
so let me just give it the ID item
one and let me give this the ID
item
two let's go ahead and give
them item
three and item
four yeah so you have a bunch of items
here and let us go ahead and set the
display property for item one to display
block okay and let's put that inside a
style
tag
so that is how we are applying CSS so
there is no change when we set the
display of item one to display
block what happens if we change the
display of item one to
display in line let's actually add a
border around item one so that we can
get a better
sense yeah you can see here that when
you have display block which is the
default value item one takes up the
entire width of the screen instead if we
said display in
line you can see that now item one does
not take up the entire width of the
screen and in fact it will show up in
line with other things that are also in
line so let me just go ahead and for
item two as well let me add a border 1
PX
solid red and let me set the
display to inline as
well okay and you can see here that item
one and item two both show up on the
same line because they are set to inline
so display in line does not take up the
entire width and allows a particular div
to get embedded in line within some text
or within other inline items but if
either of these was
block you can see that that no longer is
true all right so that is display in
line and then there is something called
display inline block which I will leave
to you as an exercise so I'll let you
figure that out what that do and how
that's different from display in line
then there is something called display
none I can say item two or item
three display
none now it just disappears so when you
don't want to show a particular div and
we'll see an example of this later today
then you just set display none now the
final property that we are going to
study which is what triggers the flexbox
layout is the display Flex property okay
so we're going to come back and we're
going to take a a closer look at the
display Flex property is which is what
makes a particular div a flex container
and allows its children to be lay out
laid out as flexible boxes okay very
important we're going to look at that in
just a second but there are also several
other display options so I encourage you
to check out the other display options
as well and I encourage you to also
maybe try out this excise which goes
into the various options that you have
for the display property but these are
the most common ones that will use
display block inline flex and possibly
none okay so with that let's close this
let us talk about
flexbox now the first key thing you want
to understand about the flexbox layout
is that it works with containers and
items so you always have an outer div
which is a parent or a container on
which you set the display Flex property
and then you have the items and the
items are then laid out in a flexible
fashion based on a bunch of CSS
properties that you set okay so the
display Flex property when applied to a
container or a parent component causes
the items or children to be arranged
using the CSS flexbox layout and the
arrangement can be controlled using
various container level and child level
properties as we will discuss in just a
second so let's go ahead and create a
new file called flexbox HTML I'm going
to right click here and create a new
file called flexbox
HTML into this file Flex flexbox HTML
I'm going to add a bunch of HTML and CSS
code to set things up let me also open
it up quickly in the live preview so
open with live server let us open it up
over
here and let us come back and let us set
up the code for this I'm just going to
copy this code and paste it in here and
we'll just walk through the code and
then start studying a bunch of
okay so this is what our content
currently looks like we have a box so we
have a div we have a div with the ID
container over here and then inside that
div we have four divs one called item
one another called item two another
called item three and another called
item four so we have these we have this
container div that's clear the container
div has four item divs and each item div
has the ID item one item two item three
item four respectively and all of the
item divs have the class item okay and
let us look at the CSS so so far we've
not used Flex box flexbox at all for the
container we have set a background color
of coral you can see that it has this
orangish background color and then we've
also given it a background one pixel
solid black background a border of one
pixel solid black we have also just set
a font family so that the font the text
is a little easier to read and finally
we have given it a padding of 10 pixels
so you can see that there is a 10 pixel
padding inside the border and then there
is a Content inside it okay so far we've
not modified the display property then
we have the item for each item and again
this is the class item not individual
items so we have specified the class
item for each item we're not using the
IDS just yet we have again set a border
of one pixel we have set a padding so
you can see that there is some space
around the text and finally we've set a
background of cornflower blue that is
the blue that you are seeing now let us
slowly start turning this into a flex
container so always the flex display
properties set on the container okay so
we say display
flex and I'm going to hit save and now
you can see suddenly that all the items
are now laid out in a horizontal fashion
okay so you set the display property on
the
container on the container you set the
display property and that causes the
items to be laid out according to the
settings the default settings of a flex
box okay so the first thing that we can
change is the direction in which things
are laid out and that is done using the
flex Direction property and the flex
Direction property has four values it
has the row value it has the row reverse
value it has the column value and the
column reverse value okay so let us take
a look again all of these properties are
first set on the container and for each
property we also have an example of
whether it is set on the parent which is
the container or the child so Flex
direction is specified in the parent so
we say Flex Direction
row and that doesn't change anything
because Flex Direction row is the
default value but we could also say Flex
Direction row
reverse and now you can see that the
items are laid out not from left to
right but from right to left so you have
item one item two item three and item
four laid out from right to left okay
they're still logically they're still in
this order but they're just laid out
from right right to left and this is
where you can use flex box to maybe do
some right to left layouts okay let's
check Flex Direction
column okay Flex Direction column as you
might expect lays things out in a column
format which is pretty similar to
display block but except you are setting
that this is a column on the parent and
on the container not on individual items
okay so fle and of course you'll be able
to set a lot of other properties as well
so this is flex Direction column and let
me just increase the height of
this so that I can show you clearly
that the way things Stack Up is at the
top okay so Flex Direction column is top
to bottom you can also do Flex Direction
column
reverse and that will send things from
the bottom to top you can see item one
above that item two item three and item
four so that is how you can lay things
out Flex Direction row is left to right
Flex Direction row reverse is right to
left column is top to bottom reverse
column reverses bottom to top okay these
are the four values you can set for the
flex Direction property and with flexbox
spe specifically I would highly
recommend that you practice this that
you check out if you have a question
what happens if I do X then just go
ahead and try it out and maybe set
proper Heights and widths you can use
the starting code that we've provided
here and experiment and understand and
improve your understanding okay all
right so that's fine now the next thing
is to check what happens if you have
maybe data that is not going to fix
within the given width of the container
so now we have a container and now for
this container we have a bunch of items
and all these items seem to be fitting
just fine well what happens if we had
more items let's say if we
had item
567 right so item 567 clearly you can
see what happens is first they try to
compress to fit within but if they
cannot go beyond a particular width then
they just go out then they just fall out
now when they do fall out what do you do
another another condition that could
come up here is let's say our left and
right padding was actually higher it
specified a 30 pixel padding left and
right what are you going to do here now
these these all seem to be overflowing
these all seem to be going outside the
box here and that is where you can
specify a flex wrap properly you can say
Flex wrap and the default value is no
WRA and again this has to be set on the
parent and it specifies whether the
container whether the children should be
be wrapped which means they should go on
the next line or not no wrap simply
means that you want everything to show
up on the same line even if it exceeds
the width of the container the other
option is to say
wrap in which case this is what happens
it takes item 1 2 3 and then it when as
soon as it finds a child element that
cannot fit without exceeding the width
of the container it wraps onto the next
line so we have 5 six 7 you can also do
Wrap reverse and the idea here is that
it s not onto the next line but onto the
previous line so you can say 1 2 3 and
then it goes 4 5 6 and 7 okay and notice
this is different from row reverse so if
you did row reverse and you can check
this
out it would now go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 all
right so keep that in mind that you have
a reversal on the row level you have a
reversal possibly on the column level
and then you can do that reversal on the
wrap level as well whether you want the
lines to go up or you want the lines to
go down
okay so that is your that is the flex
wrap property so you can of course just
use no wrap which is what just uses this
and then you have wrap and wrap
reverse can experiment with this and
you'll get a better understanding now
the next set of properties which are
around justification and Alignment
determine how Flex items are positioned
within a container so these options
provide control over the distribution of
items along the main axis so the main
axis let's say if it is a flex row then
the main axis is the horizontal axis and
the secondary axis is the uh is the
vertical axis but if the flex direction
is column then the main axis is a
vertical axis and the secondary axis is
a horizontal axis okay so we'll just
talk about it's also called the cross
axis so justification is controlled
along the the main axis that is done
using something called justify content
and then alignment around is controlled
along the cross AIS okay and I know this
seems confusing this is probably the
most confusing part of flexbox but with
some practice you'll get used to it so
let's look at justify content now here
is how justify content Works let's say
you have a flex container with flex
Direction row and on that container if
you set justify content to flex start
then things will simply show up from
left to right okay if you set justify
content to Center then the items will
still show left to right but they will
be centered on the horizontal axis or on
the main axis right so what that means
is that all the items will be shown and
then space will be added on the left and
right on the other hand if you set Flex
end as justify content then the items
will just stick to the right you notice
they're still rendered left to right 1 2
3 but they are now sticking to the right
side instead of the left side and
similarly we have a bunch of other
options as well so let's take a look
let's get rid of some of these other
items so let's get rid of item four five
and 4 five 6 and
7 or just let's get rid of items 5 six
and 7 so I'm just commenting them out
and let us reduce the padding the
horizontal padding for each item so this
is how they look right now now I can get
rid of the wrapping for now as well now
let me just add justify content and
again it's on the parent and let me say
Flex start that's where they are they
are currently sticking to the start
which is the left right it's not saying
left it's saying start because if I had
row reverse then they would stick to the
right and if I had column they would
stick to the top so it's just start at
start of the axis whatever be the main
axis okay and now I could
say justify
content
Center and now you can see that they're
still laid out left to right but now
they are placed at the center and as I
change the width of the screen you can
see that they still remain right in the
center so anytime you want to
horizontally Center content within the
page just put an outer div give it the
display flex and then put in an inner
div um and give the outer div justify
content Center and that is going to
horizontally Center bunch of content on
the page very
straightforward okay next next let us
now do justify content Flex
end now you can see that they are laid
out at the end I
modify then there's another thing you
can use you can use space
between now what space between does is
there is of course this padding for now
let me just get rid of this padding so
that we can have a better understanding
of the space so when you use space
between then then space is added between
each item and they are laid out from the
left to the right with equal space
between them you can see here that as I
change the size of the page space is
added or removed between and all spaces
equal okay then you have space
around a space around is similar to
space between but what you do is you
take half of the space between and then
you add it on the left and the right end
as well okay so that is what space
around looks like you can see visually
that this space is about half of this
space and that is why I removed the
padding for now just so that we could
clearly see these effects finally there
is something called space evenly okay
now space evenly as you can guess what
it's doing is it's going to add the same
amount of space on the left Edge on the
right Edge and between items so slight
differences between space between space
around and space evenly depending on the
use case you can use one of these or
just do something else all together okay
but for now let me bring that back to
flex
start and we can also see this effect on
a flex Direction column so let's say we
have the direction column and let's say
we have a height of 250 PX
here you can see that these are now laid
out from the top I can do Flex
end
of course I can then do
Flex
Center and they are now centered so now
the main axis is the vertical axis and
in fact it starts from the top so the
start is the top end is the bottom and I
can do things like space around space
between as well so this is space between
that is flex Direction column so all of
these properties work for Flex Direction
row and
column okay of that height
all right so that is justify content
splex Start Center and space around
space between and space evenly and the
same thing works for the column as well
when you have a flex Direction column
this is how the justify content values
look very powerful property you will be
using this a lot to create more complex
layouts then we have align items so
justify content was along the main axis
so for FX row it was along the
horizontal axis for Flex column it's
along the vertical axis align items is
used to align things along the cross
axis okay so here is what that means
let's say you have align items on you're
setting align items on a parent where
the flex direction is row let's look at
an example of this let's just see this
live let's set the height to 250 pixels
again okay so the flex direction is row
and I want to set the Align items
property the default value is
stretch and you can see that as I
increase the height of this div from
whatever was the default height to 250
pixels everything stretched all of these
inner divs all of
these child divs they automatically
stretch to take up the full height or
the full space along the cross axis
which is the vertical axis because the
main axis is the horizontal axis but I
could also do Flex start so align items
Flex start so now along the cross Axis
or along the vertical axis things are
sticking to the start okay in the cross
axis this is the start and this is the
end so things are sticking to the start
I could also maybe just stick them to
the end so I can just say Flex end and
now they are sticking to the bottom
which is again the the main axis of the
primary axis is horizontal so along the
cross axis top to bottom they're at the
bottom or at the end I can also align
items Center of course and in which case
they are centered here along the cross
axis and notice how this is different
from justify content Center which is
going to Center them along the primary
Axis or the main axis right so here is
another trick if you just set align item
Center and justify content Center then
your content is centered vertically and
horizontally on the page right as you
increase or decrease the height it is
going to be centered vertically and it
is going to be centered horizontally as
well so let's say if this was 300 pixels
it would still be centered vertically if
this was 150 pixels it would still be
centered vertically so vertical
centering can be achieved by using Flex
Direction row and align item Center or
by using Flex Direction column and
justify content Center so there are both
ways to achieve it but that is how align
items and justify content play justify
content plays along the main axis align
items plays along the cross cross axis
um what other options do we have for
Align items well we have Flex start Flex
end Center we obviously we looked at
stretch which is the default
value that there's also another specific
align items property called
Baseline which looks quite similar to
start but here's the difference what
this does is this aligns the Baseline of
the text for each of the divs so if I
were to go in let's say if I were to go
in into item one
and change the font size to 10
pixels and if I were to go in into
item three and change the font size to
pixels this is what the content would
look like so notice what's happening
here because align items is set to
Baseline the line that runs through the
bottom of each line of text aligns
perfectly now this is very different
from
doing align items X
start which is going to just align
things right at the very top or even
doing something like align items
Center which is going to just align the
centers of the items and not the
Baseline so a very special case you
might not always need this but you can
align by the Baseline if you need to if
you have text of various sizes in a
bunch of flex items okay so those are
all the ways in which you can use align
items and let us revert that for
now and of course all of this works on
Flex Direction column as well so here we
have Flex Direction column let us
increase this height to 250
PX okay so here is flex Direction column
so now the primary or the main axis is
along the bottom along top to bottom so
the cross axis is left to right right
and now I could say Flex start to align
things on the left and by default of
course the value is stretch to align
things to take up the entire space on
the cross axis and of course I could
also have align items Center in which
case they will be horizontally centered
this time because the cross axis is the
horizontal axis and vertically they're
still right at the beginning so remember
that for justify content the default
value is flex start which is right at
the beginning but for Align items the
default value is stretch which is to
take up the entire space along the cross
axis and of course I can do X end here
as well and now along the cross axxis or
the horizontal axis they show up on the
right let's rever that so that
was align items okay so on this is what
it works on row this is how it works on
column I know it's starting to get
confusing practice and that is how
you'll get it and of course you can
always come back and refer to it you
don't have to remember all of this
perfectly okay just remember justify
content is along the main axis align
items is along the cross
axis now you also have this special
property called align self which can be
used to change the alignment of along
the cross axis of just a particular
child okay so now we're looking at
certain child level properties not the
parent level properties so let's
increase the height here once again
again height 250
pixels and by default everything has
align stretch and let me just go in here
and let me just set this to align item
Center for
now so by default all the Align all the
items are aligned along the center and
let me go in here into item
one and for item one let me just set
align align self so item one just by
itself should be aligned to the start so
Flex
start now align items item one goes
right right to the top at Flex start and
I can then I can then align maybe item
to align
self to flex end now I'm pushing item to
right to the very end of the Cross axis
remember we still on the flex Direction
row so the main axis is Row the cross
axis is top to bottom and we can of
course go ahead and for item three we
can use LINE
self
stretch and now item three is stretching
and item four can be aligned separately
as well so you you can have a global
setting for Align items and then you can
override it using align self for each
item as you need of course this works
not just for column not just for row but
also for column so here now what's
happening is that
we have this let me just get rid of the
default get rid of all these for now so
now we have the colum as the main axis
so along the horizontal axis we have set
to align items Center that's why they're
all centered then if we change the
setting for item
one you can see that item one goes to
the left because we are setting it to
flex start item two goes to the right
because we setting it a flex end so
along the cross axis which is left to
right it is going on the right right
item three is stretching and item four
is in the center which is the default
setting that has been put
in for the container okay so you can set
a property for the container and then
you can override it for these individual
items now that makes sense for Align
items doesn't make sense for justify
content and I'll let you think about why
okay for now let's get rid of
this and let us just go back
here to flex Direction row
okay so that is align self you can use
flex start or you can use flex end to
move it to the end of the Cross axis you
can Center it in the cross Axis or even
stretch it or even align it to the
Baseline you have all these options
available to
you
okay next up there are also a couple of
adjacent properties called align content
and justify items I will not cover them
here because they are not very commonly
used I have almost never used them maybe
once or twice but they are slightly
different from align items and justify
justify content so I will let you
explore these on your own so check out
the properties justify items and align
content as you can imagine they might do
alignment along the main axis and
justification along the cross axis so
you have those options as well and look
up some tutorials to understand how they
differ from justify content and align
items or if you don't want to get
confused us right now just skip these
all together and just use the default
justify content along the main axis and
align items along the cross axis but if
you want to you can experiment
okay so those are some justification and
Alignment properties so in most cases
you will be working with flex Direction
you will be working with flex wrap
you'll be working with the Align items
and justify content
properties and sometimes you will use
the Align self property on a particular
child but then there are also certain
Flex properties that you can set on
children specifically to control how the
various children take up space on the
page okay and we're going to look at all
of these properties they are called Flex
grow Flex shrink and flex basis and then
we are going to look at a shorthand
property so that you never actually have
to use all of these separate properties
but it's useful to understand what they
mean okay so the first property is the
Flex grow property now notice over here
if I get rid of the height notice that
these divs are not taking up the entire
space available these and let me just
have three divs for now let's get get
rid of the fourth div as
well yeah so notice that these divs are
not taking up the entire width on the
page now sometimes you might want in
maybe some kind of a sidebar layout
where you have a left sidebar right
sidebar and the middle item should grow
to take up as much space as POS possible
in such cases you can use the flex grow
property so when you have some free
space you can specify a flex grow
property and by default its value is set
to zero which means that you don't want
a a you don't want one of the children
to grow by default you only want each of
the children to take up as much space as
is
required to display all of its children
okay so for example right now to show
item one one this is the only amount of
space that is required but if let's say
the text here was item one item
one it would go it would take up twice
the space to show the to show the
content
right however if let's say I wanted item
two to take up all the space in between
and item three to shift completely to
the right then I could do something like
this I could
say for item
two I could say item
two Flex grow one now what I'm saying is
that item two should take up how much
ever space is available in
between and you can specify any positive
number here 1 2 3 4 and we'll talk about
what they mean but as soon as as soon as
you specify something other than zero
item 2 starts to grow to take up the
available space
okay now let's say I wanted to do
something slightly more complex let's
say what I wanted to do was item one
should take up maybe 30% of the space
item three should take up 30% of the
space and item four should item two
should take up 40% of the space so it
should always be if there is additional
space available it should go 30 40 30
okay and Let's do let's see how to do
that so the way I would do that is
simply by specifying those proportions
for each item so for item one let us say
Flex
grow to be three and these are
proportions so that's why I don't
necessarily need to write 30 40 30 these
are not percentages and item three will
also be Flex
grow now you can see this layout 3 43
and maybe just to make it a little more
pronounced you can look at maybe 2
2 and you can see that 20% of the space
is taken up by
item yeah 20% of the space is taken out
by item 1 20% by item three and you can
see that item two takes up about 60%
okay you can also do something like 1
1 4 they don't have to add up to 10 or
100 or anything it's just that now you
can see
that the out of the additional space
that is available 10% of the space is
taken by item 1 10% by item three and
the rest is taken by item two okay so
what you're specifying is among the
available additional space how much
space should be taken up by each item
how much additional space so these are
not exactly in that proportion these are
actually not exactly 1 is to 4 is to one
because the base size is not affected
and that is where we'll talk about Flex
bases slightly down the line okay but
grow
tells Flex grow determines a flex item's
ability to grow relative to other items
within a flex container allowing it to
expand and take up the available space
so what you can do is you can say that
out of all the additional space how
should that space be distributed to each
item and the by default it is zero so by
default the additional space does not go
to any item and as you start setting
values for each item then by those
proportions the space is distributed
okay so that is flex
grow next up we have something called
Flex
shrink okay now just as we have Flex
grow we have the flex shrink property
and the flex shrink property determines
a flex items ability to shrink relative
to other items within the flex container
allowing it to contract and fit the
available space so here is how it works
let me get rid of flex grow settings for
now let's just disable this disable this
this okay so now let's say we had too
much content here and we had to actually
shrink things how can I do that well let
me just add a bunch
of space here okay so now there is now
there is more space here and you can see
that the text is wrapping onto the next
line but if we wanted
to if you wanted to shrink things a
little bit then we would have to go in
and set the shrink property let me set
here Flex
shrink and by default things shrink
automatically so this is the default
value so you can see that they have
shrunk a little bit headily they should
have been like this but they have shrunk
a little bit they have shrunk a little
bit
because the the text has come onto the
next line so there's definitely some
shrinking that has happened right so
shrinking is happening by default and
they're going to shrink to their base
size and they're not going to shrink
beyond the base size by default but in
case I set Flex shrink to one for one of
them and then I set Flex shrink to
zero
for the others so I've set Flex string
to one and flex string to zero you can
now see that as I shrink
it item one shrinks which is the default
it tries to shrink so till it can no
longer shrink Till There is no till it
till the space of its children is
completely taken up but item two and
item three don't shrink because the
shrinking is
Con that's what happens and of course
you can then shrink in proportions as
well so let's say you set it up in such
a way that each of these are taking up
some additional space you have original
size original size here and you then
going to try to shrink them in a certain
proportion so item one is going to
shrink in a certain proportion item
three is going to shrink in a certain
proportion this will be clearer if we
have more content here so let me just
put some more content so that each of
these can shrink
independently okay now you can see that
item one has shrunk significantly
whereas item two and item three have not
shrunk at
all but let's say we want the shrinkage
to happen in a certain proportion so
then we could say that okay item one
should shrink in the proportion of one
item four two should shrink in the
proportion of three so it should shrink
3x and item three should also shrink
proportion one right you can now see
that right now item two is shrinking the
most whereas item one and item three are
shrinking the least so what we are
seeing here is that the decrease in size
has to be distributed in the ratio 1 is
to 3 is to 1 for the specific columns
okay so that is flex
shrink and then the
final the final property is flex bases
now the flex basis property
decides what is the initial main size of
a flex item before any available space
is distributed and by default the flex
basis is set to Auto which means that
the initial main size of each child is
determined by the item's own width and
height which is basically the width and
height of its content if it is not set
okay however you can also say that the
basis or the main size of a of a
particular item is zero so let's see
what happens when we do that let us
set Flex basis to zero for all of these
okay now when we set the flex bases to
zero what we saying is that there is no
basic size you can keep reducing the
size
and well I think I guess it's one
probably yeah so by default Flex bases
is set to Auto which means it takes up
its default size and then Flex basis of
zero says that there is no basis size
and it can shrink as much as possible so
in this casee you can see that item 1 2
3 are all shrinking as much as
possible because we've not set a basis
size so the basis size is just as low as
possible right so by default there's no
shrink there is no it is not going to
take up any additional space than the
minimum necessary space on the other
hand and when Flex basis is zero shrink
doesn't really make sense on the other
hand we can add Flex grow
and now what we're seeing is that they
can grow to take up the additional space
in the specified criteria so 1 is to 4
is to 4 to take up whatever additional
space is available Beyond a very basic
minimum space okay so the interplay of
flex basis Flex shrink and flex grow is
what decides what happens in the default
State what happens when you have more
space available what happens when you
have less space available okay
but however most of the time you don't
actually use these three properties you
just use a basic value or you just use a
simple Shand property called Flex okay
so here's what you can
do instead of saying Flex instead of
saying Flex grow Flex bases
Flex um shink Etc let's say I want the
ratios to be 2 4 and four at least the
ratio of the additional space and the
shrinkage I can just specify something
like this Flex 2 Flex 4 and flex Flex 2
and now things are automatically scaling
as I expect so there is the base size
that still applies the very basic
minimum base size so when you do Flex 2
Flex 4 flex two what that means is
you're saying that the flex grow value
is two the flex shrink value is two and
then the
flex value is or the flex basis value is
zero okay or the minimum possible space
so normally you'll just end up doing
this Flex 2 flexx 4 and Flex 2 or
setting some kind of a proportion
between these Flex
items and that is how you'll use it but
you have a bunch of different ways to
use the syntax you can just set a single
initial value you can set it to Auto you
can set it to none which will just use 0
0 for 0 0 for each and you can just use
a single value one value syntax like
Flex one which is going to set it to 1 1
0 or you can use a two value syntax
which is going to set it to one one and
then maybe a specific base size a fixed
base size or you can use a three value
syntax which is going to use a certain
percentage base size as well so you have
a bunch of ways to set the flex property
okay the most common use case of the
flex property is something that I want
to show you because Flex grow bases and
Shrink i' I almost never use them
because they're never layouts are never
that complicated that you need to use
all these properties but the most common
layout that I use is that one of these
needs to take up all the additional
space and the rest of them do not need
to take up the additional space so in
that case I would do something like this
I would just go in let me just reduce
the content a little
bit Yeah and let me reduce the padding
here a little bit as
well yeah so the most common use of the
flex property which is the flex grow
shrink and basis property is this you
want item two to take up all the space
in between no matter what the screen
width is so I would just go in into item
two and I would say Flex one and just by
doing that just by setting Flex one item
two takes up all the space in between
not just horizontally but this can
happen vertically as well so let's say
we have display flex and flex Direction
column and we have a
height of 150
PX or let's make that 250
PX yeah so you can see here now we are
taking up all the available space in
this Direction all right and similarly
one other use case you might have is
that I want item one and item two to
always have the same width so let me
just go back to flex Direction row and
let me just
set item
one f
one let me just set this to flex 5 or
something like a very high
value and item
three okay now you can see here that
more or less item one item three are
going to have similar wids and we don't
necessarily have to achieve it by
setting these Flex values we can also
just do these in this way we can just
say width
20% and width
60% and width
%. okay so this is the actual real use
case of the flex property or why we use
flexbox because we want to achieve a
certain set of wids this may be our main
content this may be our left content
this may be our right content all of
that of course when we using the flex
property under the hood it's it's using
Flex bases Flex grow Flex um shrink and
all that but I just use the flex
property directly okay so experiment
with the various options for Flex growth
Flex strength Flex bases but don't
stress if they don't make a lot of sense
because there are certain edge cases
certain special scenarios which you may
not be able to keep in your head you can
always just look them up the key is
maybe just to use the flex property and
try to get what you want and the most
common use case is either setting Flex
one to expand a certain div to take up
all space or using Flex one on a couple
of divs to maybe make them roughly equal
width
okay now flexbox has many applications
in all kinds of web design as you can
see for the New York Times website this
kind of a layout is achieved and made
responsive only using flexbox it is used
to create responsive layouts it is used
to create certain grid systems as well
there's a separate layout called The
Grid layout which we've not covered
today we'll maybe try and cover at some
point it is used to create equal height
columns let's say you want to have maybe
a bunch of uh cards showing side by side
all of those cards should have equal
height that is something that you can
create using flexbox it is used to
perform vertical centering let's say you
want to center a div vertically on the
page or vertically inside another div
the way you do it is simply by setting
Flex Direction columns justify content
Center or Flex Direction row align item
Center it is used for reordering
elements sometimes on mobile you want a
left to right a certain layout and on
desktop you want a reverse layout so
that's what you can use it for it is
used for maybe showing image and text
side by side it is used for creating
responsive forms let's say you have a
form where you have a first name last
name an example of this can be seen on
the Jovian
website so you can see that first name
and last name are side by side and then
again you have email and then we have
phone number and you have the country
code and phone number side by side and
then you have again the program so all
of this is achieved using
flexbox and it is used for ensuring
spacing an alignment making sure that
something takes up the entire space
making sure that two divs are the same
size and there are many tutorials you
can go through the more practice you get
with flexbox the better you will get at
it specifically I would highly recommend
the series of screencast by West boss
called what the flex box it goes into
each Flex property and then it shows you
a bunch of specific scenarios as well
and I would also highly recommend you to
check out 30 days of flexbox which is
again a series of tutorials that you can
follow along day by day and there is
just for reference there is this
complete guide to flexbox that you can
always check out this contains a bunch
of visuals and it contains information
about each property so that you don't
have to remember this I always look this
up I never remember this even after
using this for probably 10 plus years at
this point okay so it takes a while to
get used to things in flex boox but once
you do you can build pretty much any
layout that you can imagine
right so the last thing I'll say about
flexbox is that it's powerful but
because it is so powerful it is also
somewhat confusing it takes a while to
get used to it but don't give up don't
run away from flexbox just limit your
usage to basic Flex Direction Flex wrap
and align items and justify content and
maybe every now and then use the flex
property so so let's now go ahead and
redesign the Jovian Courier site so this
is what it looks like on desktop I think
it looks fine on desktop for now we
don't need to really redesign anything
here but we do want to redesign it on
mobile because on mobile it definitely
doesn't look good at all so we want to
do something with the mobile design and
we are going to follow these steps first
we going to create a separate branch on
our Cod space remember we don't want to
affect the main side when we are making
changes when we are experimenting so
we're going to create a separate branch
and test our changes there without
affecting the main side then we are
going to create separate wireframes for
mobile and desktop
screens then we are going to set up base
Styles and media queries for a mobile
first design then we're going to
implement each section first for mobile
and then for
desktop then we're going to test each
section at various widths and make
required
adjustments and finally we're going to
create a pull request we're going to
revie review that pull request review
the preview deployment and then merge it
back to the main site okay so our main
site which is
Jovian
careers
responsive Livewell DOA this is going to
remain unchanged till we merge our pull
request right so this is what the common
practice is that you have the main site
that is running then you create a branch
work on your feature and once the
feature is reviewed and tested and
merged back then this will automatically
get updated because versal will do an
automatic deployment for okay so this is
our main site we're not going to affect
that but this is our preview site which
we are looking at here let us just open
up
index.html with live server put that in
here so this is a preview site let me
just set it to default WID so this is
what it looks like on desktop this is
100% width let me just open the same
page up in in a couple of other browsers
as well and I'm just going to select
different devices in each case so here I
want to study its width on
the tablet let's say maybe a tablet
would be about 700
pixels the width a little bit
here yeah so about 750 pixels I believe
would be a tablet
layout and let us also create a mobile
layout here so we're going to look at a
mobile layout as well so let's maybe
design
around
3 maybe around 400 pixels that is what
most mobile layouts are around okay now
we have for our code space for our
index. HTML which is running using the
live server extension so this is all the
preview of what we are doing on our code
space we have the mobile layout here we
have the tablet layout here and we have
the desktop layout here and we're going
to start with the mobile layout we're
going to do a mobile first design and
then we're going to slowly improve that
layout to account for tablet and desktop
as well okay so we're going we going to
use these break points under 576 is
going 576 pixels is going to be a mobile
layout so this is about 400 that's
mobile under 768 pixels and above 576 is
going to be a tablet layout I believe
we've set this to
about yeah we've set this to about 7
let's set it to about
740 yeah so that's in our that's in the
tablet range and we can always go left
and right and we can shift things and
greater than 768 pixels is going to be a
desktop layout which is what this is and
of course we can also then consider
large desktops etc for now I'm simply
not considering
those okay so let's get started step by
step
slowly and before we proceed I would
encourage you as you are reviewing this
to pause take a few minutes to think
about how you would design the mobile
version of the jobian career site and
take inspiration from the examples that
we looked at earlier and maybe try to
create a wireframe for the mobile
version of the site on pen and paper or
using a digital whiteboard like excal
draw.com but here is a wireframe that we
are going to be using now typically a
design mockup that is given to you is
going to be given for mobile tablet and
desktop similarly we can try creating my
frames from mobile tablet and desktop
but just to keep things simple we just
going to create a mobile wireframe and a
desktop
wireframe excuse me we're going to keep
things simple use a mobile wireframe and
a desktop wireframe and for tablet we
will just approximate and maybe pick
some elements from the mobile and somee
elements from the desktop okay so for
the desktop view we are going to use the
same layout that we had earlier so which
is the Jovian logo here at the top with
the Jovian text then an image here the
about Jan section the job opportunities
table and the submit your application
form and then there is a footer at the
bottom with a bunch of options courses
programs and
YouTube for mobile here is what we are
going to do we are going to use a Navar
but in the nabar we're not going to show
the entire Jovian logo we're just going
to show the Jovian icon okay this is a
common practice on mobile that you often
just show the icon so I'll just show you
an example of this let's say I go to
jan.com
learn zoom in here a little bit and if I
go into the mobile view
here you can see that at this point we
only show the icon because we often have
a bunch of things on the right as well
this is the profile icon which also
happens to be the Jovan logo but yeah we
only show the icon on the mobile and we
also maybe change the layout slightly on
mobile as you can see on the Jovan
platform as well okay so on mobile we're
going to show the icon we are going to
show the image but we probably going to
reduce its height a little bit not to
ensure that not to take up the entire
page otherwise it might just take up a
lot of space then we are going to have
this about Jian section where we going
to have this description and we are
going to move the image below right so
the image is going to remain below and I
think I'll use the same layout for
tablet as well then we are going to have
job opportunities but this time for job
opportunities we are going to
use a list or maybe a bunch of divs so
we are going to show these cards instead
of actually showing a table because on
mobile viewing a table doesn't make
sense
but on desktop you're still going to use
a table so we're going to see how to
achieve that then we have this layout
for application so on mobile it's a nice
idea to maybe just make all your inputs
full width so just let them occupy the
full width of the screen and uh we have
this upload resume cover letter Button
as well and finally for the footer we
are simply going to show the options one
below the other unlike on desktop we are
going to show where we are going to show
the options side by side okay and we'll
decide how to change these layouts for
tablet as well but these are the two
layouts that we are working with okay
and specifically the job opportunities
table is going to be the real challenge
because it doesn't have a table layout
on mobile it has a list of
cards and I encourage you to go ahead
and replicate these wireframes on your
own wireframing is a very useful skill
for a web developer before you can go in
and start coding the website you should
have a very clear idea of how it's going
to look at the very least using these
rough
wireframes and as I've said before we
are going to follow a mobile first
design which means we're going to first
set up CSS styles for mobile section by
section and then we are going to enhance
the CSS styles for tablet and for
desktop and maybe even for smaller uh
for larger screens okay so for that here
is how we can begin we can begin by
commenting out all the existing CSS and
just rebuild the page right from scratch
and we'll just put in a bunch of media
queries at the beginning okay so first
let's comment out all the CSS let us
open up styles. CSS here let us comment
out all the CSS the way we'll do it is
by adding this
star/ star at the top and then adding a
star slash at the
bottom okay so you added SL star at the
top and star slash at the bottom and now
if we reload our Pages we can see that
all the all the CSS is gone completely
gone right so we have no Styles we're
starting from scratch same content but
no CSS this one image is looking really
big so I'm just going to give this image
a height explicitly in my index.html
file I'm going to go into this
index.html file and I'm going to scroll
down and find this image a team image
and I'm just going to give it a
height of
100 just so that it doesn't mess up the
ENT entire page when I'm setting things
up all right so now we are more or less
ready to begin we have this mobile
layout top to bottom content we have
this tablet layout and we have this
desktop layout all right now let us
first just bring in our media queries
that we are going to use for
each layout now the base Styles because
we using a mobile first layout the base
styles are just going to be added right
at the top without any media query
they're going to apply to all the
screens and then what we're going to do
is have this condition called whenever
the width of the screen exceeds 576
pixels then we want a certain set of CSS
rules to apply right so we are going to
then copy over this media query bring
that in and that is going to handle
tablets so more than 576 pixels that is
going to handle tablets notice that it's
going to apply about 576 and it's going
to continue applying unless further
overridden in a subsequent query okay
this way we can avoid a lot of
repetition instead of setting all the
properties for each particular
possibility okay then this is maybe
going to be the second media query that
we'll use which is for laptops or maybe
desktop screens proper
browsers so this is going to be medium
devices or MD which is going to be above
768 pixels and then there are also maybe
another couple of queries which we may
not use but let's just keep them around
what to do if it's even bigger if it's
bigger than 900 pixels and if it's even
bigger than 1200 pixels again we don't
have to use these but if we want we can
maybe increase the font size a base size
a little bit or something like that all
right so now our basic setup is ready we
have this we have like basic CSS rules
that are going to come here we are going
to then add device specific or um
progressively enhance our design to
tablet and desktop okay looks
good looks good the next thing to do is
to just set up copy over some of the
basic Styles without any media queries
so I'm going to first come in here and
I'm going to say that the font
size the base font size on mobile is
going to be not 16 pixels but 14 pixels
I just want the font to be slightly
smaller I don't want it to be too big on
mobile because otherwise there may not
be enough content on the screen to be
readable so let me keep
that and then let me come in here into
body and let us come in and let us set
the font size for the body to 1
em 1 M okay that is going to be the font
size for the
body then let me come in and let me set
uh apart from the font size for the body
we've also set here that we've removed
the margin padding all of this needs to
go for mobile as well we have set the
font family to Roboto and Sans siif and
we've set the the body text color to
444444 okay great let us now set
the font family and the font weight for
our headers so we want the inter font
family to be used and remember these
font families have been included using
these link tags you can see here that
we've included the inter and the Roboto
font family and their various weights so
all of this is common all of this is
going to be present on mobile tablet
desktop that's why we just putting it
completely outside okay
so that's fine too then let us go in and
let us set the font sizes for each
header so remember we are using these
Rams we're using RMS or relative
measurements for the headers so that on
mobile screens there are going to be
multiples of or let's set this to one
ram on mobile screens uh they are going
to be multiples of 14 so on Mobile
screen you can verify here if I go into
effect and I check its computed
font size you can see that it's 35
pixels 35 is 2.5 * 14 okay but as we go
onto bigger screens we're going to set
the base font size to 16 pixels and so
the header size is going to increase as
well okay what
else yeah I think that's what we've
added so we've added
HTML um body H1 H2 and let's add a
couple more let's add the text color and
let's add the the style for the link
right now you can see that links are
underlined I don't want that and I want
links to be my brand brand blue color so
that's where I'm going to go in and grab
this decoration text decoration for the
links let me put that in here as well
okay so yeah so now you can see that if
I reload the page our links have the
desired color they don't have an
underline and on clicking our links have
the desired dark color or on our links
have the desired dark color okay
all right so now this is looking good so
far we have set the base Styles let me
just reload this
page yeah we have set the base Styles
now and of course it just spreads out um
on tablet as well so there's nothing
that really is changing across the
different layouts the first change that
I want to use is when we get to a tablet
Style I want to use a slightly bigger
font size for the body okay so within
the media query where we hit a Min width
of 576 I want to use a slightly bigger
font size I'm just going to come in here
and I am just going to use a bigger font
size here so I'll just come into the
First Media query which is over
here and I'm going to put the font size
of 16 pixels let's move these up let's
keep all the base Styles right at the
top so that things are well organized so
these are the base Styles the base font
size is 14 pixels no change here you can
see that the base font size is 14 you
can actually go in
and check somewhere that the font size
is 14 but as soon as we hit a bigger
font size as soon as we hit a bigger
screen as soon as we hit a Min width of
576 pixels the base font size changes to
16 pixels okay you can actually observe
this change in the font size by just
dragging this so
576 the text should become slightly
bigger you can see here that the text
became name slightly bigger and not just
the text because we are using Rams to
set the size of the headings you can see
that the headings have become slightly
bigger as well okay so this is one
change that you will often see that from
Mobile to tablet or maybe from tablet to
desktop there will be a slight change in
the font size of course you can go ahead
and maybe change let's say you get a
very big desktop a very big screen you
can use the base font size of 20px let
me just come in here and let me just
show you what that would look like as as
well see whenever we hit 1200 pixels I
want to use 20 PX so so far it's 16 at
some point it should
become
20 okay maybe I'm still not hitting 1200
pixels let's try that at maybe 992
pixels yeah so you can see
that it's small here so this is the
tablet layout and at 992 pixels it
becomes bigger
right and then of course on mobile it is
even smaller so you have all those well
actually let's set that to 20 so at 992
pixels it should become
bigger yeah you can see that just around
992 pixels it starts to become even
bigger right so
at here this is mobile and this is
tablet and this
is the large desktop okay these are all
the variations that you can check and
sometimes you just have to inspect
things visually and figure out if you're
getting what you're going for okay all
right so now we've changed the base text
size and I encourage you to maybe change
some other base styes maybe change base
heading sizes as well and see what
happens now the next thing we'll do is
fix the nav bar okay so first let us
implement the nav bar from for mobile
let's bring this back to about
400 and let us go check the nap bar Okay
so now the we need to bring in the basic
nav bar Styles first so let's bring that
in here the nav bar has a padding of 8
pixels and a margin of 0 pixels so let's
just bring that in I think we can keep
that I don't think we need to change
that at I'm just going to bring it all
the way at the top you can see that our
Navar is starting to look fine now one
thing I want to do in my Navar is not
use this entire logo but maybe use a
smaller version of the logo that
contains just this icon and not the text
and for that I have already put up this
this icon online so I can just use this
link or I can download it drag it within
my code space and add it to my
repository both options are available so
let me do one thing let me just add this
icon into my code as well so let me just
go
IMG
ID logo and I'm going to change the icon
with the text to logo with text okay
then alt
equals Jian logo I'm going to change the
alt of the existing IC on to Jo logo
with
text and let's specify an
SRC and let us close
it and I think we have a height 30 as
well so let us set a height equals 30 as
well I don't think we need to change the
height
particularly okay now we have both these
images we have the icon image and then
we have this logo along with the text
now we want to show one of these on
mobile and then on tablet let's I think
we have enough space that we can show
the entire logo with the text so here is
how we can achieve this first we want to
hide this icon we want to hide this icon
we want to hide the logo with the text
on mobile so by default I'm going to
keep it hidden and the way to keep it
hidden is let me just select logo with
text so I'm selecting it with the ID and
let me just set display
none there it's gone the logo with the
text is gone it's gone not just on
mobile but it's gone on tablet and it's
gone on it's gone on desktop as well now
let me make this logo text visible on
tablet so I am just going to go into the
tablet style which is above 576 pixels
or Min width of 576 pixels I'm going to
say logo with
text
display I can just say I believe I can
do lock which is the
default now it doesn't show up on mobile
which which is under 576 pixels but it
does show up
on yeah it does show up
here on tablet and it does show up
here on desktop as well okay but of
course we also need to hide the logo we
need to hide this logo icon so I can
just also say over
here
logo display
block on
mobile and I can just
say
logo display
none on tablets okay so on mobile I have
the logo only the icon on
tablets okay that should say none on
tablets now I have the logo with the
text and also on bigger screens I have
the logo with the text so that takes
care of the napar that is the change
that I'm going for that is the change
that we have on our website as well okay
all right so the napar is taken care of
and the only change we made is added
this second image and we have added the
base style where we putting the padding
in the margin and we have put the logo
with text as display none and we are
showing it on tablets and desktops and
we are not showing it on we not showing
the icon alone on tablets and notice
that once we apply for tablets because
this is this only has a minwidth
criteria not Max width it's going to
apply at all bigger sizes if I want I
can then go in and change it at a bigger
size as well otherwise I can leave it as
is so mobile first progressive
enhancement section by section okay
let's fix the banner image so the there
are a couple of issues with the banner
image one is that it's not taking up the
entire width of the page and second is
that I might need to limit the height of
the banner image for each of the the
wids that I'm working with okay and I
want to do that let me just do that so
the first thing I'll do is go into the
banner image looks like it has a height
let me remove the default height so that
I can change its height based on the
specific break points and let me come in
here and let me just copy over some of
the content that I already have for the
banner so we have object fit cover this
is to make sure that depending on what
width or height we have it
automatically fills the space the
available space
okay and here's the first thing I'm
going to do I'm going to first give it a
height of just 120
pixels the banner image and I'm going to
give it a width of
100% okay and I think that looks good so
maybe 150 pixels let's see yeah that
looks good so now on mobile this is what
it's going to look like it's going to
take up 150 pixels and it's going to
take up the entire width of the page and
it is going to cover so if we did not
have object fit cover you can see that
it stretch stretches the image which is
not good I don't want to stretch the
image especially if these are faces of
people so always use object fit cover or
sometimes you might need to use object
fit contain if you want to if you want
the entire image to fit inside which is
not what we want here we want cover so
let me just put object fit cover that's
what this looks like okay perfect so
that takes care of the banner on mobile
but you can see that starting to get
cobbed on lap on tablet and it'll get
further cropped as I go bigger so on on
maybe on tablets I can increase its
height a little bit so I can say
banner I can give it a
height of 220 pixels how about that yeah
I think that looks good maybe even 200
pixels should do it I think that's good
and
then here again it seems to be getting
cropped a little bit so I can come in
and I can come in into the next design
and this is the first time I'm touching
the desktop design so far we've just
been updating for tablet and that has
carried over to desktop so here I can
maybe give it a height of 240
pixels maybe even 250 pixels this is now
looking good okay so I should probably
verify that this scales properly okay
maybe I need to give it a little higher
let's go 300 pixels yeah I think that
looks good so far at this as well but if
I wanted I could even just do something
like 250 pixels here
and then on even bigger screens I could
just go in and I could just make that
pixels okay so at some point it's going
to become even
bigger all right so that takes care of
the banner I don't think there are any
other changes required so we've removed
the height property that was there on
the image and we've actually set height
specifically at various break points so
it's going to start out with 120 pixels
it's going to grow to 200 and then to
about 280 pixels or so at a
desktops so that was pretty
straightforward let us now go ahead and
let us now do the about section as well
so this is the about Jovian section it
has this H1 and then it has uh some text
over
here and then it has this image as well
and what we want is if I go back to
our layout we want the text to show up
above the image still centered but on
desktop we want them to show up side by
side okay let's try and Achieve
that so first thing I'm going to do is
just copy over the styles for H1 so H1
has textaline Center I that's good I'm
just going to keep
that okay but I feel that the space here
above and below H1 is seems to be very
high so I want to reset that I just want
to say
margin I just want to set the margin to
px0 so just 8 pixels of space above and
below should be good enough for me maybe
I could go
12px yeah 12px looks fine but of course
that may not look good on tablet and on
desktop so I might then have to go in
here and I might need to just put in an
H1 margin let's say 16 PX on
tablet and I might go in here in
into desktop and I might set
margin to
20px
Z okay so it's about 20 pixels
on the desktop which looks fine about 16
pixels here on mobile on p on tablet
that looks fine and about 8 pixels here
and I can verify this I can click
inspect and I can go in here into the
computed Styles and make sure that it
has the
right believe
12 pixels is what we put here so 12
looks fine okay so that's how you can
progressively enhance spacing for the H1
but otherwise this looks fine to me of
course the H1 itself is also bigger
because the base font size is bigger
okay next up we have this about section
which has the ID about and notice that
we have set a don't need this notice
that we have set a maximum width for
this about section okay so we may not
need this maximum width on mobile but it
was it is still useful
on tablet and on desktop so I'm going to
keep it around so we want to use display
Flex that that was for the horizontal
layout and then we have given it a Max
width of 800 pixels and we've given
given it a margin zero Auto and we've
given it an internal padding let's just
check okay so now as soon as we did this
you can see that here it has taken up
some space and now it is showing things
left to right here is what I can do now
this is the benefit I get with flex I
can just set Flex Direction
column I can use flex Direction column
so that things the first and the second
section the description and the image
show up one below the other and then I
can go in and let me see what I want to
do for tablet so for tablet as well I
think I want to keep this layout but I
want to limit the width to about 500
pixels I don't want it to go all over
the place so I'm just going to put in
here Max width of 500 pixels so but on
mobile and tablet it just uses 500
pixels on tablet also this looks fine
but definitely on desktop I want it to
take up 800 pixels as it is available
right so I'm going to go in and I'm
going to say for the about
section set the max width not to 500 but
to 800
pixels so now it's taking up 800 pixels
and set the flex direction to row and
not column so now it's going to show up
side by side okay
this is great but of course it's not
taking up 50% of the space so I need to
fix that as well so let's come back to
the mobile view
now there are two parts within about
there is the description and then there
is
the yeah there is the description and
then there is the image the team image
so let's first get what we're doing here
so for the description we have the width
of 50% that we need to set only on
desktop
and we have a font size as well so let's
just copy these over and let's try to
fix them one by one so let's see here we
are going to use the description we
don't need withd 50% and we probably
don't need the padding right but we do
want the font to be 1.25 RM so I'm just
going to come in here and I am going to
go into maybe the large device because I
think this still works
for the tablet layout as well I'm just
I'm just going to go into the large
devices sorry I'm just going to go into
the medium devices which is more than
768 pixels which is what this is and I'm
going to add the width condition here
under
description okay let me add a width of
50% and let me add that padding right so
that there is space between the
description and the image and now you
can see here that the description takes
up half the space only on the laptop
desktop and all the bigger screens it
doesn't take up it takes up the full
space on tablet and it takes up the full
space on mobile as well and of course
the flex direction also changes from
column to row and that is why the rest
of the space is taken up here by this
image okay so the next thing to do is to
fix this image so let's see we are going
to get this image so we have this team
div and it's currently configured to
take up only 50% of the
space and I I don't think that is
necessary here so I don't think we need
to take a 50% of the space here but I do
like this
border and looks like there is a height
we have set so this height is probably
coming from the HTML so I'm just going
to remove this
height so this is the team image I think
this is looking good and this has the
full
width I if I want I could limit the
height but I'm not feeling like it I'll
just leave it as is I think this image
is looking good I'll just leave it as is
so it's looking good on mobile it is
looking good on lapt on tablet as well I
think on tablet too because we've
limited the maximum width on tablet 2
the team image is looking
fine looks fine on tablet maybe we might
need to configure like
a might need to configure something to
make sure that it is actually show up
properly
let's just give team a maximum width of
or a width of
100%
yeah still a
bit still a bit problematic well so
there may be some minor fix that may
need that we may need to do at the very
end and we'll inspect it and fix it but
for now this is fine but where we really
need to make a change is over here so
let me do one thing let me just fix the
height of the image as well so let me
just fix the team image
height to 240
PX yes we don't need it I think this is
fine yeah but now it is taking up too
much space so we need to go in
here and on the large desktop layout the
team div should just take up a width of
50% okay all right so this is what we're
going for we have the left half which is
and of course the maximum width is 80 80
pixels and it is centered vertically
using margin zero Auto so that is all
that is being
done on the about section here margin
zero Auto and Max width of 500 and then
the max width is increased to about 800
here the flex direction is row so that's
why this is showing up like this side by
side and the team image is has a width
of 50% so that is looking fine
too okay and it looks fine on mobile as
well so mobile 2 this team image is
looking good I don't see any problems
here it looks fine on tablet as
well more or less fine don't I don't see
any major issues here we may have to
make some change later on but otherwise
this is looking fine now moving right
along the next step for us is the jobs
list so now we need to add a jobs list
now if I go back
here if I go back back here to our
mockup on the mobile we have a job list
so we have these cards and each card has
a title and then each card has maybe one
of
these jobs listed right and on desktop
we have a table how exactly do we
achieve that we can do some kind of
magic where we change the display type
from div to table and all that but the
simplest way to do it is to just show a
list on mobile and hide it on desk toop
and then show a table on desktop and
hide it on mobile okay so here is what
we are going to do we are going to first
take a bunch of HTML so we're going to
create a bunch of divs so we are going
to create a div called jobl list and we
are going to then have a bunch of divs
each with the class job and then inside
that div we going to have a bunch of
divs each with the class job title for
the title of the job and job detail for
each detail within the job okay
and of course I have the data for all
four jobs here so these are the this is
the same data that is present in the
table but now I'm no longer using a
table I am simply using a I'm simply
using dibs not even a list and I can
simply copy this so let me just take
this so that I don't have to just type
all of these jobs
out yeah let me just take this HTML and
I'm going to go put this into my
index.html file right under
or right above the jobs
table okay so now I have this data of
employment opportunities first let me
change employment opportunities to job
opportunities I think it looks better as
job opportunities so now we have this
job opportunities and I have a list of
job opportunities which are just a bunch
of divs and then I have the table of job
opportunities as well and the list of
job opportunities has the ID job list
jobs list and the table has jobs table
so as you can imagine what we can do is
we can just set display properties for
both of these to show and hide them
respectively and while we at it let us
also fix the display property for this
H2 so let's go in here and let's go down
first thing we'll do is for the H2 we
are going to set text align Center so
let's bring that up I think we are
always going to have text align Center
for H2 so let me just put that so that
H2 has text line Center we may want to
once again reduce the spacing above and
below the hed2 um I'll skip that for now
but I'll leave that as an exercise so
use a smaller spacing on mobile and
larger spacing on tablet and
desktop respectively okay next up let us
just figure out how to show and hide the
job list
so first of all the entire jobs div
itself let's see if there is some
setting for the entire jobs
div yeah so the entire jobs div has a
max Max width of 800 pixels so let's
just take that and let us just put it
here at the
top okay so the entire jobs div on
mobile just takes up the entire width no
issue on tablet it takes up the entire
width as well but we might want to limit
it withd slightly you can see here at
around
600 on tablet we might want to just
Center it we may not want to just show
it we may not want it to take up the
entire space just like this content is
centered we may want to center it so how
about we use a Max width of 500 pixels
just like that so that the content is
centered on the tablet but then
on desktop we want it to take up
slightly more width right so this is
going up to 800 pixel width so I'm going
to come in into the desktop media query
which is laptops desktops and which is
above 768 pixels and for the jobs
div I am going to set Min
width of 800 pixels okay now you can see
that it takes up 800 full pixels on the
on desktop on tablet it takes up only
about 500 pixels and on mobile it takes
up the entire space available okay
that's good Let Us Now set the display
criteria for for both of these I'm going
to go in and there is this jobs list
that I have which I want
to have display block by
default and the jobs list the jobs table
I want to set its display To
None okay so now my job opportunities is
visible here on mobile it is visible
on tablet and it is not visible and it
is visible on desktop as well and this
is where I may need to change something
so I need to change the layout here and
I want to hide this and show the table
so let us try and hide this and show the
table well so if I go in into this
layout above
768 I'm going to say jobs
list display none remember the jobs list
is simply the list of jobs that we have
so that's gone and I can say jobs
table
display
block okay now we don't actually want to
use display block here the default value
of display for a table tag remember jobs
table is a table you can see here it's a
table tag so if you just search default
display value for table
tag the default display value for the
table tag
is all right I'll just tell you the
default display value for a table tag is
actually table itself so we can we need
to set display table here and when we
set display table here what it does is
that allows the table to take up the
entire width of the screen um on most on
most screens and that will happen once
we add some of the other table Styles as
well okay so just keep that in mind that
the default display for a table a table
tag is
table all right
well we are doing fine so far um we
might need to copy in as soon as the
table is visible we want to use it we
want to set its display to use the
entire
width and yes we have a bunch of these
settings as well so we have the Border
setting we have the Border collapse
setting and then of course all the table
Styles can be incorporated directly into
the media query where the table becomes
visible let's capture all these table
related Styles so this is used to set
maybe the borders for each table cell
this is used to set a bunch of other
things now you can see here that our job
opportunities table is showing up on
desktop but it's not showing up on
mobile it's not showing up
on tablet and mobile and this is because
jobs table we are setting its display to
table we can also do block but you'll
notice that in block it doesn't do what
we want you can see that block is not
what we want we want table because we
wanted to use the entire available space
okay so display table and below below
the desktop screen width we have this
display set To None right and of course
we have this header row so we have
colors for the header row we have a
bunch of alignments then we have these
alternate rows we have borders for these
alternate rows that is something that we
specify here we have a padding to space
things out and for every alternate row
we also have this background color that
is done using the nth child all of this
is covered in the previous tutorial okay
all right we're getting there we're
almost there now the only thing left for
us to do is style this actual job
opportunities this job opportunities div
okay so let's try styling it quickly so
the job opportunities div is this has
each of these
jobs has the class job so first I'm
going to style the job class so do
job and for the job class I am going to
say let's look at mobile so I'm going to
first give it a border so border one PX
solid I'm going to use a light gray DDD
DDD okay now they have a border then I
am going to give it a margin top margin
top 4 PX maybe even 8
PX all right I'm going to give it a
border
radius of 5
pixels okay that's nice now I have a
rounded border I'm going to give it a
padding of 8px let's see what that does
okay that's looking good all right so I
have these boxes now so these boxes are
looking good then I have job title and
job detail let me try and quickly style
those as well so job
title and job
detail okay the job title is let me see
font size let me give it a font size of
1.25 RM that it scales accordingly let
me give it a font weight of
500 okay that's looking good let me give
it a color of 22 22
22 okay color is looking good and then
for job detail well let me just give it
a margin top of four pixels just to
space things out a little bit and let me
give a color
of be a slightly lighter color 55 55
55 okay that's looking slightly lighter
okay I think that looks good so I have
some job I have a border I have this
radius around it I have this title I
have U set up all of these details I've
put in some space here as well and I've
given it some weight so that's looking
pretty good I think that's looking good
on tablet as well and it is centered on
the page and that is looking that's just
not visible on desktop so with that we
have completed the job opportunities
section so you can see now we have the
jobs list on mobile and tablet and the
way we did that was first setting a Max
width of 500 and then for job giving it
a border border radius margin padding
for job title increasing its font size
for job detail increasing or making it
lighter and then of course on the Min
width of 768 we increase the max width
of jobs so that it's a little bigger on
desktop and we set the job list display
to none for the job stable on by default
we we set it display to none and once we
reach that 768 width when we want the
displayed we set it display to table we
make it full width we give it a border
border collapse and we give all those
settings which are required to show the
table properly okay all right we are on
the last leg here let's go ahead and fix
the application form as well the first
thing I'm going to do is just pull out
all these application form settings
right all the way to the top so let's
see have application form
group form
input all of that okay so how it works
is we have this application div and
inside this application div we have an
application form which is a form with
the IDE application form then each of
these inputs and labels are together
part of a form group okay so we're going
to use all these Styles and we have a
bunch of custom styles that we have set
up for all of these so let us go in and
do that let's see let's come in all the
way to the top above any media queries
and let us paste the Styles and this is
what we end up with so now we
have for the application itself the max
width is 500 800 pixels so it takes up
the full width which is not what we want
let's set the max width to 500 pixels
instead okay that's fine and now it is
in line on tablet it is all centered but
of course we can go in and on the
desktop version we can increase the max
WS so we can say hash
application Max width to be 800 pixels
so that on desktop it still takes up the
entire width it's looking good I think
the only change I'm going to make here
it actually looks fine the only change I
want to make here is maybe make the
inputs full width so I am going to come
in here I'm going to change this to form
group because that is going to be more
specific so in each form group I want
the label to have have a certain I want
the input to have the width
of of about 80% let's say so that all
the inputs are about 80% wide something
like that maybe even 90% just going very
close to full
width yeah so I want all my inputs to be
about 90% wide
on mobile but as soon as I get to the
tablet so on tablet I don't want it to
be 90% wide so I'm just going to go in
here on tablet I'm just going to
set input select text area text area
doesn't need to be modified I'm just
going to
set max
width or width to be about to be Auto
okay so on mobile it takes up about the
full width and that's nice
and on I can remove this with 80% here
and set that manually here so do form
group text
area for text area we still want it to
be a bit wide about 80% wide on even on
tablet okay so on tablet what this is
what it looks like the application look
on application on mobile looks like this
almost full width the application on
tablet looks like this so it is not
taking up the full width but it is still
centered on the page along with the rest
of the content and the application on
desktop looks like it used to there's no
change there okay so that's nice the
final thing we need to do is fix the
footer so we have a footer right at the
bottom let's go ahead and fix the footer
the first thing we'll do is just copy
over all the existing Styles we don't
need this H3 we don't need this apply
I'll get r that so we just have footer
quter links quter links Li and copyright
that with that we've exhausted all the
Styles yeah so we've carried over all
the Styles so let me just go in right at
the top before we create any media
queries let's put in the footer Styles
let's see what that gives us now we have
a footer which has this background that
we looking for and it has these links
and it has this copyright all of that is
good but on the mobile we want these
links to show up one below the other
and how do we do that well you see we
have this display in line for Li I think
we can get rid of this so the links are
going to show up one below the
other okay and looks like they're
centered now but they're slightly off
center so if I just inspect this list I
can figure out why it is off center all
of this seems to be centered but looks
like this UL this um unordered list
seems to have a padding on the left you
see that green color thing that is just
this padding on the left let's go into
the footer
links list and let us just set padding
left to
zero okay all right so that's what we
have here we have this putter div then
we have the footer links ul and then we
have a bunch of Lis and that is now
showing the Footers the footer items one
below the other I may even add some
margin bottom so I can say margin
4 PX and 16 PX so now I have a margin
bottom so that they're slightly spaced
out maybe even 8
PX okay so this foter is looking
nice okay let's see on tablet now on
tablet this footer is probably not
looking good I think I can just get it
back to inline so on tablets I'm just
going to come in here and I'm going to
say fter link
Li display in
line and let's see okay so on tablets it
is in line on mobile it is still one
below the other this is what I'm
expecting and on desktop it is in line
perfect with that we have completed the
footer so we've done the we've done all
the sections I think all of them look
good on mobile tablet and desktop so
that's good we have done the changes to
the application form the only changes we
made was some width adjustments for the
inputs and we have done the changes for
the footer the only change we made was
that we wanted to show them one below
the other on mobile and side by side on
desktop and again practice this work it
out step by step that is how all of
these steps will make sense we can now
review and deploy these changes so what
we're going to do is first we're going
to create a branch just going to do that
here by first opening the terminal so
let's say five you terminal I'm going to
first create a
branch so let's do get checkout minus P
minus B is a quick shortcut to create
and check out a branch in one step and
let me just call
it responsive
layout okay now we've switched to a new
Branch we've created a new branch and
switched to it you can see we are on the
branch responsive layout now I'm going
to do git add dot I'm going to review
the changes using git status you can see
that above bunch of new files have been
added there's a settings. Json as well
not sure what that's for but it's okay
then I'm going to do get add okay I'm
just going to do get commit minus
M added responsive
layout now we've committed it normally I
would commit after every section and
keep updating my poll request but just
for now just for example I'm doing that
then let me do get push origin
responsive layout okay so we stage the
changes using git ad we then commit the
changes using git commit and then we
create uh push that Branch to GitHub
using get push origin Branch name okay
now we can create a pull request so
there's actually a
helpful there's actually a helpful link
here that U that is printed out for us
but we could always just go on the
repository page and on the repository
page you can see that GitHub tells us
that a responsive layout branch has just
been pushed and we can create a pull
request so here's what we can do we can
say added a responsive layout for the
job page and I can mention
changes and I can just bring in the
changes that I've made here so let's see
navbar has
a logo without
text then Banner size is
updated based on
screen then about section is vertical
first then
horizontal and then we have the jobs
list
[Music]
on mobile and
tablet and table on
desktop what else application form full
width inputs on
mobile and uh
vertical putter items on mobile okay
just a short description of the changes
and we can create this pull request and
now you can see that our Joven careers
responsive site which is our initial
website
Jian careers
responsive doval
doapp live doval
doapp this is still not updated this
still has the old design in fact I can
go in into inspect I can verify this
that it's still trying to show the table
it's still trying to show things side by
side but now you can see that in this
particular pull request verel has
created a preview deployment so I can
visit this preview deployment this is
just for this branch and you can see
that on this preview
deployment if I go
inspect we have our new layout so this
is what you want to do your main website
is Asis no changes there but on your
pull request you've made all these
changes on your branch and you can test
it out so somebody who is looking at
your branch can first look at the
preview deployment and the maybe the
designer can take a look and tell you
okay maybe you need more space about
submit application maybe there is some
change to be done in job opportunities
maybe the footer is not looking nice let
me rework that a little bit you can also
maybe just see how things change you can
see that okay job opportunities takes up
the full space then it scks to around
500 pixels then it suddenly expands and
now when it expands here you get this
two column layout and here you get this
table and that is looking rather nice
and the application also expands
accordingly so the designer or maybe
another developer can review the changes
visually by looking at the preview they
can also review the changes manually so
they can go in and they can actually
check in each section okay looks like
we've added a displayed or HTML file
they can tell you maybe we don't need
this displayed or HTML file get rid of
it um we don't need this flexbox or HTML
file so you can go and delete those
files and update your pull request and
okay they can see see a splits so
there's a split view available as well
let me
just split
view yeah you can see a split
view yeah so they can see here the
changes that have been made that you
have added this jobs list as expected
and you've not modified any other HTML
except adding the job list and changing
the title here they can see here that
you've added a a bunch of Base styles
for mobile and you've made it 14 pixels
you've not changed a lot else maybe a
few things here and there and they can
give you inputs on specific things they
can give okay this doesn't look right
and they can comment it and then you can
revise those comments and P pull your
branch again and so on and they can see
that okay now you've added a bunch of
these media screen uh settings and all
so this is a good way for you to even do
a self- review before you merge your
changes to master and once the changes
are approved then you can go in and you
can get an approval and then you can
merge this pull request to master okay
now as soon as the pull request is
merged to master what verel is going to
do is it's going to pick up the new
changes from the master branch and it's
going to create a new deployment you can
check this on ver.com
that it is going to create a new
deployment just now you can see here
that's creating a new
deployment uh created just now by syy
Jovian and now if I reload the page
notice that I'm on the deployed main
branch Jovian careers responsive live.
app.app and I reload the
page and the layout is fixed this is the
layout now the main page has gone live
so this is the workflow that you need to
get used to create a branch do your work
test it out in a preview deployment and
then merge it and then your layout is
going to be fixed now we've created a
responsive design just like that and
that is something that you're going to
experiment with in your next assignment
okay so we staged and committed the
changes pushed the changes to GitHub
reviewed the code test at the preview
deployment made some if we can required
we can make some final adjustments
iterate on it and then the pull request
can be merged to the main branch and it
gets deployed and this is the final
mobile layout I think this looks pretty
good it's everything is readable
everything takes up sort of the full
width this is the final tablet layout so
we're centering the content on the page
to about 500 pixels we're limiting its
width so that things are still readable
and this is the final desktop layout
notice that we did not have wireframes
for tablet but we just use some
components from this side and some from
that side to build it and as an exercise
try adding more sections to the site try
to implement them using a mobile first
responsive design try creating a
separate wireframe for the tablet
screens and make changes to the page to
implement
it and then one other thing we we did
not look into was the media type print
what happens when you try to print this
page so you can do that by trying to do
command p and then trying to save it as
a PDF and you'll see what your page is
going to look like okay so by default it
just picks up whatever is going to show
up on the screen but for a print out you
may need to do a separate layout and
that is something that you can
experiment with u that is something that
you can experiment with the media print
query okay so that's everything for
today uh we looked at how to use CSS
media queries and breakpoints to
implement a mobile first responsive web
design we looked at how to leverage
various CSS properties uh specifically
flexbox to build fluid and dynamic
layouts needs a lot of practice so we
will use flexbox extensively over the
next several months so don't worry
you'll get enough practice we looked at
to create separate wireframes or design
mockups to determine the layout of a web
page at various breakpoints you always
always should separate the design and
the implementation don't try to do them
both together you will get stuck we
looked at implementing testing and
deploying a responsive website using CSS
media queries and
flexbox the best way to learn these
skills is to follow along step by step
and type out all the code yourself and
you can check out the completed code
here using these links I have included a
ton of resources here the idea is not
that you need to go through through all
of these resources right now a few I
would recommend though is a responsive
web design or media queries tutorial on
CSS tricks the video course by vest boss
on what the flexbox but there are a
bunch of others no matter what you are
feeling under feeling scared about or
not confident about or doubtful about
check out one of these resources you
should be able to figure it out if one
of the concepts that we covered today
did not make sense and that's it so in
this assignment two uh you will
implementing a responsive web
design using CSS media queries and
flexbox so the figma mockups are already
provided to you uh let's quickly go
through the
mockups so in these mockups uh there are
three layouts uh for desktop tablet and
mobile and on the desktop
view there is a nav
bar with the logo of the company and and
some graphics some title subtitle and
learn more
button and on the tablet and mobile view
also there is similar layout but the
Navar is different it is
not completely visible it is in the
collapse
mode and below the hero section we have
the newest read
section which is uh a card layout and on
the
desktop uh there are three cards in a
row and similarly on the tablet also
there are three cards in a row but on
mobile we can see that the layout is bit
different so it is having a column
layout so you will need to use some Flex
properties maybe to design
these uh layouts for different devices
and inside the card if we zoom in we
have few more elements the image for the
article the date of
publish and the title and read more
link so this is how the assignment 2 is
looking uh the steps to proceed with
this assignment are already mentioned
and I hope you guys have already started
on
that so coming to today's session today
we are going to build
a responsive web page using flexbox and
media queries so following topics will
be covered in today's
tutorial so we will be designing a
responsive layout using CSS media
queries then we will understand what are
selectors in
CSS and how to calculate Dynamic width
for particular uh elements using CSS
function and using the Box Shadow
property
so the prerequisites for today's session
are you should be aware about basic HTML
and
CSS and uh you should know how to create
a GitHub repository and the envirment
that we are going to use for today's
session is vs code and we will be using
the cloudbased vs code that is the code
spaces which is provided by
GitHub so as a part of Designing a web
page we are going to design a responsive
block page which will make use of media
queries flexbox layout and the design
mockup and data is provided for
you so let's go through the mockup
quickly so this is how the layout will
look on mobile uh it will have a page
title and uh it has the cards which are
stacked vertically so this is basically
a column layout you can see and on
tablet we can see that the card layout
is almost similar but the uh method of
rendering is different so we can see
that on the tablet there are two cards
in a row and for desktop it will be
three cards in a
row so this is the mock data that we
will be using for uh our today's
session so first let's quickly recap
about uh what is responsive design so
responsive design is an approach which
ensures that our websites will look
correctly and adapt to various different
screen sizes devices and
orientation so it will optimize the user
experience by making the content more
visually appealing so you can see from
this image that this is some example of
the mockup so on mobile it is vertically
aligned and when it when we change the
device it automatically gets aligned uh
to some different layouts and it gets
scaled on higher devices so there are
few key principles that we should be uh
aware about responsive web design first
is the website uh layout should be
flexible it should not be fixed sized
like the width should not be given in
pixels if we resize the screen it should
get Scaled
accordingly next is the flexible images
so images have their own size and when
we import the external images they
render directly if we don't specify the
width and the height
separately and it might happen that the
image can overflow uh of the screen
width so to ensure that this doesn't
happen we should be using some CSS
properties so one is the max width that
will ensure that our image is within the
the screen width and other is the object
fit that you might have already used in
the previous lectures so that is used to
maintain the aspect ratio of the image
and it makes ensure that the image
doesn't get
stretched so we will be using that
today third thing is the media queries
which allows uh us to write various
Styles based on the layout uh of the
device so we can specify various device
properties like width height and
orientation and write the styles for
that particular uh
query fourth is the mobile first
approach so this approach tells us that
we should start designing our web page
from mobile devices and then
progressively enhance to the larger
devices like tablet and desktop so this
approach has gained popularity because
of the number of users of uh mobile
devices compared to other
devices so the next concept uh is the
breakpoints that is also important in
responsive web design so breakpoints in
CSS are specific points or conditions
where the layout or styles of our web
page are going to change and accommodate
to different screen size these break
points are generally used along with the
media queries so what is Media query
exactly so media query is the statement
that allows us to write a specific set
of CSS rules when certain conditions are
made so these conditions are based on
the width height and orientation of the
device so let's see few examples quickly
so in this example one we have a uh
media query which says that uh it should
apply to the max width of 600 p X so
whatever Styles we will write inside
this block will apply to all the devices
whose width is less than or equal to 600
PX and this example tells us that we can
also specify mean width and Max width
together so this Styles will apply for
all the devices whose width is between
320px to 600 PX and third is the
minwidth which will apply all the styles
for the
devices which whose width is greater
than or equal to 600 PX so we can use
any arbitary width and height for
defining these media queries but there
but there are few standard break points
that are generally followed based on the
device types so for mobile the width of
the device should be less than 576 PX
and tablet which is the SM device uh it
ranges from 5 76 PX to 768 PX and
desktop ranges from 768 to 992 and there
are also higher resolution devices uh
which we call it call large desktop
whose sizes are greater than 992
PX so let's get started with the coding
part so we will be using uh GitHub code
spaces so we will be needing one GitHub
repository so I have already created a
repository here and to run in the code
spaces you just have to click on code
and click create code space on Main
which the main is the branch of our
repository once you click
that it will open a new tab and you will
get a vs code Cloud interface and it
should load in couple of
seconds
yeah so it is loaded and on the left
side you will see the list of files uh
so we are having a readme file
here and uh we we are not going to use
the terminal so I will close
it and let's quickly write our first
file which is
index.html so we will add some basic HT
ml code that is required for every HTML
document we write so we declare the doc
type then the HTML tag inside this HTML
tag we will be having a head tag inside
head tag we require a title
tag and let me give the title my
blog hey Ashish can you zoom in a bit
yeah a
little yes
okay yeah so apart from head tag we also
need a body
tag and let me add a H1 tag here which
will be the page
title
and all right so we have written the
basic HTML file and to run this file we
will need some
extension that is live server and it can
be found in the extensions tab so there
is the extension live server uh by R day
we can install
that yeah once it is installed you will
see this go live
option
uh yeah so you will see the go live
option at the right bottom you can click
on
this and it will start a server and it
will it should open in the new
tab the uh HTML page that we just wrote
so we are able to see welcome to my
blog now let's add some uh CSS Styles so
we will be using external CSS
file and and uh we will create one file
uh which is base.
CSS so this base. CSS uh will contain
all the code that is required
to be applied to all the basic HTML tags
so this is important to be consistent
across various browsers because various
browsers have their inbuilt style that
is auto applied to all the tags so for
example on this Blog Page we haven't
specified any font or any font size so
it is automatically given by the browser
so I will just copy these styles from
The
Notebook and put it into this base. CSS
file and uh we can import this file
using link
tag should be Styles
and HF should be base.
CSS
yeah so uh the file is loaded correctly
and we can see that the font is now
changed to Sans ser and also the uh
title is centered to the
page now the next thing we will do we
will create one more file which uh we
will call styles.css
so in this base. CSS file you can see
that there is no code related to our
blog page design so we will create one
more file styles.css
to write all the
application specific code it's not a
mandatory thing but to keep things more
organized and to keep our Styles more
organized we can create one more file
and it can be similarly imported the way
we have imported the base. CSS
file
all
right so there is one more important tag
that is required to make our web page
responsive and that tag is the meta tag
which has the proper attribute of name
viewport so we also need to add this to
the Head
tag
all right so we are set up with
our uh environment and the basic HTML
and the files which we will be working
on today so
the basic part of today's mockup is this
block card which is going to be
consistent across all the layouts that
we have seen in the
mockup so inside this block card we can
see that there is one image one title
author publish date and
likes and I'm able to see that there is
some spacing around the content so maybe
I will have to use some padding
left and uh that needs to be applied to
all the content
so that is one way other way I could
think of this is adding one outer
div which will contain the title author
and
likes so let's add
this HTML
code me quickly resize this a
bit
all
right so let's add a d with which uh
will be our for the block
card and inside this block card we will
require one
div which will have the image for our
block and
uh
for the title we can use the div also
but I will use
H2 because it is the second uh prior
title after the page
title so I will give it a class name
block card
title we will fill in the data
shortly and after the title till we
have uh the author and the publish
date so maybe we can put this
information in a single div because it
is horizontally
aligned so let me add a div for
that with the
class block card
info
and one more div will be required for
this likes
count all right
so we can wrap all these three uh
elements inside one more div to add the
spacing around them correctly otherwise
we will have to add the padding for each
of these elements
separately so let's add a div
and give it a class name maybe blog card
body
okay and inside
this image we will be having our image
tag so image tag has will have the SRC
attribute and Alternate text
attribute okay so now let's put some
data and see how it looks so I will just
copy the data and put it in the readme
file so that that we can get it from
here so let's copy the title
first and put it in the all tag as well
as the title
tag
refresh this
[Music]
once sometimes it takes
time
let me try to restart
this
so if
we disable and reenable the extension it
would
work
all
right yeah so we have loaded the title
now let's add a image to this Blog the
image link is is provided in the
notebook and add that in the
so the image is loaded and the title is
also loaded but we can see that we
haven't added any property for the image
so it is taking its own width and height
and it's maintaining its own aspect
ratio and we can see we discussed the
key principle that the responsive design
should not look like this because we can
see that the image is going out of the
screen width so for that we will need to
add some St Styles so let's create a
style layout quickly so first we have a
block
card then we have a block
card
image then we have block
body inside this body we have one more
div
which is block card
info
okay so we'll need to resize this image
correctly so that it doesn't go outside
the screen
width so for that we will be
understanding the con concept of
selectors so selectors in a CSS is a
pattern that matches one or more
elements in a document allowing your
styles to apply to only those elements
so you have already used the selectors
in your previous lectures and
assignments so the three basic types of
selectors are the element selector which
applies to all the HTML
elements so div ptag HTML body these are
the elements so in our base. CSS file we
have used the element selector so these
are all the element selector and these
styles are applied to these
elements next is the class selector that
we are going to use in our styles. CSS
file and third is the ID selector which
begins with the
hash there are many more types of
selectors in CSS you can find it here I
have provided the link in the
notebook so the another type of selector
is the child selector so in child
selector we have to
specify two things first is the parent
uh selector and the child selector so
that is specified using the greater than
symbol so let's try to understand this
using this image so in this image I have
a div whose selector or class is block
card image and inside that block card
image I have a image element and there
is one more image element on our web
page so if we directly apply styles to
this image
selector so it will get applied to both
the images this and this but what if I
only want to apply the styles to the
image which is inside a parent whose
class is block card image so for this
particular use case
we can use the child selector so the
Syntax for that looks like this we have
to specify the parent selector it can be
either ID selector or class selector or
element
selector and some same thing can uh be
applied to the child selector it can
also be element class or
ID so we are going to use this to style
our
image so we will be using using block
card image greater than
image so let's add
that so we will use the object fit
property
cover width
100%
and height let's say 160
BX so we can see that uh the image is
resized and it is not going outside our
screen width and also we can see that
the image is not stretched if you resize
the window you will see that it is
getting scaled in and scaled out but not
getting
stretched so this is how we want our
HTML uh image to render in a particular
screen
width so let's quickly add few more
styles to our blog card
title we can left align the title so for
that we can use text align
left and we can also reduce the font
size a
bit that we can do using font size
property and let's make it
1.5
REM all right and uh now we can add some
border to the block card so that can be
done using the shorthand property of
border
whose first value is the width of the
border so we will keep it 1 PX and then
the style of the border so we want the
solid
border and uh the third is the color so
that can be any RGB color so let's
choose some light color so f f stands
for
white so something darker than white
maybe let's try
CCC yeah so this is
fine and also let's add some border
radius to let's say 4
BX all right so we can see that the
border and Border radius are added to
our block card now now we need to add
some spacing
here but uh before adding that let's
also add the other information of the
blog the author and the publish date and
the likes
count so we can go here
and add the author
name coton and let say the publish date
you can put today's
date
and the likes to be let's say any random
number
okay yeah so the content for our first
card is done now we need to style it
more so we will go to the styles. CSS
and first we will add the padding here
so let's give it a full padding from all
the sides
so that can be done using the padding
property and let's give it 4
PX okay and we can see
that there is lot of space at the top of
this title and that is coming because of
the h2 tag that we have used so we can
reduce that maybe let's make
it
zero because we already have a padding
here and also let's change
the bottom to let's say
5px so that it's
look uh more visually
appealing and we'll also need to add
some spacing between the author and the
likes so the author and the publish date
information is stored in the div which
is having a selector block card info we
will add a
5px margin bottom to the this div so now
it is looking
fine maybe we can increase the font size
a
bit but uh we want a font size which is
larger than the current one but less
than the uh title of the blog so let's
try
is
1.25
R all right so our block card is
ready now we will have to make it uh
like we we will have to set the max
width because we can see that it is
getting scaled horizontally as I am uh
increasing the SC screen width but we
want to scale it up to a particular
width and after that it should have a
fixed width so for that we will have to
add a layout that is the parent
component to this block card because
right now it is taking the width which
is available to it that is 100% of the
screen so we have designed the block
card and it is currently looking like
this so now we will need to add some
layout to this card right now as you can
see in the HTML file we haven't added
any parent div to this card so let's
quickly add
that so I will create one more
div whose class name we can call block
Parts
wrapper and we will put this block card
inside
this
okay and let's define
some style for
this
Block cards
rapper so I don't want uh the blog card
to take the llit width of uh which is
100% so it should scale up to certain
limit but after that it should have a
fixed width so for that uh I will have
to use a Max width
property and uh so we are designing for
the mobile view first and uh mobile view
the max width is 576 PX so our Max width
should be such that it it is less than
576 so I will just use
360px
okay and refresh the page yeah so now
you can see that the block card is
restricted by its parent uh component or
elements Max width which is
360px and also I want all the blocks uh
to appear centered horizontally so for
that we can use uh margin left Auto and
margin right Auto it will auto center
the Block cards forer horizontally
centered
okay so now
uh let's see the device mode
quickly and if we go to 320 you can see
that the card is scaling up to certain
limit till 360 PX and then it will be a
fixed width so in this way we are
restricting the card width so that it
looks consistent on all the devices
because we are working for a range of
devices so all devices might have
different width so it our web page might
not look consistent so let's so that's
that is the importance of adding the max
WID to the wrapper so now let's add few
more Block cards to see how the vertical
layout looks like for that we will need
some more data and let me
quickly see
these
and grab the mock data from
here so we will be adding it at two
places one is the m
alternative text attribute and other is
the block
title and also let's add the
[Music]
image okay loaded
we add other
images
title
all right so we have all the data in
place and we can see that all the images
and the title are loaded
correctly
so
we we want some spacing between two
consecutive cards right now there is no
spacing so there are few various ways to
add spacing between the card the most
efficient way that is uh used in the
flex layout and that is the gap so let's
quickly see what Gap
is so gra property explicitly controls
the space only between the uh Flex items
that are the children of a display Flex
layout
it applies that spacing between the
items and not on the outer edges so the
another uh way to do this is the margin
top but if you apply margin top it will
also apply to the first element and we
don't want that we only want the spacing
between the consecutive elements so
that's why uh it's best practice to use
the
Gap and GAP will require us to
So currently we are not using any
display property for this wrapper so
let's add a display Flex
property and the layout is in column
format so we will have to use flex
Direction
column okay and GAP property which will
be
10px
so now you can see that our mobile view
is looking nice so it is evenly spaced
and there is no additional spacing here
that is applied to the
card so if we inspect this and we can
see that there is no additional spacing
applied here and the the so the margin
or the spacing is uh highlighted using a
color and there is no highlight or of uh
the margin here so that is the advantage
of using Gap so we have uh completed our
mobile
view so we uh so this is the mobile
first approach and we haven't written
any additional rules that how our web
page should look like on tablet and
desktop devices so it will look uh as it
is as it is looking on the mobile to
make it respond responsive to the other
devices we will have to use media
queries with the break points so let's
uh first design the tablet
view so in tablet view we want two cards
in a row so in this case we won't be
using Flex Direction column we'll have
to change it to row and also we will
need some
wrapping okay so these are the
requirements and the spacing between the
two cards horizontally and vertically
should be
10px and all the cards should take the
space exactly half of the available
size so for that we will need to add a
media query so let's add
that so we will
require M width
of 576 PX right that is the break point
of the
tablet and
uh we first we will add the flex
direction that will
be
Pro so we will also need to add the
class name
here so we can see that all the cards
are coming in a single row so to uh
evenly space them and not to shrink them
we will have to use the property Flex
wrap and set it to
wrap so after adding this now you can
see that uh all the cards are taking the
space so that they fit their content
correctly but uh we can see that now if
we are on the let's say tablet device we
want two cards in a row and it is just
taking a single card in a row that is
because of the max width which is set to
360 so we will also need to modify the
max width because now for the tablet
devices we have more space available on
our device so let's update the max width
to uh maybe we can double that because
now it should be less than 991 PX which
is the boundary of the tablet
device so let's make it 720
PX okay
and so still it will not work because we
haven't specified any width to the block
card and block card is still taking the
complete width so we'll have to add a
property to the block card to uh to let
the block card know how much width it
should take so that it can fit two in a
row so we can add this property again
using the media
query and we can put the block card
class inside this media query
and let's add a
width of let's say
50% okay so we can see that still it is
not showing two in a
row so the reason behind this is we will
have to check if 50% of the available BD
is available for the card or
not so let's understand the concept
here so we want two cards in a row and
there is already a gap of 10 PX between
the two cards and each card has a border
on the left and the right side and the
Border width is 1
PX so in
total 10 PX is gone from
100% and uh comp like in total for the
border is taking 4 PX so the actual
available width is 100% minus 10 PX for
The Gap and 4 PX for the border so that
much width is available and that needs
to be divided into two and if we give
that then only the cards will show two
in a row so how to do this
so in CSS there is a way to calculate
the width or any other property and that
is done by using the calc function so
calc function is used to perform
mathematical calculations to determine
the value of a particular CSS
property so it is used to calculate the
values dynamically and it is allows us
to make more flexible layouts and even
if we resize the screen it will
automatically recalculate the values and
apply it to the uh
elements so to do that we will have to
use the width property and the calc
function so uh inside the Cal function
we will put the calculation that we want
to do so out of 100% 10 PX is for Gap
and 4 PX is for border and the remaining
width we will divide into two parts two
because we want to show two cards in a
row so let me add this
width to uh this block card inside this
media
query so we can see that the blog page
is looking correctly on the tablet
device and from 570
six it should change to tablet View and
below that it is still uh taking the
column layout that is uh expected from
the
mockup so you can see that by writing
just three lines of code here and one
line of code here we were able to make
our web page responsive for
tablet now similar thing we will have to
do for
desktop so for desktop
so this is the formula that we can use
in general to calculate the width of the
card so here 100% is the uh Total Space
in width available and N minus one where
n is the number of cards we want to show
in a row and GAP Gap is 10 PX in our
case minus 2 into n so n is again the
number of uh cards and two represents
the border on on the left and the right
side so if we put two in this formula we
will get the same
expression so for desktop view we want
to show three cards in a row so for
showing the three
cards we will have to uh again calculate
the width by substituting n is equal
3 so
let's understand again how it is done so
this is the % width which is available
out of that there are two gaps because
we have three cards in a row so there
will be two gaps 10 PX each so in total
Gap is taking 20 PX space and Border
left and border right 2 PX per card so
in total we will have to subtract 20 PX
and 6 PX and then divide uh the
remaining space into three
parts so this is how uh the block page
will become responsive for desktop let's
try to quickly add
this so uh for desktop now we have
larger screen width so we can change
this 720px to maybe some more device
because now we have space uh till 991
PX so I will copy this media
query and change the minimum width to
991 PX which is the starting sorry 992
PX which is the starting point for
the uh desktop
devices and put the blogs card
starter
and we can see that these two properties
we don't need to again copy that because
uh on the desktop view itself we will be
requiring the row Flex Direction and we
want them to wrap the only property that
we need to change is the max width
because we now want three cards in a row
so let's copy only the max width and add
that here and let's say we make it 960
PX and similar thing we will have to add
a media query for the block
card so here the minimum width will
be 992
PX
and the width will
be
20 100% - 20 PX - 6 PX ided by
so if we go to 992 PX we can see that
now three cards are shown in a
row so this has made our web page fully
responsive for
mobile tablet and desktop and if you
want to make it more responsive by
making use of the screen width of the
higher devices you can add
the green uh you can add more more media
queries
and can make that more uh responsive for
the higher
devices so you can see that we have
added less than 60 lines of code CSS and
have created a responsive block page
design so now let's understand some
other properties of CSS uh for adding
the hor Styles so suppose we want to add
some hor styles to the card so right now
if we H using the mouse or this card it
is not uh changing the style but let's
say we want to add some Shadow to the
card and also want to change the cursor
of this card so how can we do that so
for that CSS provides some pseudo
classes so the one example of pseudo
class is the hor so to add styles to the
pseudo class we have to use the selector
Po and the pseudo class name so for the
block card we will be using the hor
pseudo class and let's try to add
that we can add it
here
and add
cursor
pointer now you can see that the default
pointer device is the arrow and when I
hold any card it is showing me the
pointer
device so in the similar way we want to
add some Shadow to the card to indicate
that the mouse is over that particular
card so for doing that we have a box
Shadow property in CSS so the way of
specifying the Box Shadow is in this way
so it accepts five parameters first is
the offset X second is offset y third is
the blur spread and last is the color so
offset X means how you want to position
your Shadow if you specify some positive
value here the Shadow will shift to the
right side and if you specify negative
value it will shift to the left same
thing applies for offset y if you
specify positive value it is going to
shift downwards and if you specify
negative value it is going to shift
upwards there are few more properties of
the Shadow one is blur spread and the
color of the Shadow so you can check
this out uh I have provided a link here
here which uh specifies some more
properties and how specifying these
different values how the shadow changes
so you can play around with that for now
we will use this
Shadow property and add it into the or
uh
style so you can see that let me zoom in
a
bit
so you can see that uh there is a shadow
here which appears when we ho or the
card so in this way we can also change
the background color of the card if we
want to also we can change the font size
all the colors and font size can be
altered here if we want to do that on
hor all right right
so that's the end of the session let's
conclude so in this tutorial we learned
how to create the responsive web page by
just writing less than 60 lines of CSS
code and uh we learned how to use scal
function in CSS to compute the width
dynamically for our block card and we
also use the object fit property so that
the blog images are not
stretched we also learned the child
selectors if we want to apply uh styles
to a particular element inside a
particular selector that can be done
using child selector there are few more
child selector that you can check I have
provided the
link and uh also we learned how to add a
shadow to the card using the pseudo
class
core so few tips that you should keep in
mind so don't create unnecessary HTML
tags and try to design the web page with
the minimum tags and same thing applies
for the CSS properties don't add
unnecessary CSS
properties check if the display Flex is
whether really required or not if it is
required then only add otherwise it it
will become very hard to scale on
various devices and lastly use
meaningful class names to make it human
rable and signify what they are doing so
if you look to the class names that we
have used so all have a meaning to what
element they are representing on our
HTML
page in today's web development
landscape CSS Frameworks play a crucial
role in simplifying and Expediting the
design and development process you've
been building web pages for some time
now and you may have seen that a lot of
effort goes into making sure that things
looks things look exactly how you need
them to and this is where CSS Frameworks
can help reduce the amount of code that
needs to be written and make the process
of web development more
efficient we are going to talk about the
bootstrap CSS framework today which is a
powerful and widely used toolkit for
designing responsive and mobile first
websites and bootstrap bootstrap offers
a vast array of pre-built components
utility
classes and a responsive grid system
which also makes it very easy for you to
work with flexbox without actually
having to write a lot of flex
properties So today we're going to see
how to install bootstraps CSS and
JavaScript bundles into a web
development project we're going to learn
how to modify bootstraps default Styles
which is colors and typography using CSS
variables we are also going to learn how
to use bootstraps breakpoints and grid
system for creating mobile first
responsive web pages we'll talk about
leveraging bootstraps utility classes
for applying layout and style changes
without writing a lot of CSS and finally
we'll also use bootstraps pre-built
components and examples for building a
web page quickly and
efficiently and the best way to learn
these skills is to follow along step by
step and type out all the code yourself
so I highly encourage you to do that the
more code you write and the more you ask
yourself about every line of code you
write the better you will become as a
web developer so always make sure that
you understand every line of code that
you're
writing so we will explore these Topics
by attempting to solve this problem
statement over the course of the past
few lessons we have been building a
jovian careers website so here is what
it looks like there is a nav bar here at
the top then there is a banner image
then there is an about Jovian section
followed by some employment
opportunities a table followed by an
application form followed by a footer at
the bottom so this is the website that
we have been building so far and and in
today's lesson in today's tutorial we
will rebuild this Jovian careers website
using the bootstrap CSS framework now
the reason we are rebuilding this same
site again and again is to understand
how to make the web development process
more efficient while at the same time
improve the Aesthetics and the
completeness or the finish of your
websites okay so that I would like you
to just keep that in mind today that you
will notice today that we're writing
less code but we're ending up with a
better website and that is something
that makes you far more efficient as a
web developer so specifically we will
add some links in the navigation bar as
well so here we have a navigation bar
We'll add some links here at the top and
we will also then make that collapsible
on mobile because you don't have a lot
of space to Show links on mobile so
we'll add a menu button over there we
will also show the list of jobs using
cards on mobile and using a table on
desktop so here we using a table on
desktop that is fine but we will also
see how to use cards on mobile devices
so right now we just have a list
here uh yeah so we are using cards of
some kind here but we'll see how to
improve the layout of these
cards using
bootstrap
and we will also make the color scheme
typography and layout a little more
consistent and a little more
aesthetically pleasing okay so this is
the website that we had and let's see
what we're able to create
today now of course we assume here that
you have basic knowledge of HTML and CSS
and there is also an assumption here
that you know about flexbox in
responsive design and Version Control
with GitHub and Cloud deployment to
versel all of this is covered in the
previous lessons so I would highly
encourage you to go back and review
specific pieces if some some of these
parts don't make sense
today now please post your questions in
the chat because we will pause
periodically and take questions and the
entire code for the tutorial can be
found here so the starter code which is
the site created in the previous
tutorial can be found here and the
starter site can be found here and you
can find the completed code and the
finished site using these links so the
first step today is going to be creating
a GitHub repository so I'm just going to
go in here into github.com and once I'm
logged in I'm going to click the new
button and now I am going to give this a
repository name so let me just call it
Jovian careers
bootstrap live because I'm doing this
live let me give it a short description
a jovian careers
website built using
bootstrap CSS
framework I'm going to make this a
public Repository so that you can access
this code when I'm done I am going to
add a readme file as well just so that I
have some initial code in the repository
I am going to add a git ignore file as
well so I'm just going to type node
which is going to generate the git
ignore file for JavaScript which is
going to ignore any files that are not
necessary to be saved in Version Control
things like temporary files or compiled
files
Etc and I'm going to add the MIT license
here so that people can build on top of
this and now I'm going to hit create
repository and with that our GitHub
repository is created perfect so now we
have a GitHub repository called Jovian
careers bootstrap live and we now need
to start developing this repository and
that is something that we'll do using
Cod
spaces so we are going to use a
cloud-based programming platform called
GitHub code spaces which lets us open up
vs code or Visual Studio code in the
browser so I'm going to just just click
the code button here and select create
code space on mean and that is going to
Now set up a new machine for us on the
cloud it is going to download the code
from the repository that we've just
created onto that new machine and then
it is going to allow us to start
developing it using this browser based
vs code and we can also start previewing
it as we develop the website okay so
there we go now this has just opened up
and I can open up any of the files here
and I can now open up any of the files
here and start editing them for example
I can open up the G ignore file here and
start editing it okay so with that our
basic development setup is complete we
have created a GitHub repository and we
have opened it up using GitHub codes
spaces the instructions are available in
the notes if you need them now to begin
we can set up a basic HTML page so we
are not going to copy over any code from
the previous uh tutorial we are going to
type out all the code or most of the
code from scratch today so let us create
an SRC folder within the repository it's
always a good idea to create an SRC
folder containing the actual files for
the project that are going to be
deployed into production because we
don't want to send our get ignore
license Etc into production and in the
SRC folder I'm going to create a new
file
index.html and now in my index.html I
can start putting in some things so I
can start by maybe a doc type tag which
just indicates that this is an HTML file
I can now go in and put in a head tag I
can go in and put in a body tag and now
I can start adding some information on
the web page so I'm just going to copy
over a few things here which is
something that we've been creating over
the past few weeks as well so I'm going
to copy a title tag so I'm I'm just just
going to have this title
tag in the head and this simply says
that the title of the page is Jovian
careers powered by bootstrap then I'm
going to copy a bunch of meta tags a
meta caret tag to indicate to the
browser that that we are using the utf8
character set so this is something that
you should put into pretty much every
website that you build I'm going to copy
over the meta viewport tag and The Meta
viewport tag specifically with the
content width equals device width an
initial scale equal 1.0 is necessary for
triggering responsive design otherwise
older mobile browsers may try to
automatically zoom in the content of
your page to adjust for a desktop
website so this is a way of telling the
browser that you have created a
responsive design don't worry about what
these specific things mean this is
something that you should have in pretty
much every web page I'm going to put
that in here as
well then I'm going to copy over a meta
description and a meta
OG properties so an OG or open graph
title open graph description and open
graph yeah open graph description and a
normal description all of these as we've
discussed in the previous lesson are
used when you share the link that you
have for the deployed web page with
somebody else so this is what this is
the title that is going to show up in
the link preview and this is the
description that is going to show up
below the link apart from that we are
also going to add a couple more tags so
there's going to be one tag called the
OG image tag this tag is going to
determine the image that shows up as the
preview image when you share this link
on WhatsApp slack or any other social
platform and that is going to be
something set to the Jovian meta PNG
file
and we're going to need that meta PNG
file so I'm just going to drag in that
meta PNG file from my desktop so I'm
just going to drag in this file from my
desktop into the SRC folder so this is
the file that is going to show up as the
preview this image is going to show up
as a preview when somebody shares the
link to our website
online okay finally I am also going to
drag uh put in a link tag with the Rel
equals icon and this is going to point
to the fave icon so the fave icon is
what is the icon the little icon that
shows up in the browser like this when
we open that website in the browser okay
so let us add that meta tag in here as
well so let's add the
fav ion meta tag and let us bring that
in here as well chian favicon.png
okay so with that we have a basic setup
of the
page let me just open it up here so we
have HTML head title meta a bunch of
meta tags then in the body because we
are going to create this Jovian career
side I'm just going to put in a bunch of
empty divs for now so I'm just going to
put in a nav bar and about Jovian div a
jobs list and application form so all of
these are just empty placeholder divs
along with HTML comments above them so
let's do that as well and let us just
format the
document okay looks good so now that we
have some code that we have added into
our HTML page we need a way to actually
see what this page looks like and that
is where we're going to use the live
server extension so I'm just going to
search live server and the live server
extension allows us to preview the web
page that we are building in our Cod
spaces machine which is running
somewhere on the cloud so it sets up a
server and it serves that page so that
we can open it on the browser and once
it is installed I can come back into my
index.html file and right here at the
bottom I should be able to see a go live
button or I can also just right click on
my index.html uh file and just select
open with live server either way once I
click
this you can see that the website is now
open all right so let me just put that
website here so this is the site that we
have right now and this is the site that
we're going to start slowly building you
can see that there's not a lot here even
if I zoom in there there is just this
Navar there's a bunch of divs with some
placeholder text within them and this is
site that we are going to slowly start
building using bootstrap
now with that out of the way we can
start actually using the bootstrap CSS
framework so bootstrap is a powerful
open source CSS framework and this is
the website of bootstrap get
bootstrap.css
and it has an extensive library of
pre-built components Styles and util
ities and it enables developers to
rapidly create visually appealing and
highly functional websites a lot of the
websites that you see on the internet
either use bootstrap or something very
similar to bootstrap some kind of a CSS
framework to add all the interactive
features all the various interesting
layouts that you see on most modern
websites
and there are many ways to install
bootstrap and you can check out the
different ways of installing bootstrap
on the website on the get started page
but the easiest way to use bootstrap is
to include it CSS and JavaScript
directly within an HTML page so
bootstrap has two parts it has a CSS
file which contains a bunch of existing
styles that you can use within your HTML
page and it has a Javascript file
JavaScript is used to enable some
interactivity things like drop-downs
popups tool tips Etc so there's a
Javascript file that you need to include
as well okay so let us first grab the
link tag so there are two things here
there is this link tag right over here
which contains the bootstrap CSS file so
I'm just going to grab that and it's
always a good idea to grab it from the
website because that is going to have
the latest version of bootstrap which
currently happens to be
5.3.0 so I'm just going to come in here
and I'm going to paste this link tag
right here right below you can see we
now have this link tag bootstrap.min.css
that gets included and you can also
command click this link and see what
that file contains so you can see that
it contains a whole bunch of CSS Styles
we will obvious obviously not be using
all of them but many of them are going
to be useful for what we're going to do
today okay so that is the link tag then
another thing that you can do is include
this script tag and interestingly this
script tag goes not in the head but in
the body and right at the bottom of the
body and the reason for this is you do
not want the loading of the script to
prevent or block the loading of the web
page and that is why putting it the
putting it at the end of the body
ensures that only after the entire
content of the HTML page is loaded only
then the Javascript file gets loaded
okay we don't do that for CSS because we
want the styles to load beforehand
otherwise if the Styles load after the
page loads there's going to be a
flickering effect but for the script
because a lot of the interactivity is
going to happen after all the content
loads it is okay to put that script at
the bottom of the page okay so I'm just
going to go in and put that script right
at the bottom of the page and you can
see again there is this bootstrap
bundle. min.js and this is all the
JavaScript that is getting included by
default so that is how you add
bootstrap to your web page and once you
save the
file and come here and reload the page
you can see already that the Styles have
changed significantly so earlier we had
a slightly different font we also had
some default padding but let's say I
comment this out you can see that we
there is some padding on the body you
can see that the font is slightly
different so there's already some change
that bootstrap has brought in in fact it
resets a lot of the basic Styles and it
sets up basic styles for text it sets up
basic colors for the text it sets up
basic font sizes fonts it sets up a
bunch of things by
default so that is how you set up
bootstrap now before we actually start
building something we will have to start
first maybe customize the bootstrap
setup to use the fonts and the colors
that we want to use because given the
whatever company you're working at
they're going to have their own
preferred fonts and colors that you
might want to use and you can override
or customize
bootstrap very easily and Frameworks
like bootstrap enable customization via
CSS variables and CSS variables also
known as custom properties allow you to
Define reuse usable values in your
stylesheets and this makes it easier to
manage an update values such as colors
and font sizes throughout your CSS code
so I'm going to give you a quick
tutorial of CSS variables and then we're
going to start customizing some CSS
variables to change what bootstrap gives
us now to define a CSS variable you need
to use the hyphen hyphen syntax or the
minus minus syntax so any time you put
minus minus followed by something that
is treated as a CSS variable that's the
first thing the second thing is uh as a
good practice you should always Define
your CSS variables in this selector
called colon root and this is just this
is called a pseudo selector this
basically says that you want to put
these variables and you want to make
these variables available right at the
very root of the CSS file so that it's
available no matter where you are in the
CSS file okay so it's it's it'll be at
the root of the document and it'll be
available across all different kinds of
styles maybe even inline Styles and
style tags within the page so here is
how you can create some CSS variables so
right now we don't have a CSS file that
is Con that is connected to this web
page but I can just put in a style tag
here for now and I can just create a
bunch of CSS variables here using the
root tag okay so now I have this root
and in the root I have set a primary
color to be a certain blue I've set a
secondary color to be a certain green
and I've set the font size to be 16
these styles are not applied to anything
yet these styles are just variables so
just like variables in any other
programming language The Hyphen hyphen
font size is a variable and it has the
value 16 pixels and similarly hyphen
Hyer primary color is a variable it has
the value blue or a variation of blue
okay and of course this is the hex code
of the color and vs code show very
helpfully shows us a preview as well now
once you've defined a CSS variable you
can then use it within some CSS property
and you can use it using the V function
in CSS so here is how you might use it
you might say something like body and
then you might set the background color
of body to where and then here you
provide the name of the color provide
the name of the variable hyphen hyen
primary color and now what's going to
happen is when I paste in this style and
I save the page you can see that the
body got a background of blue that's
because where primary
color invokes a search for CSS variables
and there is a CSS variable in the root
called primary color and its value has
been set to 3498 DB which is a blue
similarly the font size of the body is
going to search for the variable font
size and that is going to get the color
16 now the benefit of CSS variables is
you can now go in and you can actually
update these variables so once again if
I go in here and then let me also create
a button here just to complete this
example and let's put a button here here
right at the
top let's say click
me let's save that so there's a button
right here right at the top and this
button has the color secondary color and
the secondary color is a green so
clearly the button has a green color and
the CSS uh the body has a blue color now
you can go ahead and update a CSS
variable so you can either update it at
the same place where you defined it or
you can update it some where maybe let's
say you have a bunch of CSS files and
you've updated it in a second or third
file so let me just go in and update
these two values or just update the
primary
color and now you can see as soon as I
update the primary color to a purple
that automatically updates the
background color so wherever the
variable is used the color is now going
to get updated okay so now you can see
the value of CSS CSS variables I can
define a bunch of variables based on the
scheme that our design team has
currently given us then I can just use
those variables everywhere in my CSS
Styles and then when the design team
comes and says okay we need to change
the color we are moving from Blue to Red
we don't have to go in and edit a bunch
of different properties we just go to
our root tag our root selector we just
simply check the primary color and
change its color to whatever the design
team is asking us to do okay so that is
the value in CSS colors so that is a
value that CSS variables provide us okay
so for a moment I'm just going to get
rid of all of this now now that we
understand how CSS variables
work the last thing you can also do is
you can also provide a fallback value so
that let's say you providing a
background color and that is going to
come from a variable let's say this
variable is not defined for whatever
reason Somebody went and changed the
name of the variable or it was in a
certain file that did not actually get
included you can actually provide a
basic fallback or default def value as
well so this is something that I leave
as an exercise for you to test out okay
so you can learn more about CSS
variables and experimenting
experimenting and experiment with them
by following this guide on the Mozilla
developer Network so I'll let you check
it out as well but here's what I want to
now tell you customizing bootstrap is
done by changing CSS variables so many
of bootstrap's default color and
typography settings can be customized
using CSS variables and you can get the
full list of CSS variables that have
been defined in the bootstrap.min.css
file over here on bootstrap's
documentation website you can see these
are all the variables that have been
defined by default and what you can do
is you can now overwrite them in your
own style tag or style file and then
what is going to happen is all the
bootstrap classes which use these colors
are going to pick up the new colors that
you've provided or the new fonts or
sizes that you've provided okay so I
encourage you to check out all the
different variables that you can
actually
modify in in
bootstrap so that's one way using CSS
variables another way to bootstrap to
override bootstrap default Styles is
simply by supplying your own Styles in a
CSS file with appropriate selectors
let's say you don't want to change the
primary blue color for the entire
website only for a particular set of
buttons in a particular section you want
to change the color so you can just
provide the CSS selector maybe give it
an ID be given a special class and then
in that class you can simply go ahead
and apply the changes to that particular
button so remember that CSS styles are
cascading which means a more specific
rule can override a less specific Rule
and if two rules have the if two rules
have the same specificity then the rule
that appears last in order takes
precedence okay and this is something
that can be confusing and may require
some experimentation to understand so
let's make the following changes to our
page we will use the font Roboto for the
body text if you check the CSS variables
here it looks like there is the the font
family for the body BS body font family
this is what is going actually going to
be used in the body if you check the
bootstrap CSS file it itself uses the
variable BS font sanserif and looks like
BS font sanserif uses something called
system UI which is simply the
default sanserif font in the browser or
in the system or or in the operating
system all right so we don't want to use
this we want to always set it to Roboto
so that is one change we're going to
make then we will also use the font
inter for headings now if you check here
there is no specific font that has been
specified for headings looks like
bootstrap by default just uses a single
font for the entire page for all kinds
of text so that's where we can probably
use some CSS selectors and change the
font for headings and finally at Jovian
we have a specific blue color that we
use and there are different shades of
blue that different companies use about
half the companies on the Internet seem
to use a blue color for some reason but
we are going to use this
2067 F5 as the primary blue color and
you can see here that the primary color
that is used or the primary blue and
bootstrap is something else and there's
also this BS primary which is exactly
the same blue that is here at the top
we're going to change both of these the
BS blue if I zoom in a bit so we're
going to change the BS blue color and we
are going to change the
BS primary color as well to our desired
Jovian
blue okay so let's start doing this step
by step so first We'll add a sample
heading sample body text and maybe a
sample blue box that is going to be
present in the index HTML file so that
we can actually observe these changes
let me copy over this H1 tag this div
tag and also this third div or the
second div tag which has a height of 200
pixels and it uses the background V BS
blue so you can use CSS variables within
inline Styles as well so within the
actual style attribute let's go ahead
and let us just put this within the body
here and let us save
it and let's reload this page okay so
now now you can see we have H1 so this
is the H1 tag and the H1 tag has the
sample heading and then we have some
sample body text so I've just created
some sample body text and of course I've
zoomed in here a bit that's why it looks
big this is the ual size but let me Zoom
back in so that you can actually see
this properly and we've created this box
here which contains the default blue
color of bootstrap as the background it
has a height and width of 200 pixels
each okay it's using the bootstrap blue
as the color next we can now first to
change any fonts we have to first import
fonts from Google fonts so you can
always go into Google fonts and let's
say there are a couple of fonts that you
need to use you can go into that
particular font you can add all the
styles that you need and once you've
added all the Styles which I've done
here for inter and
Roboto and generally speaking you should
be able to copy over pretty much all the
Styles because you might you don't know
which one you might need then you can
come in here and you can actually go
ahead and copy a link tag so if I zoom
if I scroll up here you can see that
there is this link tag that can be
copied and that link tag has to be added
into our index.html file to load these
fonts from Google fonts onto the page
okay so I'm just going to add this link
tag right below my bootstrap link
tag okay and let's format the document
once again as well perfect so now we've
included some fonts but of course no
change has been made yet because we've
not actually used those fonts next let
us set up a styles. CSS file and connect
it to index.html using a link tag within
the head so I'm going to come back in
here I'm going to create a file
styles.css
and I am going to link L
it using a link tag so link Rel equals
stylesheet HF equals styles.css so I'm
just going to put that into Styles into
the index. HTML file now one important
thing you should keep in mind here is
you have to put the your custom Styles
below the bootstrap Styles because that
is the order in which the CSS variables
will be read so if you put it above
what's going to happen is first your CSS
variables will be read and then the
bootstrap CSS variables will get read
and and those bootstrap CSS variables
will override your values but you want
to do the opposite you want to take the
bootstrap CSS variables and you want to
overwrite them and then all the classes
that are present in the bootstrap CSS
file will automatically pick up the
overridden value so that is the
interesting way in which you can go back
and you can change some of the Styles in
in bootstrap okay all right so now we
have the styles.css file still there is
no change that has happened now let us
start by first adding this root tag and
then changing a couple of or a three
properties so we're going to change the
variable BS font Sans serif you can see
here that there is this
BS there is this BS font Sans serif this
is what is actually going to be used as
the body font family so the body font
family variable gets used in the body if
you study the bootstrap structure um so
I'm just going to come in here and I'm
going to create the root tag and you can
see as soon as I pasted it a bunch of
things have changed and we can disable
these and we can observe the changes one
by one first let us keep an eye on the
text over here as soon as I enable this
you can see that there has been a slight
change in the text it's
very it's very minute but if you just
look at it carefully you see this is
different and this is different right so
these are minor changes in the font but
you want to get the company font the
font that your company uses that's why
this is important let's then change this
blue color as well again it's going to
be very
subtle yeah so looks like there's a
minor change here in the blue you may
not even be able to detect it but I can
always go in here and just for the sake
of testing I can go in and maybe make
this a green color and you can see that
now the color changes to Green right so
whatever value you set for the BS blue
CSS variable that is going to override
the default value in bootstrap and that
is then going to be used within all the
classes within wherever you want to use
uh this color okay so I'm going to reset
it back to the color that we had for
Jovian and just like that we have
modified a few basic Styles we've
modified the body font family and we've
modified the blue and primary colors to
our desired color of course we also want
to use the inter font for headings so
that is something that we can simply do
by adding these selectors H1 to H6 and
we can simply set their font family to
enter with a fall back to Sans siif if
the font could not be loaded so let me
come in here and you can see that there
is a slight change here to The Heading
and I can even come in here and maybe
know check out the font
weight six and set that to 600 you can
see now my fonts or my headings are a
bit thicker so remember that if just
because you've used bootstrap does not
mean you can not use your own CSS Styles
you can customize pretty much everything
in bootstrap and simplest way to do it
is often to just add a class let's say
there's a particular button you want to
customize just add a class to that
button and simply go into your CSS file
and then apply the styles to that
particular button or div or whatever it
is okay and with that we have performed
a bunch of customizations the and we can
now get rid of the sample heading sample
body text and the sample div that we had
and we can proceed with the rest of our
website right now I want to point out
that there's actually a much more much
deeper customization that you can do at
a
very specific component level within
bootstrap and bootstrap is written using
this language called SAS which is
essentially an extension of or an
expanded version of CSS that can then be
compiled down to plain CSS for
distribution and for more advanced
customizations you can actually go into
bootstrap source code you can make
changes to the original SCF CS files
which is what bootstrap is written in
that this is the format of the file and
then compile them down to your own CSS
file and all of that is described on the
bootstrap documentation website okay
most of the time you will not need to do
this but in some certain cases where you
cannot figure out a way to do it by
using CSS variables or using custom
classes you can go ahead and simply edit
the scss files and generate a new uh CSS
file for your project okay so as as an
exercise I would encourage you to maybe
make some more changes to the page
either by modifying bootstrap CSS
variables or by providing custom Styles
within the styles.css file and observe
their changes on the web page now let's
talk about how you can build responsive
layouts so bootstrap contains built-in
breakpoints media queries and a grid
system to create responsive layouts
simply by adding some classes to HTML
elements without requiring any custom
CSS and this is one of the nicest things
about using bootstrap that you don't
have to write breakpoints and media
queries yourself replacing CSS
properties with utility classes is one
of the biggest benefits that you can get
from a CSS framework and we will explore
multiple CSS Frameworks over the course
of this program this course and future
courses but all of them will have this
common pattern that they're going to
take away some CSS that you had to
earlier write manually and just turn
them into simple classes that you can
include within your HTML file so first
let's understand the buil-in breakpoints
and boot straps because in bootstrap
because it's still useful for us to know
this so breakpoints in bootstraps are in
bootstrap are predefined screen widths
that help you create responsive designs
for various devices like smartphones
tablets and
desktops and bootstrap uses a mobile
first approach which means that the boot
which means that the styles that you
supply for the smallest breakpoint will
automatically follow through or get
applied to bigger breakpoints until you
choose to change them all right so that
is where you should always first design
the mobile version of your site make
sure that it looks good on mobile and by
default all those Styles will carry over
into the bigger layouts as well and then
you can specify some custom Styles when
you get to a tablet layout and just make
the required changes that you need and
then you can again uh go to a desktop
layout and specify some more changes so
that is called mobile first responsive
design with incremental adaptation to
increasing screen size so by default the
styles that you supply to bootstrap they
get applied on excess screens which is
screens smaller than 576 but of course
they also carry over to bigger screens
then if you can if you supply some style
for the S screen and we'll see where
this SM word actually gets applied then
that is going to only apply to screens
that are bigger than 576 pixels then if
you want to apply some styles for bigger
or brows with a bigger width width
greater than 768 pixels you then use the
MD and then similarly there's a breako
for LG Xcel and
XSL okay so the way you create layout
changes for specific breakpoints is not
by writing media queries but by simply
using certain class prefixes in your
HTML markup and don't worry if that
doesn't make sense right now because
we're going to see an example of that
very shortly so the first key component
that we are going to use from bootstrap
or the first key layout element is
containers and whenever you want to use
some kind of a responsive layout
whenever you want to do something
interesting with bootstrap where the
layout changes across different wids you
have to first create a container okay
and the way you create a container is by
simply adding the class container to a
div that's it so you create a container
by creating a div and giving it the
class container now bootstrap comes with
three different containers or three
different types of containers and we'll
take a look at them one by one so the
simplest container that you can create
in bootstrap is just by creating this
div and giving it the class container
okay I'm also going to give it a height
and width so I'm just going to give it
maybe a width of 200 PX height of 200
PX or actually let me just give it a
height not a width right now because the
WID WID is going to be set automatically
so I'm going to give it a height of 200
PX and I'm going to give it a background
of let's use the blue BS blue now we
have this container uh we have just
created a div with the class container
and we've given it a height of 200
pixels and a background of blue and you
can see here that this container has
this property that it is always centered
on the page and you can see when the
when the page is really
small maybe let's use browser tools to
see the this it's going to be slightly
easier to do it this way yeah you can
see that when the page is very small it
takes up the full width of the page but
as we start increasing as soon as we
cross the excess
boundary okay now looks like up to
500 okay up to 576 pixels it takes up
the full width and then its width
reduces and it just remains centered on
the page and then we hit the next break
point which would be about 768 at 768 it
becomes a little bigger but but it still
remains centered on the page it still
does not take up the entire page and
then as we keep going we hit the next
break point and then when we hit the
next breakpoint at around 9 996 pixels
or so it once again expands and it
remains centered in the page and so on
okay so this is what happens when
remember we were doing all this business
of setting a of first creating a div and
then centering it using margin zero Auto
by adding left and right equal margin
and at various break points adding
various wids well bootstrap has already
done that for us and you can simply add
the class container and when you add the
class container till about 768 pixels or
so so till about the let's see what this
means yeah till about 768 pixels it's
going to occupy the full width no till
about 576 pixels it's going to occupy
the full width now at more than 576
pixels it's going to be 540 pixels at
more than 768 pixels it's it's going to
be 720 pixels wide at more than 9 960
pixels it's going to be 960 pixels wide
and so on okay so it's it just gives you
a nice centered div or or horizontally
centered div on the page and you can put
all your content inside this div okay so
the container is going to contain all of
the rest of your page content now of
course you may not always want this what
you may want is maybe you may want it to
always occupy the full width if you want
it to occupy the full width just use the
class container fluid if you use the
class container fluid and let me reload
that page if you use the class container
fluid then it's going to always occupy
the full width of the page all right
that's container fluid and then there
are various steps in between you could
do something like this you could say
container SM and if you say container SM
so up to the highest point of SM which
is just before MD it's going to probably
still use up okay or up to the size SM
it's going to use up the full width and
from the size SM it's going to become
centered okay so container SM I think
it's going to do the same thing as
container for us up to 540 pixels it's
going to take up the full width at at
560 or 576 pixels it's going to become
centered you can also use container MD
Now container MD is going to take up the
full width till 768 pixels and at 768
pixels it's going to start restricting
its width and progressively increase
size with break points similarly you can
do container LG which is going to use up
the full up to a certain large size and
then after a certain point it's going to
use the center okay so depending on when
you want to constrain the content of
your page you can decide which container
you want to use and for now I'm just
going to use set it back to div
container and what that is going to do
is given no matter what width I'm at
it's going to just Center the content a
little bit on the page have some padding
left and right okay so that is the
container that is the first basic thing
no matter what you're doing in bootstrap
what whatever page you're building the
first thing you'll probably do is just
create a
container okay so one thing you can do
as an exercise is maybe create a bunch
of containers one below the other and
give them all different container
classes and see what happens to each of
them as you resize the page now the next
thing that we need to understand once
we've talked about containers is the
grid system so every container contains
12 columns you cannot actually see these
columns right now but every container is
inherently or internally divided into 12
columns and then what you can do is you
can decide to put content and you can
decide how many columns that content can
take up okay so here is an example you
can you can just maybe have a bunch of
dips you can have maybe 12 dips each of
them takes up one column and there is
also some space between the columns or
you can have something like two two divs
and you can have six of those divs
taking up six columns or you can even
combine things you can maybe have a div
that takes one column you have have a
div that takes two column next to it a
div that takes some more columns next to
it and so on okay so whenever you need
to horizontally arrange columns in a row
or so whenever you want to arrange divs
in a row and you want to control their
relative width that is when you use this
grid system and the grid system is
invoked using two classes so the first
class is a row so let's say you want to
create three divs here you want to
create three divs and each of those divs
should have an equal width so here's
what you can do within your container
remember all of this always happens
within a container create a class create
a div with a class
row okay now we've created div with the
class row nothing has changed here yeah
nothing has changed here now I can
create a div with the
class
column okay and let me just call
this box
one and let me also maybe give it a
border let's give it a nice solid black
border and let's create a couple more
Dives like this okay so I'm simply
creating a few I've created a row and
that is going to Simply put things in a
vertical order then I'm going to create
a bunch of boxes here box two and box
three okay and let's see what happens so
you can see now that we have taken the
container and then there is this row div
that has been created and I can just go
in and actually get to that row div here
as well just by selecting inspect
element yeah so there is this row that
has been created and then Within that
row we have these three columns let me
just make the background white for these
just so
that you can actually see these
clearly yeah so within the rows we have
these within the rows we have these
three columns okay box one box two and
box three now something I can do is I
can actually specify ratios for for
these I can say call one which means I'm
wanted to take up one out of 12 columns
and I can say call two I want this to
take up two out of 12 columns and I can
say maybe call six so now you can see
that I have this box one which takes
roughly one 12th of the space available
in that row okay this is the entire row
and it takes up 1 12th of the space box
two on the other hand takes up 2 12th or
one six of the space and box three takes
up six columns right so imagine there
are 12 columns here and what we've
specified here is call One Call 2 and
call six are the relative column wids
that should be taken up now of course I
can play around with this let's say I
want four columns for Row one and then I
want two columns for this so 4 + 2 6 and
then the remaining half goes here and
let's say maybe what if I had three
columns what would that do so now you
see what happens when I have four
columns here plus three columns here so
that becomes 7 7 + 6 becomes 13 and then
the next column automatically drops onto
the next line okay so it's using Flex
boox internally but you don't have to
worry about Flex bases Flex grow Etc you
just tell it how many columns uh how
many columns should be taken up by a
particular box and it's going to
automatically uh arrange the wids and if
the number of columns in a particular
row goes higher than 12 then it's going
to drop down into the next uh next line
automatically okay now where this gets a
little more interest testing is that you
can actually modify the widths of each
of these boxes based on the break points
okay so we can start out like this we
can just say call 12 which means we want
box one box two box three all of them to
take up all 12 columns okay so no matter
what width I am at it is going to take
up the entire width of the row and that
is why even though it's it's supposed to
be a row because box one takes up all 12
columns box two drops onto the next line
box three drops onto the next line and
so on right so this is fine but maybe
when I get to and this is maybe nice for
a mobile layout I want to show three
things one below the other but maybe
when I get to a tablet or a MD layout I
want to show maybe box two and box 3
together or some other layout so then
you could do something like this you
could say that okay
at MD so you can say call hyphen MD so
what you're saying is when we hit the MD
breakpoint of 7 68 pixels I want box one
to take up only six columns okay so
remember we are going mobile first so
first everything takes up 12 columns but
now I want box one to take up six
columns so I'm going to come back in
here and I'm going to add the class call
md6 and with that you will see that as
soon as I cross 768
pixels box one starts taking up only six
columns and not 12 columns now of course
box two is still falling on the next
line because there are not enough
columns to fill its 12 and maybe then
once again we want to use six columns
for box two as
well right and now you see what happened
that up to 768 pixels all of them show
up one below the other but as soon as we
go into
767 769 pixels box one and box two come
up side by side and the reason they're
coming up side by side is because we
have overridden the property at this
break point using call md6 and call md6
and at maybe at MD we still want to
retain 12 for the third column so we
don't technically we don't need this
property because it's simply going to
carry over from whatever is there here
so whether I keep this or I don't keep
this it's not going to make a difference
it's box three is always going to take
up the full width
now let me also increase the body font
size a
bit
oh let me just increase the font sizes
of the
columns yeah so that our columns are a
little bigger I'm just using font sizes
of
30 okay perfect so now I have box one
box two and box three and this is on MD
and now at some point we're going to now
hit maybe the next layout which is going
to be LG right so LG is going to be
about 968 pixels or 992 pixels or
so so there's no change yet but maybe on
a very large screen I want to show all
three columns side by side so in that
case I can do something like this I can
say call lg4 and I can apply that style
to all of them so let me go
into the first box and use call lg4 let
me go into the second box and use call
lg4 you can see now that as soon as we
crossed about 96
996 pixels or
so now box one and box two are no longer
taking up half of the row they're only
taking up 1/3 of the row which is four
out of 12 columns and now we can maybe
take box three and put this here on the
corner so let me also
apply call lg4 and now box 3 show shows
up here as well okay and we could do
this in a slightly different way as well
we can maybe use call LG3 for the first
two boxes and maybe six for the third
box because the third box may have more
content so now you see what we've
achieved we've not written a single line
of CSS but we've achieved this very
interesting layout where first we have
box one box two box three all three of
these and you can put any content inside
this maybe an image a heading and then a
and then some text and then as soon as
we or maybe a heading text and then some
content as soon as we go into the tablet
layout which is about this much then box
one and box two come up side by side
because we have more space now so we can
do that and as soon as we go into LG
then box one box two box three all show
up side by side and they have the
proportions that we need this is very
very powerful and if you can Master
using bootstraps grid and if you can
know what are the right properties to
use here then things are going to become
really really easy for you okay so that
is the bootstrap grid system using rows
and columns now one thing I want to
mention here that you have to have this
row if you want to put put things into a
column okay if I don't have this row
class
here
then every all the divs inside the
container are going to be one below the
other you cannot avoid that although the
column the number of columns they pick
is still going to get picked so box one
is picking three columns box two is
picking three columns as well and box
three is picking six columns right so
that's they're picking up the right wids
but they're not showing up in a single
row because to to make them show up in a
single row you have to drop them you
have to wrap them in a particular row
Dev okay so keep that in
mind all right so that is the that is
how this behaves on excess screens all
columns take up the full row width and
show one below the other on MD screens
768 and above column 1 and two take up
half the row width while column 3 takes
up the full row WID and on LG screens
all three columns are on the same row
and we can decide what are their
relative
proportions now I would encourage you to
experiment with bootstraps grid system
so there are a couple of resources you
can check out one is the documentation
itself and it has a bunch of different
examples and you can just click this
button and live edit these examples so
it's going to open up a cloud editor for
you and you can start editing this is of
course the equal layout but you can also
have these unequal layouts like this and
you can do a whole bunch of things so I
would encourage you to experiment with
this there are are also a bunch of
examples that are given along with the
documentation so you can check these out
as well okay make sure you get a strong
a clear understanding of how the grid
system works now apart from this you can
also sometimes you may not need a column
on the left and a column on the right
you may just want to maybe just shift a
particular column a little bit so then
you can also use something called an
offset so an offset is useful when you
want to add some empty space before a
column and you can apply an offset using
the dot using the off offset star class
where offset represents the number of
columns that you want to leave empty for
a specific breakpoint for example we
could have something like this we have a
div and the we have a container inside
it we have a row and inside it we have
just a single div okay now we don't have
multiple divs we have just a single div
and I'm actually just going to copy this
class from
here and I'm going to get rid of all of
these so now I have a row but what I
want is I want this box to only take up
six of the columns and I want it to
leave three columns on the left and that
is what the offset does so when I say
offset three it's going to leave out
three columns on the left and it's going
to start from the fourth column if I set
that to offset one you can see that it
leaves one column here empty and it then
spans six columns I can of course then
maybe set it to call 7 and you can see
that it actually does that and I can
also then play around with break points
I can say that maybe this offset should
kick in only at MD so when I have the
when I have the basic layout on mobile
there is no offset here the column it
shows up right from the left Edge and
maybe there's something else I want to
put here but as soon as I cross 768
pixels you will notice here as soon as I
cross 768 pixels there this offset gets
added okay and I can control this offset
maybe I want this to be offset 6 in
which case it is going out now offset
has this property that if you set too
high offset it's simply going to go out
of the of the Rope it's not going to go
into the next row because that doesn't
really make sense for an offset so yeah
so keep that in mind that if you don't
actually need to create a column you
just need to maybe shift a column a
little bit you can offset and of course
you can combine things here as well so
you can do something like maybe this is
three columns with an offset of two and
above this you have another
box so this is box zero and maybe this
is one
column yeah so you could have something
like this you have this one column box
over here then you have a three column
offset and then you have a three column
box over here okay so you can create all
sorts of interesting layouts uh using
offsets so that is all about offsets
in the bootst grid system next I want to
talk about something called gutters now
in the grid system you can you have 12
columns but those columns do not have to
essentially necessarily stick together
to each other you can have a gap between
those
columns and you can specify gaps between
those columns using the gutter or the G
or the G Class so you can specify at the
row level you can simply say that you
when you're creating a row you want the
gutter to be of a certain size okay and
the there are sizes the sizes go from 0
to five and it's not 0 to 5 pixels you
can actually check inspect and check I
believe it's zero time I believe it's a
multiples of four or something like that
so a gutter of three would essentially
result in 3 fours about 12 pixels or
there's some kind of a ratio that that
it actually ties into uh there is some
responsive layout that it handles but
just think of the gutter sizes as a sort
of a scale of 0 to five that you can
modify things for okay so let us come
back here and let us maybe revert to the
columns that we have so we had three
columns
here yeah so we have three columns
here and all these three columns you can
see show up like this uh and there's a
sort of a responsive design in play here
already now if I just add G3 you can see
that some content or
some space has been added on the left
and right and also between these columns
and for now let me just make these very
simple columns so I'm just going to make
it call
three each of these is going to be a a
call
Four yep so you have a call 4 and maybe
G3 doesn't seem to be working okay yeah
it is yeah so the gutters are the spaces
and as we increase the space you'll see
that the gutter should
increase
let's see well this doesn't seem to be
doing the
job probably because of
the yeah let's add a border to
this
okay so let's take a look at this so you
can see that there is some Gap here and
there is some Gap here now if we remove
this
gutter you can see that some of that Gap
disappears now that Gap should also show
up between columns I am not 100% sure
why it's not showing up right now maybe
it's because I maybe that that Gap is
actually getting is going to get added
inside the Border that's why we're not
seeing it um but yeah so what the gutter
does is it adds gaps on the left right
and between your columns right so you
can check maybe
G4 or let's just try
gx4 and G
y4 yeah so gutters should add gutter
should add gaps I believe it's because
it's probably going to overlap with the
Border here that is why it's not showing
up but whenever you want to add spacing
between the columns then you can simply
set the gutter on the row variable okay
so you can check out the documentation
for gutters here this is this is exactly
what it should look like so there should
be some column there should be some uh
space here some space here and some
space here on the right and similarly
here you can see that there is a gutter
on the left and right and that gutter
can also be changed customized on the
left right and bottom as well so you can
have some spacing between the columns
you can have some spacing between the
rows when things overflow into the next
line and that is being set here you can
see using
gy5 and so
on okay so that is all about how you use
the bootstrap grid system so the key
things for you to keep in mind are
always use a container and the three
types of container are a container that
is always kind of centered and
restricted and then a container that is
completely fluid that always takes up
the full width of the page and a
container that takes up a full width up
to a certain breakpoint and from that
breakpoint it remains centered on the
page okay so just use bootstrap
containers don't you don't have to
create your own containers or add your
own break points or maximum wids
generally speaking your bootstrap
container should do the job for you okay
now apart from containers you have rows
and columns so you can create a row and
then you can put a bunch of boxes in a
row and then you can specify their
widths using the 12 column grid system
and you can change the widths based on C
certain break points you can also then
use offsets and you can also specify
specific gutters and based on uh the Gap
that you need between your
columns okay now next thing I want to
talk about bootstrap utility classes
because this is also something that
we're going to use when we start
building our websites so utility classes
in bootstrap are single purpose reusable
classes that can help you quick quickly
style and modify elements in your
project and they include various aspects
of styling such as spacing text
backgrounds Etc the key idea here is for
a single line of CSS property that you
might want to put in the CSS file you
can simply include a utility F utility
class that's going to do the job for you
so here are a few utility classes that
uh we're going to look at the first is
spacing related utilities spacing simply
means margins and paddings so bootstrap
provides a bunch of classes like this so
you can say Mt hyphen 3 and what that
does is it says margin top should be set
to three and again this is not three
pixels this is just on a scale of 0 to
five this is a certain five is a very
high pad margin 0er is zero margin so it
is just somewhere in between and you can
verify what that actual value is by
inspecting it in your browser and
similarly you can say mt3 or you can say
mb2 okay so T includes t means top b
means bottom so just using these few
characters we've specified the margin
top and margin bottom or we could also
do something like this we could do p
hyphen 4 which means that you want a a
padding of four units not four pixels
four units on all sides let's see what
that actually
means so let's maybe go in here get rid
of this container over here and simply
post these in so you can see now this
particular div that we have here this
div has a top margin of three and what
do we mean by three well if we just in
look at the styles for this div the
computed
Styles you will see that this div has a
margin of 16 so three simply means maybe
about 16 and this div has a bottom
margin of two so that is 8 so I believe
it works 1 is 4 and 2 is 8 and 3 is 16
and 4 is 32 and so on so yeah so mt3
means a margin of 16 pixels at the top
and M mb2 means a margin of 48 pixels
and you can go ahead and change this you
can change this to maybe mb5 and see
what that changes it to now the margin
becomes 48 all right so you can always
check what these margins are and let's
check this div so this div does not have
margins but this div has paddings so it
has a padding of four pixels all around
it or a padding of 24 pixels all around
it so P4 simply adds 24 pixels on all
sides I could also do PX4 and py3 in
case I wanted to just X direction is
left and right and Y direction is top
and bottom now you can see that top and
bottom py3 applies a padding of 16
pixels and left and right py4 applies or
PX4 applies a padding of 24 pixels so
this is how you can quickly apply
paddings and they've already set some
some default values so that the spacing
doesn't look very off so always just try
out maybe mt1 mt2 mt3 and see which one
works best for for the
layout okay so those are the spacing
related utilities apart from that we can
also
use utility classes for styling text for
example you maybe want to Center some
text or maybe you want to make these
make it italic or so FST stands for font
style or maybe you want to change the
font weight you want to change the font
weight to bold so all of those things
are something again you can do using
utility classes so I can come back in
here and I can just drop this in and you
should see that this text is now bold
because it has the class FW bold and by
the way if you're ever curious what
styles does a particular class actually
apply you can come into the inspect
tools and you can check the Styles Tab
and in the Styles tab you can see that
the class FW bold applies the font
weight of 700 okay so that's what it
actually does so there's a very deep
level of CSS inspection that you can do
whenever you're looking at a website or
maybe youve just use some bootstrap
class and you want to know what exactly
it does just right click on the text
just click
inspect oops Yeah just click
inspect just click inspect and then you
can either check the layout here using
in the computer tab or you can go into
the Styles T Styles Tab and see the
exact styles that have been applied for
each of the selectors that applied to
this particular file okay or to this
particular element and FW bold is
clearly coming from bootstrap and it
sets a font we to bold let's check this
one this FST italic this checks this
sets the font style to italic and then
we have text centered this is simply
going to Center the text of course you
could also do text right or something
like that and that is going
to put the text on the right maybe it's
text align right
okay I don't know so yeah maybe there's
a way to align the text to the right I
would just probably look it up in the
documentation so how do you know these
how do you know what utility classes are
available well you just have to check
the documentation if you check the
documentation of bootstrap you can see
that there is a section called utilities
and then there are various utilities for
text display Flex Etc so we were looking
at text and you can see that there is
text alignment so you have oh you have
text start and text end so if you want
to align something right you have to say
text end and this is because it supports
right to left layouts as well you can
see that now text has moved to the end
so I would just keep the utility section
of bootstrap open and look it up how is
it better than typing out classes in
your CSS file because by using a utility
class you are collocating the style with
the HTML so at a glance it's going to be
very easy for a developer or just for
you to be able to identify ify what are
the styles that are getting applied to a
particular HTML element okay so utility
classes are great because they just
bring the Styles into the HTML and help
you get a clear picture of what the what
the element is going to look like okay
then there are a bunch of background
utilities so you could do something like
this you could let's say set the
background color to the primary color
which is the blue that we have set so
let's create this div over here let's
get rid of these text utility classes
and this this is a particular div let's
format
that yeah so you can see that this div
has a primary background color which is
the blue color that we've set and it has
the color of the text white so you can
say text white that is going to Simply
change the color of the text and I could
also do something like P4 let's say if I
wanted to add some padding to it and I
could also add borders and things like
that so there are lots of utility
classes available that you can apply
here there are also dis display related
utilities so let's say you want to
change the display property remember you
can have block Flex inline all of those
things uh you can do all of that using
display properties as well so let's look
at an
example so now we've created this span
and we've set its display to inline
block using D hyphen inline hyphen block
so the shortcut or the Shand for the
display utilities D and hyphen inline if
you wanted to show it in line or hyphen
block if you wanted to show it um block
within in line so all of these have
different meanings this is going to turn
it into a flex container and again you
can verify you can just go in here click
inspect and you can check that this is
actually this has the display type flex
and you can verify that it actually has
a display type Flex by putting a bunch
of items inside it so let's say let me
put item
one item
two item
three you can see that they show up in a
row of course if this was not flex but
if it was
block then item one item two item three
would show up one below the other okay
um but and I could also have set it to d
none so I could have done something like
this that this is just simply not
visible and here's one trick let's say
you want to make something visible for a
particular size for a particular break
point so you can say d none and then you
can say d MD block or let's maybe say
DSM block and let's say DMD
Flex okay so what we saying here is I
don't want this div to show up by
default I want this div to show up as
block on SM and higher which means 576
pixels and higher and then on 768 pixels
and higher I want it to show up as a
flex div which means its items are going
to show up in a row okay so here this
and let's just give it a little bit of
padding as well so let's give it P3 and
let us give it uh BG
blue so that you can actually see what's
happening here okay so right now that
div is not showing up item one item two
item three let's get rid of this upper
span and now if I just increase it
slightly okay I guess DSM blog did not
actually work out here for some
reason
I'm not sure why but DSM block should
also show up but you can see here when
we set when we set it to uh let's just
put it this
way okay that initially it's set to
display none and when we Clause when we
go to
MD we want it to show up as
Flex
yeah okay let's just look let's just do
this so d none so it is none by default
and when we go into the SM layout which
is the small layout it's going to turn
into block so you can see that below by
at this point it is not visible at all
and let's just set this to BG
primary or how do you set the background
yeah BG primary should be fine
yeah so it's not this div is not showing
up here but as soon as we cross
569 pixels or 5 576 pixels then this
becomes visible and you can see that it
is using the layout block SM block and
let us add DMD Flex here so that when we
cross 768 pixels it should show up as a
flex container so all its items should
go into a row and you can see now that
its items have gone into a row okay if I
come back at SM it is blocked so its
items show one below the other and it is
just not visible on small screen on
excess screens okay so these are the
display utilities is very useful for
just hiding and displaying things
sometimes you may want to do it the
other way around and of course we it
also contains a bunch of utilities
around Flex box so one of course is D
Flex or DMD Flex or DSM Flex so all of
these utilities you can trigger them at
specific break points so you can say
dyen MD or BG hyphen MD hyphen blue or
primary Etc and all of these
utilities um can then also and there are
a bunch of flexbox related utilities as
well specifically the few the two you
might use and are justify content and
align items so let's just take a look at
an example of this so here these are now
this is now Flex div okay
and let me just also give it a big font
size
yeah so this is now a flex container at
MD screens and I could do something like
this I could
say
justify
content
Center and now you can see that along
the main axis because Flex direction is
row by default all the content is
Justified at the center or I could say
space
between or I believe it's just between
yeah so now we have added space between
the content so that is the other way
this can work or I could say justify
content
end and now all of the content is
Justified at the end similarly you can
have align items as well so let's say we
give this a height so let's say we give
this
a height of 300
pixels now I could do this I could say
align items end and you can see that
items 1 2 3 have all moved to the end
right and the most common use case would
be probably align item Center where you
want to Center them along the cross axis
and sometimes you want to combine that
with justify content Center and what
that essentially ends up doing is it
centers no matter where you are of
course the flex gets triggered only at
at LG or at MD but no matter how you
increase the height or width of the page
the content is going to remain centered
vertically and horizontally okay you
have all these nice utilities where you
don't have to go into your styles.css at
all you can simply just add them at the
class level in the HTML so I encourage
you to create a simple layout using the
bootstrap F utility classes where you
create a container with three equal
width columns then set the top and
bottom padding of each column to size
three and then apply a different
background color to each column and
ensure that the text inside is white and
then try to Center the text horizontally
and vertically within the columns so try
to do all of this and make sure and also
maybe throw in some changes at specific
breakpoints and make sure that you are
able to do all of this without writing
anything within the CSS file okay you
have to look up the documentation and
you have to achieve a certain layout
just using bootstrap CSS utility classes
and let's see if you can do that the way
to become comfortable is just to
exercise there's no way you can remember
all of these things it's just the more
you use them the more they get committed
to memory
we've now learned about the bootstrap
grid system it's pretty extensive it
allows you to do a lot of interesting
things we have learned about bootstrap
utility classes they allow you to apply
text Styles background Styles Flex
Styles display Styles Etc now we are in
a position to actually start building
out our page and we're not going to
write the HTML of our page from scratch
completely in the sense that we're not
going to just use grid and styles we're
actually going to use some components
that the the creators of bootstrap have
already put together for us okay so
bootstrap offers a wide range of
pre-built components and these
components are designed to streamline
the development of responsive mobile
first projects and these components
provide a solid foundation for creating
visually appealing and also highly
functional websites now there are a
bunch of different components and we'll
go through various uh we'll go through
some of them definitely not all it's a
huge library with a whole bunch of
components but the few categories are na
navigation components so things like
navigation bars headers Footers
breadcrumbs pagination that is something
that we'll find in bootstrap then there
are layout components so you can create
cards you can create list groups you can
create media objects like images Etc
there are a bunch of form related
components so the creators of bootstrap
have set up SE special classes for
rendering forms nicely so that you don't
have to do a lot of work to show forms
on your web pages there are a bunch of
modal components which is basically
popups that overlay the entire screen or
things like dropdowns and Tool tips that
you can add um then there are of course
like a bunch of utility components like
small alerts and badges and small things
that you can use to highlight important
information within your page and there
are also a lot of interactive components
and this is where a lot of the
JavaScript is used because remember we
used a we imported a JavaScript module
as well so that's where we have like
accordians carousal tabs Etc and I
encourage you to check out these three
not going to cover them today so they
will possibly be get covered as part of
a future assignment or something but I
encourage you to maybe play around with
these a little bit
okay so you can check out the various
components offered by bootstrap here so
bootstrap has this section called
components in its documentation and
there are a whole bunch of components
that you can pick up so I'll I'll let
you check these out and then there are
also several examples on bootstrap's web
page on how to use these comp components
in a proper page so here there are some
common patterns for building headers nav
bars building the hero or sort of the
main section maybe building some feature
sections building sidebars so you can
create all sorts of interesting layouts
using bootstrap components so check out
the documentation for components and
maybe also check out examples so
whenever you're working on a project
these two pages are going to contain a
lot of useful information for you so
with that let us redesign the Jovian
careers website so this is the Jovian
careers website right now this is what
it looks like there's a nav bar there's
a banner image there's this about
section employment opportunity submit
your application Etc so let's redesign
the careers website step by step using
bootstrap components as mentioned in the
problem statement so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to add
some links in the navigation bar and
show a collapsible menu on mobile
devices we'll see what that means we'll
also show a list of jobs using cards on
mobile and on table we're going on
desktop we're going to use a table and
we're going to make the color scheme Ty
typography and layout consistent and
aesthetically pleasing okay so let's
start with the Navar and this is where
we can use bootstrap's Navar component
so we can come in here and you can see
here that there's a component called
Navar and a component essentially is
simply a bunch of HTML and CSS along
with some special classes so the way you
use a bootstrap nav bar is basically by
adding a class nav bar to a nav element
and there are a bunch of classes that
need to be added so the information
about the classes that need to be added
are here there's this navbar brand
navbar nav navbar Toggler Navar text
collapse Etc and naar scroll so the best
way to actually do this is to maybe go
through the examples that have been
given on the page and pick the example
that is closest to what you want to
achieve okay so here is an Navar which
contains this maybe this could become
the logo and maybe these could become
the links we don't need this form as
such so we may not need this but there's
and so this is an example example Navar
and this is the code for that example so
what you can do is you can simply copy
this code and paste it now remember
whenever you paste code you should study
it line by line to know exactly what it
does okay so copy this code and paste it
in your HTML and that will give you a
Navar and there are also various other
examples so this is like a plain nav bar
simple nav bar uh you can check out
these two as well this is a nav bar with
an image this is an AB bar with an image
and some text this is an AB bar with a
just a bunch of links I think this is
something that we might be able to
use and then there are a bunch of
different examples so you can you can
also embed forms within the nav bar I
think I am simply going to maybe just
pick the first let's pick a very basic
one Navar with a bunch of links because
that's what I want ultimately so let me
pick this up and let me start
customizing it step by step okay okay
let's get rid of this
and let us just maybe bring this make
this a little smaller and make this a
little smaller as
well let's reload this okay so this is
what we have no change here now let me
just come in here and replace this
navbar div with the code that I have
just copied over okay so this is the
code that I've copied over and this code
results in this nav bar being added to
my page all right well so first thing I
want to do is I'm just going to study it
line by line and I'm going to make some
changes to it so all right I have this
class navbar and I want this Navar to
show so it's going to show up in a
collapsed form like this you can see
that there's a button
here there's a button here and when I
click on this button it opens up this
menu so bootstrap automatically gives me
this nice mobile drop- down menu so that
on mobile I there's no space to show the
links so it's going to show up in this
button so that's nice now I can specify
when I want it to expand do I want it to
expand on small screens medium screens
or large screens So currently it is set
to LG which means when the width of the
page crosses 992 pixels I'll have to
maybe zoom out a little
bit yeah but when the width of the page
crosses 990 pixels or so then this gets
shown normally otherwise this getss
shown like this maybe I don't need
expand LG maybe I can do with expand MD
so yeah so you can see here that up to
the MD breakpoint which is about 768
pixels it's going to show up like this
and after the MD breako it's going to
show up like this okay so that's what
these two classes mean Navar is simply
going to trigger the entire Navar
component um for this particular element
and then the BG body tertiary I believe
this is simply the background color I
don't need that so I can I've gotten rid
of the background color what I do want
is I want to add this nice shadow I want
to add like a small Shadow here which I
have which we have on the Jovian website
you can see that we have this nice
subtle Shadow below the nav bar so I'm
going to try and add that shadow and I
believe there is a utility class for
adding Shadows I believe you just say
shadow and that's going to add a utility
Shadow here but this Shadow is too big I
can make that smaller so there's like a
shadow SM utility class again something
that you can just search online how to
add a shadow and bootstrap and you can
just find it online on Google or chat
jpt okay so now our nav bar has a shadow
that is nice next we have this container
fluid so we have this Navar it's going
to take up the full width of the page
what do I want do I want it to take the
full width of the page well maybe I
wanted to take the full width of the
page
till the medium screen but for LG and
bigger I want it to be centered okay so
I'm just going to do this I am going to
pick yeah so I'm just going to maybe
make it fluid I'm just going to make it
LG uh at LG it's going to become
centered and it's going to remain fluid
for MD and Below okay
so remember what this container is doing
is this container is deciding whether
the entire Navar should be centered on
the page or not now if I don't have this
container LG you will or if I just make
it container fluid it's always going to
span from the left Edge to the right
Edge okay and that is different from the
toggle the toggle the toggle is
controlled using the Navar expand the
container fluid decides whether the
Navar takes the full width of the page
or not let me just set it for now as
container um MD or container yeah
container MD so from for MD screens and
bigger it is going to be centered on the
page okay so that is what this this does
so far this is fine okay then we have
this brand Navar okay I think this is
where I might want to put the Jovian
logo so I'm just going to grab the
Jovian logo from here I have already put
this in here so I'm just going to grab
the Jovian logo so we have a couple of
logos there's one logo that is going to
show up on small screens which contains
just the icon does not contain anything
else so let me remove this text Navar
over here and let me just put the
Jovian I
icon and you can see that it's going to
show up on small screens but as soon as
I
hit yeah so you can see that I have
given it the class DMD none which means
it's going to show up on small screens
but as soon as we hit the MD breakpoint
it is going to stop showing up okay and
why do we have that because for bigger
screens or for MD breakpoint actually
want to show the full Jovian icon or the
full Jovian logo with the text so let's
put this in here okay okay we given it I
I don't think it needs an ID anymore so
I think the ID can be gotten rid of and
even the height may not be necessary but
it's fine let me just keep the height
for now okay so let's get another Jovan
logo for bigger screens so let me grab
the Jovin logo with text so this is
simply again the Jovian logo with
text so again it's an image tag and what
we're seeing here is that it is hidden
by default so it has a display of none
but from the MD breakpoint which is 768
pixels we wanted to show up in line okay
so this is what that ultimately results
in that up to MD we have the smaller
logo which contains just the icon and
then beyond MD screens we have this
bigger logo which contains the actual
Jovian logo Okay cool so our Navar is
almost ready I think we're almost ready
to go ahead I let's see what we have
here we we have this Navar Toggler of
the type button if I understand
correctly I think it what it's doing is
basically
simply setting this button so this
button is the button that is rendered
here so this is simply the toggle button
so I can also maybe just add a
quick uh comment here so this is the
toggle button and this toggle button
only shows up till MD because after MD
it is going to just uh expand
automatically and maybe I can add a
small
uh comment here saying this is the
logo okay so now in my navbar I have the
logo and I have the toggle button all of
this is fine now in the Navar we have
and in the toggle button we have this
that it controls or it Targets this
Navar nav and the Navar nav happens to
be this div which contains a list inside
it okay so it's not visible until we hit
the MD breakpoint and then from the MD
break point it becomes visible and we
can verify this by clicking inspect and
let me just turn off the device mode for
now you can see that this ID Navar
nav ID Navar nav is visible here but if
I reduce the width a little bit it's not
going to be visible okay so this is the
nav all all right this is fine now what
do we want to do here well we want to
maybe first edit these links so let's
see it has collapsed Navar collapse I
don't think there's any change we need
to do here this seems fine ID seems fine
so I'm verifying every single line of
code this is very important when you are
working with bootstrap so let's see
let's make the first link instead of
home let's make the link
courses and let's make this
link
programs and let's make this
YouTube and let's make this final link
sign in so in case somebody wants to
sign in here from the careers page they
can sign in okay so now you see now we
have courses programs YouTube sign in
okay looking good so far now of course
there are some styles that have been put
in here so I think I can remove those
Styles let's see the class is nav item
for all of
these and I believe we can simply change
the actual HFS first as well let me just
set this
to jan.com
SL
learn so that is the link that I want
the courses to go
to and this is not the current page so
this current page is causing the courses
to look slightly different from the
programs in YouTube so I'm going to
remove this ARA current current page so
that all of them look
similar and I'm going to to remove this
active as well so that yeah because all
of these are going to some output So
when you say active it's just going to
give it a special style so I'm just
going to remove this active as well so
you can try out removing each class and
see what happens and that's a great way
to understand what these classes are
doing okay then we have the second nav
item and I think I also wanted to open
in a new tab so I'm also going to say
Target equals underscore
blank okay so now when I click on this
it's actually going to open the Jovian
courses in a new tab so that is the
courses nav item let's now fix the
programs nav item as
well I think I'm going to send it to the
same
location so we have the courses nav item
then we have the programs now item both
of them are going to the same location
for now uh I we may create separate
pages later on but for now both of them
are going to the same same location okay
so these two are fine I want to fix the
YouTube link as well so let me just copy
this come bring it in here for YouTube
again it has a class nav link it is I'm
going to give in our YouTube link here
so
youtube.com/ Jovan HQ that is going to
be our YouTube link so that is going to
open our YouTube link perfect and
finally there is the sign in I want to
turn the sign in into a button so let's
come into buttons and bootstrap also has
a bunch of button classes so let's come
into buttons here and I can just turn
that into a button simply by doing
something like this and there are like
there are examples here that I all I
need to do is I need to say button type
equals button class equals button button
primary Prime and then I can put in
whatever content and this way I'm going
to get this nice blue button but one
thing you can also do is you can
actually just
use not just a button tag but you can
also just use a a tag or a link tag and
this link tag by itself can
Auto or this anchor tag this a tag is
the anchor tag this anchor tag can also
be made to look like a button using the
BTN class okay so we are using a link
but we're going to turn it into a button
by simply providing these classes and we
can also give it the roll button just
for screen readers and such so I'm going
to remove this nav link disabled class
from my signin so now signin is just a
normal unstyled link and I'm going to
add to it the class BTN BTN primary
and maybe let's see if we can also do
nav link let's see what that does no
that's going to change override things
maybe I can simply do a p l or a margin
left
two that doesn't seem to be doing
anything maybe I can do it here I can do
PX or P
L2 no
nothing
MX2 yeah MX2 does the job right maybe L
should also do it no l okay I believe it
is Ms margin start that does the job
yeah so Ms is margin start so I'm just
using the utility class margin start to
give just some space to the button maybe
ms3 can be tried as well yeah that looks
good so now I have my Jovian logo I have
courses programs in YouTube and I want
this to go all the way to the right I
don't want it to show up here right in
front and also want it to be Center
aligned with the logo so there are a
couple of things we may need to do here
and let's see how we can achieve them
now this is where the abstraction breaks
this is where you'll have to actually
inspect the actual nav bar and make some
changes directly so I am going to first
just select inspect the nav bar here so
right click select inspect okay so this
is the nav bar this is fine and this is
the container of the nav bar okay so
this is where this is where my entire
nav bar lives this is fine then I have
the navbar brand this is all well and
good then I have the Navar toggle that's
not visible right now and then I have
this navbar
collapse okay so I want to looks like
this Navar collaps is right after the
Navar brand I want it to go all the way
to the right how could I do that let me
take a quick look at the parent
component which is this container and
let me check the what is the display
type of this container so if I check the
display type of this container the
display type of this container seems to
be Flex okay so that means my Navar logo
and the links are both items within a
flex container and it has a flex
Direction row you can verify the flex
direction as well by default it's row if
it doesn't say anything so in a flex
Direction row I want the contents to be
spaced out how do we achieve that well
along the primary axis so along this
axis I want there to be an automatic
space added between the starting
component and the end component the
first and the second component that can
be added using justify content space
between okay so think about this I'll
let you think about this and when you
practice this on your own so what I'm
going to do here is in my container
MD I which is a flex container which
contains the brand and which contains
the the list which of course it contains
the button as well which is not visible
right now I'm going to say
justify
content
between or space
between what does that
do
well that did not seems like it didn't
do anything but maybe justify content
let's try
end okay that didn't do it as well so
maybe maybe I need to take another
closer look at what exactly is happening
here so maybe I let me check this
element so it looks like this div is
also a flex div so maybe it's possible
that this div may be taking up the
entire space so justify content end is
not working here let me try and come and
set it on this collapse div which is
also a flex div right so this collapse
div is also a flex container and it it
contains a bunch of these um list items
and all of these list items are
contained in this so let me come into
the collapse div and let me
add justify content end and you can see
that it shift it to the end okay so how
do I how did I achieve this well I
actually just tried it out so sometimes
all you have to do to achieve the
desired layout is to think from first
principles okay this is the box I have
and I need to shift something to the
right or left and how can I achieve that
using some Flex property or using some
display property and then just dig in
into the inspection and fix things right
but whenever you're using bootstrap the
one tip that I can give you right now is
if you want all of your elements in the
list of nav links to shift to the right
simply go into that collapse div the
collapse Navar collapse which is the
list of things that gets collapsed um at
a particular breakpoint and just add
justify content end and it'll shift
everything to the
right okay uh and on a Case by case
basis you'll just have to search this
sometimes you can just search this
online as well and you can find the
answer okay one other thing we can do
probably is maybe seems like this is not
these things are not aligned properly so
maybe I think it might also help to add
an align item Center
here okay that's not doing anything all
right I'll experiment later but one
thing I want to do is maybe just
slightly fix the alignment so that
courses is Right lining up properly with
the center of the logo which doesn't
seem to be happening right now okay okay
so now we have courses and we have
signin as well for the signin Button as
well let me just add an
href and the HF is simply jan.com
login and the class or the target is
uncore blank that is simply going to
open it in a new tab okay yeah so this
is looking rather nice I would say so
here we have this mobile view okay looks
like on mobile view we need to fix the
signin button it should not have the
left Stop left padding right so I'm just
going to trigger this from
MD yeah so now what's going to happen is
that the margin is going to kick in only
from MD so let's see now this is looking
good I can collapse it I can expanded
this is looking nice and as soon as I
increase beyond the medium
width which is somewhere about here now
it goes into this nice layout where I
have these links right at the top and I
have this nice sign in button I think
maybe md2 might be sufficient I don't
really need md3 okay I have this nice
sign in button and this is looking
pretty good so with that we have
completed the nav bar this is the
original layout I've just zoomed in a
little bit so that you can see more
clearly okay so that's what we did you
can just check out the layout exactly
the code is present here as well but we
have just made it in made it so that it
expands and it shows up a bunch of links
from MD and higher right so this is the
layout that we've achieved on mobile and
this is the layout that we've achieved
on desktop okay next up is the hero
section or the about section so this is
where bootstrap also provides various
examples for specific sections so
remember in this page we have this about
Jovian then we have this then we have
this and then we have this spanner image
as well so let's look at some examples
from the bootstrap examples so these are
all the these are a bunch of examples
for the hero or the about section and
for for this looks like there is this
centered option that we can just have
some centered content on the page I
don't want that uh there is this
centered option with an image below it
that's not what I want either okay this
looks promising so I have some text here
I have some text here and then I have an
image here that looks somewhat similar
to what I need here okay text image Etc
and maybe this layout is actually better
where the text even the title is on the
left and not on the center and then I
have these buttons here but I don't have
to use these buttons instead of these
buttons I can simply put in these two
items that I have here okay so I guess
I'm going to use this layout and this is
one of the examples on this examples
page we have a bunch of examples how do
I get the code for just this example
there is a way you can download the code
and then search it so you can go into
bootstrap examples you can download the
source code of these examples you can
open the hero folder etc etc but I'm
going to show you a quick way uh when
you're looking at a bootstrap example
just right click click
inspect and find the
outermost container so okay this is the
container and looks like this container
contains this entire hero element and
inside it is the entire thing so you can
just click on this container right click
select copy element and that is going to
copy the HTML code for this entire
container that we're looking at here
okay so with one click I've copied the
entire HTML code for this container and
now I can come in into my code and here
in this about Jovian section I'm
removing whatever placeholder text I
have I'm just going to paste in this
container and just like that you can see
that we got
this nice responsive left Aline hero
with image and of course the the image
is not present here so we can change
this image we have an image here um well
actually I think we have a link to an
image here that we can
grab uh let's see yeah so I've hosted
this image online so that I can just
copy it over easily let's see I am yeah
so the image source is
this yeah and so with that I have this
nice layout where I have this responsive
left aligned hero with image uh and with
some text with these buttons and I have
this nice image on the right okay
looking pretty good and let us start
understanding and customizing this okay
first thing I wanted this to be a
container I think that's fine I want the
content to be sent on the page no matter
what screen size we are on so this is
fine it's this content is always
centered on the
page okay let me get rid of this I think
I don't need this call XXL 8 I am not
interested in that right now it has this
PX4 what is this
PX4 okay so this PX4 seems to be this
padding on on the left and right okay I
think I can keep the PX4 it also has
this py5 which is the space above it I
think maybe this this py5 may not be
necessary right now so I'm going to get
rid of this py5 and automatically you
can see that the top and bottom padding
has completely gone away all right
um
yeah so that is looking good so far next
let us come in here and let us
check okay what's happening here so it
looks like we have
Flex by default we have like
it's just a normal div with things going
top to bottom that's fine and at some
point it becomes a flex container with
the direction row but not just row it it
becomes a flex container with row
reverse so on large screens we have Flex
LG row reverse which means on large
screens it becomes a flex container with
a direction row reverse and that is why
the image comes on the left and the on
the right and the text comes on the left
okay I think that works for me that I
have this top to bottom layout here this
is fine and then I have this left to
right layout here this is fine I may
need to do some centering but it's
fine okay maybe I can just use a flex
call layout initially a flex column
layout so that there's already this
align item Center so what that can do
for me is just make sure that the
content becomes centered okay that's not
exactly doesn't exactly seem to be
happening
yet okay maybe we don't need this Flex
call here so this is okay align item
Center I
think what this does I can I can remove
it and see what happens so when I have
align items when I don't have align item
Center the text comes on the top and it
is aligned with the top of the image
when I have align items oops when I have
align items Center the text is Center
aligned vertically with respect to the
image okay earlier it was here now it is
here I think I like this better so I'm
going to keep align items Center okay
there is this G5 let's see what happens
if you remove the
G5 well looks like there was some shift
in the gaps I think it's fine it's
probably okay not a big issue there is
this
py5 okay do we need this
py5 yeah I think we need that py5 maybe
I can just make it py4 maybe we don't
need that much space okay looks
fine or py5 is fine
too okay looks fine so far my layout is
looking good then we have this image so
we have this call 10 call sm8 call lg6 a
bunch of stuff going on
here I think I'm going to make it very
very simple I'm just going to say call
12 and call lg6 so that it takes up the
full
width and I think we'll probably need
that Gap five now
because yeah I think we need that Gap
maybe I can make that Gap smaller yeah
so I I wanted to take up the full width
the the div containing the image I
wanted to take up the full width on all
screens and then at some point I wanted
to take up just half the
width so at LZ I wanted to take up half
the width but that doesn't seem to be
happening okay so let's give this call
12 as
well and on LG
screens yeah on LG screens it's both of
these are going to take up half
width okay so there seems to be this MX
LG Auto I'm going to get rid of that
there seems to be this image fluid this
is
okay what else
well I think it's this a gap that might
be causing the problem we'll fix the Gap
later okay so yeah so till LG it takes
up the entire width of the uh width of
the page or width of the container the
centered container and from LG screen
screens and bigger it simply takes half
the screen width okay so this is good
this is looking good so far and let me
also maybe add a rounded border to the
image so I can just go in and say
rounded okay and let's also maybe say MX
Auto so that it's centered on the page
no matter what width it's taking up okay
let's maybe add some
padding below the image so let's just
say MB
four yeah I think this is good so now
we've added some padding below the image
and let's add a
similar We'll add a similar padding for
the other content as well okay so this
is looking pretty good so now we have
the Jovian logo and let's make this py4
I think py4 should do the job for
us yeah so now we have this Jovin logo
we have this image okay we have this
text here I'm going to change this text
so let's see display 5 FW bold text body
emphasis all this looks good I'll keep
those
lh1 all that looks fine I'm just going
to change this
to work at
Jovan okay I think I want it to be
centered by default so I want to say
text
Center by default and then it's looking
good and then at a certain point I want
it to become left align so at LG when
the layout shifts I want to say text LG
left align to left align I have to say
text LG start and it's going to become
left align over here like that okay
great so again we' you can try removing
some of these and see what it does what
happens if you remove display file what
happens if you remove text body emphasis
Etc let's try it let's try removing text
body
emphasis okay it didn't make a
difference so probably we didn't need
that what about font weight bold do we
need that
that okay we definitely need that what
about display 5 do we need that yeah we
definitely need that okay so this is all
looking good we have work at Jovian this
is a nice little uh thing that we've
added
and let's get rid of these buttons I
don't need these buttons
here okay let's take a look at this
actual paragraph of text I think this
paragraph you want to maybe change it to
the paragraph that we were actually
using earlier so I'm just going to come
in and maybe copy over the paragraph
that we had earlier let's paste this
paragraph
here okay looks good yeah this is fine I
think we also had another paragraph
linking to a couple of courses so we had
this full stack developer boot camp data
science boot camp let us maybe add those
paragraphs as well so let's add another
paragraph and and let's see if this
class lead is important what if I don't
have this class
lead okay this class lead seems to be
important it's going to make the text a
little nicer to read a little bigger so
I'm going to keep this and I'm going to
keep this in my next paragraph as well
and in my next paragraph let's add this
text let's we also offer to Industry
Focus boot
camps all right cool and let's get the
links to those boot camps so let's get
the I'm just going to copy this entire
ordered list so we
have an ordered list o with the class
lead it contains one list item which
contains a link to the full stack
developer boot camp it contains another
list item which contains a link to the
data science boot camp okay and just
like that we have created a very nice
looking hero section so this is often
called the hero section um I think we
can probably get rid of this margin you
can see that there's this margin bottom
that we had kept I think we can get rid
of it when we get to a large
layout yeah so we have this margin
bottom I don't think it is very useful
here in this case so for the large
layout I'm going to get rid of it so I'm
just going to say m
lg0 okay nice so now it's nicely
centered on the page okay perfect so on
mobile screens we have this toggle and
we have this image we have this centered
work at chian but of course this
paragraph It's better to just keep it
left aligned and then we have links and
then um the font sizes are also
responsive you'll notice that the font
size is actually increasing that's what
the display fonts or the utility classes
allow us to do then as soon as we hit
this large layout you can see that we
flip into and then at Excel there's a
certain change as well in terms of the
container size but we flip into this
nice two column layout which is looking
rather nice and I don't think we need
this Banner image anymore because just
this layout itself is looking so nice
that I don't feel like then further
adding a banner image or anything
okay yeah looks good I am feeling pretty
happy with this and now we can probably
move on to the next
section okay so the next section is the
employment opportunities which we want
to show as a list of cards on mobile and
on desktop we want to show it as a a
table okay so how do we do that let me
just copy this over here so that we can
actually just see this side by side so
here you have this employment
opportunities table by default it's a
list of cards like this let's see if
there is something to create cards in
bootstrap so let's go into the bootstrap
documentation let us search for cards
yeah so there seems to be this card
component and this card component can be
used to show an image can be used to
show a card title used to have have some
text and maybe also have some content
here at the bottom I need something much
simpler maybe I need something like this
which has a card title a subtitle and
maybe just some text about it so I'm
just going to copy this and I am going
to come in here I'm going to create a
new
section again I'm going to create a
div and I'm going to give it the same
class that I had for the previous div
Above So container let's see what did
that look like container and PX4 so I'm
going to give it container and PX4 so
that left and right we have some space
so that the content does not stick to
the left end of the page and let me put
in an H2 here and let me just put uh let
me just call this job
opportunities okay so now we have this
job opportunities let me also just add
class text Center
here okay and I want to right now I want
to just work with smaller
layouts so I'm just going to going to
keep it like that and let me just now
add this maybe I'm going to add a div
and I'm going to give it the
ID jobs list well maybe I don't really
need an ID let me just drop in a comment
here saying jobs
list okay and inside this div is where
I'm going to create my
cards all right so let me paste in this
card and let's see what it gives me okay
so this is the card that I get it's on
the left
so I'm going to change a few things up
first I'm going to remove this width I
don't need this width I do need this
class card because that's what adds this
nice border around it I am going to add
maybe a
my4 which is just okay maybe not here
my4 which is margin in the Y Direction
Four units which is going to just give
us some space here and maybe I'm going
to also add a
Mt
five here yeah so that this is a little
spaced out from the previous
content okay looks good so far and let
us now add okay let's now fix the card
title so we have this front end
developer role let me just grab the
content of the front end developer role
here okay so C title is front end
developer so I'm just going to use
that frontend developer okay that looks
fine then we have a subtitle in the
subtitle I'm going to put in
the location of the job which is
bangaluru India and 12 lakh rupees which
is the annual salary so I'm going to put
that in here I don't need these Links at
the bottom so I've gotten rid of these
links and then I here maybe I can just
put in that this was posted three uh
this was posted like on March 3rd 23 or
something like that so I'm going to put
in that information over here okay so
very basic
content yep okay so now I have front end
developer this is good bangaluru India
March 3rd 2023 looking good I can maybe
just make this slightly better I think
the spacing is a little off so maybe
this mb2 is not required maybe just make
it mb1 this looks fine and I guess this
text can be slightly smaller and maybe a
little grade out and that is where I can
use this small um tag HTML tag which
bootstrap automatically turns into
slightly smaller text and I'm also going
to use text body secondary so I still
have this card text class but instead of
using the P tag I'm using the small tag
and I'm using the color text body
secondary color now you can see that we
have this nice hierarchical card where
we have this frontend developer
bangaluru India 12 lakh rupees and
posted March 3rd 2023 okay so that is
the yeah so that is the card that we
have created and I'm just going to copy
this over just so that we have like a
nicer version of this available for us
to easily
replicate yeah and let's fix this
padding here as well to
My5
empty maybe this H2 needs some padding
below so I'm just going to add mb4 to
this H2 yeah so that things are a little
spaced out okay so that's one card let
me copy over the other cards as well so
this is
the full stack developer role so let me
come in
and let's
[Music]
now oh looks like I have this additional
div here full stack developer role let
me just format the document looks fine
okay full stack developer let me add in
the data scientist role as well data
scientist that is the data scientist
role right here and finally let me add
in the ml engineer role as well okay so
all we're doing is simply using the
classes from bootstrap we still using
writing plain HTML code but now we
adding classes from bootstrap and all
those Styles and maybe also some
JavaScript nice features can get added
in autom atically via bootstrap so now
we have all of these job opportunities I
think this is looking pretty good um
this is fine but I don't want this to
show up Beyond MD so I think when we hit
the MD
breakpoint I want it to I want this to
disappear so that's where we have
this DMD nonone class so we can say that
by default it has a certain display but
at the MD breakpoint we want it to
disappear so for the entire jobs list so
this is the jobs list I'm just going to
give it the class DMD
none okay so you can see that at in very
small screens this is visible and this
is looking good as soon as we hit the MD
breakpoint then this goes away and is no
longer visible okay so with that I think
we've completed the first one or the
first half of the page which is the
Navar the hero section and the job
opportunities at least B on the mobile
view now of course at MD this disappears
and from size MD we want to show a table
so let's maybe first bring in a table
here so inside the jobs list well right
after the jobs list but still within the
jobs div So within the jobs container we
want to add a table so let's just add a
jobs table
here okay and let's first maybe I'm just
going to put in a div containing a table
so you can see all I've done here is
I've have a div and inside the div I
have a table and inside the table I have
this table row uh or the header row and
of course I've used certain col column
spans and row spans to achieve this kind
of a layout where you have know job
title and location has City and Country
under it and so on so to achieve this
layout I have used column span row span
so this is the exact same table in terms
of the basic HTML that we had the last
time and I'm just going to save that and
let's see what that does so now this has
added this table here at the bottom
right but there are two issues here one
is that this table is always visible we
don't want it to be always visible we
want it to be visible only on MD and
higher so I'm just going to say class D
none so which is by default we don't
want it to be visible and then DMD
block okay and what that does is from MD
on MD the list disappears and the table
appears okay that's good the second
thing is of course this table is not
looking very nice right now so one thing
we can do to trigger bootstraps Stables
is simply use the table class and how
did I get this well I simply looked up
the documentation so in the
documentation just search for table and
they have this class for table so you
can just add in
table the table class to any table
component and that's going to create
this nice table for us okay the table is
looking nice but we still want borders
around the table so we want a bordered
table so let's see where how do we add a
border to the table it looks like we
just have to add the table bordered
class so I'm just going to come in here
and I'm going to add the class table
bordered and voila our table now has
borders pretty good I would like to
maybe give it some more color so let's
see how we can add colors so accented
tables well let's see how we can maybe
make get these striped rows I think this
would be nice so let me copy this table
striped CSS property and this is how you
work with bootstrap you look at an
example that contains what you need and
then you just add that property so table
bordered let me add the Cs CSS property
table striped and yes I think the table
is looking nice okay maybe I can make a
few changes to this particular to The
Heading because the heading the header
row should probably look a little
different let's see how can we color how
can we color the table are there any
color tables here okay looks like there
is a way to color tables as well we can
use this table primary class to give it
a primary
color but I don't want it on the entire
table I just want it on the header rows
so looks like I can just add class table
primary on a row and it should just
color that row let me color the first
header row table primary okay nice it's
gets it gets this nice primary color let
me add this to the second row as well
which contains a city and Country and
this gets the nice color as well and
because of the striping logic this gets
a slightly different color okay our
table is starting to look good I think I
want to Center the titles here the so
I'm just going to add text
Center for the table row text
center right so this is how you build it
out step by step okay nice the table is
looking good so till mobile this is fine
on MD we switch into the table which is
looks fine to me I think it's not uh
it's not cramped or anything okay when
we get to LG and higher looks like this
is this table is getting too big maybe I
might want to just limit the overall
size of the table a little a little bit
so this is where I can maybe use a
small helper layout here so what if I do
this let's say on
LG on LG I limited to just eight columns
instead of taking the entire 12 columns
I limited to eight columns so on MD it's
going to take up the full width which is
here but on LG it's going to just take
up eight columns but of course I don't
want it to take up the left eight
columns I wanted to take up the middle
eight columns out of the 12 so that's
where I can add an offset so I can say
offset LG 4 or maybe offset LG
2 yeah so what I'm saying is leave two
columns here leave uh and then take up
the eight columns and that automatically
leaves two columns here 12 - 8 - 2 is 2
all right so that way the table is going
to be sent completely full width on
medium screens but on large screens it
is is going to Simply take up okay on
large screen it is simply going to take
up the eight columns in between and that
just expands a little bit but it still
looks nice I feel okay so that's great I
think we've been able to set up a nice
table let's see maybe I can just
increase this Gap a little
bit mb5 maybe
here yeah this is looking a little
nicer okay so our with that we are done
with our
jobs list and jobs table so this is what
our jobs list looks like job
opportunities on mobile and then we've
also added
a table and this is what our job
opportunities table looks like okay
perfect next let's move on to the
application form that is probably the
only big piece that's left here and the
footage should be pretty straightforward
now for the application form once again
bootstrap offers various pre-built form
components okay so first let us just set
up the basic layout and then we are
going to start incorporating this one by
one so once again I need a container
here so I'm just going to give it a
class of container and PX4 because I
want some spacing left and right so PX
is the padding it is basically this
space that you see on the left and right
it's nice to have I think it's it's good
we can keep it okay then I need an H2
here so
H2 and in this H2 I want to put in sub
MIT your
application okay the H2 is looking okay
too well maybe for this H2 I can add a
text Center because I want to Center
this text and maybe I need to add some
space above as well so maybe let me add
mt5
above okay now that has added some space
above and let me then also go ahead and
had a form here so I'm going to copy
over the form that I had the last time
at least in terms of the
basic um action and Method so remember
we were using a tool called form bold to
actually post the form let me add the
form element here okay I've added the
form and now into the form I can start
adding inputs okay so I've created a
form but this form doesn't have any
inputs yet I could put like input type
equals
text
and that should create an input box here
so let me just move this up a little bit
you can see that now I have this input
box but of course I want to use a nice
input form that is created very nicely
with bootstrap so I'm going to come into
bootstrap here and I'm going to search
for
form okay so here is an example of
forms looks like you don't need anything
on the form component and for the actual
inputs looks like we need to do a bunch
of things here we need to set a class of
okay this is just a we need to put the
input and label and maybe some help text
in a div and we then need to maybe
specify the class form label for the
label we need to specify the class form
control for the input and if we want
some helper text so this is some helper
text that we want to show below the
email then we can specify some helper
text as well so how about we simply copy
this over I think we understand this
well enough so we can just copy this
over and let's put it into our form
instead of
this okay all right so just like that we
have this email address input field that
is looking good
and I am going to Simply give it the I'm
going to give it the ID email so the
input is going to have the ID email and
the email help is the description below
the email address this looks fine as
well and yeah I think this looks good so
we need form label and form control it
looks like these are the two things that
we require and that automatically helps
us create the layout okay what else well
I feel like maybe we don't want to use
the
entire uh we don't want to use the
entire width for email of the page maybe
we want to use just maybe half the space
so I can go in here and I can say call
six
and this way it is only going to take up
half the
space but now the trouble is even on a
really small screen it takes up only
have the space so let me say call
sm6 and this way on a really small
screen it's going to take up the entire
width and then as soon as we enter
bigger screens it's going to take up
less width okay so this is good I think
I'm happy with
this okay perfect so just like we have
email I have also already put together
some other examples so here now I have
this name field so I'm just going to
copy the name field all we have is we ex
we have the exact same mb3 calls sm6
except this time the ID and the name are
full name or or name I guess um so let
me just copy this over and this is of
type text so let's insert the name field
that's giving us the name field email we
already have the email field but let me
just in any case copied over once again
so that is going to give us the email
field the only difference between the
name and the email field is of course
their ID and name are different the
field name but also that the type is
email and that is going to automatically
add some validation and we've also added
a placeholder and we've added a required
field so forms we've covered in a lot of
detail already so I'm not going to go
into the specifics here but now we have
the name field we have the email field
all we've done is added a few bootstrap
classes form label and form control
which makes it look nice
let's get the phone number field so
again the only difference here is the
titles labels IDs and the type is TE
tell which requires this to be a phone
number
field okay and let's format the document
a bit yeah cool so now we have the phone
number field as well this is looking
good let's get up the let's get the date
of birth field as
well okay let's get date of birth so
yeah for date of birth we
have once again we have the same layout
exactly except that this time it's a
date picker so you can go in and you can
actually select a particular date here
so that's good okay next up is the apply
to field so this is more of a drop- Down
uh this is like a select component so
I'm just going to bring it in here first
so the position applying and then we're
going to look take a close look at
it okay so the position applied for is a
drop- down and from here you can select
whether you want to apply for for full
stack developer front end developer Etc
so how are we doing this well once again
we have class mb3 and call sm6 now the
only difference here is instead of an
input we're using a select which is what
we have to do anyway but the class we
are changing now from a form input to a
form so it was called form control here
now that has been changed to form select
and that's it that's the only change the
label still says form label and we have
a default option with an empty value set
to select a position that's why by
default it is pointing to select a
position and we
have then a front end developer full
stack developer data engineer ml
engineer I believe we can also make it
required so that the user has to select
a particular option so yeah this is just
a normal drop down all we've done is
added a class to the label added a class
to the select and added maybe this uh
layout or this bottom margin and this
six column layout here so that it looks
slightly
nicer okay then we have this resume
upload this is a file upload and the
only difference here is the input type
is file so again I'm just going to kind
of bring that in directly as well so
here is your file upload and that allows
you to pick a file again exactly the
same finally we have this cover letter
and in this case it is a text area Okay
so no change here again the only change
I'm making is I want the text area to
actually be full width right so I want
the text area to
be I want the text area to actually be
full width and that is why I've set I've
removed that call sm6 so I'm going to
use a full withth text area and that has
a um label cover letter and once again
you give it the class form control and
that's it we have our application form
the last thing we have is the terms I'm
just going to bring in the terms real
quick really straightforward it's just a
simple checkbox so all we do is we say
form form check input and form check
label again all this is borrowed from
the bootstrap documentation simply
copied over and with a quick assessment
of how things are what else um I think
we have the submit button right here so
let's grab that submit button that is
going to be a primary button for us so
we have submit application and now we're
ready to submit the application so
that's it I think this form is looking
good maybe we can make like some final
changes here let's see okay I think the
form
goes I guess the form goes too wide I
think we want to restrict the form to
just be just as wide as this job
opportunities table because otherwise
it's going to become a little hard to
actually read the content of the page so
I'm going to add the exact same classes
here that I had for the previous one so
on the form I am going to add the
class LG let's say call lg8 so that it
is not too wide and I'm also going to
add offset LG2 so that it is relatively
speaking centered on the page okay so
now we have work at Jovian job
opportunity submit your application and
we have the form as well let's quickly
verify the form okay we have email we
have
phone okay phone looks fine we have date
of birth we have
position yep I think this is all let's
check date of birth yeah I guess date of
birth needs to be changed to do let's
change this to D OB d o and yeah with
that our date of birth is fixed as well
perfect so now we have the form now we
have the hero section we have job
opportunities the final thing that we
need is
the foter okay now where do you get the
footer again bootstrap has a bunch of
examples that you can choose from so
here are some examples for the footer
let's look for
footer and let's open up the footer okay
so there's this example right here this
is something we could do or we could do
something like this I think this might
work out fine for us so we could
probably just right click inspect and
copy this entire
container paste it
in and make some desired changes to it
so I can get rid of this I can simply
paste that in and then I just need to
make the desired changes to it and
because I've made these changes already
I'm just going to copy it over from here
it's exactly what it looks like um I'm
just taking an example of the footer
which is a container and then it has
maybe a py my and it has the list of
links and below it it has this copyright
text it's a very simple straightforward
footer I've just made very minor
modifications to what we already have in
the bootstrap example okay so let's
paste in the footer here as well and
with that we have a
footer so great this is what it looks
like on let's just go normal to the
basic device mode and let's see things
from scratch so this is what it looks
like on mobile there is this nice drop
there's this nice menu here we have and
then we have work at Jovian and maybe we
can make this a little bigger on maybe
we can make this a little smaller on
mobile I'll let you maybe explore that
as an exercise then we have job
opportunities maybe we can make this
heading a little bigger I'll let you
experiment with that as well then we
have submit your application then we
have the form here full name email
address phone date of birth Etc upload
resume cover letter agree to conditions
submit application and then we have a
footer now as soon as we get into the MD
layout the cards disappear and the this
appears the table appears but we still
have this vertical layout for the hero
section and the form seems to take up
the full width when we get to
LG then this now becomes comes
horizontal as well and these open up as
well you can see that on md2 these open
up and on SM these
don't so yeah a bunch of changes going
on in each section you can just browse
through each break point and you can see
that the footer also slightly changes
you can see that the fter here it splits
into multiple lines and here then it
expands into a single line and of course
we have this nice line here as well okay
yep so I think this is looking good at
this point I am just going to make the
change so I'm I'm just going to commit
this so I'm I'm going to say added
bootstrap
styles for sections and I'm going to
commit this and I'm going to sync it and
we're ready to actually deploy this okay
so this is the final step we're going to
take this repository and just deploy it
on verell and you know how this is this
is really really simple so we just go to
github.com or we just go to verel
. and on wal.com let us just add a new
repository and you can sign up and
connect your GitHub account let's add
the repository Jovian careers bootstrap
live which we have created just now and
we are going to the root directory is
the SRC directory so I'm going to select
the SRC directory and I am on the main
branch and I can click
deploy and now it is going to take the
code that I've just pushed to the get
repository and you can see that we can
actually see what the change that was
just
made yeah so we just added the bootstrap
styles for sections and in the SRC
folder we have this index.html file
which contains bootstrap it contains the
nav bar it contains the logo toggle
button the collapse section it contains
the about section with the hero image
and it contains a description and links
to the boot camps it contains the list
of jobs so this is a normal list of
cards and it contains a table with
bootstrap Styles and it contains an
application form and it contains uh the
application form contains various types
of inputs contains a position resume
cover letter Etc contains terms contains
a submit button contains a footer and
that has just been deployed so in just
under 2 or 3 minutes we've deployed our
project to verel now we can open it up
and check it out and of course it is a
fully responsive website so we can
actually just open it up here in our
device mode View and we can check out
the links the links seem to be working
fine okay this link maybe needs to be
updated to open in a new tab we can
check out that job opportunities show up
properly all right this is good submit
your application this looks fine too and
let's just try filling out the
application as well Akash
NS aashan join.com
plus 9
one okay let's try to hit submit and
it's going to say this is a required
field so let us fill this
in and let us upload a
resume so let's grab a resume here I'm
applying for the let's try to apply
again okay this is also required so
let's select that too well cover letter
why
well I no responsive
design and bootstrap
and then I agree to the terms and
conditions I click submit and this is
going to make a submission remember we
were using this third party tool called
form bold so if you check the form here
we had set the action to form bold and
in a future lesson we'll look at how to
actually handle the content but we are
simply sending it to third party and
that is going to then send us an email
with the response but yeah the form has
been submitted and the Jen team will get
notified so perfect I think this page
looks pretty good now considering where
we started and even compared to where we
were the last lesson I think this was
looking good better than what you had
earlier but it still had certain issues
you couldn't you could tell that it's
not very polished but you couldn't tell
exactly why and that is where Frameworks
like bootstrap come into picture you can
use their default Styles you can use the
examples that they have and you can
build out these nice looking uh web
pages I think there's still some spacing
that we can improve here probably I
think the spacing seems a little bit off
here too I'll let you fix that as an
exercise maybe we can add maybe like a
subtitle or something like that but
otherwise uh maybe we can increase the
size of this header but otherwise I
think this is looking pretty pretty good
and it also has like slight interactive
elements U on
mobile so that's it that is what we have
ended up with this is what the page
looks like all good and this is what it
looks like on mobile uh we have these
nice cards and we have this nice
separation of the different elements of
the card as well that's good so in this
tutorial we saw how to install bootstrap
CSS and JavaScript bundles into a web
development project we saw how to modify
bootstrap's default colors and
typography using CSS variables and
custom selectors we saw how to use
bootstraps breakpoints and grid system
for for creating mobile first responsive
web pages remember you have to first put
a container then inside it you can put a
row if you want to put columns and then
you put put multiple columns within the
row and you can use sizes on a 12 column
grid to arrange them then you can have
use the break points as class prefixes
and that is how you achieve all kinds of
interesting layouts and of course you
have a lot of utility classes for
display for background for text for Flex
so all those are going to be really
useful as well we saw how to use
bootstraps pre-built components so we
used the nav bar we built we looked at
an example hero section we we used form
components we used tables we used a
example
footer and we use these for building a
web page quickly and efficiently and all
the code for this tutorial can be found
at this link and you can also check out
the finished site because it's deployed
to verel automatically and I would
encourage you to check out some of these
resources the official bootstrap
documentation is really the only
resource that you need to work with
bootstrap and most of the time what
you're going to be doing is finding an
example or finding the documentation
copying copying it over and then
carefully making changes to each line
always make sure that you understand
what exactly what each class does and if
you're confused try removing it see what
it does or go into inspect element and
see what it uh see what explanation you
can come up for it
with and then we have a bootstrap crash
course you can check out which is
similar to what we did today but a
different example so maybe looking at a
couple of different examples can help
you just Explore More components become
more familiar there are also a bunch of
other tutorials and there's this nice
cheat sheet that you can check out if
you want to understand what are all the
different classes that are available and
what do they do hello and welcome to
this live tutorial on building a
scientific calculator from scratch using
HTML CSS and JavaScript no Frameworks
required we're going to do this all live
step by step and we're going to try and
replicate the functionality of Google
Go's inbuilt scientific
calculator and stay till the end because
I'll also show you how you can do most
of your work simply by asking chat GPT
the right questions so with that let's
get
started now this is what Google's
inbuilt scientific calculator looks like
if you just head on to google.com and
search for calculator you will be able
to see this user interface and you can
perform calculations here for example
7 - 3
multiplied by 69 * by pi and you can see
that that gives us the result
86779 and of course you can then use
this result and build on top of it as
well but this is the basic functionality
that we will try and replicate today you
can see that there are a bunch of simple
calculator buttons here and then there
are a bunch of more complex scientific
calculator
calculation buttons that are also
included here so let's see how many of
these we can actually Implement and this
is what the calculator looks like on
mobile so here is the user interface on
mobile and here all the functions are
under this other tab FX so we'll try and
replicate maybe some of this
functionality as well and we are going
to do this step by step using just basic
HTML CSS and JavaScript so all the steps
that we're going to follow are listed
here in this doc which is linked from
the description so you can follow along
if you'd like like now there are some
prerequisites here you need to know a
little bit of HTML a little bit of CSS a
little bit of JavaScript and a little
bit of git and GitHub now don't worry if
you're not an expert in any of these
because we are going to cover just
introductory uh explanations about each
of these as we use them apart from this
we will also be using the bootstrap CSS
framework and that is again something
that I'll refer you to the documentation
for in case you're not already familiar
with it and you will be able to find the
link L here as well so here are the
steps we're going to take we're going to
first prepare our development and
deployment environment so we're going to
create a public GitHub repository launch
it in GitHub code spaces to edit it
completely online then we're going to
set up our basic bootstrap framework and
also then deploy the web page to verel
quickly so that we can test and share
our implementation easily then we're
going to build the user interface with
HTML and CSS we're going to look at what
the Google Calculator works like and
we're going to build that mobile first
design and progressively enhance it for
tablet and desktop and then we're going
to add some functionality using
JavaScript so this is where we're going
to add a script file we're going to
create some variables and functions to
keep track of current and previous
expressions and then we're going to
create functions to implement the logic
for each button and add some click
handlers as well finally we are going to
test the page carefully on different
screen sizes ensure that the HTML CSS
and JavaScript is well organized and
then stage commit and push the changes
to GitHub and verify that the site is
deployed now I will leave some parts of
these as exercises for you to do so try
and build on top of what we are doing
today and we'll see how far we can get
in about 90 minutes or so and then we'll
also talk about how you can use chat GPD
to take away maybe more than half of
your work all right so with that let's
get started and if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments so the first thing that I am
going to do is start a new
GitHub repository so I've just gone into
github.com I've signed in and I've
simply I've simply uh ready to I'm ready
to put in a repository name so let us
call it
scientific calculator live perfect and
let's give it a description so a
replica of
Google's scientific
calculator built live or right and I'm
going to make it a public repository I'm
going to make it open for everyone to
use so that you can see the code I'm
going to add a readme file and I'm going
to select the git ignore template node
and that is going to add a bunch of git
ignore uh settings which are going to
ignore any temporary files that get
created when working on a HTML or web
development project I'm going to choose
the MIT license here because I want you
to be able to build on top of this and
let's click create
repository and just like that we have
our repository now created on GitHub
GitHub of course is the platform used by
50 million plus Developers for sharing
projects online we use GitHub internally
at Jovian as well and of course now we
need a way to actually write the code
and that is where we going to use an
online coding platform called GitHub
code spaces so I'm just going to click
the code button here and you can develop
this locally you can get clone the
repository and then you can run the code
locally but I'm just going to use an
online coding platform offered by G
GitHub called GitHub codes spaces now
what that is going to do is it is going
to set up a machine for me in the cloud
and then it is going to clone the GitHub
repository over there and then it's
going to give me this Visual Studio code
interface within the browser Visual
Studio code is the editor that we use
for web development and a lot of
software projects and now we can
actually start writing our code in this
Visual Studio code browser all right so
let me just bring this to one half of
the
screen so that we can be a little more
organized here I'm going to close this
terminal over here and let's bring this
here and we're going to use this for
just testing what we are building okay
so to begin I'm just going to go back
and search calculator so that I have for
reference what my calculator looks like
so this is what my calculator looks like
right over here I am just going to right
click and click
inspect and gently when you inspect you
will see a view like this so you will
see some developer tools here below your
actual web page and in the developer
tools there's this button right here
this is called the device mode so what
you can do here is click this button and
now you can view the web page in a
mobile device so you can see a mobile
preview of the web page and you can also
put the dock to the right side or the
left side so that you can actually line
it up nicely with a mobile device so
this is what let me just reload the page
so this is what the calculator looks
like on a mobile device on google.com
and I'm going to open up one version of
it on desktop as well so this is the
normal view of the calculator and this
is the mobile view of the calculator and
we're going to start by building the
mobile view of the calculator okay now
to start coding uh I am going to start
by creating an SRC folder over here so
I'm going to just create a folder SRC
which is where I'm going to put in all
my HTML CSS and JavaScript and now let
me create a new file index.html which is
going to contain all the HTML that I'm
going to write so let me just uh put in
a doc type here so that's something that
you should always put in let me put in
the HTML tag and in the HTML tag let me
put in a head tag and let me put in a
body tag and in the head tag let me just
put in a
title scientific
calculator
and in the body tag let me put in for
now just a div that says hello world all
right so this is what we have so far we
have let's Zoom that in a bit so we have
scientific calculator let's get rid of
this yeah so we have scientific
calculator that's the title of the page
we have a body inside the body we have a
div that says hello world and now let us
simply try and view this page so we want
to be able to preview this index.html
page and to preview it we can use an
extension called live server because
it's not very straight forward to
preview a web page directly from Cod
spaces you need a vs code extension for
that so just head into extensions and
search for live
server okay the live server is simply
going to let us preview the web page we
are
building within code spaces okay so once
this live server extension built by Ric
day is installed let's close this
extension tab here so extensions are
found here in the menu you can see that
there's an menu called extension and
just search for live server install it
now once you do that you will see that
there is a go live
button I'll have to expand this a bit
yeah you will see that there's a go live
button at the bottom of the page and
this go live button is going to turn
your code space into a server
essentially and it's going to give you a
preview of the page that you had open
here so I had open index.html here and
now you can see that I have this
index.html if I zoom in a bit you can
see the words hello world over here and
you can see scientific calculator in the
title so that is how I've set up a
preview of my code okay so that's great
now we have on the left we have an
index. HTML file on the right we have
this hello world text so that's great
now of course we want to use the
bootstrap CSS framework so I'm just
going to go in here and search boot
bootstrap CSS and bootstrap CSS makes it
really easy to build very flexible
layouts it also provides a bunch
of yeah maybe I should go for the latest
version uh it also provides a bunch of
different components that we can use and
that makes development really fast so I
am just going to let's see read the docs
and we want to get started with
bootstrap so let's start by okay it says
that you need to create an index.html
file and we need to add a couple of meta
tags so let's copy these meta tags meta
caret equals utf8 and meta name equals
viewport so these are both required to
enable proper responsive behavior on
mobile devices so I'm just going to come
in and paste these meta tags in my code
over here so all I've done is I've read
the documentation so read meta tags from
here and pasted them here then the next
thing I'm going to do is include
bootstrap CSS and JavaScript so
bootstrap contains a CSS file which
contains all the styles that it provides
and it contains a JavaScript file which
contains all the all the interactivity
it provides with drop downs and things
like that so let's just come in and
include those as well so I'm going to
include my the link tag for this
bootstrap CSS file in my head tag and
I'm going to include the script tag over
here at the bottom of the body okay now
if this doesn't make sense don't worry
you can spend some time learning
bootstrap but the idea here is we using
an external framework all it gives us is
some nice things that allow us to
quickly build web pages without having
to worry too much about writing a lot of
custom CSS okay perfect It also says you
can also include popper and JS
separately well I'm not worried about
that so with that I think I have added
bootstrap and I should immediately be
able to just see that you can see here
that the Styles have immediately changed
I had a different font earlier and now I
have a slightly different font so that's
great now we've added bootstrap as well
and at this point I my web page is
looking pretty good and I think I'm
ready to start building my scientific
calculator but let me also save the work
I've done and the way I'm going to save
it is simply by adding so going into the
git tab in Visual Studio code and adding
a adding a commit message to perform a
git commit so I'm just going to say here
um add
bootstrap let's see add index.html and
bootstrap and I'm just going to click
commit and it's going to ask me a few
things and it's going to just commit
those changes and that's it and now this
is going to get pushed so you press the
sync button and that is going to now
push that code back to the repository
okay so that of course is the git
workflow you open up the code either
locally on your computer or on a GitHub
code space then you make some changes
and you test them out using a live
server or some kind of a server and then
you commit and push those changes back
to GitHub so GitHub makes this workflow
very simple and now you can see that in
this index.html file you actually have
the scientific calculator basic code
that we have put up so
far all right so with that let us
actually start building this scientific
calculator so I am just going to build
this piece out for now to to begin with
and this looks like okay maybe I just
want to put this in the center of the
page somewhere somewhere over here and
maybe I'll just put a title called
scientific calculator somewhere so I'm
going to start by creating a bootstrap
container so I'm going to create a div
with the class
container and what that does is that
creates this nice div which is always
going to remain horizontally centered
within the page and let us inside this
div let us put in an H1 or a header tag
and let's call it scientific
calculator okay perfect so now we have
this scientific
calculator thing over here and this is
looking fine um I and you can also see
that the container is actually centered
on the page so that's why this is
centered but I could also just add text
Center the class text text Center on the
header itself so that this header comes
right in between okay I could also
control the font size if I wanted maybe
this is too big for me maybe I don't
want something so big well actually I'm
not I'm a bit zoomed in and that's why
maybe it appears a bit too big I might
want to add some space above and that
that is where you would normally write
some CSS you would say margin top 32
pixels or something like that and again
bootstrap provides some
simple U simple classes utility classes
where you can say something along the
lines of myy or Mt which stands on
margin top and you can say mt2 and it
has like a preconfigured sets of margins
so you can say 1 2 3 4 or five and that
is going to control the margins let me
try mt3 yeah so I think mt3 that is the
amount of margin that got added here
that looks good okay so that's the
utility of bootstrap and you can check
out all of these classes simply by
looking up the documentation so there
are these utility classes for spacing
and you can see here bootstrap includes
a wide range of shorthand responsive
margin padding and GAP utility classes
and you can do something like mt1 mt2
mt3 so I'll let you experiment with it
this is not a bootstrap tutorial but the
idea is we've just spaced things out a
little bit we've centered this on the
page and we have now put some space
above our
title and let's start building this uh
let's start building this actual
calculator so I'm going to put this
calculator inside a card a bootstrap
card because that would be a nice way to
kind of contain the entire user
interface of the calculator because my
page is largely empty and the way I'll
do that is first I will create a row so
in bootstrap whenever you're creating a
responsive layout you start by creating
a row and in that row I am going to now
create a
column okay and in this column so maybe
let's just look at the row and let's
just add a border to the row so that you
can see what the row looks like so right
now we have this row and this row takes
up all the space from this end to this
end that's a lot of space I probably
don't need that much space uh so I'll do
something about it but let me now add a
column to it so let me add a column and
let me make this maybe just six U let me
make it width six columns long so in
bootstrap there is something called the
grid system so every row is split into
12 columns and you can create a div
spanning six columns so this is where
my UI my UI is going to go so I could
say UI goes here all right so now you
can see uh if I add another border
around
this you can see that now we have this
row of content once again I'll zoom in
for you so that you can see clearly
what's is happening but yeah you can see
that now we have this row of content and
in that row of content we have this
column this one this one div that covers
six columns out of the 12 I I want to
Center this div I don't want it to take
up the entire it but I want it to Center
so that's where I can say something
along the lines
of
offset call
and okay that doesn't yeah I guess it's
just offset three
yeah so now what we have done is we have
said that we have a row and the row
spans the entire width of the container
and in that we are going to create a
column A div which spans six columns but
of course it's going to leave three
columns on the left and then it's going
to create span six columns and then of
course three columns are going to be
remaining on the right okay so we've
left an offset of three columns we are
taking up six columns and then we have
three more columns on the right that we
uh that is that way we've centered this
user interface on the page all right so
so far so good this is looking fine to
me now let us start adding some of the
user interface for our
calculator um now I'm going to use a
card to create the calculator just to
have a
nice let's see let's just search for
card so just to have a nice border
around my calcul around my calculator
I'm going to use a card so here's what
we can do we can create a div with the
class card and then we can create a div
with a class card body so let me just
quickly do that let me get rid of these
borders and let me get rid of these
borders and I'm just going to say div
class equals
card and I'm going to say div class
equals card
body and my UI goes here okay so we're
getting close so you can see that by
using the card component from bootstrap
again just look it up just look at an
example you'll get it now we've created
this nice card and inside this card we
have this nice user interface that we
can now start building okay
and now let's start by creating so
what's the first thing here the first
thing is this input box right over here
so let's start by creating this input
box how do we create an input box let's
search for input okay looks like there's
something called an input Group which we
can use or maybe even like form control
I think we need something like this we
probably want to just show the output of
the button clicks the current expression
in an input box like this so I am going
to use I think this looks good form
control LG so maybe I can just use this
so let me just copy this form control
LG and come back here and paste that in
here and yeah that looks good to me of
course I probably don't
need I probably don't need this
placeholder over here so let me get rid
of placeholder so you can see we have an
input of the type text and it has the
class form control and form control LG
to LG simply means large so to make it a
little bigger and finally we have uh a
bunch of other labels that we might find
useful okay so now we have form control
LG I'm also going to make this read only
because we don't want to be able to edit
this directly so I'm just going to make
it read only uh like that uh and we only
want to edit it based on the content
that we put from the buttons that we
click okay and that's going to come up
soon all right the last thing I'm going
to add here is maybe an ID
because so I'm just going to give it an
ID Cal display and because this ID is
going to be used to actually set the
value of this particular field over here
okay so now we have this field something
like this not exactly this but close
enough now we need to start adding some
buttons so we have all these buttons
okay brackets percentage AC 789 Etc so
let's start adding these buttons so to
add these buttons I am once again going
to create another row so I'm going to
say
div class equals
row okay and let's add the first row of
buttons here so the first row of buttons
is I'm going to use the BTN or button
tag and each of the buttons is taking up
1/4 of the space so remember that every
row has 12 columns inside it so that
means each button is going to take up
three columns so maybe first let me
create a div with three columns so div
class
equals call three and that's going to
take up three columns and inside this
let me put in a button now again there's
a way to put in buttons in bootstrap
there there are some helper classes so
I'm just going to search for button
right over here and again we're going
quickly because this is not exactly a
bootstrap tutorial but you can go to the
documentation you can see what buttons
look like this is what buttons look like
uh I don't want a base button maybe I
want a button like this because that
seems to be the color that is used in
most of these buttons so I'm just I'm
just going to use BTN light or button
light let's grab that okay button type
equals button BTN light and let's just
paste that in here and yeah looks like
we now have this light button so that's
good uh of course we need some spacing
around it we maybe need to add a border
around it so let's fix that in a second
but at this point let me add one button
here so the the button here is
that okay so my buttons looking fine and
let's add maybe a couple more buttons
and then we'll fix this spacing Etc so
we have another closing bracket
percentage and AC so let's come in and
fix those
buttons okay this is interesting now
when we make when we reduce the size of
our scientific calculator of our browser
that is going to squish the calculator a
little bit so maybe we can do this we
can say offset
md3 and call
md6 and for small screens we can just
take let it take up the entire space
call
12 okay so for small screens it takes up
the entire width of the container the
this is the the div wrapping or the
column wrapping the card so for small
screens it takes up the entire width and
then it shifts into a smaller width
later for MD screens okay and we can
adjust this further towards the end but
for now this is
fine all right coming right back we need
to add a few more buttons but let me
just improve this button slightly a bit
the first thing I want to do here is
let's put one more button and then we'll
see what we can do about
it so the first issue that I'm running
into that this button is not really
taking up the entire width of the column
maybe it should so I could just come in
into the button and let me just go into
the button and say
w00 and w00 is a helper class within
bootstrap that makes the button take up
the entire width of the column okay let
me add that here the w 100 let me add
that in here as well so both my buttons
have width of 100 so that's good I think
buttons can also have a margin top
probably so let me add a margin top here
so let me say mt1 or mt2 okay mt2 looks
good so now there is some top margin
that we have added Let Me Maybe also add
a border to these buttons because it'll
be nice these buttons seem to have a
border around them maybe so let me add a
border to this as well so let me add
empty2
border okay the button is looking good I
think the space between these buttons is
too high um maybe I can reduce the space
and this is a default Space Between The
Columns within a row and you can control
the space between columns using
something called gutters uh in bootstrap
again that is done I I'll let you
explore this but the basic idea here is
you can use these GX and gy classes to
control the amount of space between
columns so I'm just going to come into
the come into my row here which which is
the row of buttons that I've created and
I'm going to say gx1 and you can see
just as as soon as I say gx1 the buttons
become a little wider and the space
between them reduces okay so yeah I've
just added a bunch of classes here and
you can always look up what these
classes do so I encourage you to do that
and I encourage you to also maybe right
click inspect and see what exactly what
are the CSS properties that get applied
here okay all right so now we have the
button and we have uh another button
let's take and let's take these two
buttons and add a couple more
buttons
oops
okay let's add let's see what these
buttons are so percentage and AC are the
buttons that we are adding here so let's
add the percentage symbol let's add
AC okay that's good now we want more
buttons here so one thing we could do is
maybe create more rows uh we could
actually create another row and then in
that row add multiple columns but
remember that bootstrap has 12 columns
within a row and if you try to create a
div that does not fit within those 12
columns it'll automatically go to the
next line or the next row essentially
it's going to wrap onto the next uh line
so I can I don't actually have to create
a new row I can simply copy these
columns and just create another set of
columns right below it and what that'll
allow me to do is I can then make it a
little more flexible maybe uh in my
layout but you don't have to do it this
way it's just an easy way to do it okay
so here's my second row of buttons how
many rows do we have so we have 1 2 3
four five rows so let's add those five
rows here
so I'm just copy pasting uh I'm just
copy pasting these four columns or these
four column buttons again and
again 1 2 3 4 and let's add one more set
of buttons Perfect all right so now
we've added a bunch of these buttons and
let's maybe actually put in the values
so we have 789 and the division symbol
we should find a way to actually copy
that division
symbol uh let's find
it so if you just search division symbol
you can actually find the symbol online
uh but anyway let's first put it in so
this is the first row of data this is
fine then this is the second row of data
or second row of buttons let me make
them 7
9 and the division symbol so let's copy
that division symbol and put that in
here okay so now you have 7 8 9 find
division perfect then let us get that
next row that is 4 5 6 and the
multiplication symbol so let's get that
in
5 6 and multiplication
symbol yeah this is the multiplication
symbol so 4 56 and the multiplication
symbol perfect it's looking good let's
get the next uh set of rows here so one
three and the minus
symbol so let's get the minus symbol is
already present on the keyboard so we
don't need to change a lot here 1 2 3
and the minus
symbol okay we've added the next set as
well finally we have 0 dot equal to and
the plus
symbol so now we have zero we have dot
or point or percentage or decimal point
equal to and the plus symbol okay but
perfect it's looking good I think the
equal to symbol can be made blue and
again this we can do simply by changing
the class here instead of button light I
could say button primary and instead of
Border I could say border primary or
maybe like border and then border
primary and that's going to give it the
blue
color okay with that we have implemented
the basic user interface of the
scientific calculator right over here
and we have of course it's not working
yet none of the buttons actually do
anything but if for 15 20 minutes of
work this is not looking too bad okay
so let's go ahead and commit that so
basic
buttons and input box let's commit it
and let us just sync
it and that's going to now go and get
added to our GitHub repository okay
perfect now we'll also see how how to
deploy this so stay tuned till the end
and as I mentioned earlier we'll also
see how to do all of this or most of it
using something like chat GPT okay now
let us start adding the functionality
for this and to add the functionality
for all of this we are going to have to
use some JavaScript so I'm going to
assume basic knowledge of JavaScript
here variables data types functions and
I'm going to show you how you can use
JavaScript within an HTML page and there
are various ways to do it but but the
simplest way to do it is by using a
script tag so you could for example go
to this bottom of your body and add a
script tag here so I'm just going to go
in here and add a script
tag and you need a closing script tag as
well okay and you can also put in yeah I
think that's it and then now you can put
in anything inside this so I could put
for example
console.log hello
world okay and and now this anything you
put within the script tag is Javascript
code so now you can actually check you
can
inspect let me yeah so this is the
mobile view I think that's fine but let
me just bring the doc down to the bottom
and let me also turn off device mode for
now yeah so you can actually check the
console tab here of the developer tools
you can always go go here from window
developer tools or just type developer
tools here from the okay it's from The
View tab so view
developer developer tools or JavaScript
console that's going to bring you to
this page so view developer JavaScript
console there's also a shortcut for it
you can see here that we typed
console.log hello world and that printed
hello world here instead if you had
said hello Jovian that would say hello
Jovin so this way you can add JavaScript
code within your or HTML now of course
we need a way to actually connect this
JavaScript code with the buttons that we
are seeing on screen so the first thing
we'll do is we're going to say document
dot on
ready yeah something like that so uh
what what we want to do is we want to
make sure that we run the JavaScript
only after the entire document has
loaded up properly so I'm just going to
go in maybe and ask this on jobot our
chat GPT powered chat assistant so let's
see how do how to run some JavaScript
code after the HTML document is ready
okay and it's going to tell me some
explanation which you should read
absolutely okay so basically what it's
telling me is that if you want to run
some JavaScript code if you want to
interact with an HTML page after the
HTML page is loaded up properly then you
need to put in your JavaScript code
inside this piece of code so basically
what we are saying here I'm just going
to first come in and paste it in here so
basically what we saying here is that to
the document which is the entire HTML
document and this is a predefined
variable in JavaScript there's a bunch
of predefined variables like window
document Etc so to the document we are
adding an event listener which means
when this event occurs we want to do
something with it what is the event that
we're looking for we looking for the
event Dom content loaded which means
that the entire page the HTML the CSS
Etc of the entire page has been loaded
in by the browser and when that event or
when the entire content has been loaded
then we are
asking the browser to fire this
JavaScript function so you can see that
we've provided two things we to add
event listener which is a function or a
method inside document we've added two
things we said when the event Dom
content loaded is fired which means when
the entire content is loaded then call
this function inside call this function
or call the code inside this function
okay and that's why we're providing it
as a function because a function can be
invoked when the event occurs and not we
don't want to run this code immediately
we want to run it only after the page is
ready okay so that's how you add some
JavaScript code into um an HTML page
okay now what do we want to do here I
guess first thing to do is maybe just
once again add that console log saying
that document is ready and let's just
see and you can see here now the same
thing is printed document is ready but
of course it is printed after the
browser has loaded the entire content
okay now let's get remember this input
over here we have given it an input uh
we have given it an ID calc display okay
we've given an ID calc display so let's
first get this input let's get a hang of
this input so let's um let's call it
display so let me say const display
equal equals document. getet
element by
ID
Cal
display okay so what we're doing here is
we are saying that we want to get the
HTML element which has the ID calc
display and document. get element by ID
is the function you use to do that we
want to get the calc display HTML
element and we want to store it in the
variable display okay and now we can
just do console.log display for example
okay let me fix the tab size over here
looks like it's just adding a bunch of
spaces that I don't need end it using
spaces and two spaces yeah all right I'm
good so now we have this now let's do
console.log
display okay and now you can see here
that as soon as the document loads our
JavaScript code is searching for the
element with the ID Cal display and it
is simply printing it here in the conso
cons and you can see when I hover over
it it actually shows me on the screen
right over here that the input box is
what um this element is referring to
okay so now we've gotten a hold of our
input box now let's try to get a hold of
all these buttons okay how do we get all
these buttons well let's see const
buttons equals document dot get Elements
by class name and I think all the
buttons have the class name
BTN and I can say
console.log
buttons okay great so you can see here
that each button has the class BTN all
right so we have gotten a hang of all
the buttons with the all the elements
with the class BTN simply by saying
document. get Elements by class name BTN
okay and you can see here that we've
printed them out and it says that it's
an HTML collection of 20 buttons and
each Button as I hover over it you can
see that shows me that specific button
so that's the first first thing you need
to understand whenever you're writing
some JavaScript code to add interactive
interactivity into an HTML code you
can simply uh select a some HTML node
using things like document by. getet
element by ID or you can get element by
class name or you can get element by tag
name there are a bunch of ways and you
can store those HTML elements or
references to those HTML elements in
these uh in variables of your choice
okay all right next up now let us maybe
try to add a click Handler to one of the
buttons let's do something when a button
is clicked so let's say buttons zero and
that should simply pick the first button
dot add event listener so again now I'm
adding an event listener to the button
and what event do I listen for want to
listen for I want to listen for the
click so I'm saying when the button is
clicked I want to run a function so I
have to provide the function that is
going to get executed when the button is
clicked okay so the function that gets
executed when the button is clicked uh
for now I'm just simply going to say
console.log first button
clicked all right and now you can see
that I have this event listener attached
to my first button and nothing happens
so far you we are not printing first
button clicked and let's say I click the
first button you are going to see
printed your first button clicked so
that is the next thing you want to
understand that you can add event
listeners or click handlers to specific
Dom nodes in this case it's a button and
you do that using add event listener and
you can do that not just on uh click but
you can also do hover and let's say I
could just then print out first button
hovered and this time what happens is
when I simply well maybe not hover maybe
it's some other event I don't know like
Focus I don't know well there's probably
some event uh out there but yeah uh for
click you can simply get uh some
something printed out on clicking okay
perfect so now we've added a click
listener to one of the buttons but
ideally we want to add click listeners
to all of the buttons at once uh or
individual click listeners to all of the
buttons how do we do that well we can do
something like this we can say buttons.
for each so for each is a way for you to
do something for every element in a
array in a JavaScript array okay so what
you can do is you can now provide a
function to for each okay which is going
to take each individual
button and it is going to operate that
on the individual button so the button
now is going to refer to each button one
by one and now I can say
console.log button
clicked and from this button maybe I can
get the text of that button so button do
inner text so if you want to get the
text inside an
HTML uh element then you do that simply
by simply by calling do inner text okay
that's a
property let's see maybe it's for each
without a yeah like
that okay
so let's turn that
into get Elements by I could just use a
for Loop here I I think that would be
simpler so for let I equals z i less
than buttons.
length i++ a for each would have been
nice but looks like there are some
problems when you're working with an
HTML collection you probably can't do
for each or something but button so
const button equals buttons I so what
I'm doing here is I'm looping over the
list of buttons and I'm getting each
button and then I'm
saying button
clicked button do inner text
okay all right so now what we've done is
for each button we are simply going to
log that the button was clicked when the
button is text and we are going to log
the inner text of that button
so ah I need to add that
actual um click listener so I need to
say button do add event listener click
of course we want to do the console log
only when the button is clicked and not
always so let's add this console log
only when the button is clicked
okay all right well let's see what's ah
l n GTH that should fix it yeah okay so
now you can see here all we've done is
got in a list of buttons using get
Elements by class name gotten a list of
the actual docu the actual display input
display using get element by ID and now
we are looping over the buttons using
this for Loop we saying I equal 0 I less
than buttons. length i++ and we getting
each Button as buttons I and then we
adding a click listener uh event
listener to each button and on the event
click we want to invoke this function
okay the function that that's going to
get invoked is simply going to say
console.log button clicked and now when
I click on a button you can see that
each time we simply print which button
was clicked button click percentage
button click 99 8 7 Etc okay so it's a
bit of work to hook up JavaScript code
with some of the event handlers for
specific Dom nodes for specific nodes on
the HTML page that's why a lot of people
use Frameworks or libraries like jQuery
react Etc but this is just raw
JavaScript we're simply picking up a
button we are attaching an event
listener to it and this is what it's
doing okay now of course what we want to
do instead is not actually use the
console loged event but simply add that
here add that information here for
example if I type seven I just want
seven to be added here okay so here's
what we can do about that so let's
say in this button let's do this let us
first keep track of the current value of
the
input in a variable called current value
okay so let's do that and let us
say
const value so this is the value that is
present inside the button is simply
button. inner
text okay and now I can say current
value plus equals value okay so we have
adding we adding the inner text of the
button to the variable current value
which we have here and then we can
say current value uh then we can we have
the display here so we can say display
do value remember display this this is
simply the input box over here so we can
say display. value equals current value
all right so let's try that
out okay so you can start to see here
what's happening as soon as we so what
we're doing is we creating this variable
current value it contains the empty
string right now but what we then doing
is when a button is clicked we're
getting the inner text of the button
adding it to the current value so the
current value now contains the empty
string plus the value from the button
plus the value from the next button that
clicked and so on and then one very
important thing we also doing is we also
setting the value of the input box to
current value if we didn't have this
then current value would keep changing
so we could just log current value over
here okay we could just log current
value over here and you can see current
value is changing to whatever I set it
to but this is not changing there's
nothing is getting added here and that
is where you can actually set the value
of the value inside an input field and
you can change the text inside a
particular div and you can do all sorts
of things so basically you can modify
the content on the page using display.
value or display. inner text or whatever
you want to uh want to use for it and
you can set it to some value that's
coming from a JavaScript variable or you
can just set it to something manually
okay so that's great so now we
have this functionality and I think one
thing we can do maybe bring it to the
right instead of the left so I'm just
going to come back in here into my text
uh into my HTML code and I'm just going
to say for this input text end and I
believe that's simply going to orient
the text at the end for
it and that's looking good okay so now
we able to actually capture this value
but of course we are not actually
working with the equal to yet so we need
to handle equal to we need to handle AC
let's start with AC AC is simply going
to clear the entire thing so let's start
with AC so what we can do here is we can
actually do an if else on the value of
the button text of So based on the
button that was clicked we need to do a
simp we need to maybe uh run a separate
piece of logic so I'm going to say if
value which is the button that was
clicked equals and I'm just comparing
here that's why I'm using the double
equal to equals AC then we want to do
something else otherwise we want to do
something else right so else we want to
do this so let's get this into
else okay let's get this into else over
here and let us now go in here and let
us set the current value simply to
empty and again let's just set display.
value equals current value okay so now
we've implemented the functionality for
the AC
button
so let's say minus 3 and when I press AC
you can see that's simply clear clearing
the current value because its value is
AC and it is setting the display value
to the current value okay
so now I am I think things are looking
pretty good so now we are working now
this is working of course brackets and
all are also working these may not be
Val valid Expressions but nevertheless
these expressions are working the next
thing we need to do is actually evaluate
these so when equal to is clicked we
don't want to insert an equal to we
actually want to evaluate these and for
this we're going to use a shortcut here
normally some something like Google
would actually do a proper ifls
condition they would pass the string and
they would have some logic to evaluate
it or maybe they would send it to a
server and evaluate it and get the
result here but we just going to use a
shortcut which is not safe to use in a
production application so I just want to
tell you that but here's what we're
going to do um let's put another else if
over here so let's say else
if and after lsf let me just uh close
the bracket over here as well and let's
say if the value is equal to the string
equal to okay I know this looks
confusing but we saying the value inside
which is the inner text of the button is
equal to the string equal to in that
case what do we want to do well uh let's
maybe write a helper function here to do
this so let's see uh let's call this
function evaluate so function
evaluate and let's call it evaluate
result and let us just call this
function evaluate result in that
case okay and we're going to put and
this is just to keep our code organized
slightly nicely so evaluate result so I
am just going to here's what I'm going
to do I am going
to Simply say con result equals eval
okay now this is a very dangerous
function be very careful while using it
but here's what eval does you give it
some JavaScript code and it is going to
ex execute that JavaScript code for you
ideally you should not be evaluating
User submitted JavaScript code on your
website because they can have some code
there which can fetch some data from
your um from somewhere on your server
and then do malicious things with it uh
this code could be coming from some
Chrome extension or something so
definitely never use eval in production
applications rather you might want to
write an if else to kind of pass the
expression and then execute it so that
as an exercise but for now I'm simply
going to evaluate the current value so
I'm going to take the current value as
an expression as a JavaScript expression
I'm going to evaluate it and you can
test this out you can actually go into
the yeah so let's say you you type 2 +
3 you can see that that evaluates to
five right and you can also do slightly
more complex things you can say 2 + 3
now of course in JavaScript
multiplication has this star symbol 4 /
and that evaluates 2.85 Etc right so
eval is simply going to take an
expression and execute it like
JavaScript code and store that
result in this thing called result okay
and then we can say current value equals
result and maybe we can convert it to a
string so how do we convert something to
a string in JavaScript I'm just going to
add ask
jobot how do you convert something to
string in Java
script and you can just say two string
and that's going to convert it to a
string so I'm just going to use that so
I am just going to say result dot two
string perfect and let me now set
display. value equals current
value and I think this should be it um
let me also maybe yeah let's let's try
this out first so let's say 4 + 3 = 7
and just like that we've implemented our
calculator see that wasn't that hard and
we still just about at 160 lines of code
but of course most of this code is just
a bunch of buttons copy pasted many many
times and we will when we learn
Frameworks we are also going to learn
about how you can reduce the amount of
HTML that you write where you don't have
to copy paste things and if you have to
change the style of all the buttons you
have to go and change them in a bunch of
places but for now since we're keeping
things simple let's just uh keep it way
but just like that we've implemented the
functionality and it works probably with
something even more complex I could say
7-
3 plus and then in Brackets
2.1 +
6 and that entire thing works okay so
that's good there is one problem though
AC works as well let's try 8 * by 9 what
does that
do okay that that fails and that fails
specifically because well uh inside
evaluate result let us just log the
value of current value so let's say
console.log current
value current value okay it's always a
good idea to give labels to your logs uh
let me get rid of this document. is
ready I think I don't need that anymore
okay so when I do 8 * 6 you can see here
that the current value is 8 * 6 it has
this time symbol but we don't want the
time symbol we actually want the
symbol star the star symbol is what is
valid JavaScript code so we may have to
do some replacement over here and that
is where we can
say
const
um let's see converted Val let's just
call it converted value equals current
value so current value is a string and
and in the string we simply want to
replace the the this character over here
which is the times character let's get
that from our code over here yeah so
this is the times character so we want
to replace the times
character with a star okay so that's all
we are doing here and now we oops sorry
about that and now um we can log the
current value and let's log the
converted value as well in the converted
value we've simply replaced times with
star and let's evaluated let's evaluate
the converted value okay so let's now
try 7 * 6 equals and you can see here
that the current value was 7 * 6 and uh
the converted value this should say
converted
value and the converted value is let's
try that again 9 * 6 so the current
value is 9 * 6 and the converted value
is 9 star 6 which which is valid
JavaScript code and that ultimately ends
up being converted into the string 54
okay so that's great we have fixed that
maybe there we also want to fix the
division symbol so let's go ahead and
fix that as well we don't need to fix
minus and plus they're probably fine we
probably need to uh do something about
the percentage as well we're going to
see what to do about that but let us fix
the division symbol as well let's grab
the division symbol over
here and let us come in here and let us
just go in and
[Music]
say yeah replace right so I'm just going
to come in and say let's let's add some
space here just so that things are a
little easier to
see and by the way in JavaScript you can
actually put statements on the next line
just for better readability so I'm
simply replacing the division symbol by
slash and hopefully now 6 / 3 should
work that's two uh let's try percentage
so now 9 29% equals okay that doesn't
work again so we want to convert
percentage as well a quick replacement
for percentage would be to Simply
multiply by 0.01 so I could just say
multiply it by
0.01 and let's see now so let's see AC
9% equals
0.09 okay that's working as well I think
that's it that is our basic calculator
we've not added the scientific functions
yet we will see how to add them in just
a bit but that's looking pretty good and
things are looking so good so far so I'm
just going to commit this so I'm going
to say added basic
functionality and let me just commit
that and let me send that back to the
GitHub repository okay now I can check
back the GitHub repository over here
let's see
github.com
and I should have my reposit
here where is
it well I'm just going to go into my
profile and in my profile I'm going to
look for
repositories and here we have scientific
calculator live and you can see
scientific calculator live has all the
code and everything is still inside
index.html uh one quick thing I'm I'm
going to show you right after this is
how to separate out the script into a
different file so let's do that as well
let me come back in here let's create a
file
script.js and let's grab all the code
from index.html into
script.js okay and let's put that in
here so that we can worry about it
separately and let us now just give this
SRC
equals
script.js okay and it should still work
exactly the same
way
H let me just restart the live server
and let's
see
okay let's uh let's try going live
again yeah there it is and let's see if
the let's grab this and put it in
here
okay well it says refuse to execute
script
from such and such let's we should be
able to fix that so let's just go into
jobot and let's search
I got this error while
including JS in
HTML okay so we sending the wrong mime
type Etc the server needs to do
something okay looks like there's some
kind of
a yeah I'm just going to say I don't
have
access
all right well looks like there's
probably nothing I can do about this at
the moment so I'm just going to have to
maybe bring back my uh JavaScript code
well no it's
gone okay yeah that did it I think I
just had to put SRC script.js instead
of/ script.js and that worked yeah
sometimes you run into these errors and
you just search online and you should be
able to to figure them out and let us
just Commit This so let's say separated
out the script
file and let's push it back and now the
next thing I want to show you now that
this is loaded up let's just yeah you
can see there's index.html script.js I
want to show you how to deploy this so
you can go to wor.com and create an
account and worel is a platform for very
easily deploying JavaScript related or
nodejs projects in any web related
project and I'm going to say add new
project and you can connect your GitHub
account here and it can get access to
your private repositories public
repositories Etc and you can see here
that it can see in my account that there
is this scientific calculator live so
I'm importing this project over here and
here on ver cell.com I can select some
framework so I'm not using a framework
right now there's a CSS framework but
this is talking about more of a backend
framework that I'm using I'm not using
any of these but I do need to tell it
which directory contains my index.html
file and that happens to be SRC so I'm
going to select the SRC directory as the
Live directory and then I can just click
deploy okay it's as simple as that you
go to wor.com sign in connect your
GitHub with it and then click deploy
create a new project and select the root
root directory and now you can actually
go ahead and uh you get this nice URL
scientific calculator Livewell doapp and
I'm just going to drop that in the chat
and you can try it out you can try it
out on your own and you can see whether
it's mobile friendly or not yep it looks
fairly mobile friendly to me yep and
we'll have to figure out how to make it
exactly like the Google uh scientific
calculator but for now I am pretty happy
with how this is looking okay great so
now let's continue on now that we've
done this deployment as well let us
continue and add maybe some of the
scientific features we may not get to
everything we are kind of running out of
time here as well but let's see let's
add maybe a couple of rows all right so
so now there is this selector here 1 2 3
in FX I'm just going to add it below I'm
just going to keep keep things simple
for now but I encourage you to try it
out and I'm going to add this row s Ln
pi and cos because these seem like an
interesting set of things to
add so let's see let us come back over
here and let us say uh let's add another
row
of values so let me grab the last four
buttons and let me create a copy and let
me paste that in here so one is called
s then one is called Ln which is
logarithm and the natural logarithm
probably and one's called Pi let me just
get the pi
symbol let's get it
here okay and the pi symbol over here is
just
that character and let me get in what's
that last symbol over there C so let's
get C in here as
well
okay so let's see if we are able to make
that work of course this doesn't need to
be a primary button anymore this can be
our
normal light
button all right and yeah there we have
sign Ln Pi cos and let's try to just
Implement sign for now okay what if we
do s and then maybe Open brackets of
course like it has to be proper it has
to be a proper expression for it to get
evaluated and I click
equal okay runs into an error so it says
reference error sign is not defined okay
and I'm literally just going to copy
this error and I'm going to come back to
jobard and said um say let's just reset
this I got this error when trying to
compute
sign in JavaScript script and what does
it say it looks like you may have
forgotten to prefix a sign function with
the math object and this is how you
should be using it nice so I'm just
going to go ahead and use that I'm going
to go into my script.js and into my
script.js I'm just going to add that
replace and for
sign I am just going to replace that
with math. sign and hopefully that
should fix it let's go back in here and
let us check so
S
4 equal okay looks good it's probably in
radians not in degrees that's fine I'm
not too concerned about the specific
details right now so sign is implemented
here minus
0.75 uh maybe we should fix cost the
same way as well let's see
cost uh that is simply math. cost for
cost okay so let's try cos
8 * sin 9
equals okay yeah seems fine I could I
could just test that in this calculator
as well uh this calculator actually
allows typing to in case you want to try
that and it also inserts button it also
inserts a bracket and all but cos 8 *
sin 9 that's what we did so cos 8 *
sin
9 yeah that's about the same 0.559 0.559
0599 okay that's good uh let's deal with
Ln over here so okay I think one thing
we should do is somehow find a way where
if the result has already been computed
then we should not um pressing a button
should not add to that but again
Advanced behavior I'm going to leave
that for now but
Ln 8 let's see if that works nope so
let's try math. Ln I'm just going to try
this out and see what
happens
Len math. Ln
okay so
Ln
8 H math. Ln is not a function so let's
see um I'm going to come back here to
jobot I'm going to ask it once again uh
I'm trying to
compute the natural
logarithm in
JavaScript I get this error
okay jan.com jobot just go in here and
drop it in okay it's math.log I believe
so for the mathematical for the natural
logarithm you just say math.log so I'm
going to change that to math.log
um and I'm going to say uh while we
here can you also tell me how to find
the value of
pi yeah it's just math.pi so I'm going
to going to fix that as well so let's go
in here and let's
replace the pi symbol I'm going to get
the pi character the pi symbol is right
over
here and there you go we have fixed that
as well so now we type Pi you press
equals that's 3.14 and whatever pi means
okay and we can for example try to
compute the the P Pi R square of a
circle okay that reminds me we can
probably add things like Square to
let's get one more line while we while
we're doing this this is interesting
let's go go ahead and Implement one more
line over here okay we have log e tan
and square root fine let's do it so log
I believe would be the log to the base
10 and I can verify that by again going
into log to the base
10 equals 1 yeah so log is log to the
base 10 so how do we do log base
lock to the base 10 in
JavaScript yeah I think it's going to
try and figure out yeah okay there's
something called math. log 10x and that
is going to do log to the base 10 for us
so we can do one more row and probably
square root is going to be somewhat
interesting so let me just do one more
row and I'll leave the rest rest as an
exercise for you um so that I don't give
everything
away let's see so we have these buttons
I just going to grab these buttons once
again and I am going
to drop that in here let's add
log uh by the way if you have any
questions please drop them in the
comments we will look at the questions
and alongside I want to tell you that
wait till the end because there's going
to be something really interesting that
you don't want to miss okay so we
have
log
e tan and the the square root symbol so
let's go in here square root
symbol and let's grab that okay that is
called the radical symbol but let's yeah
let's just put that in
here and now we might want to just
handle these as well so what what about
e let me just ask it what about the
constant e how do I get that well that
is simply math. capital E so we just use
that so let's go in let's go into the
settings uh let's go into the script.js
file and let's add those Replacements as
well so replace we want to replace log
with uh math. log 10 that's fine and we
want to replace e
with
math. e okay and we want to replace tan
with math. tan before we actually
evaluate it and finally we want to
replace let's see the square root symbol
and what exactly do we replace it with
I'm not
sure okay let's just search here what
about square
root you just use math.sqrt so I'm just
going to put in math.sqrt right in here
okay and with that hopefully let's see
square root of 4
equals ah
okay there some something went wrong
here I believe this requires a bracket
so um I think we might need to actually
put a bracket here so square root
bracket 4 close bracket equals yeah
that's two so that works so we might
need to rep be a little careful while
working with square root or we might
want to do something something a little
more interesting while replacing instead
of just replacing the square root itself
maybe you want to take square root
followed by whatever comes after it and
put that in Brackets or something but
for now it's fine but uh another thing
that I should do properly is I should
maybe just put all of this into a try
catch okay so JavaScript has something
whenever there's an error you can
actually catch the error and you can
handle it in some fashion and maybe show
a message to the user so let's say try
and let's put all of this into a try
block okay so it's it's going to try to
execute this code and if the uh if the
ex if the code works then that's fine
but otherwise okay let me just search
what is the Syntax for TR catch in
JavaScript what is the
Syntax for try catch in
JavaScript okay the syntax is like this
so try catch and then you catch an
error and then I'm going to print the
error so I'm going to say console.
error and that's going to print the
error in that nice red format so I don't
want to get rid of the error but what I
can do is I can set current value Val
equals error and I can say display.
value
equals current value okay this way I'm
also informing the user that there is an
error and they can then deal with it
somehow okay so let's try that again
let's do something wrong let's say
percentage and let's do equal to here
and it just prints error over here just
like a normal calculator and it also
prints out the exact error for us for
the developer to debug invalid regular
expression missing slash or something
like that right so definitely this is
something that you want to do you want
to try and catch these errors so let's
say you want to understand what exactly
is TR catch you can actually ask jobot
um or there's like a personal tutor here
and you can just ask it teach me about
JavaScript TR cat
statement and start conversation and it
is going to just tell you a bunch of
things about the TR catch statement okay
what exactly it does it's going to maybe
show you an example so it's going to
show you an example of how to use it how
to catch these errors so you can
generate tutorials on demand just go on
join.com jobot and if you want to go use
one of these specific tools over here
just scroll down and use them or you can
just type start typing and get help okay
all right I think I'm pretty happy with
the scientific calculator at this point
I am not going to go any further than
this um I will leave the design the
responsive design to you as an exercise
so how do you make it go from this to
this that is something I let you figure
out uh if you can't then just put all
the buttons here below that's perfectly
fine you don't have to exactly implement
the design and then there's also this
one other interesting thing that the
Google um that the Google Calculator
does you can actually give it a certain
input and when you click when you click
enter it stores the previous result on
top and you can see that pi equals is
stored over here and it shows this
recent history as well that is probably
too complex but this is something might
worth checking out where you can have a
previous result variable and just show
the previous result above the current
result again uh it's an optional part so
you don't actually have to implement the
whole thing but we've got ourselves a
pretty good scientific calculator I
think I'm pretty happy with this uh
right now so I'm just going to save it
over here so let me go ahead go ahead
and say
um
implemented a few scientific functions
I'm just going to commit it and I'm
going to publish it and my scientific
calculator should now be live now one of
the things that verell does the platform
that we've used for deployment because
it's connected to our GitHub uh what it
does is every time you push to the main
branch or the the main branch or the the
primary branch of the repository it is
automatically Ally going to redeploy
your code and you can see here that now
you can see that on my versel production
website uh it is automatically now it
automatically contains the updated code
so you can play along with it right now
and this is one of the best uh things
with using an integrated platform like
worel for deployment now you you're
probably wondering what if I make a
mistake WIll the what if the deployment
fails well it's going to use the
previous version but if you create a
branch and this is something that we
cover when we talked about git but if
you create a branch then on that
particular Branch it's going to create a
preview deployment it's not going to
affect your main deployment and then you
can create a pull request merge it back
so that's all about the GitHub workflow
okay the final thing that I want to show
you before we close is that we didn't
actually have to write any of this to
begin with um the tools that we that are
at our disposal are actually getting so
good right now um that you might not
actually have to write much of this code
at all um so this this is one thing that
I tried to do earlier today I just
figured what if I could just ask jobot
which is powered by chat GPT GPD 3.5
right now soon GPD 4 what if I could
just ask it that I want to build a
scientific calculator similar to the one
available within Google search Okay and
let's build it step by step so first
please give me the basic HTML code for
the page and the calculator without any
buttons and use the bootstrap 5 CSS
framework and make it responsive okay
that's what we've said here and let's
see if we can if jobot can generate some
code for us and looks like it is
generating some code looks like it is
okay it's generating it it created an
HTML page for us it has a meta it has
the right meta tags it has this link tag
for the stylesheet it has the scientific
calculator and I've asked it not to put
any buttons right now I'm going to add
the buttons in The Next Step but it
could have just created the buttons for
me as well there's a limit to how many
characters it can can give you at
once and let me just grab this and let
me open up this online platform where I
can quickly uh test out HTML code let me
get rid of what they have here let me
put in this HTML and you can see here
that it is creating this scientific
calculated this basic layout already now
the bootstrap styles did not get added
and I have a sense of why that is so one
of the issues that the chat Bots or the
code generation Bots run into is that
they may not because they're
character-wise generators they may not
actually have picked up the right
Integrity which is the hash that is used
to verify um the link tag so you might
need to replace this link tag with the
actual link tag from bootstrap so I'm
just going to go back in here go into
introduction and grab the link tag from
bootstrap itself okay uh so let's go
ahead and fix the link tag so you should
always verify any AI generated code that
you are working with you should always
go through every line of code but just
because it's not directly giving you the
result that you want doesn't mean that
it's not going to be able to solve your
problem okay let me add that script tag
in here as well so it is created for me
the scientific calculator and you can
see that it's followed the same best
practice that I followed or maybe I
copied it uh but you can see that it has
this row over here and it has this
column and okay has okay it's made it's
made this calculator too narrow so I'm
just going to stick with call md6 or
call
sm6 so so far so good okay let me now go
in here and let me come back okay so now
let me ask it okay give me the
additional
code to add the
buttons
within the
calculator and I'm just going to tell it
not to don't rewrite the entire
HTML yeah and let's see if it can just
give me the code to add the buttons and
it does so now it tells me that copy
paste this code into the form element um
just below the input field so let's do
that so now it's adding a bunch of
buttons you can see it's adding 78 9/
456 star 1 2 3 so it probably also knows
what Google's calculator looks like or a
calculator in general and that's great
and it's got these bunch of uh other
buttons here at the end equal to Z Dot
and then it's got maybe a button called
clear that's like a huge button and
maybe a backspace button
okay and it's given me some explanation
about the code as well yeah this is just
insane I did not expect that things
would get to this point um but it it is
and let's just put that in here let's
add in the buttons okay well it's not
looking too bad I think definitely
there's maybe some layout changes we may
have to do to make the buttons look
slightly nicer but I'm not complaining I
think this is is fine for now and we
could for example go in here and we
could say
gx1 right uh not just for this row but
for every row so we could go in and say
gx1 over here we could go in and say gx1
over here and we could go in and say gx1
over here and maybe gx1 over here right
now of course it is using button
secondary maybe we could just fix that
and use button outline and um let me
just actually ask it if it can add some
space
between the
buttons so let's say uh
provide some CSS to add space between
the rows of
buttons okay so now it says okay just
add
that that's it just add the
margin and you can just add it within
the you can just add it as a style tag
within your
HTML and I just go in there and I just
put that in there and there you go the
scientific calculator is looking rather
nice I could maybe come in here maybe uh
the H5 I could maybe just uh text Center
it and I could maybe just make it read
only okay that's nice and but it of
course doesn't have any logic yet let's
see if jobot can actually write the
logic okay this part I'm not too sure
but can you
now
write the logic for the buttons
using
JavaScript um don't use any
Frameworks because sometimes it might
use jQuery or something like that that's
what a lot of examples on the internet
contain don't use any libraries or
Frameworks and just give me the content
for the script
tag okay and let's ask it and let's see
if it can do that okay perfect it is
giving us
H okay it seems like then I I then have
to add this okay I let me tell it I
don't want to add I don't want to add
any on click
handlers so you can actually tell it
that you're not happy with the code I
don't add any on click handers all the
code
required to implement the
logic
should be in the script
tag
okay yeah look at that so now it's just
doing document. query selector all
expression field and it's given it's
given it the ID expression probably and
then it is evaluating a bunch of things
let's see let's just copy this
JavaScript and let's see if that works I
am not very confident if this is going
to work uh gp4 would definitely do do a
much better job gp4 is the newer version
of chat
GPT but
okay yeah so now we have added some
event listeners I think it we might want
to put it inside document. element ready
or something like that but let's see if
this works seven nope let's see so what
does it say the expression field is
called uh okay the input does not input
has the idid result so maybe this should
be get element by ID
result what's the expression field well
there's no expression
field H Maybe not maybe this is uh
you've added the result field okay let's
just
do let's just change that to current
value well what if we just give it the
ID result as well so looks like it is it
has two Fields one for expression one
for result maybe it got confused there
but look at
that 8 - 9 = -1 that's not bad okay
clear and backspace are not working so
let's tell it you're not handling the
clear and backspace
buttons please update the
code also there's no field with the ID
expression
we just have one result
field okay and it apologizes for the
mistake obviously and now it is going to
update things to also handle the yeah
again it probably messed things up a
little bit like it is thinking about C
and slash I guess it probably doesn't
have the full context with it anymore
but let's go ahead and fix make that
small fix uh this is still a lot faster
than coding everything from scratch of
course and yeah so here it's using this
backspace button so instead of the back
word backspace it's using just this
arrow and it's using C so maybe just
let's replace that with clear and let's
replace that with or how about we do the
other thing we we replace clear with c
and and we replace backspace with the
arrow
character like
that okay so how about that 56 and that
backspace is now working 56 589 *
23 equal 13 457 yeah 5889 * 23 that's
actually right great you could probably
also now go in and say add sign log and
a bunch of other buttons but I'm pretty
happy with this it it just generated an
entire scientific calculator with maybe
two or three messages it is uh just
insane and not only that it also we also
just copy pasted a bunch of errors that
we encountered and it's all those errors
for us so use these tools use chat GPT
use jobot uh of course verify the code
that it writes do not just depend on the
code without verification I've not had a
chance here to look through every line
of code but you should you should do
that because it may introduce some
security ver abilities or something like
that but in any case that is how you
build a scientific calculator using HTML
CSS and JavaScript I hope this was an
informative session uh a lot of things
that look fairly complex are actually
really simple to build out it's that you
don't have to build in a lot of the
complex functionality you should always
focus on building the most simple Parts
first and then you can always add in the
responsive design the animation uh the
multiple rows of data the history etc
those are all things that actually do
require a lot of additional code but the
simple functionality is generally fairly
straightforward to implement and in a
lot of cases you can get a lot of help
from from jobot from chart gbt from
whatever AI tools you're using Okay so
let's see now if we have any questions
at uh this
point okay
well I do not
see any questions can this be uploaded
on YouTube this is on YouTube it's going
to stay on YouTube so you're fine how to
create a function for the how to create
the functionality of clicking on either
FX or 123 and the buttons to Ensemble
changing
entirely yeah so see if you want to do
something more complex than what we've
done here ideally what you should be
doing is two things one uh you shouldn't
just be storing the current value in a
string what you should be doing is maybe
having an you should have an array of
tokens and you should have an array of
tokens or array of uh whole hosting the
value of button clicks and that array
could be converted into some value that
is actually displayed in the input so
that when we click the equal to button
you don't have to evaluate a particular
string but instead you can look at
element by element look you can look at
the array and you can then use some
JavaScript code to evaluate an
arithmetic expression right so yeah you
could for example let's just try this
and see what happens okay jan.com jobot
you could for example ask jobot write a
JavaScript function to
evaluate
um an expression from a scientific
calculator don't use eval okay let's see
so this takes an input and it has this
whole set of operators and you can add
more operators as well you can see here
that it has created a bunch of like a
BAS basic code for you and now it's
going to do some of this business and
you can see here that it can work with
all of these interesting operators
clearly H it could also potentially okay
square root is not yet supported but
let's say add support for S
log
cos
Etc it's going to then update that and
let's see maybe we can actually use it
in our code I don't know but uh possibly
yeah so it's basically what it's doing
is it's maintaining a stack it is
putting tokens into the stack getting
tokens out of the stack and it is also
testing whether the expression is
invalid and yeah all of this should work
if all of this works then
potentially let's see
if okay the maybe the expression may not
contain any spaces so we may have to fix
that it says let tokens equal to exp.
spit space um the
expression may not contain any spaces
what will you do
then yeah so it's going to write more
complex logic and you can keep working
with it and try and figure it out so I
encourage you to try that out with chat
GPT okay instead of eval you want to
create a different function is there a
better way yeah so one thing you could
do is you could actually attach onclick
handlers on specific buttons directly
from HTML so I want to show you right
here this is what Char GPD or jobot
tried to do you can say onclick and then
you can provide the name of a JavaScript
function that is defined in the script
file and you can call it with some value
right so you can have a function called
button clicked and button clicked Can U
be get called with this particular value
when this button gets clicked so that's
one other way to do it I am not going to
go into a lot of detail with that right
now but just know that you can also
specify onclick handlers within the HTML
itself so I hope that answers your
question
yeah looks like this is actually working
not too badly let's just try it out I'm
not sure if this is actually going to
work but let's see let's put that in
here so let's get our evaluate
expression and instead of eval let's
just do evaluate expression over
here evaluate expression I should be
taking a close look at this code but
what the hell let's see 7 * 9 equals
nope there's definitely some error here
I guess there's it's not uh that
straightforward because it's like doing
some regular expression
match yeah but now 7 * 8 works fine yeah
so you might need to just test this a
little more carefully than what we have
done here um you can one way to test
this would be maybe to put it into a
JavaScript console and then test it out
uh but this
looks this looks good I don't have have
a problem with this um with the
modification it should probably work out
just fine
okay all right I think that's everything
that we were covering today so let's
just go back and check where we started
so we wanted to build a scientific
calculator and the way we did this is
let's grab those links and put them in
here as well so that you can actually
see these so here is the finished code
I'm just going to add it right here in
this Doc it's also going to be in the
description here is the actual
scientific calculator that we built out
the finished site uh that's right
here so we created a public GitHub
repository we Ed GitHub code spaces for
development we added the bootstrap CSS
framework and of course we also later
figured out how to deploy this web page
to the cloud by creating a verel project
and you can then connect it to your own
domain as well something like scientific
calculator. a or something and it should
it should work fine too so that was the
first step prepare for development and
deployment the second step was to build
the user interface with HTML and CSS so
we added the content for each section
one by one using HTML This Is What It
ultimately looked
like this was the HTML code so we had a
bunch of uh we had like this row we had
maybe a a column inside it we had the
title we had a card we had a body inside
the card we had an input then we added
the buttons row by row so uh we could we
could also have used the browser inspect
tab on Google to inspect it but we
didn't need to do that uh we didn't
really get into a lot of progressive
enhancement for tablet and desktop but
we did make it a mobile friendly or
mobile first design and we've not tried
to design replicate the design very
closely but we did our best effort given
the time we had then we did add a script
file later in the in the process but we
started out Simply with a a simple
script uh tag of the file was added
later f variables and functions to track
the current we were just tracking the
current expression we didn't really
track the previous expression uh we
added functions to implement the logic
for each button Well turns out we could
just use eval and we did not actually
have to implement the logic separately
for each button and then on click
handlers those we just added it in a
loop so we took a bunch of shortcuts
here which is fine for something like
this where there is no sensitive
information for us to worry about we
just used eval but otherwise you might
want to use an evaluate
expression kind of formula or an
evaluate expression function again could
be generated with help from jobard you
could also give it some example inputs
saying these are some example inputs you
have to handle and giving the keeping
those example inputs in mind it's going
to then generate a function so remember
that it's not always going to be able to
read your mind and know exactly what you
need so you need to give it some input
you need to give it some examples and in
a lot of cases you can also give it uh
if it does not give you exactly what you
want you can then ask it another
question follow up with it it and it can
give you the right answer and you can
also just copy paste your error and
it'll fix things for you okay um and of
course you should very carefully look at
all the code that is generated by AI
definitely don't just copy paste the
code into your projects okay test the
page carefully at different screen sizes
Ure that HTML CSS JavaScript is well
organized yeah it looks fairly well
organized to me I could add a few
comments here in there maybe I could add
a few comments here so I could always
just go in here and I could would say to
jobot add some comments to the following
JavaScript
code and it can add a bunch of comments
for
me yeah it is now explaining the code
but I want to I want to add some
comments inside the code and I can
always tell it that uh yeah please
add comments inside the code
okay so it may not understand it may not
exactly understand what you want it to
do but just talk to it just don't give
up immediately and now it is rewriting
the code for us with a bunch of comments
how nice is that all right and one thing
you can also do is you can just use
jobot to get explanations on code so you
can always just go on jan.com jobot and
simply go on code explainer and paste
whatever piece of code you have enter
the programming language and it's going
to explain that code to you but let me
just for now now let me just take this
code put that in here and see if it
still works I think it should I don't
see any reason why it shouldn't
generally doesn't mess this up too much
let's see 8 88 - 3 = 85 yep Ln or let's
do AC
Ln 8 that should be about okay Ln seems
to have
failed yeah for I I'll investigate that
later but yeah you can definitely use it
to document your code as well just
verify that it has not modified any of
your existing code okay so that we did
then we staged commit and pushed our
changes all in a few clicks on vs code
didn't have to write any get commands
and then we verified that our site is
deployed to verel we tested it
out and it's working
fine again maybe there might be
something I might need to fix yeah
there's something wrong with my Ln
function cannot read properties of
undefined log 10 yeah I guess it's
probably math log 10 there's something
wrong with
that in
JavaScript math.log
10 H okay I don't know what's
um what's going on here but we'll fix it
we'll find it and we'll fix it no
problem so with that we've reached the
end of this tutorial I hope you enjoyed
it do leave a like on the video and of
course please do subscribe we we're
going to do more of these
tutorials and if you have any questions
please post a comment we will try and
reply to all the comments uh
specifically if you have technical
doubts or you could also just go on
jan.com jobot and ask your question
there and continue building on this try
to see how close you can get to the
Google scientific calculator the closer
you get try to implement this toggle for
radians and degrees see exactly what it
does um and and try to maybe also add
this button which is going to toggle a
few things again the hint here is maybe
use some JavaScript to trigger the maybe
have like one div of buttons and another
div of buttons below it and have a
JavaScript variable which tracks which
mode you are in and based on the change
to the variable also change the display
property of the divs so that's kind of
the hint that I'm going to give you here
but I'll leave it at that so thank you
for joining and have a good day or good
night take care now the express web
application framework is a minimalist
web framework for nodejs streamlining
serers side application development with
flexible routing middleware and a
vibrant ecosystem of libraries so we'll
talk more about all of these aspects
don't worry if these don't make sense
right now now you might think that a
server is a piece of software and that
is partly true server is some uh is a
piece of hardware and uh you might think
that a server is a piece of hardware and
that is partly true these are racks of
servers in a data center but the server
that we going to talk about today is a
piece of software that serves
requests now uh here's what we're going
to cover in today's tutorial we'll talk
about creating and running a web server
using the express web framework we will
talk about serving HTML Pages static
files and dynamic data using templates
we will talk about using route
parameters to create and serve Dynamic
Pages we will talk about accepting form
submissions and sending emails from a
server so there's a lot of ground we're
going to cover today and in some sense
we are stepping into the full stack
domain here in some sense we are
covering the backend side of things now
that we've learned basic web development
so let's move forward now of course the
best way to learn these skills is to
follow along step by step and type out
all the code yourself so make sure to do
that to get a proper understanding and
we will explore these Topics by
attempting to solve this problem
statement so the last time we created a
jovian careers website powered by
bootstrap and this is what it looks like
it has a navigation bar it has a bunch
of links here in the navigation bar and
a sign-in button it has this work at
Jovian section with some text and an
image and it has this job opportunities
table a list of job opportunities and an
application form and it has a footer
here at the bottom okay so we built all
of this using
bootstrap and you might also
remember you might ALS also remember
that uh we had made this responsive so
you can see here that there's an image
here at the top there is some text and
on the mobile view we have cards instead
of um instead of a table and we have the
same application form except that it is
now adjusted to show up properly on
mobile and it scales properly as we grow
from Mobile to tablet where we switch
into the job opportunities table from
the job opportunities card list and then
we also take up more space on the screen
okay now uh we are going to do a couple
of things this time the first thing is
that we should we want to make the main
page only show a list or a table of job
openings we do not want to have the
application form on the same page uh
it's probably a better idea if clicking
on a particular job role opens a job
Details page with an application form
and submitting that application form can
then potentially trigger an email to us
and also show an acknowledgement for
acknowledgement page to the user so now
we going to build a server which is
going to accept these form responses and
send out an email so let's get into it
now of course we assume here that you
have knowledge of HTML and CSS Basics
and a responsive design with bootstrap
and you are familiar with Version
Control with GitHub and Cloud deployment
with verel okay if you haven't please
make sure to review the previous lessons
uh before we move forward and you can
find all the source code and the result
for the starter site and the Finish site
over here in the notes so we'll start by
creating a GitHub repository so I'm just
going to go over to github.com and if
you're not signed in make sure to sign
in and I'm going to click new and I am
going to create a repository and let me
just call this Jovian careers express
live because we're building this live
and this is simply a jovian career
site powered by
expressjs all right and this is going to
be a public repository I am going to
initialize it with a readme file I'm
going to select the git ignore template
nodejs because we're going to actually
write some nodejs code this time and I'm
going to give it the MIT license and
let's create this
repository so with that the repository
is now created and now we need a now we
need a way to run this repository and of
course you can download this repository
onto your computer and run it but we are
going to run it using Code spaces and I
just select the code option here and
select code spaces and click create
codespace on Main and what this does is
GitHub sets up a machine for us on the
cloud where it pulls the contents of
this repository and opens up a visual
studio code interface for us to interact
with the repository which is to write
code and run the code test things and
then we can push these changes back to
the GitHub repository okay so that is a
GitHub workflow that we have been
following for the past few
lessons all right let's give that a
second to uh start
properly
now um let us uh so here's what you do
to uh start developing on GitHub Cod
spaces and now let us start building our
web server now web servers are software
applications that handle incoming
requests from a client and that client
could be a web browser or that client
could be a mobile application or that
client could be a Discord bot slackbot
anything any form of a client any
anything that requests or needs some
information makes a request to a web
server and then the web server processes
that request and for processing the
request it may then contact a database
it may contact another external service
it may do some uh data processing and
then it returns that response back to
the client all right so there is a
request sent from the client some
processing happens from the server and
the response is sent back to the client
so that's basically what a web server is
software applications that handle
incoming request from web clients and
it's a it runs on a computer essentially
so web server is running on some
computer on the cloud and is handling
incoming requests and it responds to
these requests by sending back the
requested content and that could be web
pages images videos data Etc and to
communicate with the web server
typically you use an
HTTP um protocol which is where you
often see if you just check the URL of
any page it says https or HTTP and that
basically means that you using the HTTP
your browser is using the HTTP protocol
to commun Comm unicate with the web
server and web servers can be configured
to handle different types of content for
example HTML CSS JavaScript PHP python
all it just depends on what kind of uh
software you want to run on your Cloud
computer which is powering the web
server and web servers can obviously be
used to host web applications for
example Jupiter what we are using here
is running on a web server Jovian itself
runs on a web server Google Instagram
Facebook everything runs on a web server
now the difference between websites that
we've been building today St the
difference between websites that we've
been building so far called statch
websites and web servers is that web
servers can deliver Dynamic content from
a database or a rest API whereas static
sites like index.html the web pages that
we were building cannot deliver Dynamic
content so today we'll talk about how we
can deliver Dynamic content using the
express web application
framework so let's get uh started with
Express um so here's what you need to do
to set up a simple hello world project
using Express GS step one is to
initialize a nodejs project inside a
project directory so we are here in this
GitHub uh project GitHub repository that
is open on codespace and I guess we can
just go ahead and use this as our
project directory so I'm going to
initialize a new nodejs project here and
to do that I'm just first going to zoom
in a little bit all right so let's zoom
in here and I am going to start by
typing npm init minus y so let's type
npm init minus
y and
now the you will see here that a project
has been initialized and what that
really means is a package.json file has
been created so you can check here in
the sidebar there is a package.json file
which contains the name of the project
which is auto inferred from the name of
the directory it contains a version and
a description again both of these are
Auto inferred version is set to 1.0 and
description is auto inferred from the
readme and then we have a then we have a
main file so this is not something that
has been created yet and this is
something that we can potentially change
when we want to in fact we can even
remove it if you want then we have some
scripts here some keywords some author
some license these are not important
right now these are more important when
you are publishing a module to uh the
npm registry but for us the key things
here are um these and these are some
things that we will modify over time all
right so now that we've initialized the
nodejs project the next step is to
install the expressjs web framework and
we're going to install the expressjs web
framework by simply running npm install
Express so I'm going to come in here and
once again let me reset things here and
I'm going to
say and I'm going to say npm install
Express now when we click npm when we
type npm install Express you can see
that a node modules folder is created
here and inside these node modules
folder Express and all of its transitive
dependencies get in installed so you can
see here that you have uh you have
Express here of course this is the
Express framework then there is also a
bunch of other Frameworks that have been
installed now I do want to mention that
the node modules folder will not get
added to your GitHub repository when you
push these changes back to GitHub
because if you check the git ignore file
you'll see that node modules is
mentioned here uh so basically we don't
want to uh send all of these dependency
files all their JavaScript code to our
GitHub repository because that's going
to make our GitHub repository really
heavy uh so instead what we do is we
simply add that dependency in
package.json and that happens when you
run npm install so you can see that
package.json contains the name of the
dependency that you need to install and
the version of the dependency and
whenever you need whenever somebody
someone else need to run your code they
can simply get the bare minimum code and
then they can run npm install and they
can install all the dependencies on
their computer and the same can happen
when you're trying to deploy this
application to the cloud all right so
keep that in mind that we don't commit
the node node modules server the node
modules folder to our GitHub repository
because it is ignored in the git ignore
okay now you will also see this package
log. Json file basically what this
contains is all the dependencies that
node modules uh that expressjs depends
on those are listed here and their
versions are listed here so this is to
ensure that some of the transitive
dependencies don't go out of date and
cause problems later so this is to lock
the version verions of all the
dependencies that you've installed and
and their dependencies and their
dependencies and so on okay now don't
worry if all of that doesn't make sense
the only key thing you should keep in
mind is when you say npm install and
type the name of a package that is going
to get added into the package.json file
and that can then be used to reinstall
that package on any other computer okay
now next we are going to create a folder
called SRC and we are going to put all
our application code inside that all our
HTML CSS Javas script Etc and inside the
SRC folder we're going to create a new
file app.js and inside it we're going to
add some content so let's create a
folder SRC so I've just created a folder
SRC and now let's create a file
app.js and now in the app.js file I'm
going to say uh let me copy of the first
two lines so I'm going to say Express
equals require Express this is how we uh
pull in the express dependency so this
is how we get access to the express
Library by saying require Express and
then I can create an app an express
application a web application simply by
calling the express function okay and
just like that an app has been created a
web server has been created but we're
going to do a couple more things as well
now the first thing we're going to do is
set a basic um set a basic route okay so
let me just paste this over and then
we'll talk about it here so what we're
saying is app.get so we're saying that
when the app gets a request and when it
gets a request on slash which means when
it gets a request on the basic route
right by the basic route we mean it's
simply let's say this application was
deployed on jan.com then when you try to
access jan.com that is treated as the
slash or the root level route but let's
say if you try to access jan.com aashan
that would be treated as the SL aashan
route okay so if you just try to access
the server raw without any sub path to
the URL then that is going to get sent
to this particular route so whenever
you're add whenever you're attaching a
route Handler to whenever you're
attaching a route for an express
application you need to specify a route
Handler which is basically just a
function that is given the request that
has been sent from the client and that
is given a response object and it can
then use the response object to send the
data back to the client okay so the
request object is used to get data from
the client the data that the client has
sent in its request the response object
is used to send data back to the client
all right so you will see this pattern
very commonly in all JavaScript web
Frameworks you'll attach a route and the
method could be get post Etc we'll talk
about that but you'll attach a route and
to the application and for that route
you will specify a route handling
function
okay finally we actually need to run the
server and the way you run the server is
by calling app. listen so once you've
created an express application you can
say app. listen and basically what this
is saying is now the app will start
listening for requests now to start
listening for requests it needs to
specify a port there are many
applications that can run on the same
computer on the same Hardware so the
different applications or different
servers can occupy different ports they
can listen at different ports all right
so that's where so think of it as
mailboxes within a building so you
specify your mailbox number or your port
number so let's see app. listen port and
the port is currently just being set to
three ,000 but what we also often do is
sometimes while running the application
a an external Port is specified so when
an external Port is specified while
running the application that is going to
be configured in what's called an
environment variable process. env. Port
but we uh if that is not specified we
just pick the default value of 3,000
okay so for now again don't worry about
this line basically what it says is use
the port 3000 if no other Port has been
specified while running the application
okay all right so this app is going to
start listening on this port 3000 when
we run the project and it is also going
to just print something out to the to
the console saying that the server is
running on such and such URL
okay so with that we have set up our
very basic web application that is going
to take a request and simply return
hello world now uh the last thing we
need to do is we actually need to
configure
a command to run this server so one way
we could run the server is just go and
say node SRC app.js okay that's one way
to do it we just go into the terminal
and type node SRC
app.js but the preferred way to run or
configure applications in general is to
specify the script that is used to run
the server in the package.json file so
in package.json you will you will have
this scripts object and in this scripts
object it is common to just add a start
key and in that start key specify what
command should be executed to start this
application okay and the command of
course that we want to execute is node
SRC app.js okay so now that we have done
that now that we've started now that you
have specified a start script in
package.json we can say npm Run start
okay and when we say npm Run start that
is going to do the exact same thing as
node SRC app.js why are we doing npm Run
start well it's just good convention any
nodejs applications that you create it's
a good convention to specify the start
script so that somebody else who's
running the application can does not
have to guess what the start script is
uh going to be okay so let's just run
npm run
start and with that the server is
running so now the server is running on
the visual studio code uh the server is
running on the GitHub codes space
machine that is somewhere in the cloud
and to access that machine we can just
click this open and browser button that
shows up what it does is that is it
takes our request from our browser and
forwards it to the port number 3 3,000
of the GitHub Cod spaces machine okay
and you can already see here we now have
on this port we are simply printing
hello world and you can see now that if
I just change this to hello
Jovian and I kill the server and I
restart the server and I reload this
page you can see say hello Jovian so
just like that we have set up our first
basic server so here's what's happening
when we type the URL into the browser
that URL sends a request to the server
and see this URL this is basically just
like a simple URL like a simple
something. something.com or dodev slash
and there's nothing after it and that is
why that is going to match with this
particular route Handler and this
particular route Handler simply says
hello Jin now suppose I had said in here
SL Akash so if I had something at the
end of the URL SL something you can see
that it says cannot get slashes it only
knows how to get slash and we'll see how
to add more of these routes to our
servers shortly as well
okay so now we've set up our Dev server
and one thing I want to mention is
instead of running npm Run start because
start is such a special common command
you can also just say npm start instead
of npm Run start and both do the same
thing and with that we have set up a web
server that shows hello world
okay now the next step would be to serve
an HTML file now of course we don't just
want to return hello world from our
server we want to actually return some
nice HTML so here's what we'll do we
will create a folder Pages inside the
SRC folder so I'm going to say SRC I am
going to create a new folder
Pages all right and now inside Pages I'm
going to create a file
index.html so now we have an index.html
file all right and into this index.html
file I'm going to put in some content so
I'm just I've just taken some of the
content from the from the website that
we had created the last time the Jian
careers website and I have included it
here on this link so I'm just going to
copy paste it because we don't want to
just uh sit and reimplement the entire
page that we had created the last time
already okay so now we have put in
inside SRC we put in a folder pages and
inside Pages we put in the file
index.html however this browser has no
way to actually access that index.html
file this browser can only make a
request to the server and the server is
only listening on the route slash and on
that slash route it is simply returning
hello Jovian it is simply sending hello
Jovian so instead of sending hello
Jovian we need to send the contents of
the index.html file all right how do we
do that well here is what we can do so
we can first include this new utility
function called path so we say path
equals require require path and this is
path is simply a utility to construct
full file system paths based on based on
relative paths next let us change this
one line of
code so instead of saying rest. send
file instead of saying rest. send hello
Jovian so let me comment that out I'm
going to say rest. send file path. jooin
name Dame is basically just the name of
the current directory which is/ SRC
soore uncore Dame is a existing variable
in nodejs that automatically gets the
name of the current directory so we want
to take the name of the current
directory and to it we want to join
Pages index.html all right so we want to
get current directory which is the SRC
folder SL pages index.html and we want
to send that file in the response all
right that's all we are doing here so
let us hit save again and let us reload
the page nothing happens because we have
to restart the server so remember this
Express what it does is when you start
the server it reads the entire
Javascript file and then if you make
changes you have to restart the server
so let's see control let's typ control C
control C is used to kill the server or
stop the server and then uh so you just
go into the terminal press control C and
then type npm Run start or npm start
again and now if we reload the page you
can see now that it actually shows us
the job applications page that we had
created earlier so it has a header it
has this work at Jovian over here and it
has this footer over here as well all
right we've not added the jobs table and
we've not added the application form yet
we've just added these parts and you can
of course you can study the code inside
index.html to make sure that's exactly
what we have so yeah we have a head and
inside the head we have a title we have
some meta tags looks like we have some
link tags Joan favicon.png we have some
um we have bootstrap we have some fonts
and looks like we have a stylesheet
styles.css so we might need to add a few
more files but then we have a nav bar
over here and that is what is uh showing
this nav bar then below the nav bar we
have this about Jovian section over here
all right and then below the about
Jovian section we have a footer over
here and that's basically what we are
showing on the page all right so with
that we have just returned some HTML
from the server now one very important
piece of information I want to point out
to you to you here is to understand what
is visible on the server and what is
visible on the client now all of this
code that we are seeing here it is
Javascript code but this JavaScript code
is not running in your browser this
JavaScript code is running on the server
so your browser simply makes a request
your browser simply sends a request to
the server all the JavaScript code
inside app.js is executed on the server
it picks up the index. h HL file and it
sends it back to the browser and now
it's in the browser that the index.html
file is passed and displayed as a web
page okay now what you might also have
is that you might also send a Javascript
file to the to the browser and then that
Javascript file can get executed on the
browser on the browser as well okay but
that's different from the app.js file
the app.js file only runs on the server
and I'm stressing this again because
this is a common source of vulnerability
right so understand that only the result
of the execution which is hello world or
the HTML file is sent to the browser
this should say
browser uh is sent to the browser and
the rest of the code remains on the
server so understanding which part of
your project code is executed on the
server and which part of your project
code is executed on the browser is very
important to avoid any security
vulnerabilities you do not accidentally
want to send some database credentials
to the browser because then your user
will be able to see your database
credentials and they'll be able to
access your entire database rather you
want to keep them on the server and just
send the response that the user needs to
them okay so with that we have figured
out how to display a HTML file so that's
great now uh the next step is to maybe
make our workflow a little easier every
time we make a change to the index. HTML
file we have to manually restart the
server and each time uh that requires us
to go in press contrl C and then restart
the server there's a better way to do
this there is this helper Library called
nodemon uh which stands for node monitor
so I'm just going to say npm install
nodemon so that's going to install the
node Monon package for us and you can
see here that it gets added here to
nodemon all right and now I'm going to
add
another script here called Dev so now in
my package or I already have the npm
start script which is going to be used
when I'm Happ with all the code I don't
feel a need to change the code too many
times but uh I also want to use another
script during development and here I'm
just going to say nodemon SRC app.js so
the only change we've made between start
and Dev is that start has node SRC
app.js and dev has nodon SRC app.js what
this is going to do is every time the
every time there is a change made to any
file in the project it is going to
restart the server automatically so that
we don't have to in and restart the
server manually okay so let's now run
npm run Dev instead of npm Run start I'm
just going to run npm run Dev and now
you can see that if I go in here and I
change the title of this page for
example so the title of this page is Jan
careers powered by bootstrap and let me
just change it to Jovan careers powered
by Express you can see that the server
will restart
automatically well looks like it did not
so that's where you also have to
configure what causes the server to
restart so we say noon. Json noon. Json
that's a new file we put into the root
folder of the project and then we
say um
EXT and then we give it the list of
extensions for which nodon should
monitor right so let's see nodemon
extensions let's just search that
format yeah so you can specify it this
way you can say um EXT and then you
provide a list of extensions so I'm just
going to provide a list of extensions
here I'm going to say that anytime a JS
file or JavaScript file changes restart
the server anytime an HTML file changes
restart the server anytime a Styles or a
CSS file file changes restart the server
anytime a PNG or a JPG file changes
restart the server so any time any of
these files change I want to restart the
server and let me just restart nodon
itself once
again let's
see
okay I think I might have messed
something up
here ah I believe it's just uh you do
not need it to be an
array yeah you just need it like that
okay so you provide a list of extensions
as a comma separated string and let's
now run npm run Dev once again and now
you will notice that anytime we change
any HTML file CSS file Javascript file
it's going to restart the server okay so
I'm just going to say powered by Express
here and I'll just reload the page and
now you see here it says powered by
Express all right so that is the benefit
of using nodemon it's going to
automatically restart the server but you
still do have to go to the browser and
re reload the page all right um so now
we've set up not nodon and we are using
npm run Dev for development and when we
want to do a final testing or deployment
then we can just use npm start okay now
the next thing I want to point out is
that index.html contains references to
files like styles.css Jovian meta PNG
and Jovian fave icon.png but so far we
have not added any of these so you see
we referring to styles.css but there's
no styles.css file here and more
importantly there will there is no
styles. CSS file here so all of these
things are executed on the browser all
the HTML is run on the browser and when
the browser when the browser tries to
get styles.css it's going to run into an
error so we need to find a way to pass
all of these files styles. CSS and PNG
and all of these directly as is without
any changes to our um browser and that
is where we are going to create a folder
called Static okay so we are going to
create a folder called let me just
rename it public
actually
yeah let's create a folder called public
so
SRC
public and into this I'm going to uh put
in all the files that are going to be
sent as is without any change to the
browser okay and inside the public
folder let me put for example styles.css
and into the styles.css let me put in
some
content all right okay I've put in some
content into styles. CSS looks like I
have one more piece here
yeah so all we're doing in this
styles.css is maybe configuring the
default font body font and config
configuring the default blue color and
the primary U color on bootstrap so
these are all CSS variables we're
configuring and then we are also
configuring the font family for the
headings so we're using the inter font
family which we have included within our
index.html page from Google fonts and we
are also configuring that the a tags or
the link tag should not have any
underlines so text decoration under line
is the default we are setting it to text
decoration none okay so that's a styles.
CSS file next I have a couple of these
files I have this file Jovian fav
icon.png and Jovian meta PNG on my
computer I'm going to drag them in here
and put them both into this public
folder as well and you can download
these files from these URLs so just go
into this URL and right click and save
it as Jovian favicon.png and Jovian meta
PNG so this is what the Jovian
favicon.png looks like it is going to be
used to configure the fav icon or the
icon in the browser and this is what the
Jovian meta image looks like this is
simply going to show up when we share
that link with somebody else on on
social media Etc okay so um all right so
now we've added these files styles.css
index.html uh styles.css Jovian 51
Jovian meta but nothing seems to have
changed even if I try to access SL
styles.css I still cannot get it so it's
still says cannot get styles.css so what
do we do well you actually have to
inform Express that there is a certain
folder on your in your project from
where you want to directly send all the
files to the browser you don't want to
make any changes to them okay so how do
we do that the way to do that is by just
adding this one line within Express so
we say app.use after creating the app we
say
app.use and app.use is a very common
pattern in Express where any new feature
you want to add any what's called
middleware in express any new features
you want to add you just add them using
app.use and here in app.use we're going
to use uh we're going to set up a static
folder using express. static and we need
to give it the exact directory name so
all the full or the full path of the
directory where this um all these static
files are located okay so I'm going to
say path. joinor Ford name which is
simply getting the name of the current
directory
SLU so what we're seeing here is take
everything that is there in this folder
called public and send it to the browser
as is when requested okay and now it
says the app
crashed okay I put in an extra
underscore so yeah now the app should
have restarted y so now the app is
restarted and now if I reload the page
watch closely you will notice the fonts
change there you go you see the fonts
just changed and you can actually see
here if I open SL styles.css you can see
that now we have this Styles file that
is served and if I open
slash Jovian _ FV icon.png you can see
now the fav icon is getting rendered if
I open
Jovian cora. PNG you can see that our
Meta Meta image is getting rendered as
well okay and all of these are linked
from index. HTML as well well so that
will show up properly too you can see
here it shows the nice icon here in the
browser tab so that's one other thing I
want you to take away anything that you
want to directly send out to the uh to
the browser then you simply create a
folder and put all of those files into a
folder and you uh simply configure a
static folder within app. use okay now
we didn't do this for index.html because
we're going to make some changes to
index.html show some Dynamic data on
that page that is why we want to process
it before we send it that is why we
didn't put it in the public or static
folder
okay all right so just keep that in mind
static files are served as is by the
server and it is generally used for
stylesheets scripts images icons that
you just want to pass on to the browser
directly and you can check out this
resource to learn more about static file
serving now one last thing we can do is
to Simply push our changes back to
GitHub and then deploy it to verell so
I'm just going to come in here into the
git
tab of the sidebar and I'm just going to
say
added basic uh well added Express
app index.html and static files I'm
going to click commit and that is going
to Simply stage and commit all the
changes and I'm going to sync this back
to GitHub so stage commit and sync
three-step process and once this is done
we can go in here and you can just
reload this page and you can see here
that we have this SRC folder we have
this package.json you can see
package.json has the dependencies
express and nodemon and there's no node
modules folder because it is ignored in
the git ignore and the SRC folder has a
Pages folder where it has index. HTML of
course it has app and it has this
styles. CSS Etc as well okay now let's
deploy this so I'm just going to go to
wor.com and worell is the platform we
typically use for deployment because
it's really easy to use that's what
jan.com is replied on as well and I'm
going to select add new project here and
if you haven't connected your GitHub
account you can connect it here if you
can if you haven't connected all the
repositories you can configure your
GitHub setting here as well but in this
case we're simply going to go into the
Sydney Jovian account and import Jovian
careers express live and when we import
it we can select the framework preset
okay now uh there's no framework preset
here and because this is just Express
there's no framework as such it's just a
in fact versel does not have inbuilt
support for Express but the root
directory is just the directory which
contains the package.json file and we
can click
deploy now hopefully what this should do
is it should look into the package.json
file and it should deploy and let's see
if that
happens okay so looks like the
deployment is complete but if we try to
access it it says 404 not found and this
is because verel needs things to be
configured in a certain way versal needs
to be told what is the root file that we
need to access versal needs to be told
what are uh the different ways in which
different routes need to be handled so
there is one special piece of code that
you need to add when you're deploying an
express application to worel okay and
again this is not something that you
know by default this is just something
that you would normally Google and
figure out but you need to add a file
called verel Json that informs verel a
few things one it tells verel that s rc/
app.js is the key is the main file that
it needs to build the for for which it
needs to install all the dependencies
ETC and you also need to tell it that it
needs to use the nodejs environment so
what supports a bunch of different
runtime environments and we just
informing here that we want the nodejs
environment and finally so this points
to the main file of the server this
points to the uh the use points to the
environment all of this goes into builds
and finally you also need to configure
we want what we want to do is all the
routes
and no matter what route we try to
access we want them all to be sent to
app.js and we want app.js to handle the
routing and not verel itself so that is
again something that is configured and
again don't worry if this seems
confusing whenever you are deploying an
expressjs application to verel you
simply copy paste this um or find it
online Okay so let's go back here and
let me go in here and create a worel
Json
file so new file verel do Json and in
this file I'm just going to put in this
code version two builds routes um just
standard code for configuring versal to
run with Express and I'm just going to
say add worel do Json and let me click
commit and sync it and that should now
get sent up to the
server and now let us go back into our
versal dashboard let's go back into
Jovan careers express live and delete
this project and and just create a new
one with the worsal Json file so
sometimes what happens is if you change
the worel Json file you may have to just
uh recreate the project so I'm just
going to delete this project and you can
delete the project from the project
settings and let's check the worel do
Json file so the worel do Json file
looks fine to me and now let's come back
into verel and create a new project so
now once again I'm going into new
project I'm set i'm selecting the Jovian
careers express live project which has
the ver. Json file already uh no
framework preset and the root directory
is just the do slash which is the root
of the entire directory because that's
where the package.json and other files
are present and I'm just going to click
deploy okay and hopefully this time it
should pick up the settings from the
ver. Json file yeah looks like you have
a versal Json file so it's going to pick
up the settings properly and let's see
if it's going to do that deployment this
time and it does perfect so our
application or our web web server is now
deployed to verel and it is now scalable
so our Cod space machine can shut down
anytime and it cannot scale but verel
will automatically scale things
depending on the traffic and it will
automatically redeploy whenever you push
to the main branch so that's it so now
we have a basic deployment ready as well
and now we ready to start maybe
rendering some data dynamically into
that page maybe let's see if we have any
questions at this point already okay the
there's a comment here server is a
special computer to deal with traffic
that's right yep that's a good way to
look at it what's the difference between
using static. apppp and using Express so
in static. apppp all it does is it takes
the files that you have and it gives
them to the browser when requested in
Express we can write some custom Logic
for example uh fetching data from a
database sending an email handling form
submissions and all of that okay so I
hope that answers that what is the
difference between flask and express
well flask is a python web framework
Express is a JavaScript web framework
they do the same thing they are both the
smallest possible Frameworks essentially
in each of those languages um but that's
basically it what are Dynamic contents
so anything any data that is for example
fetched from a database for example if
you go to my Jovian profile each time
you open it you'll see something
different because I may have worked on
New notebooks in the meantime now
obviously I'm not creating an index.html
file and putting it up each time I
create a new notebook this data is going
to be fetched from the browser from a
database and that HTML file is going to
be created on the fly when you try to
request it okay what was minus y doing
here so when I said npm init minus y I
will let you search that online all it
does is well it makes our work a little
easier otherwise npm minute is going to
ask you for the package name etc
etc okay what is a route well a route is
simply a path on the page so for example
if you
have um for example if you have jan.com
aashan that's a route right so SL aashan
is so join.com here is the domain and SL
aashan is the path or the route which is
where within this server do you want to
go or SL Akash notebooks which is what
you see here that is another route or SL
Akash or SL Sydney Express web
application that is another route or SL
learn SL courses that is another route
or SL learn SL full stack developer boot
cam that's another so these are all the
sub paaths that you can have present in
your application and uh we've just
looked at the root route which is where
there is no subpath which is just
jan.com or wherever or in this case it
is deployed at Jovian
careers yeah in this case it is deployed
at Jovian careers live. W.A so that is
what we've looked at so far but we look
at some sub routes as well uh
shortly okay what is a port well as I
gave the mailbox analogy let's say in a
building you have a bunch of people
living and every everyone needs to get
their mail delivered so that's where
there's a mailbox and the mail for each
person comes into the respective mailbox
in the same way when an application is
running when a server is starting on a
particular computer and there are many
servers all the time running on your
computer internal processes that you may
not be familiar with each of them can
can put their claim on a port and all
the requests messages sent to that Port
are going to get delivered to that
server so that is something the
operating system provides if we deploy
to the cloud do we have a different port
and how does it work yeah so when we
deploy to the cloud what happens is
worel or whichever Cloud framework we
are using it
automatically puts in a variable called
Port process. env. Port so it
automatically supplies a port number and
ideally your application should have the
ability to read that port number from
the environment variable that is being
provided by the cloud infrastructure
platform so that it can run on that Port
okay okay where can we read these good
conventions any resource well these are
all just things that you will almost
always end up doing so what we're doing
right now is just the only way to do it
uh you just have to go through the
process of building an application and
you kind of learn all these conventions
along the way it's hard to go wrong you
can just search these online how do I do
this or
that okay why do we do it this way why
do we have a request why do we have a
client and a server so the client let's
say you have an application like Jovian
which has the data of 300,000 users now
when we have the data of 300,000 users
and you you open join.com on your
computer I don't want you to be able to
access the data of access the private
data of all 300,000 users that is why
your in your browser I simply give your
browser the ability to contact my server
and then when the when your browser
sends a request to my server I have a
way to validate okay this came from this
particular user and then I can ensure on
my server that I can contact the
database and only return the data that
is um that makes sense for you okay but
if I simply open up my entire database
then anybody would be able to access
anything and that's why we put a server
in between to do
this okay what is durame well uh as I
mentioned underscore uncore Dame is
going to simp when you use it within a
particular JavaScript or nodejs file it
is simply going to get the uh directory
which contains that file and we have
just used it to get the full path for
the pages index.html and for the public
directory what is colon root pointing to
yeah so in our styles.css this is
something we covered the last time in
our styles. CSS file colon root simply
is a way to define some Global CSS
variables all right and it's it's Global
not just within this file but across all
files so because we want to override
some CSS variables that have been
defined in bootstrap that is why col rot
is going to take whatever Global CSS
variable is there and it's going going
to rewrite the variable with this name
with this value okay so this is how you
overwrite the CSS
variable if we are creating a web server
using Express then what are Apache web
server or enginex or Tomcat okay I will
not get into those right now I will
encourage you to ask chat GPT or jobot
this
question uh is there an app. delete app.
put yes so we'll talk about HTTP methods
so you have all of these app.get is just
the simplest way where you simply get
it's just one of the HTTP methods that
is used why is there no Express
framework preset inv versal yeah it for
some reason they don't have it I'm I
guess they should they should probably
have added it at some point but they
decided not
to okay please add the questions in the
chat as well when recordings are posted
okay we'll try to do that are all these
routes basically different folders in
the server in the source code okay not
exactly so conceptually yes as a browser
or as a user I can think of folders I
can think of them as folders on the
server however if let's say we have
zin.com Akash join.com sidhant shin.com
somebody else if we create ended up
creating folders on our server for every
single person then we would end up with
a lot of folders and we would run out of
server space what we do instead is we
put all the data in a database which is
optimized for storing large amounts of
data and then our routes are configured
in such a way that given whatever route
we get they can figure out how to fetch
the right data from the server and we're
going to take a look at that
shortly okay next question difference
between HTTP and https so HTTP traffic
is not encrypted which means if somebody
is uh can track the packets going uh
going through your network so basically
somebody who can kind of listen into
your Wi-Fi router or maybe even your
Wi-Fi router company or maybe your
internet service provider everybody can
see exactly what you're sending the full
contents the the email that you're
sending or the password that you're
sending whatever whatever it is but
https means that the client and the
server they have initially done some
kind of an encryption handshake and the
client encrypts the data sends it to the
server and when the send server sends
back the response it encrypts to the
data sends it to the client in the
client being the browser in between your
internet service provider or somebody
just listening into your Wi-Fi will not
be able to see what's going on and now
most websites just work on https so
moving right ahead let us now
send some Dynamic data and add it into
the index.html page now of course we are
not going to talk about databases just
yet but we're going to simulate
databases in a certain way essentially
um so here's what we're going to do
we're going to create a file called
jobs. JS so I'm going to create a file
here called jobs.
JS okay and in this jobs. JS file I'm
going to put in some data let me take in
all this data over here
and this is simply a list of jobs so
cons jobs equals uh this is our first
job object which has an id1 title
front-end developer location bangaluru
salary 12 lakhs um posted on March 3rd
2023 similarly there's a second job
third job so we've taken a Json array an
array of Json objects and put that into
this variable called jobs and uh we are
going to just export this as the default
export from this module okay so jobs. JS
is this into which we have put in a
bunch of jobs now um we can actually
import these jobs here so we can say
const
jobs equals
require do/
jobs okay and I can also just
console.log
jobs and you can see that when we import
this from require do/ jobs we get all of
this data here and we can now use it in
our server and we can even send it to
the browser however we want okay now of
course right now we are getting this
from a file but in a real world scenario
you would be getting this from a
database which is something that we'll
look at in a future course okay the next
thing is to actually put these jobs into
the index.html file so now what we're
going to do is turn this index. HML file
into a template and we're going to turn
it into a template us using a template
rendering system called mustache and
I'll talk about what mustache is in just
a second but here's what we need to do
the first thing we need to do is install
this mustache Express package so I'm
just going to go in into the
terminal and I'm just going to stop this
server for now and I'm just going to say
npm install mustache Express okay so
mustache is the
templating uh the the template engine
that we are going to use and mustache
Express is the connector that that
allows you to connect mustache to allow
Express to mustache okay so that was
step one the next thing we need to do is
to convert our index.html file which is
an HTML file into an index. mustache
file or a mustache template okay and
here's what what we're going to do so
I'm just going to go into my index.html
file
and I'm simply going to rename this file
so I'm just going to rename this file
to index
do
mustache
okay all right so far so good we've not
really changed anything we've just
installed a package renamed a file what
difference does that make now um we'll
add some of this later now I'm going to
come into my app file my app server and
I'm going to incorporate the mustache
template rendering engine into my
Express server so first thing I'm going
to do is go into
app.js and just require mustache Express
and get this mustache Express
object okay so now I have this mustache
Express object over here and in this
object uh this object now contains the
mustach template rendering engine now I
need to add it into my app Express app
and the way we add it is like this so
first we have to
set a bunch of views within our
application so what we say is that the
views or the templates or wherever
whatever contains the markup or the HTML
is all present inside this folder called
pages okay so what we're saying is um
let's actually just make that nicer here
so what we're saying is app do set views
to path. join underscore uncore
durame Pages all right so we are saying
that inside the pages folder I have a
bunch of views or I have a bunch of
templates that I can use uh that's the
first thing second thing we need to say
is that we need to set the view engine
okay whenever you hear view think of it
as template these are all just words for
the same thing um so now we say app. set
view engine to mustache Okay so we've
set a directory that contains our
templates or our views then we set a
view engine and that engine has the name
mustache and finally for that engine we
need to provide the Handler function
okay and the Handler function is simply
coming from mustache Express all right
so uh three things we need to set
anytime you're adding some form of
templates to render some form of dynamic
data and all of this will become clear
when you actually see this in action you
need to set the views so the views we
are simply setting to the pages folder
you need to set the view engine and the
view engine we are simply setting uh to
mustache and the actual engine that we
using for the engine name mustache is
called mustache
Express all right so this is just
something that you'll have to drop into
any Express applications whenever you're
adding some some templating U engine to
it and there are a bunch of other
templating engines as well like pug ejs
Etc mustache is just the easiest one to
work with really simple to understand
all right so so far we have installed
mustach Express set it as the view
engine and we've said that all our
templates or mustache files are inside
the pages folder okay now the next thing
we can do is we can go in and render
that template so here's what we can do
instead of saying rest. send file which
is what we were saying earlier we can
say rest. render and in while we're
rendering we need to give it the name of
the view that we want to render so we
are saying that we want to render The
View
index and we want to send this data into
the that view to populate the uh to
populate that view okay again these
words will soon make sense but basically
now you can understand that okay index
simply refers to the index. mustach file
and that index. mustach file is going to
be located in the folder that has been
configured for views and the folder
folder is called Pages all right so we
have this Pages folder index. mustach so
so this is simply going to pick up the
index. mustache file and it's going to
give this additional data which is a
dictionary containing the key jobs which
points to the list of jobs that we have
and that additional data can now be used
within our index. mustach template okay
so let's come back and actually use this
now we have in this page we have this
about section and then we have this
footer just below the about about
section and above the footer I'm going
to add a new section called jobs so
here's what I'm going to do I am going
to first add this div called jobs job
opportunities
okay so so far there's nothing new we've
done we've simply added this job
opportunities div and there we have it
okay so now we've simply added a simple
div which says job opportunities nothing
fancy going on here but then we want to
now add the job list so let's add this
jobs
list so this is going to show up only on
mobile so I'm just going to reduce the
width over here as well so that it shows
up properly
so this is going to be our jobs list and
let's add the SL div over
here okay now inside this jobs list I'm
going to do something very interesting
I'm not going to type out all the jobs
one by one but instead remember that my
template is being rendered with this
data so I have access to a variable
called jobs which points to a list of
jobs okay so so I can take that list of
uh I can take that variable which is a
list and I can Loop over that variable
like this I can say hash
jobs SL jobs so what this is doing is
this is basically creating a for Loop
and inside this for loop I can put in
this
content like
that okay so let's see what is happening
here we have it we had an index. HTML
file we just renamed it to index.
mustach inside it we added this new div
called jobs list inside this jobs list
we use this special syntax called
bracket bracket and that's why these are
called the mustaches or the curly braces
that's why the library is called
mustache and then we said that okay we
want to look for this object or this key
called jobs and whatever is there in
that key if that is a list we want to
Loop over that list and that is where we
use this hash character this hash
basically means we want to Loop over
something and this slash simply means we
are we are at the end of the loop and
then in each Loop so remember our jobs.
JS
file our jobs. JS file contains a list
of jobs so in each Loop we have access
to the job and now what we can do here
is we can use a particular key or a
particular a particular key from the
object for example we have the key title
we have the key location we have the key
salary we have the key um we have the
key posted so all of those can now be
accessed within this Loop okay so now
bracket bracket title bracket bracket ET
is going to get the value for the first
element in the first Loop in the second
loop it's going to get the value for the
for the title from the second element
then it's going to get the title from
the third element and so on so because
there are four jobs listed here four of
these divs will be rendered div div div
div and in each of these four divs the
data from that corresponding job will be
picked up and what data are we picking
up we are picking up the title we are
picking up the location we are picking
up the salary and we are picking up the
poster okay so wherever you see bracket
bracket that is going to get replaced
with some actual data and finally uh we
are also picking up the job ID and using
that we're creating a link okay let me
save that and again I encourage you to
just run this yourself and see if you
can make sense of
this and let
us yeah and now you can see here now we
have job opportunities front-end
developer full stack developer data
scientist machine learning engineer all
right so again think about what happened
what we did was we installed the mustach
Express package we then imported it we
configured it as the default view engine
for Express and we configured the
default view directory as the pages
folder then in the slash route we are
simply rendering the index mustache file
or the index mustach template into that
template we are passing a dictionary in
that dictionary we have a key called
jobs which is a list of jobs now
whenever you have a list you can use it
within that mustache template like this
to Loop over that list and whatever you
put inside the hash and slash that is
going to be applied to each element of
the list okay so each element is going
to be one job or one job object from
that one job object we want to insert
into our HTML the title the location the
salary so that's why this title gets
inserted the location gets inserted the
salary gets inserted the posted gets
inserted and all of this gets looped
four times for each of the jobs that we
have okay so here this data came from a
file but this data could instead have
come from a browser or from a database
or could have come from a third party
Source like Twitter or something like
that if you're using the Twitter API or
something okay so think about this but
this is basically what mustach or any
templating engine is used for to insert
data into an HTML template and fill it
out and create a proper HTML page out of
it now if you just right click here and
click inspect you will not be able to
see this template over here what you
will see instead is that we have this
jobs list and in this jobs list we have
these four jobs these four cards and in
these four cards we have each of these
particular data for each of these
particular job roles okay so the so this
template combined with the code that is
running over here is going to generate
the HTML and only the HTML the final
HTML sent to the browser uh and that is
how things work okay now if you can wrap
wrap your head around this and you may
need to just re-watch this a couple of
times to get it then you've basically
understood what most web servers do they
take some data from a database put that
into a template using some kind of a
templating engine and then they just
send that data back to the client okay
so that was the jobs list but why don't
we also do the jobs table so let me just
grab the jobs table as
well
oops yeah let's grab the let's grab the
jobs table as well so I am going to zoom
out here a little bit grab this entire
jobs table like
that and let's put that right below our
jobs
list so that's our jobs table let me
just give that a tab and all right and
now you can see that on mobile I still
have the jobs
list yeah on mobile I still have the
jobs list but on the desktop I have the
jobs table okay jobs list on mobile jobs
table on desktop how did we create the
table again we created a normal table
with the table TR and it had a th job
title location salary Etc but once again
we use the same jobs variable and now
using the jobs variable we now created
the title we created the location we
created the salary and posted at and we
this time we created not a card but we
created a table row and four of these
get rows get created and each of them is
going to have the appropriate
information okay so just understanding
this templating syntax can sometimes be
a bit tricky at the beginning but once
you get it it becomes second nature and
mustache is actually really simple to
understand so with that we have rendered
the mustache template you can see here
we say rest. render we've given it we've
given it the name of the template index.
mustache and a list of parameters that
we wanted to pass in
okay now of course uh if we wanted we
could also pass in more parameters for
example I could pass in a parameter
called company name and I could pass
that in as let's
say Google for Just For example then in
my index. mustach I could come in here
right at the top where I have my
H1 where is that yeah so I have I have
my H1 and here instead of saying work at
Jovian uh I could maybe have just done
work
at company name
all
right and if I had done that work at
company name you would see that now it
would say work at Google so you can pass
not just one parameter but you can pass
any number of parameters you want and
now I change this back to Jovan and it
says work at Jovan and you can modify
any part of your template as you want
you can modify something inside the
class inside the tag name whatever you
want templates are very flexible but
also they can also be a little tricky to
work with for the same reason all right
so now the job now the page shows a job
table or list on the appropriate device
so now it says work at Jovian and now we
have the job opportunities table one
thing I want to mention is we have also
added links to these taable so what
happens is when you click this link it
goes to this uh if you if you see here
at the end of the URL it goes to SL job
SL1 or two or three or four based on the
job ID it's going to go to a different
route so the next step for us is going
to be Implement that route page
implement ment the individual job Pages
for each of the jobs and we'll see how
to do that in a dynamic fashion once
again without having to create four
separate pages because you could have
100 jobs or you could have 50 jobs so
you do not want to create U hardcode the
number of jobs you have or create a
bunch of routes uh anticipating how many
jobs you'll have you should just be able
to handle any number of
jobs okay so that is our second step and
I would encourage you to maybe check out
the mustache manual to learn how the
mustache templating engine works it's
actually really simple all it does is
given some text like this it could be
HTML CSS whatever it and given a bunch
of these uh template tags name value in
and slash in or whatever it can take
this data and it can just simply uh fill
that data into this template
okay now the next step for us is to
create a page for each job add the URL
SL jobjob ID okay and for this we we are
going to again follow a two-step process
first we're going to create a template
for that particular job so I've already
again put together some content so I'm
just going to create another
template called job. mustache so in the
pages file I'm going to go in the pages
folder I'm going to create job. M job.
mustache and let's close everything else
and let's paste in here the job.
mustache file and what does it contain
well let me just change this formatting
to HTML yeah so what does this contain
this contains again a bunch a head
basically a bunch of meta tags Etc then
it contains a body in the body it
contains the nav bar so it's the exact
same Navar that we have in index. HTML
but then it contains an application form
okay so it contains an application form
and here it says there is an H1 that
says that it is going it is going to say
apply job. title so you can already
guess here that it expects to maybe get
a variable called job which has a title
field inside it or a title key inside it
similarly it expects to get the variable
or input job which contains a location
and a salary and a posted information
and also it's going to uh create this
form and the form Action Now is also
going to be something different we'll
come and touch on this later but then it
renders this form over here this uh
application form and then it renders the
footer below it okay there's no yeah
there is a footer here as well okay so
we have you can already visualize that
this is going to render the same page
but instead of the about section and
instead of the table it's simply going
to show an application form with a title
on it okay but how do we actually show
this page when you try to access a job
that's where we now need to add a new
route so here's the route that we're
going to add we are going to go back
into
app.js and now we're going to create a
new route this time we're going to say
app.get slj jobs colon ID and in this
case or the and you see here we've not
put in a particular job ID we could have
put in SL one SL2 sl3 sl4 but we have
created a more generic route and this is
called a route parameter we've created a
more generic route that can handle
anything after SL job so it can handle
SL job1 SL job SL2 sl99 slob hello
slobby slob gooogle it could handle
anything but of course we want to maybe
do some filtering and ensure that it's
actually a number a job ID okay so what
we do then in our route Handler function
is uh we get the ID so whatever is
indicated using a colon at the beginning
you can access its value in request.
params okay you can always just go in
here and also do
console.log rec.
params and that's going to print rec.
params okay and by the way this console
log is not going to show up on the
browser this is actually going to show
up on our terminal down in the server
over here oops yeah this is all this is
going to show up in the terminal down in
the server over here so if I just run
the page once
again and open that and if I actually
try to open that particular page that uh
that particular route then it is going
to show up here in the server it's not
going to show up on the browser so
remember what is executed on the server
and what's on the browser all right so
we get the ID uh that is present in the
route parameter and then we try to find
so we are using the find method of an
array all it does is given a condition
or given a function it finds that job uh
that element which matches that
condition so we saying jobs. find given
a job the job. id. twring so we've done
two string here because the IDS here are
numbers so what we're saying is in the
jobs list find the job whose ID when
converted to string matches the ID that
we got from the URL so from the URL we
get an ID and we search for the job
matching that ID in the job table and
that gives us the match job and let us
also log the Matched job so
console.log matched
job and let's log match job okay and
finally we are saying rest. render job
so we we are rendering the template job.
mustach this time which is present in
the pages folder which is configured as
the views uh for our Express so we are
rendering the job. mustach template and
we rendering it with the data job where
the key job or the variable job job will
have the value of mash job okay so let's
just run this let's see it in action and
things will become clearer let me click
on front end developer over
here yeah let's click on front end
developer and you can see now magically
we have navigated to/ job1 because that
is something that we configured in our
index.js template we've navigated to/
job1 so that automatically gets caught
by this uh route Handler and when it
gets this ID you can see that the ID it
printed here is one
and you can see that it's a string so by
default all route parameters are strings
and then we Tred to search for that ID
within the jobs array and we got back a
match job and this was the match job it
had the ID one Title front end developer
location bangaluru India salary Etc and
then we put that into the um into the
template like this and in the template
job. mustache we actually using it to
render things so we are using it to
render the job title which is showing up
here after apply we are using it to
render the job location job salary and
posted on which is all showing up here
all right and the application form is
generic there is no change here so
that's I think that's pretty neat now we
can go back and like let me open full
stack developer and now it says apply
full stack developer and there's a
different salary and location let me
open data scientist now it says
something different and let me open
machine learning engineer and now it
says something different all right so
that way with just one route we have
handled four jobs but not just four jobs
potentially hundreds of thousands of
jobs on Jovian for example we have
hundreds of thousands of notebooks that
people have created but there is only
one route that is serving every notebook
right and that is the benefit of having
web servers and web applications that
can do all this kind of dynamic stuff
okay so let me get rid of these console.
logs
and now uh we are ready to move forward
because now we've created the single
individual job page so the next step for
us is going to actually support
submitting the application so if you see
here if I click on a job Ro and I fill
out the
application let's say I fill out John do
and I fill out the email address John
do.com and I fill out a phone
number and let me fill out a date of
birth here let me fill out a cover
letter
and agree to the terms and conditions
click submit application so now what
happens when we click submit
applications is in the form we have
specified a certain action so and we
have specified a certain method so all
of this data is going to be posted uh so
there are two ways two methods we can
specify one is get one is post and I'll
talk about the differences as well get
simply means that all of the parameters
or all of the data that has been filled
in into the form will be sent as part of
the URL
whereas post means that the URL is going
to be just this the data that is there
in the form is going to be sent as the
body of the request okay so every
request has a URL and a body and it has
something called headers as well which
we'll talk about later but a URL and a
body get is going to just put everything
in the URL your url is going to become
really long with your cover letter and
name and email and everything which is
something we may want to avoid
especially if you can if you have these
text Fields with a lot of content so
that's where we use post so in post this
is we simply going to send this data to
this particular URL SL jobs SL
particular job id/ apply on the server
but we're going to include all the data
in the request body and let me click
submit application and it says cannot
post slj jobs / one/ apply well that is
because in our web server currently we
can only we have only handled the slash
route and we have only handled the SL
job /id route well we could try to
handle like this we could say app.get SL
jobs slon id/ apply and we could say
something along the lines of Rec
res um and let's say let's simply send
rest.
send got the application let's see if
that works so let me go back here and
let me click submit application it still
says cannot post that is because here I
listening for the get HTTP method so if
I was sending the data using the get
method like this then it would work so
if I click Send I'd have to reload the
page yeah so if I just put in something
here a
b.com and something here and something
here and something here and I click
submit application now it says got the
application so when I send with the
method get and I have a listener with
the method get it gets the data but
where is the data all of that data is
here right here you can see it's part of
the URL it's all part of the URL phone
equals such and such email equal such
and.com U and name equals such and
suchar and this is not a good idea for
long longer forms for short forms it's
okay but for long forms it's not good
but on the other hand what we want to do
is we actually want to send it with the
method post and we want to listen to it
with the method post as
well okay so this time when I reload
this and let me fill that in
again John
do a date and something and
submit
okay do at e.com and submit this time
you can see that we actually listened so
every request and hence every route has
two things it of course has the route
path which is going to match the
specific route depending on the
parameters and it has a method so we
need to to accept form submissions which
are sent using the post method we need a
route that can uh that is declared using
the post method okay and now here we
will be able to get some things out from
the request uh all the all the form
elements that have been sent and then
maybe do something with them maybe send
an email send them to a database Etc so
uh there's a comment here well a lot of
things make sense now yep y so this all
fits together is we have to go about it
see the whole thing to actually
understand and um this was I was going
to say this is so much easier it is such
a hazle typing table rows one at a time
exactly so you almost never type out the
data by yourself you almost always get
it from a database and you just use some
kind of a templating engine to just
generate all that HTML for you okay what
is the small tag well it simply makes
the text a little smaller that's all
okay when do we learn to get data from
the database in a future
course are you also using Express for
the Jovian website no so we're actually
using
another framework called nextjs which is
what is part of the next course because
we use a UI Library called react and
nextjs plays better with react a lot of
people use express it's part of this um
you might have heard the mean stack
which is the mongodb express angularjs
and um angular and nodejs stack I
believe or something like that and
similarly there is a M Stack which is
the mongod express reactant Nots yeah so
yeah there are a bunch of these Stacks
but U there's also some Frameworks that
are specific to specific UI libraries
for example nextjs which is what we use
which is what we're going to cover okay
then we were using flask and later using
something yeah so we're also using flask
for us somehow for some reason we
because we've migrated to things over
time we started out with python as our
backend and or JavaScript as a front end
and that's why we still using both flask
and
nextjs okay yeah so so we are planning
to use react we are already using react
Nexis we just haven't migrated to it
fully how can you make the web app
remember what you input you cannot it's
just that when you go back and forth in
a browser uh the browser retains the
history of the page uh so that's all I
was just using that normally a web app
will not remember what you inputed what
other Dynamic content can we use this
framework for well you can create a blog
post all of Jovian could have been built
like this there was no problem with it
okay is Java lets us do multi-threading
and jospt script allows for asynchronous
programming but it is still single
threaded yeah so this is some more
advanced concepts I will not really
address this but I'll answer your
questions say if I want to handle
multiple concurrent request I think a
Java backend would do better than a
JavaScript well not necessarily because
what you could do is you could run
multiple JavaScript processes so what
you do is Ja JavaScript itself is single
threaded but what you can do is you can
run five JavaScript processes and all of
them can asynchronously handle a lot of
uh load
for you or you could just use a bunch of
servers um that said a Java backend
would be better if you have to do a lot
of processing on the server typically if
you simply have to call a database and
then return the result maybe just format
it in a certain way fill out a template
nodejs is going to be as fast as you can
get more or less because it has that
asynchronicity it's very easy to write
asynchronous code with it um but if you
have to do a lot of processing then you
might run into issues where if you have
like one second of processing where you
have to process maybe 10,000 rows of
data or something in that case you might
want to use Java or something okay and
if for those of you who have no idea
what we just talked about don't worry
about it it doesn't
matter okay my end goal is to build a
web app like Jovian uh by the end of the
program that is going to be a final
project to build something like uh
something along the lines of Jovian uh a
proper web application with a user login
with a database with uh proper framework
a UI framework etc etc
so let's continue on now uh so far we
have created this individual job pages
so obviously we have the main page which
contains the list of job opportunities
either as a table or as this nice list
of cards and when we open up a
particular page we have a dedicated
application page for each role front-end
developer along with some information
along with a bunch of uh inputs and when
we click submit application so we have a
submit application button over here
right now that doesn't work so if I just
put in John do and I put
in something like
that and put in a date of birth here or
something and finally put in a cover
letter and agree to the terms and
conditions it does work but it doesn't
really do anything right now uh it
simply says got the application but it's
not doing anything with it okay so now
the next step for us is to actually fill
out the application
um or is to actually maybe do something
with the application data so I'm just
going to delete this right now um and
that is going to ensure that this
doesn't do anything like that so we
we're now going to fix
that okay so let's now add another page
that can accept form submissions and
send the application over email and then
send send an acknowledgement show an
acknowledgement page to the viewer so
for this I'm going to need three
packages I'm going to need a package
package called node mailer which is
going to be used to send an email so
what I want to do is I want to just
inform myself like I'm the creator of
the site I'm the CEO of Jovian and I've
put up this job site and I want to just
send an email to myself whenever
somebody submits a job application okay
I don't want to give away my email
publicly so that not everybody can
contact me I want them to fill out the
form on this site but I don't want to
store that in a database anywhere right
now that's too much work I'll just send
that data to myself as an email okay and
maybe I could also CC the person who uh
who applied just so that they know as
well but in any case now for that we're
going to use the node mailer package
number one second we are going to use a
package called EnV now the EnV package
is useful when you do not want to put
sensitive information like your email
password in the code remember we going
to put up all the code for this
particular email um for this particular
um project on GitHub uh in public or
sometimes even even in private and we
may not want to put our password there
because then our password will will just
be present there on GitHub for everybody
else to see so that's where there's a
way to securely read some of these
things using environment variables for
which we use the end package and finally
um the request body that is being sent
when we are posting the form data that
that body is going to need to be passed
in some way and for that we need to use
this body parser package okay and you'll
see all of them in action shortly so
let's come back in here let me shut down
the server for a second and let me now
just install these packages nod mailer
Dov and body parser okay all the
packages are installed now I can restart
the server npm run
Dev and let's close this for
now next let us create a file called EnV
at the root of the repository so I'm
going to create a file over here called
EnV into which I'm going to put in my
email and password password credentials
so let's put in a folder EnV in the root
of the repository and into this I'm
going to put in these two things of
course what I'm going to put in here is
the actual email and the actual password
that I want to send the data to um
obviously I don't want to show you that
information so what you will have to do
is you will have to replace this with
your email and your password and I would
suggest not using your primary email uh
just to be careful what you can do is
you can go to gmx.com this is a website
where you can create a free email and on
gmx.com you can just create an a
throwaway email and just use that and
its password okay and that's what I'll
be using as well so I'm just going to go
in into another desktop over here and
I'm going to close it over close it here
but I'm going to put in my email ID
which I have created for this
tutorial and
password okay and I've done that so I'm
not going to show you my enem file again
if I open it you'll be able to see my
email and password so I I I won't show
it but it's there now the other thing I
want to mention is the EnV file is
already ignored in the dog ignore file
so which means when I do a git commit
and send it to GitHub then this data is
not going to be sent it is going to
remain securely on my code spaces
machine which is just private for me and
it's not going to be sent to the GitHub
repository which is public for everyone
to see or if it was private and my
co-workers would be able to see which is
again undesirable okay but now that we
have put the uh information in this v
file we need a way to actually load this
information into our app how do we load
this information into our app we do it
by saying this require. env. config so
the first line require. env. config is
going to read the EnV files that are
present in our project folders and it is
going to then read each of those and
then automatically add them to the
process.env variable okay so remember we
had this process EnV variable so now
instead of apart from Port it can also
get a bunch of other things that we have
defined so let me just put this right
here at the
top EnV and now here we have the we've
also included the node mailer package
and we've also included the body parser
package okay all right next step is to
also configure our application to use
the body parser so remember when we send
the data from this form we are posting
it which means we are not sending the
data in the URL we which means we are
actually um sending it in the body of
the request and that body of the request
needs to be passed in a special way so
right below app do uh Express right
below my app creation logic I'm simply
going to say app.use body passer. URL
encoded extended false now don't worry
about all all of this right now if you
just search online how to add body
parser to express you'll get the line of
code that you need to add and you can
look up what exactly extended does okay
but the basic ideas is and by and just
one General tip I want to give you here
is from this point on you will see a lot
of code which we are using uh which we
will not exactly describe perfectly and
the idea is that you have to kind of
look it up online maybe use chat GPT
jobard Google and understand what it
means because there are so many
libraries so many Frameworks so many U
options in each of them that it doesn't
really make sense to cover all of them
it's something that you should just look
up uh and try to figure out as you need
it okay so now we add body part we've
added this middleware essentially to our
application to which is going to parse
the request body and now uh one other
thing we need before we actually start
processing the request we are going to
create a transporter we going to create
a transporter which is going to have the
configuration required to connect with
the mail server and send the email okay
so I'm let me create this transporter
over here so I'm going to say node node
mail create transport and this transport
uh is basically it needs it needs a host
the host is mail. gmx.com so depending
on which email provider you're using
you'll have to look up their SMTP host
so just search for SMTP host for your
email provider and you also need to look
up their SMTP Port all right and then
finally you Al secure true is almost
always said secure true means you're
using https the secure version of the
transport and finally you need to
provide authentication and in the
authentication you need to provide the
username and the password as the user
and pass keys of course I'm not going to
type in my username and password here
rather if since I've already put
something into the EnV file and I've
read that using the require n um line of
code over here so this is automatically
going to get populated with my email ID
and this is automatically going to get
populated with my email password so now
we have this transporter and now we can
simply say transporter. send and that's
going to send whatever email we want to
send okay so with that we are finally
ready to actually pass all the content
so let's just go about this line by line
so let me come in here first and let me
just for
now simply say
console.log
requestbody req. body all right let's
just do that much very straightforward
we're just going to Lo the body over
here so let me just open up the
terminal this is my terminal over here
and let's just click submit
application and you can see that when I
clicked submit application it simply
said um name John John do email whatever
Akash jo.com phone number do cover
letter Etc so we simply logged the body
over here and nothing happened here
because we've not sent anything from the
server let's just go back yeah yeah what
we can also do here is we can we can do
right now rest. send application
received if we had done that then when I
click submit application it's going to
log the request body over here you can
see it loged the request body over here
for us but along with that it also
printed application received right but
that's not what we want to do we want to
actually do something with the
application now that we have the request
body okay so what next well next up then
let let us get so the request body has
this name email phone date of birth and
cover letter let's get all of that
information out from the request body
and for that we're going to use this
special syntax called destructuring
whenever you have a particular object
and you want to get the keys out of that
object and you know the names of the
keys you can put all those keys into
specific variables like this so you can
say const and then you can open brackets
and you can type the names of all the
keys that are present in the object or
you can pick just some of the keys that
are present present in the object and
you can say equal to request. body so
it's kind of the opposite instead of
saying request. body equal to name email
Etc now you're saying that from request.
body extract the name and put it into a
variable called name extract the email
put it into variable email and just do
that and now you can see if we do
console.log
name now this will just have the name
picked out from the request body all
right and I can see submit application
here yeah if I say submit application
you can see it prints the name John deto
okay so we now have all this information
from the request body into a bunch of
variables nice next let us now get the
job that we are currently working with
so remember we are posting when we're
posting we're also specifying the ID of
the job in the URL as a route parameter
so let's get the request. par. ID that
is going to get this uh that is going to
get this URL parameter ID and let's get
the matching job so let's also print in
the matching job so let's log
console.log matched job matched
job okay and let's also for now just
do rest.
send received so that is a match job but
then let's also maybe log the request
body just just for complete
clarity
okay and let's click submit application
once again so now you can see that this
was what was sent or submitted by the
user so this is obtained from the form
that the User submitted name email phone
number date of birth cover letter and
this was received this was a match job
so that means in the URL we had SL1 if I
check the URL over here you can see that
we've done SL1 SL apply right so SL1 SL
apply and that is get getting picked up
as the ID here so and that has been
matched or searched within the jobs list
which currently comes from a file but
could have come from a database and from
there we get the title of the job
essentially um so now we have all the
information we have the information
about the job that uh that is being
applied to we have the information about
the application itself the applicant
itself so the next step is to actually
construct an email so for constructing
an email we create this mail options
object all right so all we doing here is
into it we are putting a from email now
the from email ideally is the same email
that whose password you have put in into
the transporter so yeah you put in a
username and password so the from email
should be the same the two email could
be whatever you want let's say you've
set up this GMX email because you don't
want to reveal your credentials or put
your password of the primary email the
true email could be I could put into the
two email I could just put in Akash ANS
jan.com something like that or I could
also put in I believe I could put in a
list as list here as well so let's say I
also apart from from sending it to
myself I also wanted to send it to the
person who has actually emailed me so
their email is present now in the email
variable I can pick it up from the
application and I can email them that
the application sent and such and such
but for now just to keep things simple
I'm going to send it to the same
throwaway email that I've created all
right I don't want to worry about that
but I could send it to whatever email I
wanted so keep that in mind from is
ideally the same email that you've
configured in the transport two can be
whatever you want you can put in
multiple emails here as well all right
then we have a subject we can set and
I'm just saying new application for
matched job. title so that when I get
the email I want to know which job the
person is applied for and then you can
create some HTML so what you can do is
you can create an HTML string and inside
that HTML string we have inserted a
bunch of these things so this is what is
called a JavaScript string um formatting
essentially or a template literal where
you started with a back code and then
you insert into it using a dollar you
insert name email Etc okay you can learn
about this what you can do is you can
also just paste this code on chat GPT or
jobard and ask it to explain the code
but essentially what we doing is we are
creating a simple HTML email with name
email phone number date of birth and a
cover letter information all right name
email phone number date of birth cover
letter all of that and that is our mail
options so with that our mail options
object is ready and finally we can now
just simply send that using transporter
now we can say transporter.
sendmail
yeah so now let me get rid of this rest.
send and let me paste this in here so
now we can simply say transporter.
sendmail and I give it the mail options
which contains the from to subject and
HTML body and then I can give it a
Handler so when it tries to send the
mail and let's say it succeeds or fails
after the mail sending is done it is
going to get called uh it is going to
call this Handler function that is
provided here with whatever error or
info was received so if there was an
error then we want to Simply log that
error we want to print that error here
in the server and we want to say error
sending email if there was no error then
we want to Simply say email sent
successfully okay so let's just save
that um so now we have all the
information I think this position is not
required because we're not actually
asking for position in the form okay so
I'm going to just close this terminal
tab here let's take a quick look at this
again before we actually run it for when
we post some data to/ jobs colon id/
apply then this Handler gets called from
the request body we are going to get the
name email phone number date of birth
and cover letter from the request params
do ID which is the URL parameter we are
going to get the ID and we going to find
the matching job we are then logging
both of them to the terminal and then we
are creating a male options which
contains a from two subject and a body
and then we saying transporter. send
mail with the mail options and if we
receive an error so we need to give it a
Handler so what happens is it tries to
to send the mail in the background and
once the mail sending is done it calls
this Handler function so you always have
this like call back function that you
keep passing to almost everything that
you do in JavaScript right this is this
is what is meant by asynchronous
programming that you're not you're not
blocking the main thread you can serve
other requests from other clients till
the mail is being sent in the background
and then whenever the mail sending is
done it is going to invoke this function
now if there is an error after sending
the email then we are going to say rest.
status 500 error sending email so what
we saying by status is HTTP status codes
indicate whether the request was served
successfully or not so I would encourage
you to just search for HTTP status
codes you must have heard of 404 which
means that the page or the the URL was
not found 200 simply means that the URL
was found 500 means that the server
encountered an error 400 means bad
request means you made some mistake
while sending the request and so on
right so there are all these HTTP codes
that the server uses to inform the
client client what went wrong if
anything okay and it also sends the
message error sending email otherwise it
says rest. status 2 200 email sent
successfully okay so let's now go back
here and let us submit this once again
so I'm going to click submit application
This Is The Moment of
Truth and when we click that it says
email sent successfully so I'm just
going to go into my GMX account so GMX
. and let me just log in over here let's
see let me grab
my
email and
password and let me log
in and once I am logged in hopefully I
should be able to see that new email so
it says here new application for front
end developer John John do Akash jan.com
phone number is such and such date of
birth in suchar and such I write code
well that seems to be exactly what I had
filled out here great now one thing I
want to mention though almost every
email provider has turned off SMTP by
default because it is somewhat insecure
and that includes GMX to so what you
what you will need to do first is if
you're using GMX uh you will need to go
into home you will need to go into email
settings and under email settings you
will need to go into POP 3 and IMAP and
under POP 3 and IMAP you will need to
enable this setting enable access to
this account via POP 3 and IMAP okay so
that is just how you enable this SMTP
business on um GMX let's see if it's not
enabled so let me just show show you
what happens if I don't enable it and I
try to send it
now you'll see that it faces an error in
sending the email and what is the error
well I can actually look up the the
error here so if I just check the
terminal and you can see that it says
that I got the data I matched the job
but invalid login authentication
credentials invalid all right but I turn
this on again and save it and fill out
this capture qdw ZZ
ZB and
continue and now I try to submit this
again let me try a different job this
time maybe D
scientist and let us put in a date of
birth
here and let's click submit and this
time the email should be sent
successfully okay I can come back here
and check the
email and let's see back to email and
you can see there's a new application
for data science is Akash he.com such
and such and the cover letter simply
says I train okay so nice I think with
that we've basically implemented what we
were looking to implement we have
implemented
uh the the page here as well now of
course this is not how we should show it
ideally we should create a nice page
saying your application has been
received maybe let's try to do that as
well let me go in here and let me say
create a new mustache template
applied.
mustache okay and let me go into my job.
mustache copy over everything from here
into applied.
mustache yeah and let me get rid of the
form here probably don't need the
form and let me simply
say in a
div
your
application has been
received all
right I'll make it look slightly nicer
so let's see what can I do here well let
me go into index. mustache let me get
some styles from my description section
just so that it looks slightly nicer
okay class lead this looks
good so let me get that class lead in
here apply.
mustache let me give this
class
container and
[Music]
Lead all right okay so let's try this
again I click submit application oh
let's also render this template so
instead of saying do send I can say do
render and I can simply give it the name
of the template I want to render and the
name is simply
applied and now if I click submit
application okay just says email send
Pro it should
probably
reload oh sorry I should not render this
one I should render in the other case so
do
render
applied that's it and now let's click
submit and you can see that the email
has been sent and it also says your
application has been received and of
course I can make a few changes here I
can make say
text Center and I can say
mt5 and I can also say maybe
mb5 so that this is slightly
nicer uh so let me go back here let me
click submit application
again yeah I'll have to restart uh
something probably oh I see what's
happening so we actually want to reload
the server even when a mustache file is
changed so m t a c e I'm adding this
setting inside noon. Json so that
whenever I change a mustache file that
automatically reloads the server as well
so let me make these mt6 and mb6 let me
go back and submit
application still okay I need to restart
noon as well when you change noon. Json
you need to restart nodon um or you
could just do you could add Json as
another file that it watches for as well
okay but npm oops let's run it again npm
run
Dev and let me just fix the spelling
here I think there is a small fix it we
have three PS here let's do that let's
put this in here quotations let's go
back and let's click submit
application and it says your application
has been received okay perfect so with
that we have
implemented we should have a pro
probably a top margin as well it's not
showing up just yet
um but you can always figure that out
small styling changes I'll leave that to
you as something to do but with that
we've implemented a nice applied page as
well that's nice um now we want to
actually deploy this so for us to deploy
this of course we can go in here and we
can
say um added
templates and dynamic
pages and click commit and let's send
this so that's going to go to iub and
that is going to automatically deploy to
verel uh however remember that ourv file
is not is not uh going to get committed
to the GitHub repository which means if
I look back at my GitHub repository over
here that is going to contain everything
but it's not going to contain the EMV
file so when worel picks up all of this
code and tries to deploy it to the cloud
worel doesn't have my credentials so I
need to give versel my credentials let's
go back here into the project your
Express Careers Live and Let us actually
see it in
action okay work at Jovian this is all
well and good full stack developer all
right let me put in some information
here aashan a
atb.com
something like that and let me put that
in here cover
letter not ready and let me click submit
application and we're going to get into
this error error sending email obviously
because versal doesn't know the email
and password that we need to have right
so that is where just like you have
environment variables in a EnV file for
local development veral has a settings
tab and inside it you can specify some
environment variables okay so here you
need to add in a couple of environment
variables and I believe I can probably
just paste the contents of an
environment variable
file yeah but I I just want to do that
securely so I'm going to go in here and
and paste my environment variables so my
email
ID yeah and I've added them and now I'm
going to just save
them yeah and now they have been added
so they've been added below I've added
my email ID I've added my email password
and these are stored securely on worell
and I can add so the way I basically
added this was to say email ID and
whatever at whatever.com
and I clicked save and that is how these
got added okay so now the environment
variable my email ID and password have
been added into verel and it is going to
populate them into process. EnV and that
is going to then get picked up but I
just need to do one more deployment to
actually send it so let me just do
redeploy and
redeploy it's going to take a second
it's going to pick up all the
environment variables as well this time
and it is going to redeploy this
versal it's it's going to redeploy the
package or
the application and now let's go back in
here let's try
again okay full stack developer role
let's see
janeo
jan.com
like
that and let us just fill that out here
so I can zoom this in for you but yeah
I've simply filled out for the full
stack developer I've simply filled out
the application and click submit and
this time it says your application has
been received right we can add some
space above it but I guess this is fine
I can also then go into gmx.com
and let's see let's just reload this
page this is a very old email service so
you can clearly see that you have to
reload things and all but yeah Jan
dojo.com phone date of birth cover
letter perfect and with that we are more
or less done so now we have created our
website which anybody can use and this
is a website that honestly at this point
we can probably deploy as our careers
website maybe just change this image to
an image of our team maybe just update
the uh roles that we have in our in the
repository and then deploy it um but the
next step here would be maybe adding
some sort of a login system maybe
storing the data in a database and maybe
allowing applications also to be stored
in the database and so on so there's a
lot you can do here now here are a few
exercises for you create a mustache
template apply. mustache we've already
done this but how about apart from
saying your application has been
submitted you also show what is all the
data that the user has filled out
remember you still have you can pass a
variable the you can pass the request
body maybe as the application data into
the template and you can populate the
template and show all the data there how
what you can try modifying the form
submission to include the resume as an
attachment to the email so what happens
here is you have to use a encryption or
an encoding typee called multip part
form data and for that you'll have to
use not body parser but something called
molter okay so multer is a middleware
for handling multiart form data in
express all right so I'll let you check
that out as well here is another thing
you can try to do now what might happen
is somebody can create a quick script
that can open up the page or maybe like
some kind of a web scraping script that
can open up the page and then just fill
out hundreds of applications and
then yeah fill out hundreds of
applications let me reload that yeah
fill out hundreds of applications by
simply automating this or clicking the
submit button again and again and again
and that will lead to hundreds of email
over here so we want to avoid that we
definitely don't want hundreds of emails
and for that what you can do is use some
kind of a capture you see that thing
where they ask you to select traffic
signs and all it's actually very easy to
add and U one one capture system that
you can use which is actually easier to
use than Google's recapture is The Edge
capture system okay so what you'll have
to do is you'll have to go in and log in
here and you'll have to generate some
you'll have to put some code into the
index.html file or whatever uh HTML
you're sending to the browser you'll
have to put some code on the server and
you will have to um then just verify
that it works properly okay now one good
way to do some of these things is to
maybe just go on uh let's say on jobot
so jan.com
jobot and you can ask jobot um show me
an example of how
to add spam
protection using H
capture in an
expressjs application okay and just like
that jobot should be able to tell us
exactly what we need to do so first you
need to install the npm install edge
capture package then inside your Express
server file you need to um require the
hedc capsa hedc capsa package and then
what you need to do is a couple of
things one um you need to create some
capture HTML and send that into your um
template and then second you need to
maybe verify the capture response using
capture. verify from the body you can
get this get this Edge capture response
and verify it okay and that's it right
or you can also look at the
documentation so the documentation there
is some documentation for expressjs and
here you can check its example and it
says something
about how you do it so there are many
ways to do it um just look it up this is
a very common use case that people do
and this is again a common pattern from
now going forward that it is impossible
for us to just learn or teach or
remember all of the various possible
things that you can do from this point
on what you need to do is figure out
what you need for example I need a
capture then search online maybe study
the documentation maybe use chart GPT or
jobot or look at somebody's blog post
understand the code that is there bring
that code into your project because that
code is never going to be directly copy
pastable bring that code into your
project test it out and if something
goes wrong check the documentation
repeat the process again um debug things
test it out and uh once it works you're
good to go right and with that you now
have access to potentially thousands of
libraries and thousands of features that
you can easily incorporate into your web
applications all right so I'll allow you
to do that modify the S modify by um
yeah prevent spam and automated
submissions by adding human verification
using Edge capture and use chat gbd or
jobot for help so here's what we did
today we created uh and ran a web server
using the express web framework really
simple just a few lines of code we saw
how to serve HTML pages and we saw how
to serve static files and then we also
saw how to serve Dynamic data using
templates where we use the mustache
templating engine and we filled in jobs
data from a list it could could also
have come from a database into the
template we also saw how to use route
parameters to create and serve Dynamic
pages so we created a jobwise
application page where we showed the job
title salary location Etc at the top of
the page and the application form and
then we also accepted form submissions
um on a new route which was a post route
where we passed the request body we
passed the content from the um form that
was submitted and from there we got the
emails and by the if you have a doubt
how did we get to know that the form had
this
uh yeah if you have a question how we
got to know that the form had has
certain Keys um so you have these things
here how did we get name email phone
number how do we know that these were
the actual names of the keys within the
form well that is actually present
within
the form itself so if you check the form
for every input we specify the name so
name equals name name equals email name
equals phone name equals doob and that's
exactly what we get here name email
phone doob and then there is that last
input which is the cover letter name
equals cover letter and that's what we
get as the variable cover letter okay so
we got all the data from the form and
then we created this mail and we use
node mailer to configure our settings
our credentials our credentials of P
post our credentials were stored
securely in aemv file read in securely
using the N library and then we created
a transport and from that transport we
sent an email and that email was then
visible here on our GMX
account yeah so maybe I was just uh I
got logged out here but yeah that was
available on our GMX account so that's
how you build a web application right
this is the most basic version where we
simply using HTML CSS JavaScript we're
not using things like react Etc but this
is the code the code ideas going to
remain the same you have a server some
logic happens on the server server can
connect to the database server can
process request server can handle form
data etc etc and then you send some HTML
to the client and that along with that
HTML you might have some CSS you might
have some static files you might
actually also have some JavaScript files
which get executed only on the client
all right so all of that is something
that you can do as well now all the code
for the tutorial can be found here it's
all open for you to see so you can check
it out except of course the credentials
themselves um this is the starter code
and this is the finished code so this is
all the finished code that you can look
at and this is the finished site that
you can check out and check out these
resources to learn more at this point
you just have to Google things or ask
jobot or chat GPT expressjs
documentation nodemon mustache body
parser HTTP methods node mailer SMTP all
of that okay one exercise I would
definitely encourage you to try is to
modify the form submission code to
include the resume as an attachment to
the email that'll be a very interesting
thing for you to try okay now your
objective with this project and with
this course really is to be able to
build uh an entire website by yourself
from scratch so you're going to build a
personal website using the tools and
techniques that we've covered in this
course okay now of course this is not a
web design course and design is its own
uh entire area that might take several
years to perfect uh so that is why I
would not recommend trying to design a
website from scratch what you can do is
check out the figma community over here
so this is the figma community if you
just go to figma docomomo figma is a
design platform web design platform and
just search for personal website you
should be able to find a bunch of
interesting personal website templates
that you can use so uh for instance this
one looks interesting let's take a look
at this and whenever you open up a figma
Community project you can actually go in
and you can check out what pages they
have provided so yeah this is a UI
design page and on the UI design page
you can see here that uh this person has
created two versions so you can use
either of these versions okay uh they
have a they have a name then they have
uh a couple of links and a download savy
button and then they have like this hero
section after that they have their
Social Links after that okay they're
talking about some of their services
this is where maybe you could talk about
your education your work experience
um then they have maybe uh some projects
that they worked on like this listed
here and then they have maybe some blog
post so if you have some blog post that
you've written on medium or elsewhere
you can link those as well and they
again they have a fitter with some
Social Links right so you do not have to
and I want to stress this again you
don't have to try to design your own web
page I would not recommend doing that
because that's not what this is about
it's about being able to code your own
web page in HTML and CSS uh and make it
look good make it responsive use the the
tools libraries Frameworks that we have
covered in this course here's another
example again let's go into this U so
here again there seems to be
this section over here there is a nav
bar and then a bunch of links here so
it's not that you will use these exact
same links in your project what you're
going to do is you're going to replace
it with some of the links or some of the
items that make sense for you and
there's this hero section you can
probably put up your own picture here
and then there is a bunch of services
there's an about section there's a bunch
of project sections a bunch of cards
here and then just more things here
right so it's again you don't have to
use all of this you can just use some of
this then there's a contact form here as
well and so on so I just want to go over
some guidelines here so there's no
tutorial here as such for this because I
want you to just try and do this on your
own this is the first open-ended
Endeavor in terms of web development so
there's not a lot of step-by-step
instructions it's a bit open-ended for
you so go out check check out the figma
community check out dribble find a good
design that you feel you can Implement
then here are some requirements that
your website needs to satisfy now of
course feel free to do as much as you
want feel free to go as deep as you want
in and as um Broad in terms of the kind
of content you want to incorporate but
the the key things that you need to keep
in mind is this that your website should
contain at least two pages and I would
recommend these Pages can be home and
contact or if you want to spread them
out into multiple pages if you want to
have home as one page and then maybe
projects as another page or one page per
project or something like that you can
do that as well or if you want to
incorporate a Blog of some kind into
your website you can do that as well but
for the purpose of this project we
require your website to have two pages
all right uh not more you can have more
than that but at least make sure that
you have two not one will not
do second the homepage should have at
least four sections and by section we
mean so and that excludes the have bar
so this is one section you can see here
this there is this section called um
this is generally called the hero
section because well this is where you
kind of put a put a picture and just say
some say something with big text this is
just welcoming people then you have
maybe uh you can have maybe a work
experience section you can have maybe a
project section if you don't have a lot
of projects you can have maybe an
education section or something like that
uh and then finally or you can just talk
about your career and finally maybe you
can have a footer you can have maybe
just like uh a a small note about
yourself maybe just sharing your uh
basic your your life Journey so far or
some just something very basic that
would
be informative for a potential employer
so when you go out later down in the
boot camp and you go on and apply for a
fullstack developer role and you share
the link to your website so keep in mind
that what do you want people to see when
they click on the website link in your
resume now what is it that you want to
say to them right you want to present
you you want to tell your story very
briefly just like you do on a LinkedIn
profile for instance and you want to
present some interesting work and you
want to showcase that you have what it
takes to build good goodlooking
responsive websites okay then the
website should contain at least one form
and I would recommend this could be a
contact form so you can maybe if you
have a contact page on the contact page
you can have a contact form or you can
have a if you if you don't have a
contact page you have a different page
for something else then you can maybe
just create a form for on the homepage
itself but make sure that it it has at
least one form with maybe at least three
or four Fields typically they would be
email name uh your your message or
something like that and uh I would
recommend that as you browse a few of
these examples and we have included
several examples here start by first
creating an a wireframe because that is
what we have been doing so far right so
follow that procedure of creating a
wireframe even if you've picked a design
because you're not going to implement a
design EX exactly right you are going to
change the design or you're going to
pick the content that is going to make
more sense for you for your website so
start by uh just after having selected
some design or after having just figured
out what you want to show start by first
creating a wireframe so that you can
figure out what content you want to put
on the page right so for instance is if
I were creating my personal we my
personal website I would maybe let's see
so let's say I were creating Akash that
is my that would be I would probably get
that domain and that is my personal
website and here what would I like to
put so well I would like to definitely
have a nav bar at the top and in the nav
bar I would want to mention my name I
would want to mention uh maybe like the
home link and maybe let's see I would
like to mention a contact page link
something like that right and then on
after the nav bar I would want to to
have maybe a quick hero section let me
just put in that information here and
then we'll draw the wireframe so a hero
section and in the hero section I will
probably have maybe a photo uh maybe a
heading like a big title ha am Akash or
something like that and maybe a subtitle
let me just call it title and subtitle
right something like that so that would
be the hero section then maybe I would
have an about section in the about
section I would uh create a short bio
something like hey I'm Akash I'm from
such I'm from India I live in Bangalore
I do this I do that I've done this in
the past Etc thanks for checking out my
website feel free to contact me right
something like that so uh that would be
good then I would probably want to
include maybe my uh projects because I
think that would be the most interesting
thing that I would want to showcase all
the interesting things that I've worked
on over the years so um I have a bunch
of uh like Android apps
websites uh courses ET Etc I would
mention those um then maybe I would want
to let's see I would want to maybe talk
a little bit about my um career right so
in this I would probably mention my
education and I would probably combine
education and work experience because
I've just had one job full-time job and
after that I've just worked as a
consultant and and so on so yeah
education work experience Etc uh so I
would do that then I would probably just
uh have a
and here I would put some Social Links I
don't have Social Links but I would
probably put like some external links so
like Jovian uh Jovian links Etc right
and maybe I might also have one section
here where I might highlight some of my
best uh work in terms of videos so like
uh add some YouTube
videos like that all right so that would
be what I would want to put so then what
I would do is I would try to create two
wire frames I would want try to create
one wireframe for mobile and one wire
one wireframe for desktop so I would
just put it like that maybe and I would
say okay this is my desktop wireframe
and this is my mobile
wireframe all right and then as you can
imagine I'm basically going to just put
a bunch of boxes here okay so this is
going to be my Navar and I can just fill
in some information into my Navar and
again you can do this on paper I'm just
showing this to you here on this tool
excal draw.com but you can do this on
paper absolutely fine so that would be
the nav bar and then I would have a hero
section here so I would kind of leave
some space for the hero section here is
where I would put the title something
like hi I'm
Akash like that
and often when I'm doing this I would
even just pre-draw so I would maybe just
do something like that that okay maybe
here I want to put like a uh a picture
of myself saying hi or something and
maybe have like a couple of lines
of introduction about myself here I
might want to again mention my name here
I want to say home contact something
like that then I have the about section
so that would be something like about me
and then I would have maybe a few few
lines of text about myself uh I could
also maybe put a picture on the side but
I think that's fine so then after the
about section I would probably then go
down and then uh create a project
section and that's where it's a good
opportunity to use some card maybe so
let's
see projects and I would probably just
put a bunch of cards here uh like that
maybe three cards or so and then I would
maybe just put a button saying view more
and maybe there could be a separate
project page that goes in there and uh
yeah feel free to get as detailed or as
rough as you need but uh the idea is you
want to lay out all the content that you
want to add here so so that when you are
actually implementing you don't really
have to think about what content do I
want to put here right um then okay we
have videos so I would probably put in
some videos here so let's see
videos again I would probably just embed
a couple of YouTube videos here like
that and maybe have a line describing
what projects what what videos I've done
uh and so on and then I would adapt it
to the mobile view so in the mobile view
of course you would have a slightly
different structure maybe you would not
you would need like a menu over here
instead of an actual buttons so I would
probably have that menu button over here
I would probably take
this hello uh you might also want to
take a picture uh a new picture for your
personal website it it would be nice but
yeah I would probably take this like
hello thing and I'd probably just put
that here and then the hero text would
probably become centered and that would
come here like that and then I would
have the About Me section I think this
would remain as is so you get the idea
that you want to have one breakpoint for
mobile you want to have one breakpoint
uh for tablet and one for desktop but if
you want you can just do mobile and
desktop wireframing and you you will
kind of know that okay this I'm going to
get from this so it's so the Styles I'm
going to get from here but the content
and what I'm going to write here all of
that you can actually put into your
wireframe I'm not putting it right now
because it'll take a while but you can
actually put all this into your
wireframe or maybe into a Google doc or
something uh but the idea is before you
even start writing your first line of
HTML you are in a position where you
already know what's the what the page is
going to look like
so the biggest mistake that you're going
to make and I'll repeat this again is
that you start coding right away and
then you're thinking okay what should I
put in this section and then you as
you're trying to put something into the
section you realize okay now the design
is no longer working or now uh I'm not
able to make it responsive so separate
the design content and implementation
okay um yeah so then once you've created
a wireframe then uh create you and once
you picked a design for inspiration then
create it section by section and the
website must be responsive and it should
be easily viewable on mobile on tablet
and on desktop okay so make sure to test
it on real devices and make sure of
course you can deploy it to verell you
can open it up you can send yourself a
link and test
it now you can use bootstrap or you can
use any other CSS framework you want to
build the website if you want you can do
it without bootstrap feel free this is
an open-ended project we not forcing you
to use bootstrap you don't have to but
if you want you can uh use bootstrap
that's fine or you want to use some
other CSS framework that's perfectly
fine too now for the form that you
create you can either use form.com to
collect the responses using uh and we've
covered this in one of the lessons
probably I I believe the second lesson
or you can set up an Express server uh
an Express web server to collect form
resp responses so again this is covered
in the previous lesson so in the lesson
Express web application framework you
can see here that we have a section on
handling form responses where we
basically used uh we created an app.
poost link so you can do that as well uh
both of these can be deployed to versel
equally easily so that's fine you don't
have to use express for this you can do
a simple HTML and CSS if you want that's
perfectly fine but uh yeah as a
challenge I would encourage you to maybe
try try out using Express that will also
help you practice templates and other
things then use consistent and
aesthetically pleasing colors fonts and
Design Elements so one of the things
even though we are not focusing on web
design too much in this course one of
the things we've tried to do is make
sure that
our websites that we build don't look
ugly uh which means that they don't have
a very poor or not poor exactly but they
do not have a very well they don't have
a thoughtless or or or a random choice
of colors right the default colors that
CSS gives you are not great ideally want
to use a color palette and that's where
we have looked at things like Tailwind
uh Tailwind colors it's a good place for
you to pick out yeah tailin color.com so
you want to use a color palette you want
to have one primary color and you want
to use different shades of that primary
color if blue is not your thing pick
green or pick Rose or pick red but
definitely stick to a color palette and
similarly fonts as well you want to be
consistent with fonts feel free to
experiment here feel free to try
different fonts but ideally stick to one
font for headings and one font for body
now that doesn't mean that it has to be
inter and Roboto like if I go back here
on the figma community you can see that
here there's an interesting font that is
used for the uh for the header here and
that's what's called a what's called a
set font and in fact it's not just ter
font it has slight slight calligraphic
elements as well whereas there is a
different set of different font that is
actually used for the body text all
right and then there's this uppercase
font that is used here as well so feel
free to experiment you can use two maybe
three fonts but make sure that it stays
consistent across the page it shouldn't
be the case where you use a certain font
in the nav bar then you use a certain
font in the header or the hero section
then you use certain font in the about
section please don't do that please uh
keep it consistent I hope you've picked
that up and similarly with design
elements as well like if you want to
spray in Design Elements here and there
for example here there are these dots
that are there um you'll have to figure
out how to actually add these Design
Elements but for all these Design
Elements keep them consistent like this
Arrow you see here that arrow is there
everywhere or you see this highlight
here that highlight is there everywhere
as well so um yeah make sure that you
are staying consistent in all of of
these in terms of the design that is the
key even if it is a very simple black
and white kind of page with with maybe
just one color here and there
consistency is key so make sure of that
now you need not replicate a design
exactly just try to make your site look
good just try to make it look consistent
just try to make it look well spaced out
and finally your website should be
deployed to worel and again there are no
instructions here by this time you
should be familiar with the deployment
process so you have to create a GitHub
repository keep it open source keep it
public and um then you deploy it to
verel and optionally if you want you can
also connect a custom domain to it so
you can go ahead and actually on ver.com
if you go into domain settings I'll let
you figure it out but you go into domain
settings and you can add a custom domain
so you can purchase a domain I think
some cheap domains are uh let's see so I
I believe like do XYZ domains are very
cheap so let me if I let me just search
for Akash
XYZ um
I think that's
about 164 rupees that's about less than
$2 a year right so $2 a year is not that
bad but uh so you can buy it for a buy
it for a year if you want but this is
not a compulsory part of the um this not
a compulsory part of the project even if
it's deployed to verel that's perfectly
fine even if it's Akash doval doapp
that's completely okay no problem there
now uh one thing I just want to suggest
is make sure that know as you copy over
things from different sites you might
find that there is some content there
and you might just put that content
directly uh make sure that all the
information on the website is true and
accurate that is key because we want you
to be able to actually use this website
this is not just a project that you're
creating we want this to be a website
that you can use that you can update
over time as you work on the through the
rest of the boot camp and you should be
able to link it from your resume right
so you want it to be informative for
your potential employer but at the same
time you also want it to demonstrate
your skills so finding that balance is
the key here again it's more open-ended
I I'm we do not intentionally don't want
to give you like a set pattern that you
can follow here we want you to encounter
these challenges we want you to uh like
look into these constraints and figure
out what is the right balance for you
okay and for the project is specifically
I would highly recommend scheduling at
least one one-on-one call maybe two so
once once you once you've created a
wireframe once you know what your
website is going to contain and once you
maybe pick the design as a reference
maybe schedule a one-on-one call just to
have a chat just to kind of go over the
content itself right and then the second
thing that you should do after that is
once you have implemented the website
and made it responsive maybe you can get
one get on one one-on-one call with one
of us again to get inputs on on what
further improvements you can make to
your website okay so those are the two
things that I would uh that I would
suggest you should
do okay so here are some examples for
inspiration let's go over some of these
examples very quickly um you can search
for more on dribble or the figma
community just search for personal
website and you'll find hundreds of
examples okay so let's see there is this
one this one is yeah this one is one
that we already looked at but let's take
a closer look at this so here okay it
says hi I'm San I'm a web and app
designer I designed beautiful websites
and of course you can imagine putting a
picture here there's a nice uh nav bar
here at the top then latest work so is
put like you can refashion this as an
about section of course you can just put
um uh about me and you can just write a
few things here uh and then again okay
what I do okay so this is more like the
about section want to work so there's
not a lot here there's like three
sections maybe you might want to add
another section here or maybe just reuse
one of these again this is not uh it's
not like something that you can use
directly you might have to make slight
changes to it here is one this is
something that we uh used for assignment
one feel free to use it if you like it I
would not suggest using this because you
will not be learning enough in the
process but this is a good template as
well so you can definitely use this for
inspiration in terms of how to structure
your website if you don't end up using
this
exact um if you don't end up using this
exact template
itself okay let's take a look at this
then yeah this one also looks pretty
interesting it has some interesting
fonts as well so again let's
see yeah there it is so now you can put
a logo here or you can just put your
name name here and here the napar here
is at the in the in the center and then
there's a contact button um then okay
hello I'm zeror and and then there's
some information there's an email and CV
download button okay there are a bunch
of logos of uh his favorite tools I
think that is a good thing you can put
in four plus years of experience and
here okay there is some information here
there's a Code this could also be an
about me and let's connect yeah so four
sections and of course you may have to
think about what content you're going to
put here but again a good one let's see
what's up here yeah Stefan William uiux
designer again there's a bunch of uh
interesting stuff going on here so let's
see final design there are four sections
so there's of course the hero section um
it has this nice thing on the side
that's also interesting then um yeah
these are projects so maybe you can put
some projects here and you can link to
them as you work through the boot camp
um you can maybe link to some some of
your GitHub repositories here then okay
these are also like projects so you
could use maybe this one as about this
one as projects or something and then
this one just has a code or something
you want to convey to the person seeing
it and then this is like the footer so
this is nice and then let's see a couple
more yeah this one is very detailed you
don't necessarily have to use uh all of
these sections but again use it more for
inspiration
so you can see how it goes I think this
is a great example of how it goes from
um yeah how it goes from like a basic
design setup here to something that is
more interesting here with a hero
section and some articles and some
projects and things like that okay so
great um if you want to add a Blog feel
free to add a Blog uh into your website
and blog would simply be a couple of
pages for now I like this one this one
is really simple
let's see yeah so this one doesn't have
a lot of images this is basically this
hello section over here then this is
what I do where to find my work about me
and schedule of consult this could
probably go on a second page and that's
it there's this bottom over here all
right um yeah a couple of real websites
I want to point out so one you can check
out the website for Ashish Ashish a
senior software engineer Jovian again
this is a very different style and this
is a sort of a very minimal approach
here but I think it covers everything uh
it it has a it's very text Heavy it's
sort of more structured like a resume
but it's great it does the job and for a
developer it actually might be a good
thing the font used here is a monospace
font so that's again an interesting
choice of font um but again for a
programmer that is something that might
make sense and then there's a link to a
Blog here and then so again these these
open into different uh other websites so
that's fine there's a project section
there's an achievements yeah so so this
is more structured like a CV and that's
perfectly fine it's your personal
website you give it your personality uh
just as long as you are satisfying the
requirements that we have laid out here
that is perfectly fine here's another
personal website you can check out um so
this is akansha she is or was a graduate
student pursuing Masters in uh data
science so here she has a homepage where
she has a picture she has this about
section
and she has a bunch of links and then
she has a project section where she has
like a bunch of cards uh showing her
projects right and this is great because
it um it it simply shows you that okay
there you go to this site you learn
enough about this person and you can go
into the project section and then you
can check out okay this person has done
a lot of interesting work and I probably
want to like as a potential employer I
probably want to talk to this person
then um here's another one another like
a lot of people take a more text Heavy
approach and that's perfectly fine again
I want to stress that this is your
website so this is Andre karpati he's a
researcher at open aai um so before that
he was working at Tesla so he has this
simple website where he has the timeline
of his work and after that he has some
featured talks or um that he has given
over the years and then a little a
section about teaching a section about
writing and in this case yeah the the
blog actually opens on a different s and
that's perfectly fine a bunch of pet
projects and Publications Etc right so
again great it's all and then a bunch of
Social Links here as well so perfectly
fine uh this works too so I want to say
that don't limit yourself to the kind of
websites that you see on figma or on
dribble U go feel free to go a little um
wider in terms of your search feel free
to just look at personal websites of
people uh you generally tend to follow
you can generally find them on the
Twitter you can you can find them on
their uh on their LinkedIn project or
elsewhere one other good source for a
bunch of these uh sites is just going on
YouTube and searching personal website
HTML CSS and you'll find here okay this
looks interesting that looks interesting
that looks these three look somewhat
similar I would say but still uh this
looks pretty interesting this one uh
this one over here is also good um yeah
this is also interesting this has got
some this one looks pretty
slick I it's got that whole cyber Punk
theme going on and uh it's also a
tutorial so you can actually probably
even follow along with this and again
it's fine if you're uh referring to a
tutorial a little bit so let's take a
look at this this one's got got a few
animations as well so let me just play
this yeah so this is what this website
looks like at the end of all of this
development I believe this is
implemented in react but it doesn't have
to be
so it's got a bunch of animations it
it's got a bunch of colors over here
it's got this nice bottom sticky Bottom
bar um let's
just watch the
entire demo over here it's got a
portfolio link it's got a bunch of
Social Links it's got this nice image
which is cut out in a random shape over
here got this nice about section there's
some uh animation going on here as well
there's the animation on the buttons too
then there's a more detailed section
what I do again this could be projects
as well
[Music]
possibly let's keep
going and yeah these are like some
latest projects
so that and then probably there's at the
end I believe there is a contact form
somewhere yeah so again you don't have
to add any animations but if you want to
you can and um there are often you can
use a bunch of like CSS or JavaScript
helper libraries to implement animations
bootstrap itself also allows you to
create some animations the reason we
don't cover animation a beginner course
is because most websites will not
require any animation or you'll end up
just using some prepackaged Library uh
but if you want to add animations please
feel free uh we're not stopping you so
one tip I want to give you very
important tip is that you can go beyond
the scope of work as uh that is
described above you don't have to limit
yourself to this however make sure to
First Implement everything that we've
mentioned above so first do a first pass
and Implement just the bare minimum just
Implement everything that we've done
before going too heavy on let's say
creating five pages and all that so
first create a basic version that
satisfies the evaluation criteria make a
submission here and only then continue
building on top of it very important you
have to do this iteratively because if
you keep expanding the scope of your
website you'll be stuck on the first
page or the first section forever and
you will never actually and and you'll
be trying to animate the first section
the Hero part of it and all that and
you'll be stuck on that for days right
so do the basic version make a
submission we'll give you feedback as
well um and then continue adding
whatever else you want to add okay we
started out by looking at HTML and CSS
Basics um so here we just understood
HTML CSS the very basic foundations of
uh a web velopment so we wanted to
create our first web page and creating a
first web page what we really wanted to
do was we wanted to create a jovian jobs
website which we kept building and and
improving over the course of uh the
several lessons and we just wanted to
have a Navar a header section displaying
a picture a list of job openings and a
footer at the bottom uh and that for
just for that what we did was we uh
created a folder on our desktop we
opened up visual studio code we added
just some HTML code to it that showed us
our first web page then we understood
how tags work then we uh created some
important tags like HTML head body title
Etc then uh we added some div tags with
some content um then we had created a
wireframe so we decided that okay we
need to maybe first create a wireframe
like this so this is where it all
started uh okay we wanted to have a
Navar we wanted to have this header
image we want to have an about section
job opportunities and a footer then we
added some content uh using HTML so
again we added a bunch of headings like
this then we added some text and
paragraphs so then start things started
looking a little better of course it's
still basic content then we added some
lists so we created a list for Let's see
we created a list here an ordered list
and an unordered list here for the
footer then we added some links so after
adding some links this is what our page
looked like then we added some images so
we added an image here at the top and
image here
below and and uh this is what a page
looked like without any CSS then we went
ahead and added some CSS so we started
centering things we started adding some
image Styles so we learned how CSS
declarations work we have some selectors
and then we have a property and a value
and we can put it inside the style tag
we can put it in a CSS file or we can
use the style uh attribute then uh we
looked at the different ways to select a
tag and ID a class and we understood the
CSS Box model where we have some content
padding border mark
and then we implemented the wireframe so
we started by adding some basic Styles
so just adding styles to the body then
adding the nav bar uh with the Jovian
logo then adding the banner image the
about section the jobs the footer and
this is ultimately what our first web
page looked like right so once we did
all of that this is what our first web
page looked like and then we deployed it
to the cloud using this platform called
static. apppp not something that you
would do in production but it works for
our first web page and that was was that
was our first web page and that was not
too bad for our first web page uh but
this is something that we then kept
incor improving on over the next several
lessons so the second lesson was
Advanced HTML and CSS and this time we
just wanted to iteratively improve the
existing web page by adding and
modifying sections we want to learn how
to work with tables how to add forms how
to how to work with colors in CSS how to
um save how to use meta tags all of that
so again we uh basically just and we
learned about the iterative method and
this is something that you should try to
apply to your own personal website
development as well try to get the first
version out in one day and maybe then
take the second version out everything
is something that should be deployed and
that is why we may we also focused on
deployment from the beginning your
website should be live from day one and
you should just keep adding more
information to it instead of saying okay
I'm still working on it I'm still
working on it I'm still working on I'm
I'm going to take it live tomorrow or
next week or something like that don't
do that just take it live with whatever
minimal content you can and just keep
improving it so here's what we decided
that we're going to add this job
opportunities table and then we are
going to add a form here as well and uh
then we learn about tables in HTML and
how to create complex tables like this
using the table TR and TD tags we
learned about using um The Border
attribute to make sure and collapsing
the border so that it looks something
like that and then once we had the table
okay so that's a table Without Borders
and then we saw how to style HTML tables
so again we can add a bunch of borders
we can add a bunch of background colors
we can add a bunch of text Styles so
just with a few lines of CSS our table
looked a lot better and then we decided
that we want to merge some rows and
columns make things look a little nicer
so we uh learned about row span call
span and things like that and this is
what our table ultimately looked like
then we learned about text Styles in CSS
so every website every company has a
personality and part of that personality
is the fonts they use so to use external
fonts we use uh Google fonts and again I
encourage you to experiment with fonts
but just pick two or maximum of three
fonts one for maybe headings one for
subheadings or things like that and one
for the body text um and make sure that
those fonts pair well together and there
are a bunch of resources here that you
can check out for finding good font
fairings we at Jovin we use inter and
Roboto as a heading and body uh probably
a slightly boring choice but it does the
job um maybe at some point we'll update
that but there are a bunch of pretty
interesting pairings that you can check
out here okay so part of building your
personal website is going back and
reviewing all the resources that we've
shared with you and figuring out
something that is um that interests you
but at the same time that also looks
good okay um so yeah so then that we
learned about a bunch of font and text
related properties we learned about
understanding size in CSS so there are
absolute sizes pixels are the most
common these are not really used and the
relative sizes again percentages and
Rems are the most common others are not
really used too commonly but in any case
you have a bunch of these sizes that you
can use as
well I really want to stress again that
feel free to go back and refer to
specific sections we've put we've put in
a lot into these lectures like these are
things that you'll keep probably
referring back to for months probably
even years as you going through uh the
rest of the boot camp and also your web
development uh uh job all right U okay
then we have yeah text sizes and Style
Guidelines again we have a bunch of
things over here then we talked about
colors in CSS so there are a bunch of
inbuilt colors they are not very good
for actual web design so I would not
recommend using these inbuilt colors and
in general you want to avoid something
that is too bright or too dark or too
grayish it looks very 90s um you want to
use something that something that has
like these are called pastels or
something that is slightly dull but at
the same time also has a also has an
interesting shade to it right so these
ones the all of these slate green SE
green all of these are interesting um
but really what you should be doing is
using a color palette using some
platform like Tailwind colors or
something so then we have RGB colors so
you can of course specify inbu color
names you can use RGB background RGB
values you can use hexad decimal which
is basically another another short way
of writing RGB where the first two
characters represent red the next two
characters represent green and blue and
it goes from 0 0 to FF that's why it's
called hexadecimal so 0 to 9 and a to F
all of these are used to create numbers
essentially you can learn more about the
hexadecimal number system if you need
you can also add transparency to your
colors whether you're using rgba or
you're using
hexadecimal and colors can be set for
the text colors can be set for the
background for the border for the Box
Shadow and and much more by the way
backgrounds can also be images so that's
also something that you can check out
like this one here has a background
image not a great choice but you can see
the difference between a good consistent
color scheme and fonts and a good
contrast between the text and the
background
versus a good contrast versus bad um
definitely your personal website
shouldn't look like this so I just want
to stress here that it's very the reason
a lot of the old websites look like this
or poor poorly designed websites look
like this is because this is what your
website will naturally look like if
you're thinking on the Fly versus if you
have looked up a template if you have
decided a color palette if you've picked
good fonts colors you have Frozen all
these details before you're actually
coding it then your website is more
likely to look like this okay um so yeah
so just keep that in mind
then these are all some color text color
guidelines again not it's not fixed but
you can use these as a reference so
almost always you want to start out with
some standard reference something that
is some somebody has figured out is a
good set of selections and then make
slight tweaks to it to uh do what you
want it to do um so yeah once we apply
all these uh then we get back a pretty
good-looking site and then we have forms
as well so forms are created us using
the form tag and through the input tag
select tag text area tag and we also use
the label tag so every form has an
action and again this could be an
external website this could be maybe a
server endpoint you have implemented and
a method uh but you create divs and
inside the divs you create these labels
and you have a bunch of different types
of inputs text checkbox radio
dropdown text area password email Etc
and once you've put in a form then um
you can sty it you can give it a bunch
of different styles and this is what a
form might potentially look
like okay and then there's a action and
a method and a Target so in this case
well uh we used form bold because we
were not talking about servers early on
so you can just use any service that can
receive form responses form bold is a
good one useful one uh in case you don't
have the option or the time to set up a
proper server and we simply pass its
action method Etc and it can collect
whatever we needed to collect and then
we have uh HTML meta tags metatags
provide information about a web page to
search engines and browsers so when your
website is searched online and Google
finds it and shows it in a search result
that is when all these metat tags will
come into picture Okay so these are some
common meta tags and these are some
platform specific meta tags and then
there's a title and fav icon tag that
are used to change the browser title and
fav icon so that's again something that
you can um set up as well right so you
should you can literally just take this
set of metatag pasted into any website
that you're building I think one uh
requirement we should we will add in the
project is that it should have your
website should have proper meta tags um
so that it can be shared easily by with
other people as well and then Cloud
deployment again we were still talking
about uh static app here because we not
touched on git and GitHub so that was
lesson two and then you had an
assignment where you had to convert a
design mockup into a web page so you had
this design mockup and what you did was
you had to inspect it using figma you
had to set up a basic page structure and
styles this is the mockup over here you
had to set up the basic page structure
and styles then you have to implement
the web page section by section then you
have to deploy your web page to the
cloud and make a submission all right um
a few tips avoid copy pasting Styles
directly from figma so there's a
knowledge based article on this and
we've also picked up a bunch of common
mistakes and put them into this Google
drive folder so again use these go back
and refer to all of these for your
personal website as well your goal
should be to get a pass grade on your
first submission and for you to get a
pass grade on your first submission make
sure that you're not repeating the
mistakes that you or other people have
made okay um that was this first
assignment then we talked about Version
Control and Cloud deployment the proper
uh way to do web development and that is
where we talked about git and GitHub so
we started by just getting started with
GitHub we learned about what Version
Control is how it is useful we learned
about git uh where you basically you put
your code on a remote server and then
you can pull it into any computer or
maybe a cloud computer like GitHub code
spaces and you can make some changes and
then you can push it back and still have
all the older versions available and you
can also view it from the browser on
github.com and you can also collaborate
with other people right so again there's
a lot git itself is a huge thing that
for years people um keep learning or
just try to manage through uh just
running a few simple commands that's
what I do I just remember three or four
commands and use them all the time and
look things up whenever I require but
this is the basic structure of what git
gives you and GitHub gives you a bunch
of abilities on top of uh Git it is
basically a web- based platform that
also gives you some collaboration tools
uh it's where you can find open source
projects it has a wide community and it
has great integration with other tools
right and for a web developer that
GitHub profile is kind of like the
resume so we'll talk at some point about
actually creating your own GitHub readme
profile as well okay we'll cover that at
some
point so here yeah we talked about how
to create a project repository and then
you have these things called A readme
and A get ignore we talked about them as
well and a license as well especially if
you're building an open source project
and once the project repository is
created we talked about how you can open
it up using GitHub code spaces a
cloud-based development environment with
a free tier that allows you to write
test and debug code directly in your
browser quick to set up gives you a
consistent environment you don't have to
install anything lets you work from
anywhere and starting a code base is
really easy you just click the code
button and click create codes space and
that's how you can create a code space
and it gives you this Visual Studio code
interface in the browser which honestly
is good enough that's what I've been
using for a bunch of projects that I've
been working on and uh you don't even
need to install anything on your
computer and you can install extensions
within this vs code browser and they
will remain there the next time you try
to open it uh so we at Jovian have
almost completely shifted to GitHub code
spaces uh we still do use our local
machines because the free uh tier is not
sufficient for some of our work uh
that's why um yeah and then you can run
it using a live server so especially
when you're developing a simple HTML and
CSS web page you can just use a live
server to run things and then gith
updating a GitHub repository is fairly
straightforward it's a three-step
process uh but there are buttons to to
do it in one step but you just first add
files and Stage them and then you commit
them and then you push them right so
each of them has a certain purpose a
reason they were built um but what you
should just remember is that all these
stages are important for your code to
actually reach the GitHub Cloud
repository all right so make sure that
you are always going to add push and
then add commit and then push so add is
going to Stage your changes comp is
going to record a new version and push
is going to push it to GitHub and then
somebody else can pull it and there are
ways to just do this using visual studio
code so that you don't have to run
anything on your end then Cloud
deployment with verel was again a breeze
all you do is sign up on wor.com and you
connect your GitHub account then you
select the repository that you want to
deploy and you select the folder inside
which your actual code is present that U
that needs to be deployed and it's going
to deploy it for you and it's going to
look something like this so this was
actually the website that we deployed
and um yeah that still looks fine it's
going to be there so you're going to
have all these old versions of your
websites or for each repository versus
fre has a good huge uh basically an
unlimited free tier unless you start
hitting significant amounts of traffic
at which point it will make sense for
you to pay anyway and finally once again
we just cover T talked about meta tags
So Meta tags are pretty important
because you want to be able to share
your work with other people and when you
share it it's kind of the cover for your
book uh if the website is your if your
website is is the book then the meta
tags which is the meta title and image
are the cover and books are judged by
the cover so similarly websites are
judged by their meta tags all right and
then the we talked about the GitHub
collaboration workflow when multiple
people are working on a repository the
way you should work is create a branch
then you should create a make your
changes on the branch by making a bunch
of commits like that then you should
create a pull request where somebody
from your team can or even just you
yourself can review the changes and then
you can based on the comments you can
make uh you can update your branch and
keep pushing more changes and finally
you can just merge uh the merge your
branch to the main branch and just like
that your changes will then get deployed
automatically if you're using a
deployment platform like worell right so
whenever you're doing any new
development and this you should try to
apply to your website as well once
you've pushed out the first version then
for the second version make sure that
you create a branch and then you keep
pushing your changes into a branch and
uh keep updating a pull request and when
you've done enough work that you feel
it's ready to again go live then push it
back okay so try practice uh practice
using the GitHub workflow here the
GitHub flow for your work um it's also
again just good practice and it's
something that you can talk about when
you are um let's say when you're sitting
in an interview you can mention that
when I built my personal website I used
the GitHub flow so first I created a
simple page with just my picture and a
few lines about me and then I deployed
it to verell and then I created a new
branch and on that Branch I added a
project section I um created a pull
request I tested it I reviewed my own
code and only then I merged it back and
then I updated and I I did that three
four more times to add multiple things
to my website okay so try to do that try
to follow the GitHub flow for sure and
it'll help you then creating pull
requests well pull requests are again
there's a flow here then keeping your
branch up to date so sometimes the
master Branch or the main branch will go
forward so you'll have to pull those
changes back into your branch and all
that this makes more uh sense when you
are working in a team where actually
other people working in as well and you
might run into merge conflicts you might
have to fix them uh not something that
you have to know by heart or not
something that you will be doing on a
daily basis but you can always come back
whenever you want to review this topic
so there are a bunch of resources here
that you can check out okay regarding
merge conflicts and regarding uh
branching of course git can also be
installed locally so if you're up for a
not a challenge exactly but if you want
to put in the work to actually set up
get locally you can go ahead and do it I
wouldn't say that this is necessary
anymore because either your company will
be using something like GitHub Cod
spaces or they will give you a laptop
with with all of these things
pre-installed so I wouldn't worry too
much about
it okay but all the information is here
and you can always look it up whenever
you need to so feel free to come back to
all of this whenever you need to look
into it then we talked about responsive
design and flexbox so this is now we got
to a point where we want to make our
websites look good not just on our
desktop development screen but also on
mobile screens so this is where U we
wanted to create um so we saw that the
website that we had created doesn't
really look very good on mobile and we
wanted to create the webs we want to
make it more responsive and to do that
well first we duplicated the GitHub
repository that we had and then then we
deployed it once again opened it on
GitHub code spaces and we learned that
for responsive design we have to break
up our design into three or maybe at
least two but maybe three or four uh
different designs and at each break
point which is at each device width the
layout will change a little bit so here
you can see that at for small screens
the layout looks like this and then
suddenly at about 576 pixels the layout
is going to shift into this and then the
layout is going to shift into this at
768 and at 992 it's going to shift into
something else right so this is a very
common pattern almost all websites
follow it any websites made in the last
10 years will will follow it to enable
it though you need this meta tag this is
often something that is forgotten so
make sure you do that again a lot of
these instructions are not necessarily
given on the project page but you'll
have to go back and see how to make
these happen Okay so it's also a way for
you to review all the content you have
device mode on your browser using which
you can test the respons or the
responsive layout of a website and uh
you can a great way to just see how
other websites are achieved achieving
responsive design is to just open them
up on device mode and see what they do
now the way responsive design is
implemented is using CSS media queries
where you can provide at media you can
provide a media type and a condition and
when the condition is met for example if
you say Min WID 768 so if the condition
Min width of 768 is met so when the
condition holds true then these CSS
rules apply otherwise um the CSS rules
don't apply all right so here are some
examples minwidth and you can also do it
on orientation you can Al combine Min
width and Max width like that so that
way you can define specific rules for
different Windows of width however the
better way to do it so that's how you
set you can set break points but the
better way to do it is use a mobile
first approach which is first Rite all
your CSS queries or or your create your
design for mobile and then add maybe for
small or for tablets add a minwidth
breakpoint and add some additional CSS
rules that can go on top of that and
then for your tablets and laptops add
some more Rules by setting M with 768
and so on right so you want to ensure
that you don't have to repeat a lot of
the layout uh design uh and you want to
start building from mobile first so use
this for your personal website as well
uh use a mobile first approach so start
with the mobile design and then add
these break points or you can use
bootstrap to do it uh But whichever way
you choose to do it this is um how you
should achieve it then we also talked
about flexbox because as browsers resize
you cannot exactly know what size you
should build for so you should not you
should never hardcode your wids but to
keep your proportions constant you can
use CSS Flex box and again there's a
bunch of things in CSS Flex box so the
first thing is you have to uh set the
display property now of course the block
inline inline block are some of the
basic display properties but display
Flex enables Flex box and display none
hides the element all together so
flexbox has this concept of containers
and items so there's a flex container
and then there are a bunch of flex items
now as soon as you said display Flex
then the container um or the items are
laid out
along according to the rules of CSS
flexbox and then you can give a bunch of
properties to items as well so some are
container level properties some are item
level properties one is the flex
Direction which is where things flow
from left to right or right to left or
top to bottom or bottom to top so this
is done using row row reverse column
column reverse then you have wrapping so
again uh things by default just go out
but if you say no RP then they're going
to try and fit or compress um you can
say wrap down so they can wrap downwards
and you can say wrap reverse and they
can wrap upwards like that okay um again
these change based on the flex Direction
so you might have to just also uh play
around with it but in most cases you
just want to do the simplest thing some
of these more advanced uh options never
actually get used or they get used
simply when you're trying to achieve a
fair Advanced layout which doesn't
really come up very often so then you
have justify content so along the main
axis you want things to be at the start
at the center or at the end or maybe you
want to be spaced uh you want space
around them you want space between them
or you want even spacing or uh and of
course for Flex Direction column it's
going to be
different then you have align items and
that applies along the cross axis so
again if the flex direction is row do
you want things to be sticking to the
top sticking to the bottom be at the
Center or stretch to take up the entire
space or maybe align according to the
Baseline so that is something that you
can look at as well then you can change
the alignment at a child level as well
so let's say you have an alignment
setting at the parent level you can
actually modify that setting for a
particular child using the Align self
property and you also have something
called align content justify items I've
almost never used them so I wouldn't
worry about it you also have these
properties Flex grow Flex strength Flex
bases they have a certain meaning I
would really not bother about these too
much really the only property that I
often just use is the flex property
where I would just simply put flex one
to make something take up a bunch of
space all the available space okay so
that is that and using that we then
decide that we want to redesign it using
uh flexbox so we the first thing we do
is we create a couple of wireframes we
create one wireframe for desktop and we
create one wireframe from mobile so this
is what we want it to look like on
desktop and this is what we want it to
look like on mobile and we start with a
mobile first layout so we lay out a
bunch of Base Styles and we we have a
base font size we have a base body size
we have a base um font we have a base
size we have a base heading sizes we
have uh we have a bunch of Base Styles
and then uh for tablets we want to
slightly increase the body font size and
so on right so yeah so we then we create
that Navar uh like this so for the Navar
we used a slightly different logo then
we created the banner image we created
the about section and then we added we
started with a mobile first layout and
then we added a bunch of things here to
uh change the layout slightly on Mo on
tablet and on desktop then we have a
jobs list that was shown on mobile and
tablet and then we have a job table that
is shown on desktop
so yeah a job table that is shown on
desktop and then we have this
application form we made some changes
here but ultimately this is what it
looked like on mobile about Chi and
employment opportunity submit your
application etc etc uh looks good looks
readable uh could be better but looks
readable and even these are stacked
vertically and this is what it looks
like on tablet slightly different okay
slightly more spaced out but still using
the list and then this is what it looks
like on desktop here it's using a table
and here the three footer items are
shown vertically are shown horizontally
like they are on tablet okay so that's
our uh that was a lesson on responsive
design and CSS Flex box then we had an
assignment on mobile first responsive
design where you had this layout that
you had to
implement so this was the layout where
you had a mobile tablet and desktop
layout and you had to implement each one
of these like that and yeah I think
there's not much to be said here except
that you could use flexbox to do this
and you also learned about the CSS scal
property and these are the the process
you first set up prepare for develop and
deployment you set up base Styles and
Blake points you implement it section by
section and then you deploy and make a
submission okay then we learned about
the bootstrap CSS framework which is uh
which makes life really easy when you're
working with the uh when you're working
on a complex project so again we wanted
to rebuild the Joan careers website add
some links in the navigation bar show a
collapsible menu on mobile devices show
a list of jobs using cards on mobile and
table on desktop and make the color
scheme typography and layout consistent
and aesthetically pleasing and for that
we wanted to use the bootstrap uh so
there's a basic project setup of course
but we wanted to rebuild the project
using bootstrap bootstrap is a powerful
open source CSS framework that is used
to design streamline the development
workflow uh especially for mobile first
designs so we installed bootstrap and we
installed simply by including a couple
of links within our page and right right
away it changed a few Styles then we
customized it using CSS variables so we
changed the primary color we changed the
uh let's see yeah so we changed
customized bootstraps typography we
customized uh we customized the fonts so
we used a couple of outer fonts then we
created a styles. CSS file we set the
fonts we set the primary color and we
set maybe the heading font to be enter
and there are other customizations that
can be done but these basic
customizations should do the job even
for your own personal
website then we decided that okay we're
going to start out so bootstrap has a
bunch of pre-configured breakpoint so
we're going to start out with uh uh just
building out a a basic container and
building out a layout and then making it
responsive by adding more utility
classes so in bootstrap you typically
start out with a container that centers
your content on the page horizontally
and it takes up full width till whatever
size you want and after that it stays in
the center and bootstrap has a grid
system a 12 column grid system and what
you can do is you can uh set up a row
and inside that row you you can have a
bunch of columns and you can set widths
for those columns on how many of these
uh grid elements you wanted to span so
you can mix and match you can have 3 3 3
three or you can have three four and
four you can have maybe 3 three and six
you can have 3 two2 things like that as
soon as it crosses 12 it goes onto the
next row okay so you create a row and
inside the row you create a column and
that's what it does and then we talk we
looked at offsets we looked at gutters
those are just ways to shift things
around here and there and then we talked
about util classes so bootstrap has a
bunch of utility classes to set margins
set paddings um to set sizes a bunch of
utility classes to make things bold
italic to Center text a bunch of utility
classes to set background colors a bunch
of utility classes for borders for
display for Flex Etc okay and it also
offers a bunch of components so it
offers a Navar component so you can use
something like this um so this is a naar
component for our
site and this produces an app bar like
this which on mobile created a
collapsible menu but on desktop creates
this nice Three Links with a signin
button so what you do with typically
with components is you check out the
example code and you simply copy paste
and drop it into your um not copy paste
exactly but yeah take a close look at it
and either just drop it line by line or
write it or maybe in some cases when
it's exactly what you need just uh copy
paste it and it's fine but make sure you
understand every line of code that
you're copy pasting don't have anything
that doesn't actually make sense you can
always inspect something you can right
click inspect on the page itself and see
what exactly a piece of code does okay
so that's the nav bar over here it had a
couple of images so we were using a
different logo on mobile and a different
logo on desktop like that you can do all
those using some utility classes then we
created a utility hero section again
there are a bunch of examples here for
the hero section and we found this one
interesting so we went ahead and simply
copied it from the browser itself so you
can just open up these tools so again
feel free to use some of these examples
if you think that is going to be useful
for your website your personal website
and then we pasted it in here made some
changes and we got this nice hero
section which looks pretty good pretty
well designed um and yeah that's with
that we had the hero then we created a
jobs list this is where we used a card
component so bootstrap has this card
component that we could use so we added
a bunch of cards and you can see here
that we created this nice job
opportunities and it has this nice
visual hierarchy big text bold font dark
color uh smaller text then even smaller
text lighter font even smaller text even
lighter font all right so use all of
these things to give your content some
hierarchy then we created a jobs table
for desktop again bootstrap has some
examples of creating tables and this is
the table that we ended up creating then
we wanted to create a form and again
bootstap has a bunch of great utilities
for building form so we just dropped in
a bunch of examples and then modified it
and that gave us this nice little form
with uh everything looking very
consistent very clean and also a nice
submit application button and finally
bootstrap we looked at some examples for
foots uh over here like for example you
have a bunch of footer examples so from
this we picked out an example that
worked for us and we added a footer as
well and and then we took the site and
then we deployed it and this is what our
site looked like which is so much nicer
it looks looks so much cleaner and if
you want you could just use a bunch of
these bootstrap components and templates
to build out your personal website and
make it look just something as simple
and clean as this and that's perfectly
fine that's not a problem at all and
this is what it looks like on mobile
this expanded menu and then work at
Jovian some of the content is centered
and of course things that were side by
side have come one above the other the
table has shifted and now or has gone
away and now we are showing a bunch of
cards then we have the submit
application section and that's it and
then we have summary and
references U about this and a bunch of
tutorials on bootstrap that you can
check
out okay so that was a bootstrap CSS
framework and the next assignment was
building a scientific calculator and
here your job was to use uh not just C
HTML CSS but also some JavaScript to
build out a scientific calculator that
is as similar to Google scientific
calculator as possible and many of you
did a pretty good job at this and you
also wanted to make it respon responsive
so that it looks like this on mobile and
it looks like this on desktop and um
there's this tutorial here that goes
into how exactly you add the javascri
functionality yeah uh basically what you
do is let's see you go in here you add
in a bunch of event listeners for each
of the buttons and for each of the
buttons you uh yeah you you add event
listeners and then you add the logic so
you have maybe uh you take the
expression and then you evaluate it or
you add something to the expression so
all of that is covered here I think this
is a great tutorial on uh how exactly to
use JavaScript to add interactivity and
we're going to go much deeper into
adding interactivity but for now I think
this this does the job and the last
thing I want to mention is you can build
these things pretty easily with chart
GPT anytime you want some piece of
functionality on your page you can
always say let's say how do I animate
some text to just shift up and down as
um the user is scrolling you can always
just search on chat GB and get some code
from it right so that's what I just want
to mention there as well use chart GPT
or use jobot right over here use jobot
for help
too okay so that was the um third
assignment then we talked about the
express web application framework so the
express web application framework is a
minimalist framework for nodejs for
streamlining server side application
development with flexible routing and
middleware support and a wibrand
ecosystem
so we wanted to improve the Jan careers
website this time we we wanted to have a
single uh just only show the table only
show the jobs on the main page and then
show the application form on individual
job pages and then we wanted to have uh
an application form that can trigger an
email and an acknowledgement page so
this is what we did well we again
created a new repository and we learned
about creating web servers so instead of
static websites where you simply open a
URL and then you get back in HTML csss
page page a web server can take a
request and then do some processing
maybe call a database or something get
some data from a database like jan.com
is doing and then send it back so we
learned how to build web servers or web
web applications and the way we did that
is well we use the express uh web
application framework which is really
simple to get started with you just
create a bit of text like this and uh
you just write a bit of text like this
and as just like that you will get this
when you open it up when you run it
using npm start or node SRC app.js uh
you're going to get this hello world
response and now you can start sending
whatever content you want after doing
whatever processing you need to do right
so the key benefit of uh web of uh
server side Frameworks is that you can
do some
processing so we saw how to serve HTML
files you can always just uh do rest.
send file and send out a file like
index.html and this is what it looked
like now uh as we make changes we don't
want to keep restarting our server again
and again that that's where you can use
a tool like node mod to automatically
restart things then to serve static
files you can use express. use so
Express or app.use express. static so
any images any CSS files are often
served as static files and uh deploying
Express applications to worel is also
fairly straightforward you just is also
fairly straightforward you just need
this worel do Json file in the projects
root folder with some content that uh
informs verel where to uh send all the
requests and what environment to use
okay now uh next we looked at how to use
templates so let's say we had this list
of jobs that came from a database or
maybe it's just something that we have
hardcoded um now we want to actually
render it using a template and that's
where we can create a template we can
change index.html to index. mustache and
then inside it we can create this
mustache template which can Loop over
the variable jobs and then create a list
of these cards and in each card insert
the uh title job title Job Link and the
salary and the posted date and then
similarly we can also create a table
once again that can Loop over the list
of jobs and create table rows and the
table will be shown on on desktop and on
mobile we'll show the list of cards so
we are reusing code HTML code but this
time we're putting it inside a template
and we configure mustach as the view
engine and then we simply render that
index template and we give it the data
jobs the list of jobs as the variable
jobs and just like that that renders
this
page over that renders this table on
mobile on desktop and a list of cards on
mobile and there are a bunch of things
you can do with must it's really easy to
use uh but the idea here is you take
some data and you put it into some HTML
template to uh render a page then we
also looked at Route parameters so if
you have a route like this app.get jobs
colon ID then you can take your uh you
can take some logic and then use that to
render different kinds of dynamic Pages
for example here we have this template
called yeah we had we have a template
called job so we have a template called
job and in that template job. mustache
we simply render an application form and
we render the title of the job right and
that's what that looks like I believe
the job template is yeah some it's a you
all the source code yeah here is the
template content for the job template
right so it contains just uh uh it's
going to use the job title and it's
going to show that job title in here
it's in the application form at the
title of the application form all right
uh then we looked at how to handle form
submissions now to handle form
submissions we need to use this app.
poost route okay and we need to also
give it a we also need to use this body
parer middleware so that it can pass the
uh content that is going to be sent
using the post method and finally we can
store the form responses in a database
but what we chose to do instead was to
Simply format an email and send it send
out an email using the node mailer
package okay so the idea is not that
every form response has to be emailed
but you can get that form response into
a route and then you can do whatever you
want with it store it in a database just
throw it away send out an email call an
API whatever you want to do okay and um
once yeah and then we saw how to just
make sure that we are not exposing any
credentials directly within our Cod Cod
so we put in an email ID and password as
environment variables both within
our uh as an as a Dot N file uh within
an within a n file which is get IGN noed
in a nodejs project and then also within
uh verel because verel also needs those
and just like that we created this uh
final
website which has a bunch of job
opportunities at Jovian like this and we
can also then go in fill out an
application let me just fill that
out and when you hit submit application
that's actually going to go and try to
send an email not right now this this
did not send but yeah it's going to send
an email it's going to show an
acknowledgement page so that's great and
there are a bunch of other resources you
can check out and in most cases you can
just ask chat GPD what your you can ask
it and it'll tell you exactly what you
uh what you need okay so that is the
final lesson and of course now you're
going to be working on building your own
personal website um so that's all that's
all for today and we have successfully
made it to the end of this course uh
we've learned a lot about HTML CSS
JavaScript and web development in
general um it's been a great journey so
far and I hope you feel like you've
learned something over the past uh
several weeks that you can actually
apply